WISE.
WE WILL BREAK AT NOON.
BECAUSE THEY ARE TUESDAYS IS
WHEN.
THE COXES MEETS WE WILL BREAK AT
NOON WE'LL RETURN AFTER THOSE
COX'S ARE OVER.
IF WE'RE NOT FINISHED OUR BILLS
WE TRIED TO SPEAK GIVEN THAT WE
HAVE TWENTY FOUR BE PART WILL BE
FINISHED -- WE WILL ALSO DO A
COUPLE OUT OF ORDER FOR FILE
ORDER.
JUST DUE TO SOME -- MEMBERS
OBLIGATIONS BUT WE'LL FIGURE
THAT OUT LATER.
AND THEN THERE ARE SOME ITEMS ON
THE AGENDA THAT HAVE BEEN PULLED.
AND THOSE ARE.
ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN SB.
FOUR ELEVEN SENATOR JONES AND
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY TWO SB.
SIX NINETY FOUR SENATOR STONE
THEY ARE PULLED FROMTODAY'S
AGENDA.
AND THEN WE HAVE ITEMS ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR -- BUT THOSE
ARE MARKED ON THE AGENDA --
RIGHT CHAU.
THANK YOU MISTER ALLEN LOOK AT
THAT -- WE WILL BEGIN WITH ITEM
NUMBER TWO SB FORTY SEVEN
SENATOR ALLEN AND SENATE GROWN
YOU OKAY YOU DO DO YOU NEED --
ARE YOU WAITING FOR WITNESSES
ARE.
AS WELL -- DISCONCERTED WE GOT
TO THE RIGHT WHEN WE HAVE ANY
HAVE AND WE HAVE SOME FOLKS ARE
BACK THERE OKAY EXCELLENT LET'S
GO OKAY SO -- MEMBERS YOU KNOW
WE'VE BEEN WORKING A LOT ON
TRYING TO INCREASE TRANSPARENCY.
IN THE POLITICAL PROCESS IN A
COUPLE YEARS AGO WE PASSED THE
DISCLOSE ACT.
WHICH MAKES IT SO THAT FOR ALL
THOSE ADS YOU SEE ON TV YOU HAVE.
TO HAVE THE TOP THREE DONORS.
CLEARLY DISCLOSE.
BOTH ON THE TV AD AND ALSO IN
PRINT.
HI NOW WE HAVE A LOT OF FOLKS
OUT THERE WHO ARE COLLECTING.
BALLOT SIGNATURES.
FOR HI FOR PROPOSITIONS IN IN
REFERENDUM THE LIKE.
AND YOU KNOW THIS IS A BEAUTIFUL
THING IT WASN'T A GOOD IDEA THAT
WAS FIRST INTRODUCED BY GOVERNOR
YOUNG GOVERNOR HIRAM JOHNSON HE
INTRODUCED INITIATIVE.
THE REFERENDUM AND RECALL
PROCESS OVER CENTURY GO TO GET
REGULAR CALIFORNIANS A FIGHTING
CHANCE AGAINST.
POWERFUL INTERESTS.
BUT YOU KNOW THE TO THE MATTER
IS NOW TO GET SOME ON THE BALLOT
YOU GOT A YOU KNOW SPENT OVER
MILLION DOLLARS JUST TO GET
THERE.
AND IT'S NOW ALLOW THE FACT IT
ONLY POWERFUL INTERESTED
CONSIDER WILL MONEY ARE
GENERALLY SUCCESSFUL IN
QUALIFYING.
INITIATIVE FOR THE BALLOT.
SO.
I SO YOU KNOW JUST TO GIVE YOU A
SENSE YOU KNOW WE WERE NOW WE'RE
NOW WILL YOU KNOW.
LOTS OF DIFFERENT INVESTMENT
SHOULD MEASURES ARE ARE GETTING
QUALIFIED.
AND YOU HAVE PEOPLE WHO ARE OUT
THERE WHO GETTING PAID A LOT OF
MONEY TO COLLECT SIGNATURES.
ARE THEY DON'T HAVE TO KNOW
WHO'S PAYING FOR THEM TO COLLECT
THE SIGNATURES BUT THEY DO KNOW.
THAT THEY CAN PAY FIVE OR SIX
BUCKS SIGNATURE.
AND SO WHAT THIS MEASURE DOES HE
BASICALLY BUILDS ON WHAT WE DID
WITH THE DISCLOSE ACT IN.
HI ANOTHER TRANSPARENCY MEASURES
TO REQUIRE.
THAT -- THAT THE TOP THREE
DONORS TO THE SIGNATURE
COLLECTION CAMPAIGN HAVE TO BE.
DISCLOSED TO THE PERSON WHO IS
SIGNING.
THE THE THE THE INITIATIVE AND
SO THAT'S ALL IT DOES IS VERY
SIMPLE BILL IT'S ALL ABOUT
TRANSPARENCY IT'S ALL ABOUT
GIVING PEOPLE A SENSE.
OF WHO IS BEHIND THE MEASURES
THAT ARE.
HI THAT ARE THAT ARE BEING PUT
BEFORE US AND HI BUT I REALLY DO
HOPE THAT THAT FOLKS WILL WILL
WILL SEE THE WISDOM IN THIS AND
SUPPORT US ON THIS WITH ME TODAY
WE HAVE TRENT LANGE'S PRESIDENT
EXACTLY DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA CLEAN MONEY CAMPAIGN.
AND HE'S HERE TO SPEAK ON BEHALF
OF THE HELP[inaudible]
OKAY.
YOU MAY PROCEED.
COME ON UP TO THE TABLE WE WERE.
I KNOW THE BILL PRETTY WELL SO
IF YOU KNOW [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
AT TEN YOUR PRESENT HOW
IMPRESSED [inaudible]
GOOD MORNING.
IT SENATORS -- TRENT L<c.cyan>G</c>
PRESIDENT CALIFORNIA CLEAN MONEY
CAMPAIGN -- SO.
SPONSOR SB -- FORTY SEVEN WE'RE
VERY GRATEFUL TO THE AUTHOR FOR
FOR BRINGING THIS THIS BOARD WE
THINK THAT IT'S VERY IMPORTANT
POLICY.
VOTERS.
EVERYWHERE -- WANTED TO KNOW WHO
IS BEHIND THE INITIATIVES OF
PETITIONS THAT ARE.
BEING CIRCULATED -- THE
ADDITIONS -- TO ENFORCEMENT ARE
WE THINK ARE ARE ARE REASONABLE
AND MINIMAL FOR WHAT.
NEEDS TO BE DONE THEY SIMPLY
HAVE TO SIGN A STATEMENT UNDER
PENALTY OF PERJURY -- THAT.
THAT THEY HAVE SHOWN THE
OFFICIAL TOP UNDER SHEET TO THE
ON I TO THE VOTERS AND SO --
THAT'S WE THINK WILL WILL WILL
GIVE VOTERS INFORMATION THAT
THEY NEED THANK YOU.
MURDERED -- DO SUPPORT.
THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT YOU CAN JUST SAY YOUR
NAME AND YOUR SUPPORT AT THE
MIKE OKAY MY NAME IS SURELY
SHOWING DUSKY OF FROM PLEASANT
HILL AND ASKING YOU TO PLEASE
SUPPORT SB [inaudible]
FORTY SEVEN THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME'S CAROLYN
MORAN AND FROM PALO ALTO
CALIFORNIA.
I ENCOURAGE YOU TO SUPPORT SB
FORTY SEVEN PEOPLE DESERVES TO
BE INFORMED.
HI JENNIFER HEY FROM SAN
FRANCISCO IN SUPPORT OF FORTY
SEVEN WHAT A NEW WHO'S BEHIND
THAT PETITION THANK YOU.
MERRY GO FROM STANFORD -- PLEASE
SUPPORT THE BILL THE PUBLIC
DESERVES SOME CLARITY
TRANSPARENCY.
PATCH WHEN OAKLAND I SUPPORT SB
FORTY SEVEN THANK YOU -- ROBERT
KAUFMAN SACRAMENTO SUPPORT SB
FOUR SEVEN THANK YOU.
TERRY MORE OF ITS FROM A MALE
VALLEY CALIFORNIA.
I LIKE TO KNOW WHO IS BEHIND.
BILLS THANK YOU.
HELLO MERRY RYAN FROM SAN
FRANCISCO PLEASE VOTE YES ON AS
BEFORE HE SAID.
HI MOLLY MCBRIDE FROM SACRAMENTO
PLEASE SUPPORT -- SB.
FORTY SEVEN GOOD MORNING I'M
DEBORAH LONG GONE FROM MOUNTAIN
VIEW AND I SUPPORT SB FORTY
SEVEN AND ASK FOR YOU TO VOTE
YES ON FORTY SEVEN ALSO THANK
YOU.
JACQUELYN DOER FROM SACRAMENTO
LET'S STOP DOG WHISTLE
INITIATIVES PLEASE SUPPORT SB.
pFROM DAVIS OF PLEASE SUPPORT SB.
FORTY SEVEN DENVER FROM.
DAVIS AND I VEHEMENTLY SUPPORT
SB FORTY SEVEN THANK YOU FOR
HAVING THIS HERE.
GOOD MORNING MELISSA ROMERO WITH
THE CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS IN SUPPORT.
I CAN ILL FOR CHAIR THE
CALIFORNIA CLEAN MONEY ACTION
FUN IN SUPPORT.
MY BODY ALLEN FROM PETALUMA AND
I SUPPORT SB.
FORTY SEVEN GLORIA PURCELL
BELMONT AND I HOPE YOU'LL VOTE
YES ON SB FORTY SEVEN I REALLY
CARE ABOUT THIS BECAUSE A FEW
YEARS AGO THERE WAS A SEMBLANCE
ATTACK.
SUPPORT THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I'M REYES LEBRON OF THE LEAGUE
OF WOMEN VOTERS OF CALIFORNIA IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB.
FORTY SEVEN ALLEN MARLING FROM
ALAMEDA HIGH SUPPORT SB.
FORTY SEVEN I'M JULIE CHAPMAN
WITH CALIFORNIA STATE STRONG IN
INDIVISIBLE SACRAMENTO AND WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL SO
PLEASE PASSAGE.
MY NAME'S CHRISTOPHER LISTEN
FROM SAN RAFAEL PLEASE SUPPORT.
NANCY NOW FROM PALO ALTO IN
SUPPORT.
MY NAME IS RAYMOND WHERE DOWN
FROM NEVADA CALIFORNIA SUPPORT
AS BE FORTY SEVEN I WOULD ASK
THAT YOU DO THE SAME THANK YOU.
CRAIG DUNKERLEY ME.
TOO JEFF TURNED AGUIRRE PUBLIC
ADVOCATES ORGANIZATIONS.
OWL [inaudible]
KERA -- NUMBER OF OTHERS SPARE
AND SUPPORTING THIS AND BELIEVE
DISCLOSURE IS VERY IMPORTANT.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
WE HAVE WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NINE SENATOR ALLEN -- ONE
SECOND LET ME ESTABLISH CORD.
ROLL CALL PLEASE SIR BRETT
KANTER -- HERE HERE HERE HELLO.
MORE LIKE HERE BRADFORD.
BRADFORD HERE JACKSON MITCHELL
HERE MITCHELL HERE MORALE
[inaudible]
WIENER.
OUR WE'VE ESTABLISHED FORMS THAT
MEANS WE CAN EVEN ENTERTAIN A
MOTION BUT WILL LET YOU GO AHEAD.
WELL I I YOU KNOW I THINK THIS
IS BILL THAT IS GENERATED YOU
COULD CLOSE IT TO SWELL I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE.
IS THERE -- QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS ON THE DICE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I'M JUST
CURIOUS ON I'M JUST TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT THE FLUIDITY OF THIS
HOW HOW OFTEN YOUR REPORT AND
HOW IT'S DONE.
I'M LOOKING AT PAGE.
NINETY NINE WHAT OTHER ALL.
TEN NINETY NINE HELLO I'M SORRY
YEAH [inaudible]
I'VE.
A FEW ALMOST GOT ME THERE LA.
I HAD LINES TWENTY FIVE TO
THIRTY BUT THE TOP OF THE PAGE
IS THE PAGE NUMBER THANK YOU IT
WOULD BE SEVEN FORGETTING.
AFTER THE COMMITTEE DISTRICT
WHICH THE STATE INITIATIVE
REFERENDUM RECALL PETITION SHALL
SUBMIT.
THE OFFICIAL TOP UNDERSTOOD
REQUIRED BY SUBDIVISION.
ARE THE SECRETARY STATE INTERNET
WEBSITE AND AND SO IS THERE ARE.
AND I'M TRYING TO FIGURE THE
FLUIDITY OF THAT HER WORK.
IS THERE A TIME REQUIREMENT
CHAIR. TWO THIRTY THREE THROUGH
THE CHAIR -- THE IT'S IT'S ON A
MONTHLY BASIS SO THE OFFICIAL
TOP UNDER SHEETS ARE VALID FOR
FOR ONE MONTH SO -- THAT'S HOW
OFTEN THEY HAVE TO PUT THOSE AND
THEN -- DO YOU EXPECT MUCH
MOVEMENT IN THOSE TOP.
THREE IN MANY CASES THEY THEY DO
MOVE A A FAIR AMOUNT SOME CASES
THEY DON'T MOVE AT ALL BUT BUT
ON AVERAGE TWO OR THREE TIMES I
WOULD SAY OVER A COURSE OF IT.
INITIALLY CAMPAIGN YOU YOU GET
CHANGES THAT'S WHAT WE'VE SEEN.
AND THEN IF YOU MISS THE MONTH
DEADLINE YOUR YOU'RE YOU'RE
SUBJECT TO A MISDEMEANOR -- IF
YOU MISS THE ONTH DEADLINE
NEARED YOU SHOULDN'T BE SUBJECT
TO A MISDEMEANOR BUT YOU WERE
YOUR SIGNATURE GATHERERS WILL
NOT HAVE A VALID SHEETS TO
CIRCULATE.
OR YOUR YOUR AND YOUR YOUR YOU
MAYBE HAVE -- IF YOU IF YOU HAVE
MISREPRESENTATIONS REGARDING
YOUR PERSONAL TOP UNDERS.
THAT'S A MISDEMEANOR YES.
SO THAT WOULD MEAN THAT YOU
MIGHT EVEN TIMELY BUT YOU WERE
INACCURATE YES IF YOU PUT THE
WRONG TOP FUNDERS AND THAT WOULD
BE SUBJECT TO A MISDEMEANOR.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MANAGER.
YOU'RE WELCOME CENTER MORE LIKE
NOW THAT'S WHY THIS BILL IS
BEFORE US IS PUBLIC SAFETY IS
THAT IT CREATES MISDEMEANOR FOR
KNOWING OR WE WILL FULL.
AND MISS FALSE STATEMENTS OR
MISINFORMATION.
RIGHT DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER
COMMENTS OR MOTION ON THIS ITEM.
NO MOTION ON THE ITEM.
MOVE THE BILL THANK YOU.
ON THE RIGHT SO WE HAVE A MOTION
WE HAVE A CLOSE LET'S DO ROLL
CALL.
MOTION IS THE PASTOR
APPROPRIATIONS SKINNER AYE
SKINNER AYE MOORLACH.
BRADFORD BRADFORD AYE JACKSON
MITCHELL FIVE MITCHELL I'M
AROUND WIENER.
SORRY WE ARE GOING TO LEAVE THE
ROLE OPEN FOR YOUR ABSENT
MEMBERS AND APPRECIATE THAT.
PRESENTATION ELECTRICITY I DON'T
THINK YOU HAVE ANY OTHER BILLS.
YES THANK YOU CENTRO OKAY.
SO SENATOR STERN HERE DEFINITELY
OKAY SENATOR STERN.
WE ARE AN ITEM SB.
ONE TWENTY YOU MAY BEGIN.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR -- MEMBERS.
THIS MORNING I'M PRESENTING TWO
U. S. SENATE BILL.
ONE TWENTY WHICH WOULD.
ADD THREE PROHIBITIONS TO OUR
APPS SYSTEM THOSE OF YOU
UNFAMILIAR WITH THEIR ARM
PROHIBITED PERSONS -- LIST IN
THE STATE -- IT IS ONE OF THE
PRIMARY MEANS BY WHICH WE KEEP
GUNS OUT OF THE HANDS OF THE
PEOPLE WHO I DON'T BELIEVE
SHOULD BE IN POSSESSION OF THEM
THIS BILL WOULD ADD -- THREE
MISDEMEANOR VIOLATIONS TO THAT
LIST -- OF FOLKS WHO CANNOT.
LEGALLY POSSESS A GUN IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND THOSE.
THOSE MISDEMEANORS ARE THE
CARRYING OF A CONCEALED FIREARM --
THE UNLICENSED CARRYING OF A
LOADED FIREARM AS WELL AS THE
OPEN CARRYING OF AN UNLOADED
HANDGUN.
SO IF YOU'VE BEEN CONVICTED OF
THOSE MISDEMEANORS THIS BILL
WOULD ADD YOU TO THE APP'S LIST
AND MAKE YOU SUBJECT TO
ENFORCEMENT FROM DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE OR LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
FOR ILLEGAL POSSESSION OF THAT
FIRE.
AND I DO APPRECIATE THE THE
AMENDS WORKED ON WE DON'T ADD TO
THE PRISON OVERCROWDING PROBLEM
WITH THIS WE'RE JUST LOOKING TO
HAVE SOME.
SOME CONSEQUENCE -- TO SORT OF
FLAGRANT VIOLATIONS OF OUR APPS
SYSTEM AND WE KNOW ALSO THE APPS
SYSTEM IS IN NEED OF SUPPORT AND
ADMINISTRATIVELY SO WHEN THERE'S
BEEN A LONG BACKLOG BUT OWN
EXCEPT.
CERTAINLY THE AMENDMENTS
APPRECIATE THE WORK OF THE
COMMITTEE THERE SO -- DO
APPRECIATE THAT MANAGER THANK
YOU.
CYNDER STERN SO JUST TO CLARIFY
FOR THE MEMBERS THE AMENDMENTS
TO THE BILL SPECIFIED THAT THE
PUNISHMENT FOR PERSON PROHIBITED
FROM POSSESSING A FIREARM UNDER
THIS BILL.
IS A MISDEMEANOR RATHER THAN IN
A WAFFLER IN ALTERNATE FELONY
MISDEMEANOR THIRTY MINUTES THE
AUTHOR IS ACCEPTING AND LET'S
SEE IF THERE'S ANY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
I KNOW IT'S EARLY THERE WE MIGHT
HAVE MISSED IT THE CITY ATTORNEY.
WAS GOING TO BE HERE BUT OKAY
MAYBE THIS.
IS TO ME.
MORE MEN CHAIR MEMBERS RANGE
SHERMAN WITH THE RESEARCHER
SOLICITATION SUPPORT.
EXCELLENT.
ANY OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
YES WE THAT'S FINE WE GOT GOING --
GOOD BECAUSE WE HAVE TWENTY FOUR
BILL JUST SO ALRIGHT SO LET'S
SEE IF THERE'S ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
WE HAVE SINGLE RECORD.
GOOD MORNING LESLIE CALDWELL
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION WE THANK THE AUTHOR
AND SENATOR FOR ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENTS AND WE ARE
WITHDRAWING OUR OPPOSITION.
GREAT.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR THE RECORD AND RE
WITH NATURAL SOCIO ASIAN -- ALSO
HERE FOR A GUN OWNERS
STUCK IN THE LINE OUTSIDE --
WERE IN OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL --
THIS EXPANDS.
THE FARMS PROHIBITION TO NON
VIOLENT CRIMES REGARDING THE
TRANSPORTATION OF FIREARMS TO
INCLUDE A TEN YEAR PROHIBITION.
FOR YEARS LAWS -- CAN BE VERY
COMPLICATED IN FACT WE HAVE A
BOOK ON FIREARMS LAWS IT'S OVER
SIX HUNDRED PAGES.
OF THE TRANSPORTATION LAWS CAN
BE -- CAN BE A LITTLE BIT
ONEROUS AND WE HAVE NEW LAWS
THAT ARE COMING ON STORAGE AND
TRANSPORTATION.
I'M INCLUDING CERTAIN DEVICES
THAT WOULD NEED TO BE INSTALLED
IN CARS -- WE'RE CONCERNED THAT
PEOPLE MIGHT VIOLATE THIS IN
LOSE THEIR FIREARMS RIGHTS MAYBE
THAT A RENTAL CAR OR THEY'RE
JUST ON FAMILIAR -- IN IN -- IN
ADVERSELY VIOLATE THIS AND SO --
WERE IN OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL
WE FEEL THAT -- BETTER TIME WILL
BE SPENT GOING AFTER THE
CRIMINAL MISUSE OF FIREARMS NOT
ON THOSE WHO MIGHT INADVERTENTLY
PILOT Là THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NOW JUST FOR THOSE AND
AUDIENCE OR WHO MAY BE WATCHING
I ALLOWED DOUBT WITNESS TO SPEAK
LONGER BECAUSE THEY WERE THE
PRIMARY WITNESS IN OPPOSITION --
ONCE WE'VE HEARD FROM OUR WE AND
WE ALLOW FOR IN TERMS OF PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORTER
OPPOSITION WE ALLOW FOR THREE
THEN AFTER THAT POINT EVERYONE
JUST COMES TO THE MIKE.
IN INDICATES THERE SUPPORTER
OPPOSITION SO I WANTED TO
CLARIFY THAT SO NO ONE FELT THAT
I WAS A TREATING ANYONE UNFAIRLY --
SO JUST FOR CLARIFICATION AND
NOW IS THIS A WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION OR IN SUPPORT --
LESBIAN WITH A SILLY WE ARE
WITHDRAWING OUR OPPOSITION
APPRECIATE THE WORK OF THE
AUTHORS OFFICE AND AND THE
COMMITTEE ON THE AMENDMENTS
THANK YOU GREAT THANKS OKAY.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION OR TRAINERS.
ALL RIGHT SEEING NONE LET'S SEE
IF THERE'S ANY COMMENT BY -- OR
QUESTION BY [inaudible]
MY COLLEAGUES.
SEEING -- NINE SENDER OR DID YOU
MAY RAISE YOUR HAND CENTER MORE
LIKE I HAD -- I'M JUST TRYING TO
FIND THE BALANCE IN AT ALL AND
I'M I'M WONDERING IF SOME THE
ARGUMENTS.
OUR PERSUASIVE THAT IT TENYEARS
AND YOU KNOW FR SOMETHING THAT
MIGHT HAVE BEEN ACCIDENTAL
INADVERTENT.
HELP ME OUT HOW DID YOU COME.
WERE YOU CAME TO FOR SO.
YOU KNOW WE WE DO NEED CLARITY
AROUND GUN TRANSPORTATION LAWS
IN ANYONE HE'S.
YOU KNOW BITING BY OUR RULES IN
OUGHT TO BE ENTITLED TO THAT
POSITION TO CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT --
SO WE'RE NOT AND TRIED TRYING TO
IMPEDE ON THAT PER SE.
WE'RE TRYING TO SORT OF SE THE
STANDARD PROBATION PERIOD IS NOT
A LIFETIME BAN BY THE WAY
THERE'S SOME FELONIES THAT ARE
SUBJECT A LIFETIME BANS
FEDERALLY AND STATE.
WE WE PICK THE NUMBER THAT SORT
OF WAS IN A RANGE OF OTHER
RELATED CRIMES -- I DO AGREE
THERE MAY NEED TO BE CLARITY ON
THE TRANSPORT REQUIREMENTS BUT I
DON'T WANNA ARBITRARILY --
INSULATE THOSE WHO ARE VIOLATING
GUN LAWS FROM BEING ON THE APPS
LIST IT SEEMS LIKE A A GAP IN IN
THE CURRENT SYSTEM -- IF OTHER
MISDEMEANORS ARE FELONIES THAT
ARE NOT THEY'RE NOT ALL VIOLENT
CRIMES OR EVEN CRIMES OF INTENT
PER SE -- SO WE FELT LIKE THIS
WAS A REASONABLE BALANCE AND
EVENTUALLY YOU CAN GO BACK TO
POSSESSING THAT THAT WEAPON THE
PROBLEM IS RIGHT NOW UNDER
CURRENT LAW.
EVEN IF YOU'RE IF YOU KNOW IF
YOU'VE BEEN CONVICTED OF OF A
CRIME EVEN IF YOU'RE YOUR PASTOR
PROBATIONARY PERIOD YOU MAY
STILL BE ABLE TO GO.
BACK AND OBTAIN THAT.
THE THE WEAPON USED IN THAT
CRIME SO WE FEEL LIKE THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT OUGHT TO BE
REMEDY.
IN THE END I APOLOGIZE FOR
GETTING INTO THE DETAILS BUT
SPORTS SPORTS.
IF IF YOU'RE HUNTING AND
SOMETHING.
HAPPENED YOU'RE PULLED OVER USE
YOU DIDN'T.
PUT SOMETHING AWAY PROPERLY AND
THEN YOU LOSE YOUR GUNS FOR TEN
YEARS IS.
YES SO YOU'VE GOT TO PUT YOUR
GUNS AWAY PROPERLY -- WE THINK
THAT THERE'S A THERE'S A WAY TO
SOLVE THAT PROBLEM BUT I DON'T
THINK.
WE WANT -- TO FOR ALL THOSE WHO
WERE CAPTURED IN THIS EXPANSION
THE APPS LIST WE THINK IT'S AN
IMPORTANT SIGNAL TO BE SENDING.
TO GET TIGHT ON HOW YOU'RE GONNA
BE TRANSPORTING YOUR YOUR GUNS
IN THIS STATE -- AND THERE OUGHT
TO BE CONSEQUENCES TO TO
VIOLATING THAT -- WHETHER IT'S
TOO EXTREME I THINK YOU'RE GONNA
HAVE TO MAKE THAT CALL.
THANK YOU THINK WE SHOULD
CONSIDER.
THANK YOU CENTER MORE LIKE -- MR
INTO YOU CAN SINCE WE'VE ALREADY --
PRETTY MUCH YOU CAN INDICATE WE
REPRESENT AND IF YOU SUPPORT OR
OPPOSE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS ANDREW ANTS WE WITHDRAW
YOUR AUNT'S WE WE THANK THE
SENATOR FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD.
ON BEHALF OF THE LOS ANGELES
CITY ATTORNEY'S OFFICE FOR PROUD
TO BE THE SPONSOR THIS MERGER
YES FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU YOU CAN YES GO AHEAD
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I
APPRECIATE THE INDULGENCE
CAPULETS REPRESENTING SPARK CLUB
INTERNATIONAL DOOR SPORTSMAN'S
COALITION CALIFORNIA SPORTSMEN'S
LOBBY.
IN OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL ALL
WE HAVE A LOT A LAWS ON THE
BOOKS ALREADY ON SAFE STORAGE --
I THINK CENTER MORE LIKES
BROUGHT UP A A LEGITIMATE POINT
WE HAVE A LOT OF HUNTERS THAT.
TRAVEL AND TRANSPORT AND GO IN
AND OUT OF STATE AND OBVIOUSLY
THEY'RE VERY CONCERNED ABOUT --
SAFE STORAGE THEY NEED PROBABLY
NO WROTE MORE ABOUT THE LAWS
THAN MOST FOLKS BUT INADVERTENT
ACCIDENTS CAN HAPPEN -- AND WE
FEEL THIS IS -- REALLY
PROHIBITIVE AND CONSEQUENTIAL
FOR LEGITIMATE FIREARMS OWNERS
AND HUNTERS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT -- SENATOR STERN YOU
MAY CLOSE.
YEAH.
GREAT.
AND WE HAVE A MOTION
[inaudible]
OUR MOTION [inaudible]
MAKING [inaudible]
NORMAL.
ALL RIGHT I'M BILLS MOVED --
LET'S DO REAL COFFEE.
MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS SKINNER HI
SKINNER AYE MORE LOCK.
MORE LIKE NO BRADFORD
[inaudible]
JACKSON [inaudible]
MITCHELL.
SO I MORE UP BROWN.
WIENER.
THANK YOU I WE WILL HOLD THE A
ROLL OPEN.
ANDWITH THE WIND WE HAVE ABSENT
MEMBERS.
RETURN AND WE CAN -- OPEN THE
ROAD.
LET'S DO YOU ARE CONSENT
CALENDAR WHILE WE'RE WAITING FOR
RAY -- AUTHOR.
THANK YOU -- BROKE OFF.
SKINNER AYE SKINNER AYE MOORLACH.
WE'RE LIKE AYE BRADFORD AYE
BRADFORD AYE JACKSON MITCHELL.
MITCHELL I'M AROUND WIENER.
I'M CENTER MITCHELL MAYBE YOU
CAN START YOUR BILL.
WITH THAT WORK FOR YOU.
GREAT GO AHEAD [inaudible]
YEAH.
VERY MUCH ABOUT A YEAR AND OKAY.
NO. ONE FOR YEAH OVER.
THE DUCKS TWO THINGS FROM THE
LAW CRIMINAL ADMINISTRATIVE FEES
AND RELATED CIVIL ASSESSMENTS.
CRIMINAL JUSTICE FEES POST THREE
MAIN PROBLEMS FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENT AS WELL AS RESIDENTS
NUMBER ONE THERE MORE OFTEN THAN
NOT CHARGE TO LOW INCOME PEOPLE
WHO.
RARELY COULD AFFORD TO PAY THEM
TO THEY CREATE BARRIERS TO RE
ENTRY AND THREE THEY ARE A
REGRESSIVE SOURCE OF REVENUE.
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN A BILL THAT
I HAD THE PLEASURE OF COOPER IN
SENATE BILL ONE NINETY
ELIMINATED YOU LITTLE FEES.
THE COST OF COLLECTIONS WITH
OVERLY BURDENSOME TO COUNTIES
AND FAMILIES ALIKE.
SO MUCH SO THAT ALL OF THE
COUNTIES ARE FINANCIALLY BETTER
OFF NOT COLLECTING THOSE FEES IN
FACT MANY COUNTIES ONE ABOVE AND
BEYOND AND THEN THE REQUIREMENTS
OF THIS BE NINETY AND FORGIVEN.
BACK -- THIEF.
AND A TWENTY EIGHTEEN STUDY ON
THE IMPACT OF PROBATION FEES IN
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC RECORDS OUT
REQUESTS WERE SENT TO ALL FIFTY
A COUNTY PROBATION DEPARTMENTS.
80% OF COUNTIES RESPONDED
REPRESENTING NEARLY 95% OF OUR
STATE'S TOTAL POPULATION.
RESPONSES SHOW THAT MOST
COUNTIES DO NOT TRACK COLLECTION
FEES SUGGESTING THAT THE FEES
ARE OF LITTLE CONSEQUENCE TO
COUNTY BUDGETS.
THOSE THAT DID TRACK COLLECTION
FEES REVEAL LOCAL ELECTION RATES
AND A HIGH COST OF COLLECTION.
COLLEAGUES I REPEAT THEY REPORT
LOW COLLECTION RATES BUT A HIGH
COST OF COLLECTION.
LAST YEAR CASE IN POINT THE
SITTING KIND OF SAN FRANCISCO BY
WAY OF THEIR FINANCIAL JUSTICE
PROJECT PUBLISHED A REPORT
ENTITLED.
CRIMINAL JUSTICE ADMINISTRATIVE
FEES HI PAIN FOR PEOPLE LOW GAIN
FOR GOVERNMENT A CALL TO ACTION
FOR CALIFORNIA COUNTIES.
AS A RESULT SAN FRANCISCO
ABOLISHED ALL LOCALLY IMPOSE
FEES AND MOVED TO DIS CHARGE ALL
LOCAL IMPOSE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
DEPT.
LAST WEEK THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS AGREE TO
EXAMINE THEIR APPLICATION OF
FINES FEES AND PENALTIES AND
DETERMINE THE FEASIBILITY OF
ELIMINATING SOME OR ALL OF THEIR
OWN FINDS.
IN FEBRUARY OF THIS YEAR THE US
SUPREME COURT RULED UNANIMOUSLY
THAT THE PROHIBITION IN THE
EIGHTH AMENDMENT OF THE
CONSTITUTION RELATING TO
EXCESSIVE FINES DOES IN FACT.
APPLY TO STATE AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS THEREBY LIMITING
THEIR ABILITIES TO IMPOSE FINES
AND SEIZE PROPERTY.
I APPRECIATE ALWAYS AS A FORMER
COMMITTEE CONSULTANT MYSELF ON
THE FEDERAL WORK AND RESEARCH
DONE THAT THAT CONSTITUTES THE
ANALYSES ON THAT WE RECEIVE IN
POLICY COMMITTEES.
HAVING SAID THAT I HAVE TO SAY
THAT I I THINK DISAGREED IN
THEORY WITH THE FOCUS OF THE
COMMENTS -- REFLECTED IN SEVERAL
PAGES ON THE ANALYSIS THAT.
IN IT IN GENERAL I THINK SUGGEST --
A PHILOSOPHICAL DISAGREEMENT IN
TERMS OF WHETHER FEES ARE
PROPRIA ON WHETHER -- PEOPLE
TOUCH BY THE CRIMINAL OR
JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM COULD
HAVE -- THE ONUS ON THEIR OWN TO
COVER THOSE COSTS.
I'LL JUST TOUCH ON A COUPLE OF
THEM -- IN TERMS OF THE
QUESTIONS THAT WERE RAISED -- IT
WAS RAISED THE QUESTION WAS
POSED AS TO WHETHER OR NOT --
WHAT THE QUESTION WAS PULSE HOW
MANY OF THE FEES WE ELIMINATE
ARE CURRENTLY COLLECTED BY
COUNTIES?
OUT OF FIFTY FOUR COUNTIES FOR
WHICH FEE SCHEDULES WERE
AVAILABLE THE MOST COMMON FEES
ASSESS OUR PROBATION SUPERVISION
INVESTIGATION REPORTS ELECTRONIC
MONITORING WORK ALTERNATIVE
PROGRAMS AND DRUG TESTING.
THE QUESTION WAS POSED THE FEES
RELATED TO ALTERNATIVE CUSTODY
FOR EXAMPLE HOME DETENTION
ELECTRONIC MONITORING WORK FULL
OR ELIMINATED WELL ALTERNATIVE
COFFEE STILL BE AVAILABLE FOR
ALL COUNTY FAIR QUESTION -- TO
EXAMPLE SAN FRANCISCO ALAMEDA
ELIMINATED FEES CHARGED IN SHARE
OF THE WORK IN THEIR SHARES WORK
ALTERNATE.
AND SERVICES SCHOOL LIMITED FEES
CHARGED FOR ANKLE MONITORING AND
NEITHER COUNTY ELIMINATED
ALTERNATIVE CUSTODY OPTIONS ON
ACCESS TO ALTERNATIVE CUTS THE
OPTION SHOULD NOT BE DEPENDED ON
INDIVIDUALS WELL WE ALSO FEEL
STRONGLY THAT THE COUNTIES I
UNDERSTAND THE VALUE IN THE COST
SAVINGS ASSOCIATE WITH THOSE
KIND OF PROGRAMS.
AND THEREFORE WOULD NOT
ELIMINATED IT ELIMINATE THOSE
PROGRAMS.
IF.
THEY COULD NO LONGER CHARGE --
THE DEFENSE THE THE PEOPLE WHO
ARE SUBJECT SUBJECT TO THOSE
PROGRAMS THE FEES ASSOCIATED
WITH THEM -- AGAIN I THINK IT'S
A PHILOSOPHICAL DIFFERENCE IN
TERMS OF WHETHER OR NOT WE
BELIEVE THAT.
SOMEONE TOUCHED BY THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM -- WE'LL SEE THE
FEE AS A AS A REASON TO NOT BE
ENGAGED IN THE ACTIVITY THAT GOT
THEM THERE IN THE FIRST PLACE AW
AW I THINK THAT THERE'S ADEQUATE
RESEARCH TO SUGGEST THAT THAT'S
NOT THE CASE.
HERE WITH ME TODAY MADAM --
CHAIR TO EXPRESS THEIR SUPPORT
FOR THE BILL -- INCLUDES
STEPHANIE COMPOST BELIEVE A
SUPERVISING ATTORNEY IN THE
POLICY ADVOCACY CLINIC AT UC
BERKELEY SCHOOL OF LAW AND
MATTHEW TRAPPED IN THERE WITH
THE AIR SEE THE ANTI RECIDIVISM
COALITION.
WITNESSES YOU MAY BEGIN.
YEP OKAY.
HI MY NAME IS MATTHEW TRAINER --
I AM TWENTY TWO YEARS OLD -- I
AM A PART OF THE ANTI RECIDIVISM
COALITION THE R. C. -- LAST
APRIL I GOT OUT OF PRISON --
AFTER FIGHTING AND ARE.
DOING FIVE AND A HALF YEARS FOR
SECOND DEGREE MURDER -- I WAS IN
FOR A JUVENILE CASE -- I HE
KNOWN [inaudible]
UNDERSTOOD AFTER A LONG SO YOU
KNOW A LONG STAY IN PRISON.
DURING THE TIME FOR MY CRIME AND
YOU KNOW FINDING MY FAITH IN GOD
AND AND REALLY JUST WORKING ON
MYSELF AS A HUMAN BEING.
THAT.
HE KNOW MY ACTIONS WERE WRONG
WHAT I DID WAS BASED OFF THE SET
OF CIRCUMSTANCES THAT I AM IN
DOLLARS A KID.
AND YOU KNOW HOW EVERYTHING IN
MY LIFE.
FROM THE BEGINNING UNTIL THAT
POINT AFFECTED ME AS A HUMAN
BEING TO THE POINT WHERE I MADE
A HORRIBLE DECISION TO TAKE
ANOTHER HUMAN BEING'S LIFE FACE
OFF MY OWN.
ANGER HATRED FRUSTRATION TOWARDS
MY LIFE AND EVERYTHING THAT
HAPPENED AND YOU KNOW.
A LOT OF THE USE THAT I KNEW
WHAT I WAS INCARCERATED AND EVEN
MY ME MYSELF I WAS.
YOU KNOW -- IN GROUP HOMES AND
FOSTER CARE GROWING UP I WAS
HOMELESS FOR TWO AND A HALF
YEARS AT TWELVE THIRTEEN YEARS
OLD -- HE NODDED ABUSIVE FATHER
MY MOM'S A METHAMPHETAMINE
ADDICT.
YOU KNOW THERE'S TONS OF
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT HINDERED ME
FROM POSITIVE GROWTH BEFORE I
HAD GOTTEN INCARCERATED.
AND THOSE TYPES OF THINGS THE
CIRCUMSTANCES AND IT UP LEADING
UP TO ME.
YOU KNOW LIVING A LIFE OF CRIME
AND DOING THE THINGS THAT I DID
AND HE KNOWN.
GETTING OUT OF PRISON -- I ENDED
UP GOING ACTUALLY -- HALFWAY
THROUGH MY TIME I DID OF GOING
TO A FIRE CAMP OVER IN PINE
GROVE I'VE FOUGHT FIRES FOR YEAR
AND A HALF.
AND GIVE BACK TO THE COMMUNITY
DID AS MUCH AS I COULD TO GET
BACK TO THE PEOPLE HAD TAKEN
AWAY FROM YOU KNOW I YOU KNOW DO
MY UTMOST BEST -- TO HELP PEOPLE
EVEN WHEN I WAS INCARCERATED YOU
KNOW.
TO YOU KNOW.
JUST FINDING THE MOST VALUE THAT
I COULD IN MY TIME TO BE ABLE TO
YOU KNOW.
BECAUSE EACH ONE OF US AS HUMAN
BEINGS WE HAVE THAT GO IN MY
HEART THAT.
YOU KNOW EVEN KNOW THAT SOME
PEOPLE ARE STILL ANGRY AND THEY
CAN'T GET PAST THEIR THEIR
FRUSTRATION THEY STILL FEEL
GUILTY THAT WE ALL HAVE A A
DIFFERENCE FROM RIGHT FROM WRONG
YOU KNOW IN.
MY THING IS IS WHEN I GOT OUT OF
JAIL I GOT OUT OF PRISON -- IN
IN LAST APRIL I ENDED UP.
COMING RIGHT OUT OF THERE TO YOU
KNOW PROGRESSING LIFE ENDED UP
GETTING MARRIED TO MY WIFE
RACHEL.
AND WE'RE HAVINGA CHILD.
I ENDED UP GETTING A JOB.
PROPER MEMBER SOCIETY AND REALLY
ALL I DO IS GIVE FATE YEAH --
ALL GLORY TO MY GOD JESUS CHRIST
AND IN THOSE THINGS BUT WITHOUT
MY FAITH FOUNDATION.
I NOTICED THAT A MAJORITY OF THE
KIDS THAT I KNOW FROM PRISON ARE
EITHER DEAD.
HAVE RECOMMITTED THEIR FENCES OR
HAVE DONE SOMETHING ELSE.
TO THE NO -- IN OTHER MEAN ADD
THROUGH THERE ARE COMING OUT OF
THE THE PRISON RIGHT FROM GOING
IN THROUGH THOSE NEGATIVE
CIRCUMSTANCES TO GOING IN. FOR
THEIR CRIME THEY CAME OUT.
INTO THE SAME SET OF
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT THEY WERE IN
BEFORE ON TOP OF THAT THEY HAD.
YOU KNOW RESTITUTION FINES FROM
THEIR VICTIMS WHICH IS YOU KNOW
ALL UNDERSTOOD.
YOU KNOW WE WE OWE THAT MONEY TO
OUR VICTIMS WE ACTUALLY MORE
THAN.
THAT TO THEM BUT ON TOP OF THAT
YOU KNOW A LOT OF RUMORED
JUVENILES CHILDREN.
KIDS.
COMING OUT OF PRISON YOU KNOW
GOING INAT YOUR SOME OF THEM AT
TWELVE YEARS OLD GETTING OUT OF
TWENTY ONE HAVING NO FOUNDATION
HAVING NO PARENTS HAVING NO.
ONE AND THEN HAVING ON TOP OF
THE YOU KNOW.
IT'S A GOOD GOD THAT I HAD -- A
JOB WILLOWS INCARCERATED TO PAY
OFF THREE QUARTERS OF MY
RESTITUTION WHILE I WAS IN THERE.
SO LIKE EVEN HAVE A CHANCE TO
HAVE A FAMILY IN IN SUPPORT THEM
THE RIGHT WAY THAT I NEEDED TO
AND AND DO THE THINGS THAT I
NEEDED TO DO TO REHABILITATE IN
SOCIETY.
YOU KNOW THOSE THE THAT AND
ACTUALLY MINISTRY FEES TO ON TOP
OF MY RESTITUTION.
BECAME.
IN A REALLY DIFFICULT BECAUSE
THEY DON'T EVEN GIVE YOU A FULL --
LIKE.
THEY DON'T GIVE YOU FULL
KNOWLEDGE OF VERYTHING THAT YOU --
UNTIL YOU DIE OUT AND THEN YOU
START FIGURING OUT THAT YOU HAVE
A THOUSAND DOLLARS HERE OVER.
A THOUSAND DOLLARS THEIR OWN --
A FEW HUNDRED DOLLARS OVER HERE --
AND NOTHING'S ADDED UP IN.
EVERY TIME I I'M I'M I'M NOT A
FEW KIDS.
GOT OUT OF PRISON ACTUALLY NOW
THEY'RE GROWN MEN GOT OUT OF
PRISON.
DIDN'T KNOW WHAT TO DO
THEMSELVES THEY JUST LEARN HOW
TO GET A JOB.
RIGHT EVERY SINGLE BIT OF THEIR
MONEY WAS GOING TOWARDS THESE
ADMINISTRATIVE FEES THAT ALREADY
PAID OFF THE RESTITUTION.
YOU KNOW AND IT WAS JUST REALLY
DIFFICULT ENOUGH FROM GOING FROM
YOU KNOW.
REPRESENTS SYSTEM TO LEARNING
HOW TO BECOME A PROPER MEMBER
SOCIETY TO GOING OUT INTO
SOCIETY TO LEARN HOW TO APPLY
THOSE THINGS.
AND TO HAVE.
EXTRA LIKE FINANCIAL THE BECAUSE
WE ALREADY WE LIVE IN CALIFORNIA
IT'S REALLY DIFFICULT LIVING OUT
HERE AS IT IS HONESTLY I WOULD
YOU KNOW.
THEN YOU'RE WORKING TWO JOBS NOW
ON TOP OF MY WIFE AND IT'S
REALLY DIFFICULT IT'S HARD.
AND ON TOP OF THAT I'M HAVING TO
PAY MY OKAY I'M I'M HAVING A
HARD TIME PAYING MY
ADMINISTRATIVE FEES AND ALL
THOSE THINGS SO.
I FIND IT REALLY PROFITABLE IF --
YOU KNOW.
THIS BILL WOULD GET PASSED
BECAUSE IT WOULD JUST HELP US
ALL OUT.
YOU.
THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU
[inaudible]
NEXT WITNESS.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRPERSON SKINNER
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS STEPHANIE COMBO SPRAY
AND I AM A SUPERVISING ATTORNEY
IN THE POLICY ADVOCACY CLINIC AT
UC BERKELEY SCHOOL OF LAW.
IN SINCE TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN
WE'VE BEEN RESEARCHING THE ARRAY
OF FEES THAT OUR PUBLIC SAFETY
JUST PUBLIC SAFETY SYSTEMS AND
COURTS IMPOSE ON PEOPLE.
AS DISCUSSED IN RECENT DECISIONS
BY THE CALIFORNIA COURT OF
APPEALS IN THE US SUPREME COURT
MONETARY SANCTIONS LIKE FEES ARE
NOT MEANT TO FURTHER ANY PENAL
OBJECTIVES.
BUT THEY'RE RATHER JUST ONLY
THERE TO AUGMENT THE STATE'S
REVENUE.
AND YET FEES OFTEN DON'T EVEN DO
THIS SINCE MANY PEOPLE WHO ARE
CHARGE FEES CANNOT PAY DUE TO
THEIR INDIGENCE.
EVEN STILL THE MAJORITY OF
COUNTIES IN CALIFORNIA ALTHOUGH
NOT REQUIRED CHARGE FEES.
AS A RESULT FEW TYPES AND MOUNTS
AND PRACTICES VARY WIDELY ACROSS
THE STATE. FOR EXAMPLE AN ORANGE
COUNTY AND IT'S ALL ON PROBATION
FOR FIVE YEARS CAN BE CHARGED
OVER ELEVEN THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR
SUPERVISION AND AN INVESTIGATION
REPORT.
BUT JUST MILES OVER IN
NEIGHBORING RIVERSIDE COUNTY
THAT SAME PERSON WILL BE CHARGED
SIXTY NINE HUNDRED DOLLARS.
ONCE IMPOSES FEES AREN'T JUST
BILLS THAT DISAPPEAR WITH TIME
THEY ARE ORDERED AS CIVIL
JUDGMENTS WHICH CAN BE ENFORCED
BY FRED THE FRANCHISE TAX BOARD
VIA TAX REBATE INTERCEPT AND
WAGE GARNISHMENT.
AND THESE FEES DISPERSED
DISPROPORTIONATELY HARM LOW
INCOME PEOPLE AND PEOPLE OF
COLOR.
DUE TO OVER POLICING AND TARGET
POLICING IN COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
BLACK AND BROWN PEOPLE ARE
PUNISHED MORE FREQUENTLY AND
HARSHLY AT A VARIETY OF
DISCRETION POINTS WHICH ONLY
LEADS TO HIGHER FEE BURDENS.
AND FEES ARE INTENDED TO HELP
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS RECOUP COSTS
COUNTIES OFTEN RECOVER ONLY A
SMALL PROPORTION OF WHAT THEY A
SASS. FOR EXAMPLE IN LA COUNTY
ONLY 4% OF PROBATION FEES ON
ACTIVE CASES WERE COLLECTED.
AND RECORDS ALSO SHOW THAT IN
FISCAL YEAR TWENTY SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN THE COUNTY SPENT THREE
POINT NINE MILLION DOLLARS TO
COLLECT THREE POINT FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS RESULTING IN A HALF OF A
MILLION DOLLAR LOSS.
HAS THE OPPORTUNITY TO TAKE THE
LEAD IN THIS COUNTRY ON FEES
NATIONALLY THE AMERICAN BAR
ASSOCIATION THE NATIONAL CENTER
FOR STATE COURTS AND THE US
CIVIL RIGHTS COMMISSION HAVE ALL
WAIT AND AND THEY ALL AGREE WITH
THE OVER FIFTY ORGANIZATIONS IN
SUPPORT OF THE SPELL.
THAT WE MUST ELIMINATE AND
REDUCE FEES THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME AND HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES.
OKAY THAT THE MIGRATION -- YOU
CAN JUST.
YOUR NAME AND ORGANIZATION AND
SUPPORT.
THAT'S A GOOD BIRTH LOW WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY WERE
SPONSOR AND SUPPORT.
GOING BACK IS FOR ELLA BAKER
CENTER FOR HUMAN RIGHTS
REPRESENTING FAMILIES OF
INCARCERATED PEOPLE WHO BEAR
THIS DEBT IN SUPPORT.
LOUIS BROWN JUNIOR WITH POLICY
LINK A CO SPONSOR IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
LIZZY BEACON WITH A SILLY OF
CALIFORNIA CO SPONSOR AND
SUPPORT.
I'M A SLOW BROWN OF THE LEAGUE
OF WOMEN VOTERS OF CALIFORNIA
AND STRONG SUPPORT.
LISTIA MATIX WITHIN THE FIRST
MONTHS BILL LETTING IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
KRISTER BROWN WITH THE FINANCIAL
JUSTICE PROJECT IN THE CITY AND
COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO WHERE A
CO SPONSOR IN SUPPORT.
HER CHILD DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT. THREE TO
THEN WITH THE EAST BAY COMMUNITY
LAW CENTER THE LARGEST PROVIDER
OF LEGAL SERVICES IN ALAMEDA
COUNTY WE ARE CO SPONSOR AND WE
STAND IN STRONG SUPPORT.
I'LL HAVE ANOTHER DONE ON BEHALF
OF NEXT IN CALIFORNIA AND
SUPPORT.
MARIO GUERRERO ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY SO
ASSOCIATION SUPPORT THANK.
EMILY ALEXA PNU JUSTICE
COALITION STRONG SUPPORT.
AT THE WORLD IS THAT THE YOUTH
JUSTICE COALITION ORG POCO
SPONSORED ON THIS BILL WILL FOR
THE LET'S GET FOR YOU COALITION
ALLEY COUNTY TO ELIMINATE FEES
FINES AND BAIL IN JAIL THANK YOU.
ALSO KEEP JUSTICE COALITION
PROCLUS SPONSORED ALSO SUPPORT.
CAN I GIVE YOU JUST COALITION
PROUD TO BE HERE THANK YOU.
THERESA SMITH WAS SLAIN I
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THE ACTRESS CALIFORNIA FAMILIES
UNITED FOR JUSTICE IT WAS
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
OUR MONICA SELES FOR ME BY IN
SUPPORT.
MALINA AB TO THE BLACK LIVES
MATTER STRONG SUPPORT.
BUT SHE CITY LIFT OF LOVE ALWAYS
IN SUPPORT.
LESLIE CALDWELL CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT.
THIS TAX CALIFORNIA FOUND UNITED
FOR JUSTICE TO SUPPORT.
DEANGELO MAC PUBLIC HEALTH
ADVOCATES IN STRONG SUPPORT AS
WELL.
ISRAEL WE ARE WITH ME BY SALINAS
IS STRONG SUPPORT.
THE NAVY HARDWOOD SILICON VALLEY
DEBUG STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
SURE IS THE MANGO SILICON VALLEY
DEBUG IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL.
HOLY MITCHELL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD
AND I'M STRONG SUPPORT.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
OKAY SO DO WE HAVE WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION -- GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS GUS COREY NO
RED SHOULD OPPOSITION BUT WE DO
HAVE CONCERNS ON THE LEGISLATION
I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
COALITION OF IGNITION AIRLOCK
MANUFACTURERS.
IN PARTNERSHIP WITH MOTHERS
AGAINST DRUNK DRIVING -- WE ARE
VERY SENSITIVE -- TO THE AUTHORS
OF GOAL HERE OF TRYING TO REDUCE
THE IMPACT OF FIGHTING FINES AND
FEES ON THE MOST VULNERABLE
HOWEVER WE DO SEE THAT IN THE
LEGISLATION.
THAT THERE ARE A COUPLE SECTIONS
THAT STRIKE OUT THE INDIGENT
PROGRAM WHICH IS THE INDUSTRY
SUBSIDY -- FOR WHERE THE
INDUSTRY'S PAYING FOR THE
INSTALLATION OF THE DEVICES. FOR
THOSE THAT ARE CONVICTED OF A DO
YOU WHY.
AND THE BUILDING FOR DEFENDER TO
ACTUALLY PAY WE ARE WORKING WITH
THE SENATOR AND WITH OUR STAFF
AND SO WE HOPE TO CONTINUE THAT
WORK AND HAVE THE ISSUE RESOLVED --
AS THE BILL MOVES THROUGH THE
PROCESS SO UP LOOK FOR THE
WORKING THE AUTHOR TO CORRECT
THAT -- THAT LANGUAGE THANK YOU
GREAT SO THAT'S OUR BETWEEN --
SO NOW WHO.
ARE THERE ARE TWO MAIN WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION THAT WANT TO COME
TO THE TABLE.
OKAY NO WORRIES NO WORRIES WE
KNOW THERE'S A BIG LINE OUTSIDE
SO.
SORRY.
ARE YOU CAN PROCEED.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
ELIZABETH ASPEN ALSO THIS
MORNING ON BEHALF OF THE URBAN
COUNTIES OF CALIFORNIA AS WELL
AS THE RURAL COUNTIES OUT.
HIS ME THE RURAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA WE
ABSOLUTELY UNDERSTAND AND
BELIEVE THIS IS A WORTHY POLICY
CONVERSATION TO BE HAD WE'VE
BEEN TALKING ABOUT THIS FOR
YEARS -- WE HAVE A SYSTEM IN
PLACE RIGHT NOW THAT'S THE
RESULT OF A LOT OF VERY COMPLEX
LAYERING OF A VARIETY OF FEES
FINES AND ASSESSMENTS -- CENTER
MITCHELL'S BILL DEALS WITH A
SPECIFIC SET OF FEES ARE
OPPOSITION RELATES ONLY TO THE
ASPECT THAT THERE IS A REVENUE
THAT COMES TO COUNTIES TO
SUPPORT A VARIETY OF PROGRAMS.
SO ARE OPPOSITION IS CONNECTED
TO THE FACT THAT WE WOULD
REQUEST AN ACCOMPANYING
ASSESSMENT OF WHAT THAT THAT
IMPACT WOULD BE WHAT THE
FINANCIAL -- RESULTING FINANCIAL
IMPACT WOULD BE TO COUNTIES AND
THINK THAT THAT IS A A NECESSARY
COMPONENT OF THIS POLICY
CONVERSATION WE ALSO RECOGNIZE
THERE ARE.
THERE ARE REAL HUMAN --
CONSEQUENCES THAT RESULT FROM
THESE FEES AND THAT'S THAT'S AN
IMPORTANT ASPECT AS WELL ALSO
RESPECTFULLY IN OPPOSITION AND
REQUESTING A FINANCIAL
ASSESSMENT OF THE POLICY.
AT THAT IS BEHIND THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING JESSICA SEVEN TEN
THE ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES
AND RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION -- I
WANT TO BEGIN BY THANKING THE
AUTHOR AS WELL AS THE SPONSORS
FOR HAVING NUMEROUS MEETINGS
WITH US TO DISCUSS THIS
LEGISLATION.
I WILL BE BRIEF GIVEN THAT OUR
OPPOSITION IS FOUNDED.
PRIMARILY ON THE FISCAL IMPACT
SAID ABOUT ONE FORTY FOUR RATHER
THAN THE POLICY.
AND WHAT WE DO THINK THIS IS A
VALUABLE CONVERSATION -- THIS
LONG OVERDUE WE THINK THAT
IMPORTANT PART OF THE DISCUSSION
IS FINDING SPECIFICALLY BATTLE
FOR LOST REVENUE.
AND SO LIKE I SAID WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE AUTHOR
AND THE SPONSORS ABOUT BACK. TO
GET.
THANK YOU.
GO AHEAD MANAGER MEMBERS COREY
SAYS ALONG BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION OPPOSITION.
CODY WILSON BEHALF OF THE
CHEAPER BASED OFFICERS OF
CALIFORNIAN OPPOSITION.
ALRIGHT ANY OTHERS IN OPPOSITION.
RIGHT SO -- I'M GONNA START AND
THEN I CALL ON YOU -- CENTER
JACKSON IF THERE'S ANY OTHER
MEMBERS WHO SENATOR MORE
LAUGHTER RIGHT ARM. TO
APPRECIATE YOUR BRINGING THIS
BILL.
AND AT THE POINT THAT WE TAKE A
MOTION I'LL ASK YOU IF -- IF AT
ANY POINT THAT IT'S AMENDED IF I
CAN BE ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR --
SO YOU -- I I UNDERSTAND.
WHY THE -- DIFFERENT LOCAL
GOVERNMENT ASSOCIATIONS CAME TO
THE TABLE ON OPPOSE THE BILL
BECAUSE AS WAS POINTED OUT THE
UTILIZE -- THESE FINES AND FEES
TO COVER COSTS.
NOW INTERESTINGLY ENOUGH -- IF
WE LOOK AT ALL THE DIFFERENT
SERVICES THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
PROVIDES [inaudible]
THERE.
WE DO NOT ASSESS A FEAR OF FINE
FOR EVERY SINGLE SERVICE THAT
LOCAL GOVERNMENT PROVIDES.
NOW CLEARLY LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
STILL HAVE TO OPERATE -- BUT
WE'VE SEEN THIS GROWTH IN FEES
AND FINES ON ALL ALL NATURE
AREAS -- WHETHER IT'S TRAFFIC
TICKETS OR ANY NUMBER OF THINGS.
DUE TO THE FACT THAT -- IT
BASICALLY RISEN SINCE THE
PASSAGE OF PROP THIRTEEN BECAUSE
THEIR CORE REVENUE TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS WAS GUTTED AT THAT
TIME AND SINCE THAT TIME.
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS HAVE BEEN
TRYING TO MAKE UP [inaudible]
AND UNFORTUNATELY MOST FEES AND
FINES NOT ALL BUT ESPECIALLY
THOSE. TO DO WITH ANY TYPE OF
INCARCERATION INFRACTION OR
CRIMINAL.
ARE DISPROPORTIONATELY ON LOW
INCOME PEOPLE BECAUSE
UNFORTUNATELY IS
DISPROPORTIONATELY LOW INCOME
PEOPLE AND PEOPLE OF COLOR WHO
GET CONVICTED IN THE FIRST PLACE --
AND DIED WE WE DON'T NEED TO RE
HASH THAT DATA THAT DATA IS WELL
BEFORE US IN IS SUBSTANTIATED.
BY MORE THAN -- THAT BY MOST
EVERY BIT OF RESEARCH THAT IS
DONE.
SO WHILE I APPRECIATE THAT LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS WOULD BE FRUSTRATED
THAT THEY WOULD HAVE THESE
REVENUE SOURCES CUT OFF.
I THINK THAT WE HAVE FOUND.
THAT.
THE COVERING OF THESE COSTS IN
THIS WAY IS NOT A BENEFIT TO THE
SOCIETY AT LARGE AND WHEN WE
HEAR FROM A WITNESS LIKE THE
GENTLEMAN WHO REPRESENTED ARC.
WHO TALKS ABOUT?
AFTER SERVING HIS TIME.
AND DOING -- WHAT WAS EXPECTED
OF HIM?
DUE TO THE CRIME HE COMMITTED.
BEING RELEASED AND THEN FINDING.
THAT HE HAS -- SIGNIFICANT COSTS
THAT HE NOW HAS TO COVER WHICH
IS WE KNOW YOU ALREADY IF YOU
COME OUT OF ANY FOR OF
INCARCERATION WHETHER IT'S
COUNTY DEALER STATE PRISON.
YOU HAVE AN ALBATROSS AROUND
YOUR NECK YOU'RE ALREADY
DISADVANTAGE IN TERMS OF GETTING
EMPLOYMENT IN TERMS OF ANY
NUMBER OF THINGS TO TO BE ABLE
TO PROPERLY.
REINTEGRATE INTO A COMMUNITY.
AND TO ADD TIS ADDITIONAL
BURDEN.
I THINK IS -- JUST IT IT DOES
NOT SERVICE IT IT CREATES IT
HELPS TO CONTRIBUTE TO THE HIGH
AMOUNTS OF RECIDIVISM THAT
CALIFORNIA HAS MEANING PEOPLE
RETURNING BACK TO JAIL AND
PRISON.
AND IT'S SOMETHING WE'RE TRYING
TO STOP THIS REVOLVING DOOR SO I
REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR BRINGING
THE MEASURE.
AND I THINK THAT WERE WE AS AND
AS A FORMER REPRESENTATIVE OF
LOCAL GOVERNMENT WE'RE JUST
GONNA HAVE TO START FIGURING OUT.
HOW TO PROVIDE OUR SERVICES
WITHOUT CHARGING THESE TYPE OF
PEACE AND NOW I THINK THAT'S
JUST A BASIC REALITY OR WE NEED
TO FIX?
CERTAIN OF OUR OTHER REVENUE
PROBLEMS SO -- ANYWAY
DEPRECIATED AND CENTER JACKSON
THEN CENTER MORE LACK AND I
DON'T KNOW IF MISTER BRADFORD HE
WENT OUT GO HEAD CENTER JACKSON
THANK YOU -- I WNT TO THANK THE
YOUNG MAN WHO CAME AND TESTIFIED
ABOUT HIS EXPERIENCE AND
CONGRATULATIONS ON TURNING YOUR
LIFE AROUND VISITS A HEARTFELT
STORY AND CERTAINLY ONE THAT I
THINK IS FOR INSPIRING. FOR US
TO HEAR WHEN IT BE WONDERFUL IF.
YOUR CHILDHOOD HEAD -- BEEN A
MORE STABLE -- ONE INCIDENT THAT
EXPERIENCE WOULD NOT HAVE
OCCURRED EITHER FOR YOU OR THAT.
THE A YOUNG PERSON WHOSE LIFE
WAS SIR.
WAS -- LOST.
UP MY CONCERN HERE AND I AGREE
WITH EVERYTHING THAT THE CHAIR
HAS SAID BUT MY CONCERN IS --
REALLY IT LOOKING AT SORT OF THE
FINANCIAL ASPECT FOR EXAMPLE I
KNOW IN MY COMMUNITIES -- WE
HAVE PROGRAMS FOR PERPETRATORS
OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE WHERE THEY
HAVE TO GO THROUGH ANGER
MANAGEMENT.
AND THEY HAVE TO PAY THE COST OF
THOSE PROGRAMS BECAUSE WITHOUT
THAT WE ARGUABLY WOULDN'T HAVE
THOSE PROGRAMS.
AND SOLD I WONDER IF YOU COULD
RESPOND -- TO THAT CONCERN A
REALIZING SOME OF HIS IS-BUDGETARY BUT THERE IS -- SORT
OF A SORT OF A AN
ACKNOWLEDGEMENT IF IF ONE HAS
ANGER MANAGEMENT.
PROBLEMS FOR EXAMPLE AND RESULT
IN DOMESTIC ABUSE WHICH OF
COURSE WE DON'T.
SUPPORT AND WANT TO READ A CAKE --
ATTENDING A PROGRAM THAT IS
DESIGNED TO HELP AN INDIVIDUAL
ADDRESS AND OVERCOME THOSE.
ISSUES ARE COST MONEY.
AND WE BASICALLY SAY AS SOMEONE
WHO ARE COMMITTED THAT ACT YOU
HAVE TO TAKE RESPONSIBILITY AND
SUPPORT THE MECHANISM THAT'S
GOING TO BE PROVIDED TO YOU TO
OVERCOME THAT PROBLEM.
OF WE TAKE AWAY THAT FEE IF YOU
WILL -- HOW DO WE HOW DO WE THEN
GO ABOUT ENSURING THAT THESE
PROGRAMS CONTINUE AND THE PEOPLE
UNDERSTAND THE CONSEQUENCES?
OF THAT KIND OF BEHAVIOR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- SENATOR
JACKSON FOR THE QUESTION AND AND
I THINK THE QUESTION IS REALLY
TWO FOLD YOU KNOW.
IS IT APPROPRIATE FOR US TO
ASSUME THAT THE ASSESSMENT OF
FINES AND FEES ARE INDEED A
DETERRENT.
AND WHEN WE SAY YOU'RE MAKING
SURE PEOPLE ARE HELD ACCOUNTABLE --
WERE IN THIS COMMITTEE WE HEAR.
ARE AT ARE FAMILIAR WITH PENAL
CODE -- THAT SUGGESTS THAT WE DO
HAVE A SYSTEM IN WHICH PEOPLE --
PAID THEIR DEBT TO SOCIETY AND
PAID THEIR DEBT TO A VICTIM THIS
BILL DOES NOT TOUCH RESTITUTION
I WANNA MAKE SURE THAT THAT'S
CLEAR.
BUT I DON'T KNOW THAT IT'S
APPROPRIATE IN AS THE MADAM
CHAIR SUGGESTED.
THERE'S NO WHERE ELSE IN
GOVERNMENT IN THE PROVISION OF
SERVICES THAT GOVERNMENT IS
RESPONSIBLE.
FOR THAT WE IN EFFECT ISSUE AN
ADDITIONAL TAX.
ON OUR RESIDENTS TO COVER THOSE
COSTS -- WE HAVE THE SAME HERE
DURING THAT TEN YEAR PERIOD WHEN
OUR BUDGET WAS.
REALLY DIFFICULT WE WERE CUTTING.
CRITICAL SERVICES THAT WE
SHOULDN'T BALANCE THE BUDGET ON
THE BACKS OF POOR PEOPLE.
IF YOU COULD SHOW ME A COUNTY
WHERE THE COLLECTION OF FEES.
ACTUALLY EXCEEDS THE COST TO
COLLECT IT. TO CHARGE ADDITIONAL
I'D AN ADDITIONAL PERCENT FOR
THE COLLECTION PROCESS -- I
THINK THAT'S EXCESSIVE AND
INAPPROPRIATE.
ALL WE ARE OPEN TO CONTINUING TO
HAVE THE CONVERSATION TO LOOK AT
INDIVIDUAL CASES BUT I JUST
THINK ACROSS THE BOARD WE HAVE
TO HAVE A FOR THE PHILOSOPHICAL
CONVERSATION ABOUT WHETHER WE
THINK IT'S APPROPRIATE. TO
ENGAGE IN AN ADDITIONAL TAXATION
PROCESS FOR A SUBSET OF THE
POPULATION -- WHO -- ARE VICTIMS
HAVE BEEN VICTIMIZED.
BY GOVERNMENT SYSTEMS -- AND
HAVE INDEED PAID THEIR DEBT IF
YOU WILL THROUGH INCARCERATION
WHATEVER THE CASE MAY BE -- HOW
WE PAY FOR IT IS A SEPARATE
CONVERSATION AND I BELIEVE
GOVERNMENT SHOULD STEP UP AND
ENGAGE IN PROVIDING THE SERVICES
THAT WE DEEM APPROPRIATE --
WHETHER OR NOT THEY SHOULD BE ON
THE BACKS OF THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
TOUCHED BY THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM THAT IS WHERE I HAPPEN TO
DISAGREE.
WELL I AND I AND I APPRECIATE
THAT PHILOSOPHICAL DISTINCTION --
I I HAVE A MY ASK IS VERY
SPECIFIC TO THE PROGRAMS DEALING
WITH DOMESTIC VIOLENCE BECAUSE
LIKE YOURSELF THIS IS BEEN AN
AREA I HAVE.
BEEN CLAWING AT FOR A LONG TIME
BEFORE WE EVEN RECOGNIZE
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE IS A CRIME OF
COURSE [inaudible]
AND RECOGNIZING THAT IN MANY
INSTANCES WE HAVE THESE
DIVERSION PROGRAM SO THAT THE
THAT THE COST THAT PEOPLE PAY IS
NOT NECESSARILY INCARCERATION
THE GOAL.
IS NOT.
THIS IS NOT A DETERRENT THIS
SITUATION DOMESTIC VIOLENCE THIS
IS PAYMENT FOR A PROGRAM THAT IS
HOPEFULLY GOING TO CHANGE THAT
BEHAVIOR.
AND ALSO TO PROTECT LOVED ONES
FROM CONTINUED ABUSE.
SO.
THE ACTUAL COST TO YOU HAVE TO
PAY FOR THIS AND YOU HAVE TO
ATTEND LET'S SAY FIFTY TWO WEEKS
ONCE A WEEK FOR TWO OR THREE
HOURS. TO ADDRESS WHATEVER THOSE
PROBLEMS ARE THAT CAUSE YOU TO
TO HURT THE PEOPLE YOU
OSTENSIBLY LOVE. TO ME IS NOT AN
OUTRAGEOUS COSTED TO ITS.
IT'S SOMETHING THAT HE COULD IT
ALLOWS FOR THE SYSTEM TO
CONTINUE SO THAT WE CAN TRY TO
IMPROVE AND REDUCE THIS KIND OF
BEHAVIOR.
AND IN MOST INSTANCES THERE'S NO
CONCOMITANT.
PUNISHMENT THE OF INCARCERATION
SO IF YOU WOULD I I RECOGNIZE
FEES AND COSTS AND ADD ONS AND
SO FORTH AND I COULDN'T AGREE
WITH YOU MORE BUT I AS I LOOK AT
THIS VERY SPECIFIC PROGRAM
BECAUSE IT'S ONE THAT I HAVE
BEEN.
SUPPORT OF BOB AND FOLLOWED AND
HELP TO ADVANCE -- MY FEAR IS
THAT.
WE ARE GOING TO SEE THESE
PROGRAMS ENDING BECAUSE THE
ARGUMENT IS GOING TO BE THERE
ISN'T MONEY THERE BECAUSE THE
PEOPLE WHO.
HAVE CREATED A NEED FOR THIS
PROGRAM ARE NOT GOING TO BE
CALLED TO TO SUPPORTED AND TO
FUNDED -- I HEAR YOU LOUD AND
CLEAR AND I WOULD PUSH BACK A
LITTLE IN AND I THINK A ADD TO
YOUR QUESTION BY SUGGEST WHAT
HAPPENS TO THOSE WHO ARE IN A
POSITION. TO PAY THE FEE DO THEY
THE NOT BENEFIT FROM THAT
PROGRAM THAT AND SO WE CAN
CONTINUE TO CREATE A SYSTEM IN
WHICH LIKE WE JUST HAD.
LOTS OF DISCUSSIONS IN THIS
COMMITTEE AROUND THE BILL SYSTEM
WE CONTINUE TO CREATE A SYSTEM
IN WHICH THOSE WHO CAN AFFORD IT.
GET A DIFFERENT -- KIND OF
JUSTICE COMPARED TO THOSE WHO
CAN'T.
AND SO I WOULD HOPE THAT WE
WOULD HAVE A SYSTEM IN WHICH
EVERYONE WHO.
A JUDGE OR WHOEVER FEELS COULD
BENEFIT AND MAY HOLE BY WHATEVER
THE DETERRENT IS A DV ANGER
MANAGEMENT CLASS WHATEVER THE
CASE IS SHOULD HAVE ACCESS TO IT
AND SO WE MUST HAVE A SYSTEM
THAT WHETHER YOU CAN PAY.
AND I CAN'T SHOULD MATTER IF OUR
ULTIMATE GOAL IS TO CREATE YOU
KNOW A EIGHT CALIFORNIA WHERE A
DV IS NO MORE.
SO IF I MAY HAVE ONE MORE
QUESTION TO FOLLOW UP ON THIS SO.
UNDER THIS BILL WOULD THERE
STILL BE AND FREQUENTLY THE
COURTS HAVE A SLIDING SCALES
BASED UPON WHAT PEOPLE CAN AND
CANNOT AFFORD.
WE PROVIDE JUSTICE TO PEOPLE WHO
THEIR OWN INDEPENDENT COUNSEL WE
PROVIDE THE PUBLIC DEFENDER
ALTERNATE ALTERNATE COUNCIL --
WOULD THAT BE -- IT WOULD THAT
CONTINUE UNDER THIS PROGRAM SO
IF SOMEONE IS INDIGENT AS YOU
ARE I CANNOT AFFORD TO PAY FOR
THIS.
WE'RE NOT GOING TO ESSENTIALLY
SO WITH THEN YOU CAN'T QUALIFY
BUT HAVE A SLIDING SCALE SO THAT
PEOPLE PAY WHAT THEY'RE ABLE TO
AND IF THEY'RE NOT WE STILL WANT
TO GET THAN ANGER MANAGEMENT.
BUT AT LEAST THOSE WHO CAN
AFFORD IT -- OR IF AFFORD SOME
PERCENTAGE OF THAT STILL BE --
EXPECTED TO TO TO DO THAT UNDER
THIS DEAL.
ALL SIDES AND AND THAT'S
BASICALLY RESEARCH THAT WHILE
KIND OF THIS THEORY AND MAYBE IN
THE IN THE CASE OF CAPTAIN YORK
COUNTY ARE WITH REGARD.
TO DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND ANGER
MANAGEMENT TRAINING YOU KNOW THE
THE RESEARCH SHOWS THAT IT THAT
IT IS NOT PEOPLE OF ME.
THAT ARE TOUCHED BY THE SYSTEM.
OFF IN LARGE PART IT IS NOT AND
TRAGICALLY EVEN THOUGH CURRENT
COLD CREATES AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
THOSE WHO CAN AFFORD IT TO NOT
BE CHARGED.
THAT IS FLAWED AND THAT DOESN'T
SEEM TO BE THE CASE COUNTIES
CONTINUE TO PUSH FORWARD IN
CHARGE IN THE CASE OF SB ONE
NINETY WE HAD.
AMAZING RESEARCH THAT SHOWED --
THE NUMBER OF COUNTIES THAT
IGNORED THE INDIGENT KIND OF OPT
OUT FOR THESE PROGRAMS AND THAT
CONTINUES TO BE THE CASE ACROSS
THE STATE SO THAT CURRENT
PROTECTION IN LAW IS A
PROTECTING THOSE WHO CAN AFFORD
IT.
IT'S JUST NOT.
WELL I APPRECIATE THAT I DO.
HI I'M KINDA TORN I HEAR WHAT
YOU'RE SAYING BUT I BUT I ALSO
DON'T WANT.
TO I DON'T WANT TO SEE PROGRAMS
LIKE THIS DISAPPEAR BECAUSE
ARGUABLY THERE'S NOT ENOUGH
FUNDING FOR IT I UNDERSTAND THAT
AND AND WHAT WELL THERE'S
CERTAINLY NO GUARANTEES I THINK
THE WORK.
THAT YOU AND OTHERS HAVE PUT IN
PLACE FOR YEARS AROUND MAKING
THOSE KINDS OF PROGRAMS ARE NORM --
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS HAVE TO ATTEST
THAT THOSE KINDS OF THE VERSION
PROGRAMS ARE COST SAVINGS IN THE
LONG RUN BECAUSE TO TO SAVE IN
TERMS OF INCARCERATION THAT
DOUBT THOSE DOLLARS AND SENSE
MAKES SENSE.
ALL AND I WOULD.
REFER YOU BACK AGAIN TO THE
EXAMPLES I GAVE IN MY OPENING
THAT THERE ARE TWO COUNTY
SERVICES ONE ALAMEDA.
WHO WILL LIMIT THE FEES WHO --
IN THE AREAS OF THE VERSION --
PROGRAMS ARE CONTINUING TO
PROVIDE THOSE SERVICES I BELIEVE
BECAUSE THEY KNOW THEY'RE COST
EFFECTIVE [inaudible]
AND AGAIN.
WE CANNOT FIND COUNTIES WHO --
THE MONEY THEY BRING IN AS A
RESULT OF CHARGING THE FINES AND
FEES EXCEEDS THE ADMINISTRATIVE
COSTS FOR COLLECTING THEM.
WHEN WE RECOGNIZE THAT THE VAST
MAJORITY THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
CHARGED THESE FEES DO NOT HAVE
THE MEANS TO PAY?
AND THE FEES CONTINUE TO GROW
AND THE COUNTESS CONTINUE TO
EXPEND RESOURCES IN TRYING TO
GET BLOOD FROM A TURNIP.
THANK YOU ARE.
THAT'S PROBABLY A GOOD ANALOGY
THANK YOU THANK YOU CENTER
MORLOCK. NINE CENTER WIENER YOU
WANTED TO SPEAK OKAY CENTER MORE
LIKE.
THAT I'M SURE THANK YOU SENATOR
MITCHELL THANK YOU -- FOR THIS
MAKES OUTSTANDING DEBT FROM A
LIMITED COURT FEES NO LONGER
COLLECTIBLE AS OF JANUARY ONE
TWENTY TWENTY SO.
YOUR DEBT IS FORGIVEN -- THAT
SHOULD GIVE MATTHEW TRACTOR A
WHOLE NEW APPRECIATION FOR
FORGIVE US OUR DEBTS.
SO I AM IN CURIOUS WE HAVE TO
COUNTIES THAT HAVE TAKEN THE
INITIATIVE TO SAY THIS DOESN'T
PENCIL OUT -- AND SINCE I DO
PREFER LOCAL CONTROL WHY ARE WE
IN A SENSE FORCING FIFTY SIX
COUNTIES TO ELIMINATE FEES WHEN
THEY SHOULD HAVE THE OPTION
BASED ON THEIR OWN ANALYTICS TO
SAY.
THIS DOESN'T MAKE SENSE WHAT TO
DO SOMETHING DIFFERENT.
I JUST IN OUR EFFORT TO MAKE
SURE THAT IT'S A IT'S A
STATEWIDE POLICY THAT'S KIND OF
APPLIED EQUALLY ACROSS THE STATE
I APPRECIATE YOUR PERSPECTIVE
FROM THE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
PERSPECTIVE BUT I THINK WE'RE
USING THOSE EXAMPLES OF COUNTIES.
A LARGE COUNTY LA COUNTY IS
CURRENTLY CONSIDERING WHAT MAKES
SENSE FOR THEM LA COUNTY DID I'M
STEP UP ON SB ONE NINETY BEFORE
IT BECAME STATE LAW.
AND ELIMINATE FINES AND FEES FOR
JUVENILES ON WE WERE ABLE TO
LOOK AT THE COST SAVINGS -- AND
THAT KIND OF THE THE HUMAN
SAVINGS -- WITH THAT BUT LIKE
WITH AT LIKE SB -- ONE NINETY
THE ADVOCATES THAT YOU'VE HEARD --
TESTIFIED THE RESEARCH THAT'S
COME OUT OF THE BERKELEY -- LAW
SCHOOL A CLINIC SUGGESTED A
STATEWIDE POLICY REALLY IS
WHAT'S BEST FOR ALL RESIDENTS OF
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
SO I KIND OF OPERATE FROM THE
WHILE ONE TWO VERSES HAVE TO
APPROACH THAT THAT I GOT YOU
THANK YOU SENATOR AND ON BEHALF
OF PEOPLE ACROSS THE STATE WHO
WERE TOUCHED BY THE SYTEM.
IT IS VERY DIFFICULT -- WILL WE
HAVE COUNTY BY COUNTY -- KIND OF
REQUIREMENTS PARTICULARLY AS IT
RELATES TO KIND OF CRIMINAL
JUSTICE -- AND SO I I HEAR YOUR
PERSPECTIVE AND AND YOU SHARE
THAT OFF AND I JUST HAPPEN TO
BELIEVE.
AS DO -- THE THE VERY LARGE
COALITION ON A REALLY KIND OF
THE NATION WIDE -- NEW FOCUS
AROUND THE THE TRUE VALUE OF
FINES AND FEES REALLY THINK THAT
IT'S APPROPRIATE STATEWIDE
STRATEGY THE STATEWIDE.
APPROACH SO MAYBE.
GOING BACK TO SENATOR JACKSON'S
COMMENTS WHY NOT WE ESTABLISH
MAY BE A FEE SCHEDULE SO YOU
HAVE.
MAXIMUM SO YOU DON'T HAVE ELEVEN
THOUSAND AND ONE KALYAN SIXTY
NINE HUNDRED ANOTHER COUNTY.
AND INDEED THAT IS A COMPROMISE
WHERE YOU GET THESE FEES I THINK
THE CHALLENGE WITH THE WHOLE
SLIDING SCALE CONCEPT IS OUR
CURRENT SYSTEM WHERE WE'RE
SUPPOSED TO HAVE.
CARVE OUT TO PROTECTIONS FOR
THOSE WHO CAN'T AFFORD IT IS IT
WORKING.
AND SELL TO THEN LAYER ON TOP OF
AN EXPECTATION AROUND THE
COUNTIES A BILLING A ABILITY AND
WILLINGNESS TO THE END --
OPERATIONALIZE A SLIDING SCALES
GADGIL -- I'M TIRED OF THE
GRIDLOCK AND CAUGHT SOME TALK
AND UNIFORMITY THROUGHOUT THE
STATE WE HAVE FORMALLY
THROUGHOUT THE STATE CURRENTLY
IN TERMS OF CIRCUMSTANCES IN
WHICH PEOPLE SHOULD NOT BE
REQUIRED TO PAY AT ALL AND IT'S
NOT WORKING.
POOR PEOPLE WHO WHO BASED ON
CURRENT LAW SHOULD BE WEIGHED
SHOULD NOT HAVE TO PAY THE FEES
ARE BEING CHARGED.
IN CENTER JACKSON RECOVERED SO I
WON'T ASK AGAIN BUT A
FORGIVENESS POLICY OR A YOU KNOW.
THOSE ARE SOME THOUGHTS ABOUT OF
STOP THEIR MANAGER THANK YOU
SENATOR THANK YOU SIR APPRECIATE
IT [inaudible]
CENTER WIENER.
I THANK YOU ROGER -- STRONG
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU FOR
CARING AND IT'S NOT ONLY A
SYMPTOM OF OUR OUR BROKEN CROWN
JUSTICE SYSTEM BY.
IT IS A A SYMPTOM OF OUR FAILURE
TO HAVE -- ADEQUATE PROGRESSIVE
TAXATION AND THE STATE THAT WE
WE RELY ON THE ON FEES AND FINES
AND PENALTIES. TO FUNDS
GOVERNMENT SERVICES THAT SHOULD
BE FUNDED THROUGH TAXES AND THEN
THAT ENDS UP FALLING ON LOW
INCOME PEOPLE SO.
I THIS IS A GOOD START. ONE
QUESTION THOUGH IN TERMS OF THE
CONCERN WAS RAISED ABOUT THE
IGNITION INTERLOCK DEVICE WHICH
OF COURSE WE HAD A BILL WHAT TWO
WEEKS AGO CENTER OURSELVES --
BILL WHICH WE ARE WHICH I
SUPPORTED AND OF THE COMMITTEE
SUPPORTED -- CAN YOU JUST
COMMENT ON THAT BECAUSE I THINK
THAT IS -- IMPORT IN AND OF
COURSE WE DON'T WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE WE HAVE SUBSIDIES FOR LOW
INCOME FOLKS BUT IF YOU COULD
JUST COMMENT ON THAT OCCASION AS
THE OPPOSITE THAT.
STATED THAT WE'RE IN
CONVERSATIONS WILL CONTINUE AT
THIS POINT WE HAVE A COMPANY
AGREEMENT BUT BUT WE HAVE OPEN
DOOR POLICY WE CONTINUE TO TALK
ABOUT IT THANK YOU IT IS NOT OUR
GOAL -- TO CREATE A NEW SYSTEM
THAT IS EQUALLY AS FAR AS THE
CURRENT ONE AND WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK THROUGH IT.
ARE WE HAVE A MOTION.
IN THE LAST COMMENT I WANT TO
MAKE IT SOUND.
THERE WAS REFERENCE SOMEWHAT BUT
NOT ALL OF THESE -- FINDS OUR
FEES ARE -- CAN AFFECT SOLD TO A
COLLECTION AGENCY BUT VERY
COMMONLY WHAT LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
DO NOW.
IS IN EFFECT TURN OVER THE
COLLECTION.
AND WHEN -- JUST. FOR EXAMPLE
THIS IS MORE AROUND AND PARKING
AND TRAFFIC FINES.
BACK IN THE EIGHTIES WHEN I WAS
ON THE BERKELEY CITY COUNCIL.
AND WE ASKED FOR AN AUDIT OF
WHAT WE WERE ACTUALLY RECOVERING
FROM OUR FINES AND FEES WE FOUND
THAT WE WERE RECOVERING VERY LOW
BECAUSE OF OUR USE OF THESE
COLLECTION AGENCIES.
AND WHEN WE DID PARKING TICKET
AMNESTY WE COLLECTED MORE MONEY.
THAN WE MEANING JUST BASICALLY
BRING BRING IT DOWN TO THE
BOTTOM LEVEL FEE WITH NO FOR NO
PENALTY WE'VE COLLECTED MORE
MONEY.
THAN WE COLLECTED WITH THE OTHER
SYSTEM SO I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
ALSO TO NOTE THAT THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS THEMSELVES IN A AND
I THINK THIS IS BEEN REFERENCE
IN THIS NOT THE CASE IN EVERYONE
OF THESE CATEGORIES BUT IN MANY
OF THEM.
THEY REALLY -- THEMSELVES ARE
NOT RECOVERING THIS REVENUE SO --
ANYWAY MIDDLE MAN YES ONE MORE
QUESTION -- I ACTUALLY GO AHEAD.
I WONDER SENATOR -- IF YOU WOULD
BE WILLING -- TO KEEP IN MIND
THIS ISSUE OF THESE PROGRAMS ON
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE THE VERSION.
SO THAT IF IT IS THAT WE CAN.
THAT I CAN TAKE COMFORT BECAUSE
I SUPPORT THE THE THE NATURE OF
THIS BILL.
IN THE BUT SOME ASSURANCES THAT
THAT WE WILL CONTINUE TO TRY TO
GET FUNDING FOR THESE PROGRAMS.
THROUGH THE BUDGET THROUGH SOME
OTHER.
RECOURSE.
I I WILL BE HEARTSICK TO SEE
THESE PROGRAMS DISAPPEAR WE'VE
FOUGHT SO HARD TO GET.
A CREATED THEY ARE SO IMPORTANT
TO TRYING TO DEAL WITH THIS THIS
EPIDEMIC OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
THAT WE KNOW EXIST THROUGHOUT
THE WORLD.
OUR AND AND TO SEE BECAUSE OF A
GOOD PROGRAMMER GOOD EFFORT LIKE
THIS TO SEE ANOTHER GOOD EFFORT.
TERMINATED OF WOOD IS IS A
LITTLE MORE THAN I CAN BEAR SO
WITH YOUR WITH YOUR INSURANCE SO
YOU'LL KEEP FIGHTING FOR THIS
SITE I WOULD BE WILLING AND ABLE
TO SUPPORT YOUR FILL.
OUT THAT ARE JACKSON I'M IN
RECEIPT OF YOUR BUDGET UP
PRIORITY ASKED WITH REGARD TO
THIS FUNDING I HAVE RECEIVED AND
READ IT.
US SECONDLY -- I THINK THAT
WE'VE.
THIS LEGISLATURE HAS SHOWN A
HISTORICAL COMMITMENT -- AND AND
WE'VE EVEN HAD CONVERSATIONS --
IN RECENT YEARS REALLY ABOUT
KIND OF THE CONTENT OF THOSE
PROGRAMS TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY
ARE STILL RELEVANT THAT PEOPLE
WHO DO ATTEND ON THE WEATHER NOT
THE FIFTY TWO WEEKS IS
ADEQUATELY FAT ONGOING
CONVERSATION.
ON NOT ONLY IN ON THE FUNDING
SIDE IN TERMS OF THE CONTENT
MAKING SURE THAT THE PROGRAM'S
REALLY ARE A MEETING THE GOAL
THAT WE ALL HOPE THAT THEY DO
IT'S ONE THING TO WANT TO
PROTECT THE PROGRAM THAT'S BEEN
LONG STANDING ON THE BOOK IS
ANOTHER THING TO MAKE.
SURE THAT WE CONTINUE TO BE
RELEVANT AND TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
EVEN MORE CURRENT RESEARCH IN
TERMS OF WHAT AFFECTS BEHAVIOR
CHANGE
UP I DON'T MY COMMITMENT IS NOT
WAVER I DON'T BELIEVE THE
LEGISLATURE'S COMMITMENT AS A
WHOLE IS WAVING WILL CONTINUE TO
PUSH FORWARD TO MAKE SURE THAT.
THE THE APPROPRIATE ALTERNATIVES
THE APPROPRIATE INVENTION THE
APPROPRIATE TRAINING CONTINUE TO
EXIST -- AND I'LL STAND
ALONGSIDE YOU.
ARM I DON'T WANT -- TO AND WILL
CONTINUE TO HAVE THE
CONVERSATION AS WE'VE COMMITTED --
WITH THE INTERLOCKING DEVICES TO
CONTINUE THE CONVERSATION BUT I
DON'T WANT IT LOST ON ANY OF US.
THE THE BROADER.
CONCEPT OF AROUND WHETHER OR NOT
IT'S APPROPRIATE THAT WE TAX
RESIDENTS. FOR THE BENEFIT.
OF GOVERNMENT SERVICES -- I HEAR
YOU AND WE CAN GO THROUGH THIS
AND PIECEMEAL AND PULL OUT
INDIVIDUAL CASES THAT PEOPLE
COULD ARGUE.
ON BEHALF OF AGAIN IT IS NOT THE
RESEARCH DOES NOT BRING TO BEAR
THE NOTION.
THAT IT'S A GOOD NUMBER OF
PEOPLE OF MEANS.
WHO ARE IMPACTED BY THESE FINES
AND FEES THAT'S JUST NOT THE
CASE AGAIN I WOULD ARGUE THAT I
WANT TO MAKE SURE? TO THE
DELIVERY OF THOSE SERVICES IN
THAT TRAINING THAT ALL PEOPLE
HAVE ACCESS AND IT'S NOT JUST
BASED ON ONE'S ABILITY TO PAY.
AND SO TO DO THAT IS THE ROLE OF
GOVERNMENT TO STEP UP TO MAKE
SURE THAT THOSE SERVICES ARE
AVAILABLE LIKE IF YOU TO STAND
WITH YOU WE WILL CONTINUE TO
HAVE THE CONVERSATION.
AND I APPRECIATE YOUR COMMITMENT
TO THE ISSUE AND RAISING IT
THANK YOU.
ENSURE WE TAKE THAT AS YOUR
CLOTHES I ASKED FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT SO WE HAVE A MOTION
CENTER REDFORD'S MOTION --
WITHOUT ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS WE WILL NOW DO A ROLL
CALL.
SHE IS THE PASTOR APPROPRIATIONS
SKINNER HI SKINNER AYE MOORLACH.
BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE JACKSON.
JACKSON AYE MITCHELL AYE
MITCHELL I'M AROUND.
ROLL NO WIENER.
WIENER AYE -- WE WILLHOLD THE
ROLE OPEN YEAH -- THERE WILL.
HAVE THE BILL ON CALL THANK YOU
APPRECIATE IT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR THE DISCUSSION MEMBERS.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT SO NOW WE
ARE GOING.
TO MOVE TO ITEM SIX BUT BEFORE
WE'VE TRIED AND SIX SEVEN AND
NOW IT'S MEANT -- SENATOR --
BIRD HAS NOW PULLED SB FIVE
THIRTY SIX THAT'S ITEM SIXTEEN
SO WE WILL NOT BE HEARING IT
TODAY HE IS REQUESTED TO MAKE IT
TO YOUR BILL.
SO -- WE WHILE WE ARE PREPARING
FOR ITEM NUMBER -- I MEAN I CAN
GO JONES ALRIGHT LET'S GO
SENATOR JONES WE CAN -- A RATHER
STORY CENTER HILL NAY RUMOR YES
WEEK THE NEXT WOULD BE ACTUALLY
SB THREE OR FOUR CENTER HILL.
WHILE WE WAIT FOR MISS CABALLERO.
SB THREE OH FOR ITEM NUMBER. TEN
THIRTY HILL YOU MAY PROCEED
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR -- GOOD
MORNING -- MEMBERS AMEND I'M
HAPPY TO ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS TO LIMIT
CONSOLIDATION TO FEND FELONY
FINANCIAL ELDER ABUSE CRIMES
COMMITTED IN MULTIPLE
JURISDICTIONS.
SENATE BILL THREE OR FOUR WILL
ALLOW DISTRICT ATTORNEYS TO
CONSOLIDATE ELDERLY AND
DEPENDENT ADULTS FRAUD CASES
THAT SPAN MULTIPLE COUNTIES INTO
A SINGLE PROSECUTION.
UNDER THIS LEGISLATION THE
BURDEN IS EAST FOR THOSE WHO ARE
VICTIMS OF A SUSPECTED SERIAL
PERPETRATOR OR PERPETRATORS WHO
MUST THEN COPE WITH THE
CHALLENGES.
OF TESTIFYING MULTIPLE TIMES AND
IN MULTIPLE LOCATIONS AS
PROSECUTORS TRY THEIR CASE.
SB THREE OR FOUR ENSURES THAT
THE PROSECUTION WILL CONTINUE TO
HAVE A PRESIDENT WRITTEN
EVIDENCE THAT ALL DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS IN COUNTIES WITH
JURISDICTION AGREED TO THE ONE
COUNTY BEING SELECTED
ADDITIONALLY THE JUDGES REQUIRED
TO WAY.
WHEN DETERMINING WHETHER THE
CASES SHOULD BE TRIED IN ONE
COUNTY FOR PROSECUTION THE
LOCATION AND COMPLEXITY?
OF THE LIKELY EVIDENCE WHERE THE
MAJORITY OF THE OFFENSES
OCCURRED THE RIGHTS OF THE
DEFENDANT AND THE PEOPLE AND THE
CONVENIENCE OF OR HARDSHIP.
TO THE VICTIM OR VICTIMS AND
WITNESSES BY VIRTUE OF US
DEMOGRAPHICS DEPENDENT ADULT AN
ELDER ABUSE IS THE FASTEST
GROWING AREA OF CRIME IN THE
UNITED STATES.
AS THE BABY BOOMER GENERATION
AGES.
FINANCIAL CRIMES AGAINST THE
ELDERLY WILL ONLY CONTINUE TO
INCREASE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR
WE SHOULD VERY GOOD THANK YOU
WITNESSES SO [inaudible]
PLEASE PROCEED.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS KRISTEN
MINIMAL I AM A DEPUTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY WITH THE SAN MATEO
COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
OFFICE.
AND I APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK BEFORE YOU TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF SB THREE OR FOUR I AM
A PROSECUTOR IN THE OLDER
INDEPENDENT ADULT ABUSE DIVISION
AND SAN MATTEO COUNTY.
AND I CAN TELL YOU THAT IT HAS
BEEN THE JOY OF MY CAREER TO
SERVE THESE VICTIMS.
I GET TO WAKE UP EVERY MORNING
KNOWING THAT I GET TO DO
SOMETHING GOOD FOR ONE OF THE
VOTE ONE OF THE MOST VULNERABLE
SEGMENTS OF OUR SOCIETY.
THE ELDERLY AND THE DEPENDENT
ADULTS IN OUR COMMUNITIES.
ALL TOO OFTEN I SEE ELDER
INDEPENDENT ADULTS WHO ARE
SPECIFICALLY TARGETED.
BECAUSE OF THEIR AGE OR BECAUSE
OF THEIR DISABILITY.
THESE PERPETRATORS SELECT THEM
BECAUSE OF THOSE VERY
VULNERABILITIES.
BECAUSE OF THEIR AGE THEIR
FRAILTY.
THEIR POOR MEMORIES THEIR
LIKELIHOOD OF GETTING CONFUSED.
THEIR DEFICITS AND DETECTING
DECEPTION.
AND PERHAPS MOST TRAGICALLY.
THESE INDIVIDUALS DESIRES TO
STILL BE OF USE TO THEIR LOVED
ONES INTO THE COMMUNITY AND THE
LONELINESS OF THE OFTEN FEEL.
AS THEY REACH THE END OF THEIR
LIVES.
WITH THE EVER INCREASING ELDERLY
POPULATION IN CALIFORNIA.
THESE CRIMES IN PARTICULAR
FINANCIAL CRIMES ARE MORE AND
MORE COMMON.
BECAUSE NOT ONLY ARE OLDER
INDEPENDENT ADULTS EXTREMELY
VULNERABLE BUT UNLIKE OTHER
VULNERABLE GROUPS SUCH AS
CHILDREN.
ELDERS INDEPENDENT ADULTS HAVE
MONEY THEY HAVE ASSETS THEY HAVE
PENSIONS.
THEY HAVE SAVINGS ACCOUNTS OFTEN
THEY OWN HOMES OR OTHER
PROPERTIES.
AND THAT MAKES THEM IN THE EYES
OF THESE WOULD BE ABUSERS THE
PERFECT VICTIMS.
SB THREE OR FOUR WILL PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL PROTECTIONS TO THOSE
VICTIMS BY PERMITTING OF THOSE
WHO COMMIT FINANCIAL ABUSE IN
MULTIPLE JURISDICTIONS. TO BE
TRIED IN A SINGLE COUNTY.
NOT ONLY WILL THIS IMPROVE
JUDICIAL ECONOMY IT WILL PREVENT
VICTIMS FROM HAVING TO BE
INVOLVED IN MULTIPLE
PROSECUTIONS WHICH OFTEN
INVOLVES TESTIFYING IN MULTIPLE
HEARINGS.
TRAVELLING TO MULTIPLE COURT
ROOMS AND CAN BE VERY STRESSFUL
AND DIFFICULT FOR OLDER
INDEPENDENT ADULTS.
THE LEGISLATURE HAS ALREADY
AFFORD THESE PROTECTIONS TO
OTHER VULNERABLE VICTIM GROUPS.
CHILDREN VICTIMS OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE VICTIMS OF STALKING A
SEXUAL ASSAULT.
AN OF HUMAN TRAFFICKING.
WITH THE PASSAGE OF SB THREE OR
FOUR ELDER INDEPENDENT ADULTS
WILL BE INCLUDED AND THEY WILL
GET TO THE EQUAL PROTECTION THAT
THEY SOLD.
VERY MUCH DESERVED UNDER THIS
LAW.
YOU MAY BE THINKING OF FINANCIAL
CRIMES AGAINST OLDER INDEPENDENT
ADULTS ARE DIFFERENT CLASS OF
CRIMES.
BECAUSE THEY ARE NOT CRIMES OF
VIOLENCE AND THEREFORE LESS
SERIOUS AND LESS IMPACTFUL ON
THE VICTIMS.
BUT I CAN TELL YOU FROM SEEING
AND HEARING AND SPEAKING TO
THESE VICTIMS THAT THAT COULD
NOT BE FURTHER FROM THE TRUTH.
I HAVE MET WITH A WORLD WAR TWO
VETERAN WHO IS A VERY PROUD SELF
SUFFICIENT MEMBER.
OF THE GREATEST GENERATION AND
I'VE SEEN HIM BREAK DOWN IN
TEARS DESCRIBING HOW HE WAS
SWINDLED OUT OF MONEY.
AND HOW HE WAS GOING TO TELL HIS
FAMILY.
WHO REVERE HIM AND LOVE HIM?
THAT HE FELL FOR SUCH A SCHEME.
I'VE SEEN A SEVENTY FIVE YEAR
OLD IMMIGRANT FROM MEXICO LOSE
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS.
AND WHAT HE BELIEVED WAS AN
ATTEMPT TO HELP ANOTHER LESS
FORTUNATE IMMIGRANT.
AND AS A RESULT OF THAT LOSS HE
HAD TO DECIDE FOR SEVERAL MONTHS
WHETHER TO EAT THREE SQUARE
MEALS A DAY OR TO PAY FOR HIS
MEDICATION.
I'VE SEEN A WIDOW WHOSE WEDDING
RING WAS POND.
BY SOMEONE THAT WAS SUPPOSED TO
BE HERE CARE TAKER.
THAT WEDDING RING WAS LOST
BECAUSE IT WAS MELTED DOWN FOR
GOLD AND THAT WOMAN WILL NEVER
GET THAT VALUABLE.
PROBABLY THE MOST VALUABLE ITEM
SHE OWNS BACK AGAIN.
AND I'VE SEEN DEPENDENT ADULTS
WHO WHOSE PARENTS BEFORE THEY
DIED SET THEM UP TO HAVE A
SECURE.
HOME BECAUSE THEY COULD NO
LONGER WORK.
AND TO SEE THOSE PEOPLE BE
SWINDLED OUT OF THEIR MONEY AND
FORCED TO LIVE.
IN CRAMPED CARE HOMES WHEN THEIR
FAMILIES THAT AFFORDED. FOR THEM.
A BETTER LIFE.
AND THE PROBLEM WITH ELDERLY
INDEPENDENT VICTIMS IS THAT MOST
FREQUENTLY THEY CANNOT WORK.
THEY CANNOT MAKE THAT MONEY BACK
SO ONCE IT IS GONE IT'S GONE.
AND THEY WHO WORKED SO HARD FOR
THEIR ENTIRE LIVES TO GIVE
THEMSELVES PEACE AND SECURITY
AND COMFORT.
ARE LEFT TO TRY TO PICK UP THE
PIECES.
THESE FINANCIAL CRIMES WHEN
ELDERLY OR DEPENDENT ADULTS ARE
VICTIMS ARE DEVASTATING.
THEY MUST BE TAKEN SERIOUSLY AND
WE MUST DO ALL IN OUR POWER TO
PROTECT THESE VULNERABLE MEMBERS
OF OUR SOCIETY.
WITH SENATE BILL THREE OH FOR
YOU TODAY HAVE THE POWER TO DO
JUST THAT AND I URGE YOU TO VOTE
YES ON THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT --
JUMPSTARTED KIA.
PUBLIC ADVOCATE OF KERA.
OWL.
AND HAVING HERE JUST WITHIN
SACRAMENTO IN PLASTER COUNTY.
THEME THAT INDEED OCCUR IN
JURISDICTIONS WERE ISSUES SO
PLEASE THIS NEEDS TO BE IN THERE
AND THIS NEEDS TO BE SUPPORTED
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
TELL OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
IF YOU TO STEP FOR WITH YOUR
NAME AND AFFILIATION PLEASE.
TIFFANY MATTHEWS ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU DON KEPT HIM BEHALF OF
CRIME VICTIMS UNITED OF
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT THANK YOU.
VENTURE MEMBERS CORSO'S ALONG
BEHALF FOR THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
MANAGER RYAN SHERMAN WITH THE
RIVERSIDE SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
WOULD LIKE TO TAKE A SEAT.
LESLIE CALDWELL CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION --
I AM EXTREMELY SYMPATHETIC TO
THE ISSUE -- MY OWN MOTHER
RECENTLY PASSED WAS -- SUFFERING
FROM ADVANCING DEMENTIA.
AND WE HAD TO DO A LOT -- TO
PROTECTOR.
HOWEVER -- THIS BILL ADDS YET
ANOTHER CRIME TO THE MULTI
JURISDICTIONAL -- PROSECUTION --
WE'VE HEARD VERY SAD STORIES
FROM THE THE PROSECUTOR HERE
TODAY AND I AM DEEPLY
SYMPATHETIC HOWEVER -- IN MY
EXPERIENCE AS A LONG TERM.
PUBLIC DEFENDER -- MOST OF THE
CASES IF NOT ALL THE CASES THAT
WE SAW WERE IN ONE JURISDICTION.
AND THERE WAS NO TESTIMONY AND
THE REGARDING THE INCIDENTS THAT
FROM THE PROSECUTOR THAT ANY OF
THESE -- CASES INVOLVED MULTIPLE
JURISDICTIONS -- WELL I
UNDERSTAND THAT THE AMENDMENTS
CONTEMPLATE MOVING OUT OF THE
SEXUAL ASSAULT STATUTE.
A AND I COULD BE WRONG THE
EQUIVALENT JURISDICTIONAL
STATUTE IS PENAL CODE SECTION
SEVEN EIGHTY FOUR POINT.
SEVEN THIS STATUE HAS BEEN
EXPANDED VERY RAPIDLY -- THREE
TIMES IN THE LAST FIVE YEARS
THERE'S TOO MUCH ARE. TOO MUCH
HERE WITH THE EXPANSION AND WE
DON'T KNOW WHETHER THE BENEFITS
OF CONSOLIDATION -- IN ONE
COUNTY OUTWEIGH THE PROBLEMS TO
THE PROSECUTION AND OR THE
DEFENSE OR THE VICTIMS AND
WITNESSES.
WE DON'T KNOW WHETHER THERE ARE
BENEFITS TO THAT YET WE NEED TO
PAUSE WE NEED TO FIND OUT
WHETHER THE CHANGES ARE HELPING
OR HARMING JUDICIAL ECONOMY.
HOW THEY'RE ACTUALLY AFFECTING
CONVENIENCE OR HARDSHIP TO THE
VICTIMS AND WITNESSES INCREASING
OR DECREASING OVERALL
PROSECUTION AND DEFENSE EXPENSES?
AND MOST IMPORTANTLY WHETHER
THIS ACTUALLY HELPS PUBLIC
pBE -- CONTEMPLATED BY SB THREE
OH FOUR IS DETRIMENTAL TO A FAIR
TRIAL FOR THE DEFENDANT.
WHEN THERE ARE MULTIPLE CHARGES
THE JURY OFTEN HAS A VERY
DIFFICULT TIME PARSING OUT EACH?
PARSING OUT OF THE DETAILS OF
WEIGHING EACH INDIVIDUAL
INCIDENT.
SEPARATELY IT ALSO PLACES A VERY
HEAVY BURDEN ON THE PUBLIC
DEFENDER'S OFFICES THESE CASES
ARE RARELY PRIVATE COUNSEL CASES --
IN THAT THE RESOURCES THAT ARE
INVOLVED INVOLVED THE RESOURCES
FROM ALL THE DIFFERENT COUNTIES
PROSECUTION OFFICES ALL THE
DIFFERENT LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES.
AND THEN FOR THE DEFENSE THERE
IS ONLY THE ONE PROSECUTORIAL
PUBLIC DEFENDER'S OFFICE.
AND I COULDN'T AND TELL YOU THAT
RECENTLY I TRIED A CASE THAT WAS
A SEXUAL ASSAULT CASE MULTI
JURISDICTIONAL -- SIXTY ONE
COUNTS FIVE DIFFERENT
JURISDICTIONS.
ABOUT EIGHT DIFFERENT LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES.
AND ME -- I WAS AT THAT TIME THE
CHIEF -- DEPUTY IN CHARGE OF
RUNNING THE MAIN OFFICE OF THE
SOLANO COUNTY -- PUBLIC
DEFENDER'S OFFICE.
I COULD NOT DO THAT ALL I COULD
DO WAS.
TRIED TO **** THEM TIME FOR ONE
OF THE OTHER FELONY LAWYERS.
AND DEVOTE MY FULL ATTENTION TO
THE CASE WE DID NOT GET ANY
EXTRA HELP -- WITH RESOURCES.
FURTHERMORE THE GENERAL IN TIME
HONORED RULE IN THIS COUNTRY IS
THE KIND OF CRIMINAL TRIAL
SHOULD BE HELD IN THE AREA WHERE
THEY OCCURRED WE RECOGNIZE THAT
THERE ARE SOME EXCEPTIONS TO
THAT RULE BUT THEY SHOULD REMAIN
JUST THAT.
EXCEPTIONS WE RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR NO VOTE ON SB.
THREE OH FOUR ARE THERE ANY
OTHER WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
POINTS.
ALL RIGHT COMMENT STORE -- YES
SENATOR JACKSON'S -- JUST A
QUICK QUESTION BECAUSE I DO
SUPPORT THIS WE ARE AN AGING
POPULATION.
WE ARE SEEING MORE AND MORE OF
THIS ABUSE GOING ON WE'VE GOT TO
RECOGNIZE THAT MANY OF THESE
VICTIMS ARE HAVING COGNITIVE
ISSUES -- THEIR HEALTH IS AT
RISK.
BUT THERE WAS ONE QUESTION THAT
COST ME A LITTLE PAUSE.
I'M ASSUMING THAT OF ALL OF THE
OFFENSES OCCURRED WITHIN ONE
JURISDICTION THEN THE MULTI
JURISDICTIONAL ASPECT OF THIS
DOES NOT.
TAKE PLACE IS THAT CORRECT THAT
IS CORRECT ARTS SO IT WOULD HELP.
SO WOULD HAVE TO PULL A PLY TOO
MANY OTHER JURISDICTIONS.
A LAST QUESTION I HAVE IS -- I I
THOUGHT I HEARD YOU SAY THAT
THERE IS DATA.
SHOWING THE EFFICACY OF THESE
KINDS OF PROCEEDINGS THAT SO
THAT WE'RE NOT JUST KIND OF
FLYING BLIND HERE THAT THERE
THAT THERE ARE -- IS INDICATION
THAT -- THESE KINDS OF EFFORTS
THERE WHERE YOU CAN COMPRESS
THEM ALL.
INTO -- ONE IF YOU KNOW ONE
ACTION IF YOU WILL -- IF DOES --
ASSIST THOSE.
OLDER VICTIMS WHO ARE BEING
VICTIMIZED.
AGAIN IF YOU WELL BY HAVING TO
GO TO A NUMBER OF PROCEEDINGS
WHICH HAVE TO BE THERE HARD ON
ANYBODY LET ALONE SOMEONE WHO'S
GOT ALL THESE OTHER ISSUES TO
CONTEND WITH IS THAT CORRECT IS
THERE DATA THAT SHOWS THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF THIS.
I CAN TELL YOU THAT FROM MY
YEARS OF PROSECUTING THESE CASES
WE HAVE SEEN A VERY LARGE
INCREASE ININDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
GOING FROM COUNTY TO COUNTY.
PERPETRATING CRIMES TARGETING
ELDERLY INDEPENDENT ADULTS AND
THEN MOVING TO A DIFFERENT
JURISDICTION AND DOING THE SAME
THING AND THEY ARE RELYING ON
THOSE COGNITIVE ABILITIES
LACKING.
THERE -- AND ABILITIES OF THEIR
VICTIMS TO PERHAPS IDENTIFY THE
PERPETRATORS TO THEIR FOR BRING
THEM TO JUSTICE.
AND SO -- I CAN TELL YOU THAT WE
ARE SEEING THAT MUCH MORE
FREQUENTLY AND RIGHT NOW OUR
OFFICE IS PROSECUTING.
A NUMBER OF CASES WHERE THE SAME
PERPETRATOR HAS TARGETED ELDERLY
INDEPENDENT ADULTS IN
NEIGHBORING COUNTY SUCH AS SAN
FRANCISCO SANTA CLARA ALAMEDA
CONTRA COSTA.
AND IT IS RIGHT NOW TO THE STATE
OF THE LAW IS EXTREMELY ARDUOUS
BECAUSE THOSE VICTIMS ARE HAVING
TO BE.
ESSENTIALLY TRANSPORTED FROM
COUNTY TO COUNTY TELLING THEIR
STORY OVER AND OVER AGAIN RE
LIVING IT -- IN FRONT OF
MULTIPLE COURTS.
THEY THROUGH THE CHAIR COULD I
GET A RESPONSE FROM THE PUBLIC
DEFENDER YES YES SHOW ME MY
QUESTION YES THANK YOU -- WELL
BOTH OF US CAN GO BACK AND FORTH
ON WAT WE'VE SEEN PROSECUTION
AND DEFENSE.
THERE'S BEEN NO STUDY THERE IS
NO FIRM DATA THERE IS JUST OUR
PERSONAL EXPERIENCES BILL.
SO THANK YOU AND IS SO I THINK
I'M GOING.
TO HI MY INTUITIVE SENSE AND SAY
THIS IS I THINK A TREMENDOUS
BURDEN ON SENIORS WE WE HAVE
IDENTIFIED IN WE DO NOW ALLOWING
CIVIL CASES PRIORITIZING.
FOR OUR SENIOR POPULATION --
HIGH -- I APPRECIATE THE
CONCERNS BUT I THINK THIS IS
PROBABLY AN IMPORTANT BILL AND
IF YOU DO AMENDED I WOULD LIKE
TO BE ADDRESS COLLECTED.
THANK YOU THE THINGS THAT
REJECTION AGAIN I APPRECIATE
YOUR HISTORIC A SUPPORT AND THE
AND COMMITMENT.
TO THE ELDERLY AND SENIORS AND
AND THE LEGISLATION THAT YOU
CAN'T WIN FOR AND AND I DID WANT
TO MENTION THAT.
AS WE KNOW THERE ARE NUMBER OF
SAFEGUARDS OF CHECKS AND
BALANCES WITHIN THIS LEGISLATION
THE THE ALL OF THE DA'S -- HAVE
TO AGREE IN AND WRITING AND IT
DOES GO BEFORE A JUDGE TO MAKE
THE DETERMINATION THE WITNESSES
ARE PROJECTED THAT THE OF
VICTIMS ARE PROTECTED AND AND
CERTAINLY THE THOSE ACCUSED WILL
BE THAT THEIR RIGHTS WILL NOT BE
AFFECTED BY THIS WHICH THERE ARE
SOME CHECK TO JUST.
DO THE TEACHERS CAN'T DECIDE TO
DO IT [inaudible]
THANK YOU -- SENATOR MITCHELL
THANK YOU I JUST -- SENATOR HILL
YOUR LAST COMMENT ABOUT THE THE
DEFENDANTS THAT THEIR RIGHTS
WOULD BE -- PROTECTED I'M JUST
CURIOUS BECAUSE IN THE
OPPOSITION LISTED IN THE
ANALYSIS -- I BELIEVE IT WAS THE
PUBLIC DEFENDERS WHO SUGGESTED
THAT CAN FILED THE CONSOLIDATION
OF CASES IS PRESENT IS
PREJUDICIAL AGAINST THE
DEFENDANT -- FELL.
FELL HADN'T WHAT WHAT IS IN THE
BILL THAT SUGGESTS THAT THE
DEFENDANT'S RIGHTS WOULD BE
PROTECTED IN I UNDERSTAND YOU
KNOW A LOT A LOT OF THE DIETA TO
TALK ABOUT THAT.
SPECIFICALLY WITH THE RITE OF
THE OF THE OF IN THE HARDSHIP OF
ANYONE WITHIN THAT THAT CASE
WILL BE REVIEWED BY THE JUDGE TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE PLOT. TO SHOW
IN ANY WAY THAT'S THE FOR THE
DEFENDED AS WELL THE DEFENDANT
AS WELL YES I MEAN THAT'S THAT'S
THAT THE PURPOSE OF IT IS TO
LOOK AT THE THE CASE
HOLISTICALLY TO DETERMINE
WHETHER THERE ARE.
THERE'S HARM TO ANYONE UHHUH
UHHUH BY THE FACT OF MOVING IT
TO ONE AND CONSOLIDATING WITH
JURISDICTION ONE MORE QUESTION
THEN THROUGH THE CHAIR WE WOULD
ALLOW THE REPRESENT DIFFERENT
PUBLIC DEFENDER TO RESPOND TO
THAT AS WELL BUT MY NATIONAL
QUESTION IS.
HOW WE DECIDE WHICH?
COURT OR WHICH COUNTY HAS
JURISDICTION THE IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT HISTORICALLY
THAT THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY WILL
DECIDE THAT WHAT COUNTY IS THAT
THE WAY THAT HISTORICALLY IT
WORKS.
YES AND THEN IT WOULD BE SUBJECT
TO A HEARING IN THE JURISDICTION
WHERE THE DA'S OFFICE IS
PROPOSING TO HOLD.
THE TRIAL OR TO PROSECUTE A
PARTICULAR CASE IT WOULD BE THEN
DECIDED BY A MAGISTRATE IN THAT
JURISDICTION AFTER HEARING ABOUT
THE FACTS OF THE CASE.
THE COMPLEXITY OF THE EVIDENCE
FAIRNESS TO THE VICTIMS FAIRNESS
TO OTHER WITNESSES AND FAIRNESS
OF COURSE TO THE ACCUSED THE
DEFENDANTS.
AND AND ALL OF THAT WILL BE
TAKING THE CONSIDERATION TO
FIGURE OUT WHICH COUNTY WHICH
COURT IT WOULD BE HEARD IT
THAT'S CORRECT SENATOR OKAY.
AND THROUGH THE CHAIR IF THE
REPRESENTED FROM PUBLIC
DEFENDERS CAN RESPOND TO THAT
CONCERN AROUND -- PRESIDENTIAL
PRESS.
PREJUDICIAL CIRCUMSTANCES
AGAINST THE DEFENDANT.
OFTEN IN THESE HEARINGS I AM --
ASKING YOU NOT TO TAKE
DISCRETION AWAY FROM A COURT TO
HEAR THE COURT DOES HAVE
DISCRETION.
HOWEVER IF A GROUP OF
PROSECUTORS AGREED THAT IT
SHOULD BE DONE IN ONE COUNTY.
I CANNOT IMAGINE A JUDGE SAYING --
IT'S TOO PREJUDICIAL AGAINST THE
DEFENDANT -- AND GIVEN THAT.
REALITY -- I REALLY DO
[inaudible]
HOPE THAT.
THIS COMMITTEE WOULD LOOK FOR
SOME TRUE DATA TRUE INFORMATION
ABOUT WHETHER THIS IS.
JUDICIALLY ECONOMIC IF IT
AFFECTS THE PROSECUTION IN A
POSITIVE OR NEGATIVE WAY THE
DEFENSE FOR THE VICTIMS THE
WITNESSES AND AGAIN I'M VERY
VERY SYMPATHETIC. TO THE ISSUES
HOWEVER -- WHAT I HAVE SEEN IN
THE OTHER TYPES OF MULTI
JURISDICTIONAL -- PROSECUTIONS
IS.
IT KIND OF COMES DOWN TO THE
COUNTY WHERE MOST OFFENSES
OCCURRED AND WHERE THE DEFENDANT
IS YEAH SO THE CASE THAT I SPOKE
OF MY CLIENT WAS IN MY COUNTY.
THEREFORE I INHERITED
EVERYBODY'S CASE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR THE
CLARIFICATION FOR SHIP
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
IN ANY OTHER COMMENTS.
SO WE HAVE A MOTION SENATOR HILL
WHICH ELECTRICAL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH VENTURE I APPRECIATE THE
CONVERSATION AND DISCUSSION AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL COLLEGE.
AND THE BILL IS AS AMENDED YES
THAT'S THE MOTION -- ALL RIGHT
THEN WE WILL HAVE A ROLL CALL.
MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS SKINNER FIVE IN A
FIVE MORE LOCK [inaudible]
BRADFORD.
JACKSON HI JACKSON AYE MITCHELL.
MITCHELL AYE MORALE.
MORRELL AYE WIENER WIENER AYE.
THE BILL WILL REMAIN ON CALL
pTHANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU COLLECTION THANK YOU
[inaudible]
RIGHT [inaudible]
AND NOW.
WE WILL MOVE TO ITEM NUMBER
[inaudible]
SIX SENATOR CAFIERO.
WE BELIEVE YOU PROBABLY HAVE
SOME WITNESSES THAT WILL BE
COMING TO THE TABLE SO I WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT.
THE OUR SPECIAL SERVICES FOLKS
OUTSIDE KNOW THAT WE ARE
STARTING THIS BILL SO THEY CAN
ALLOW. FOR WITNESSES TO COME IN.
CALLING ALL WITNESSES.
THE AND THE PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION WOULD BE GOOD IF THEY
ARE IN --
YEAH
.
AT YOUR CELL.
WE NEED SOMEONE.
PART SENATOR CAREER YOU MAY
BEGIN THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
CHAIR AND SENATORS THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO INTRODUCE SB.
TWO THIRTY A BILL DESIGNED TO
REDUCE THE USE OF FORCE BY
POLICE OFFICERS AND AND THAT
WILL CHANGE THE CULTURE IN THE
WORKPLACE OF OVER FIVE HUNDRED
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
FIRST LET ME THANK THE COMMITTEE
AND THE CHAIR FOR YOUR
ASSISTANCE AND PATIENCE IN
WORKING WITH ALL THE PARTIES TO
MAKE THIS BILL BETTER.
SECOND WE ARE TAKING AS AUTHORS
AMENDMENTS TO AMENDMENTS ONE TO
DELETE THE FINDINGS AND
DECLARATION SECTION ONE F..
AND TO DO THAT TO DELETE SECTION
THREE OF THE BILL RELATING TO
PEOPLE BECAUSE ONE NINETY SIX
AND FINALLY TO ADD SECTION SIX
WHICH WOULD DURING MY BILL WITH
AB.
THREE NINETY TWO WE JOIN WITH
THE JOINT MAKING IT.
JOINING IT.
YES.
LET ME ALSO BEGIN BY THINKING
ALL OF THOSE INDIVIDUALS AND
GROUPS THAT SPOKE TO ME ABOUT SB
TWO THIRTY THEY CAME TO MY
OFFICE R RALLIED FOR CHANGE.
WE HEARD YOU WE LISTENED AND WE
RESPONDED BY MAKING AMENDMENTS
AND WILL CONTINUE TO DO SO.
QUESTION ME WHY WOULD YOU BE
INTERESTED IN THE BILL THAT IS
SO CONTROVERSIAL.
WELL I TELL YOU I SERVICES CITY
COUNCIL MEMBER FOR FIFTEEN YEARS
AND EIGHT YEARS AS MAYOR.
AS A MAYOR AND CITY COUNCIL
MEMBER I TOOK VERY SERIOUSLY AND
PERSONALLY THE RESPONSIBILITY TO
CREATE PEACE SAFETY AND HARMONY
AMONG ALL RESIDENTS OF THE
COMMUNITY.
NO MATTER WHO YOU ARE WHAT YOU
LOOK LIKE.
HOW YOU DRESSED IN WHAT KIND OF
WORK YOU DID?
THIS ISSUE OF WHEN THE USE OF
FORCE BY POLICE OFFICERS IS
APPROPRIATE AND UNDERWENT
CIRCUMSTANCES.
WAS AND IS VERY PERSONAL TO ME
AND IT IS AN EMOTIONAL COMPLEX
AND DIVISIVE ISSUE.
YET WE HAVE TO COME TOGETHER AND
FOCUS ON THE TRUE INTENT OF THE
BILL.
WHICH IS TO REDUCE THE NUMBER OF
USE OF FORCE INCIDENTS WHERE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO LEAD THE NATION
BY CITY SETTING A NEW STANDARD
THAT ESTABLISHES THE MOST
COMPREHENSIVE LEGISLATION
LEGISLATIVE SOLUTION. TO ONE OF
THE MOST CRITICAL ISSUES FACING
AMERICA TODAY.
THE COUNTRY NEEDS LEADERSHIP ON
THIS A ISSUE AND CALIFORNIA
NEEDS TO STAND TOGETHER AND LEAD
THE WAY FORWARD.
WE HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY AND MORE
IMPORTANTLY THE OBLIGATION TO
ENACT THE CHANGES NECESSARY TO
PROTECT OUR COMMUNITIES AND OUR
OFFICERS AS THEY UPHOLD THEIR
COMMITMENT TO SERVE.
THE TRUTH OF THE MATTER IS THAT
WE KNOW WE HAVE ROOM TO IMPROVE
WE NEED TO DO EVERYTHING IN OUR
POWER TO MINIMIZE THE USE OF
FORCE AND CALIFORNIA'S.
CALIFORNIANS DESERVE PROGRESS IF
WE WANT TO ACCOMPLISH MEANINGFUL
CHANGE.
WE HAVE TO WORK TOGETHER.
WE ARE COMMITTED TO TO DOING
JUST THAT AND TO DEVELOP AN
EFFECTIVE SOLUTION AND THAT
CHANGES.
OUR USE OF FORCE POLICIES THAT
WE CAN ALL CHAMPION TOGETHER.
THAT IS WHY I ALONG WITH THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT COMMUNITY HAVE BEEN
WORKING WITH THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL COMMUNITY LEADERS AND
THE TWENTY ONE LEGISLATORS WHO
CAUGHT THROUGH THE BILL TO
DEVELOP LEGISLATION THAT
INCLUDES INPUT.
FROM PERSPECTIVES ACROSS
CALIFORNIA.
WE HAVE USED RESEARCH AND
SURVEYS AS THE AND HAVE FOUND
THE MOST EFFECTIVE METHOD PROVEN
TO REDUCE THE USE OF FORCE.
IT IT IT IS AN EVIDENCE BASED
APPROACH THAT FOCUSES ON
ADOPTING NATIONALLY RECOGNIZED
BEST PRACTICES WITH PROVEN
RESULTS.
SB TWO THIRTY IS THE ONLY
LEGISLATION THAT WILL PROVIDE
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS WITH
THE TOOLS AND RESOURCES THEY
NEED TO REDUCE THE USE OF FORCE
EFFECTIVELY.
AND IT WILL BUILD ON
CALIFORNIA'S RIGOROUS OFFICER
TRAINING REQUIREMENTS BY
STABBING XING A MINIMUM STANDARD
ON THE USE OF FORCE FOR ALL FIVE
HUNDRED LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES
THROUGHOUT THE THE STATE.
CALIFORNIA WILL RAISE THE
NATIONAL STANDARD TO PROTECT THE
SANCTITY OF LIFE BY REQUIRING
THAT THE USE OF FORCE BE
PROPORTIONAL TO THE THREAT
IMPOSED.
ESTABLISHING THE FIRST STATEWIDE
GUIDELINES TO CLEARLY DEFINE
WHEN OFFICERS ARE AUTHORIZED TO
USE FORCE REQUIRING THAT EVERY
CALIFORNIA LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICER RECEIVED THE MOST ROBUST
TRAINING.
IN THE NATION STRICTLY DESIGNED
TO MINIMIZE USE OF FORCE SETTING
SPECIFIC POLICY REQUIREMENTS ON
DE ESCALATION INTERPERSONAL
COMMUNICATION TRAINING TACTICAL
METHODS THAT USED TIME.
DISTANCE COVER AND CONCEALMENT
REQUIRING IMPLICIT AND EXPLICIT
BIAS AND CULTURAL COMPETENCY
SETTING FOR DETAILS DETAILED
STANDARDIZE REQUIREMENTS FOR
REPORTING ALL INSTANCES WHEN
FORCE IS USED.
SPECIFYING THAT THE USE OF FORCE
POLICIES AND TRAINING ARE
CONSIDERED IN LEGAL PROCEEDINGS.
AND ADDING NEW DUTIES SUCH AS
THE DUTY TO RENDER MEDICAL AID
THE DUTY OF OFFICERS TO
INTERCEDE TO REPORT INCIDENTS OF
EXCESSIVE USE OF FORCE IN THE
DUTY OF SUPERVISORS TO REPORT
AND INVESTIGATE INCIDENTS AS
WELL.
ALL OF THESE NEW GUIDELINES AND
DUTIES WILL REQUIRE THAT ALL
POLICE AGENCIES IN THEIR
OFFICERS UNDERGO AND NEW
TRAINING AND EDUCATION PROGRAM.
THE STATE WILL NEED T COMMIT
THROUGH POST OUR POLICE OFFICERS
STANDARD TRAINING PROGRAM.
UP TO UNDER TACK UNDERTAKE THIS
TRAINING AND DEFINE THE CHANGE
WE BELIEVE THAT SB TWO THIRTY
MAKES FUNDAMENTAL CHANGES TO HOW
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS ARE
TRAINED AND THAT THIS WILL
ENABLE THE CULTURE SHIFT AWAY
FROM DEADLY USE OF FORCE.
THAT IS SO IMPORTANT.
THERE IS WORK STILL TO BE DONE
AND I'VE COMMITTEE YOU TO
CONTINUE FOCUS ON SOLUTIONS THAT
CREATE CREATE MEANINGFUL CHANGE --
SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE WITH ME IN SUPPORT IS BRIAN
MARVEL PRESIDENT THE PIC POLICE
OFFICERS RESEARCH ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA.
KATHLEEN MISS MISS STAGNATE
STORM ATTORNEY WITH MISTER THE
WHOLE STATE AND CHIEF RON
LAWRENCE PRESIDENT THE
CALIFORNIA PEACE OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION.
WITH -- THANK YOU YOU MAY
PROCEED.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I'M BROWN
MARBLE PRESENT THE PEACE
OFFICERS RESEARCH ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA PORAC.
APPRECIATE THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
PROVIDE THE COMMITTEE WITH
TESTIMONY ON THIS CRUCIAL BILL
SB.
TWO THIRTY WHICH WILL SET A
NATIONAL PRECEDENT BY
ESTABLISHING THE MOST
COMPREHENSIVE LEGISLATIVE
SOLUTION. TO ONE OF THE MOST
CRITICAL ISSUES FACING AMERICA
TODAY. FOR ACT IS THE NATION'S
LARGEST STATEWIDE ASSOCIATION
RUBBER REPRESENTING PUBLIC
SAFETY PERSONNEL WITH OVER
SEVENTY FIVE THOUSAND MEMBERS.
OUR MEMBER SERVICE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IN MANY CAPACITIES AS
MUNICIPAL PEACE OFFICERS.
SHERIFF'S DEPUTIES CORRECTION
PROBATION OFFICERS.
SPECIALIZED PEACE OFFICERS
WORKING IN OUR AIRPORTS AND
SCHOOLS ONE WITH A VARIETY OF
OTHER STATEWIDE PUBLIC SAFETY
JOBS.
WE'RE DEDICATED PUBLIC SERVANTS
WHO ON A DAILY BASIS KEEP OUR
COMMUNITY SAFE.
THE LOSS OF EVEN ONE LIFE IS TOO
MANY.
THIS IS WHY THIS BILL'S AUTHOR.
SENATE KAVANA CAVALLARO AND ONE
FORTUNE COMMUNITY HAVE BEEN
WORKING WITH THE SENATE PRO
TEM'S OFFICE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DR WEBBER'S
OFFICE.
IN THE AMERICAN CIVIL LIBERTIES
UNION.
OVER THE LAST FIVE MONTHS TO
DEVELOP LEGISLATION.
IN ADDITION WE SPOKE WITH THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE.
LEGISLATORS AND COMMUNITY
LEADERS FROM THROUGHOUT THE
STATE.
THAT INCLUDE INPUT FROM
PERSPECTIVES ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
WHAT DEVELOPING THIS LEGISLATION
WE MET WITH USE OF FORCE EXPERTS
AND SURVEYED THE MOST EFFECTIVE
METHODS IN TRAINING PROVEN TO
REDUCE THE USE OF FORCE?
SB TWO THIRTY IS AN EVIDENCE
BASED APPROACH THAT FOCUSES ON
ADOPTING NATIONALLY RECOGNIZED
BEST PRACTICES.
AND PROVEN RESULTS.
SB TWO THIRTY IS THE ONLY
LEGISLATION OR PROVIDE LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS WITH THE
TOOLS AND RESOURCES THEY NEED TO
REDUCE THE USE OF FORCE
EFFECTIVELY.
CALIFORNIANS DESERVE PROGRESS.
WE WANT TO ACCOMPLISH
ACCOMPLISHMENT A FULL CHANGE WE
CANNOT WORK IN SILOS.
THE BEST PUBLIC POLICIES ARE NOT
MADE IN A VACUUM.
WE UST COME TOGETHER TO SHARE
OUR EXPERIENCES PERSPECTIVES AND
EXPERTISE.
PORAC IS ASKING THAT SB TWO
THIRTY BE PASSED OUT OF
COMMITTEE TODAY.
I CAN'T SPEAK FOR ALL ALONG
FORSMAN BUT I BELIEVE THAT I
WOULD THEY WOULD AGREE WITH ME
WHEN I SAY.
WE'RE COMMITTED TO WORKING
TOGETHER TO DEVELOP AN EFFECTIVE
SOLUTION THAT WE CAN ALL
CHAMPION TOGETHER.
IN FACT AS OF YESTERDAY DOCTOR
WEBER REACHED OUT TO US FOR
MEETING AS EARLY AS THIS
THURSDAY.
OR EARLY NEXT WEEK.
ON BEHALF OF POOR ACTOR WANT TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR ALLOWING
ME TO SHARE OUR VIEWS AND
HIGHLIGHT SOME OF THE REMARKS
REMARKABLE WORK BEING DONE BY
LAW ENFORCEMENT AND OUR PARTNERS
ACROSS CALIFORNIA THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
NEXT WITNESS.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MY NAME'S RON LAWRENCE
IN THE PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA POLICE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION.
I REPRESENT THE THREE HUNDRED
AND THIRTY TWO ACTIVE POLICE
CHIEF FROM THROUGHOUT THE ENTIRE
STATE WHO ARE DIRECTLY
RESPONSIBLE FOR PROVIDING PUBLIC
SAFETY TO MORE THAN TWENTY EIGHT
MILLION CALIFORNIANS.
OVER THE DECADES OF SERVICE TO
OUR COMMUNITIES WE HAVE
UNFORTUNATELY BEEN CONFRONTED
WITH MANY TRAGIC EVENTS AND NONE
MORE SERIOUS THAN THOSE
RESULTING IN THE USE OF DEADLY
FORCE.
MUCH IS AT STAKE ON THIS VERY
SERIOUS ISSUE BEING DEBATED HERE
AT THE CAPITOL SURROUNDING USE
OF FORCE.
A MATTER SO SERIOUS THAT IT IS
AT THE VERY CORE OF HOW WE
SAFELY GO ABOUT PROTECTING
VICTIMS ARE COMMUNITIES AND
FORCING LAWS CREATED BY THE VERY
LEGISLATOR IN VOTERS OF THIS
STATE.
WITH EACH SEEN THE DAMAGE DEADLY
FORCE DOES TO FAMILIES NEIGHBORS
FRIENDS AND COMMUNITIES.
ANYONE THAT HAS BEEN THROUGH
SUCH AN EVENT IS FOREVER CHANGED.
AS POLICE CHIEFS WE ALL KNOW WE
ALL KNOW TOO WELL THE DANGEROUS
CIRCUMSTANCES OUR POLICE
OFFICERS FACE WHEN MAKING SPLIT
SECOND DECISIONS LIFE OR DEATH
DECISIONS WHEN CONFRONTED WITH
AN ASSAILANT OR AN ATTACKER.
WE KNOW THE PAIN IT CAUSES US
OUR DEPARTMENTS AND OUR
COMMUNITIES WHEN WE LOSE A
POLICE OFFICER KILLED IN THE
LINE OF DUTY.
FOLLOWING THE USE OF DEADLY
FORCE BY ONE OF OUR OFFICERS.
THE POLICE CHIEF RESPONSIBILITY
TO SEEK THE TRUTH YOUR FACT
BASED INVESTIGATIONS.
HELPING THE PUBLIC TO FIND
ANSWERS HOLDING OUR POP OUR
POLICE OFFICERS ACCOUNTABLE AND
ADDRESS THE EMOTIONAL TRAUMA AND
FINDING WAYS TO IMPROVE.
THESE ARE THE PRIMARY FUNCTIONS
OF THE POLICE CHIEF AND THE TAX
THAT WE TAKE VERY SERIOUSLY.
IN OUR EFFORTS TO CONTINUOUSLY
IMPROVE CALIFORNIA POLICE CHIEFS
FROM ACROSS OUR STATE.
HAVE BEEN DEVELOPING POLICIES
AND TRAINING THAT HELPED US
DEVELOP SB.
TWO THIRTY MANY OF THE ROBUST
POLICY REQUIREMENTS IN SB.
TWO THIRTY WHICH INCLUDE
REQUIREMENTS ON DE ESCALATION.
RENDERING MEDICAL FIRST DATE
DEALING WITH VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS AN OFFICER'S DUTIES
INTERCEDE WHEN OBSERVING
EXCESSIVE FORCE REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS TRAINING AND MUCH
MORE.
COME FROM ADVANCED WORK BY
POLICE CHIEF AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
TO ADDRESS MANY OF THE ISSUES
NOW BEING FATE RAISED IN THIS
DEBATE.
MANY ALSO CAME DIRECTLY FROM THE
CALIFORNIA ATTORNEY GENERAL IN
HIS RECOMMENDATIONS ON POLICE
USE OF FORCE POLICIES.
IF THE POSITIVE RESULTS THAT
WE'VE SEEN IN THE RECENT YEARS
USE OF DEADLY FORCE DROPPING
NEARLY 35% FROM 200-017-22000
EIGHTEEN AND WE BELIEVE THE
POLICY IN TRAINING AND SB TWO
THIRTY WILL LEAD TO EVEN MORE
GREATER OUTCOMES.
IT IS ALSO IMPORTANT TO PUT
THESE REQUIREMENTS REQUIREMENTS
CONTAINED IN SB TWO THIRTY IN
PERSPECTIVE AT A NATIONAL LEVEL.
ONLY ABOUT 30% OF THE NATION'S
NINETY ONE LARGEST LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES HAVE ANY DE
ESCALATION REQUIREMENTS IN THEIR
USE OF FORCE POLICIES.
AND ONLY ABOUT THE SAME NUMBER
AS REQUIREMENTS FOR OFFICERS
INTERVENE TO STOP ANOTHER
OFFICER FROM USING EXCESSIVE
FORCE.
UNDER SB TWO THIRTY EACH OF OUR
OVER FIVE HUNDRED LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES IN OUR
STATE WILL MEET THOSE STANDARDS
AND OVER A DOZEN MORE.
NO STATE IN THE NATION WILL HAVE
A LEGAL REQUIREMENT MANDATING
THE TYPE OF STATEWIDE
COMPREHENSIVE AND ROBUST USE OF
FORCE POLICIES THAT SB TWO
THIRTY MANDATES.
SB TWO THIRTY WILL RESULT IN
SIGNIFICANT AND POSITIVE CHANGE
BUT WE UNDERSTAND THE TRAINING
OF POLICIES ARE NOT THE ONLY
PART OF THE SOLUTION.
THE CALIFORNIA POLICE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION LOOKS FORWARD TO THE
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK
COLLABORATIVELY WITH THE
LEGISLATOR ON THIS ISSUE.
AS WE HAVE DONE NUMEROUS TIMES
OVER THE PAST ON IMPORTANT
ISSUES SUCH AS CIVIL ASSET
FORFEITURE.
IMMIGRATION TRANSPARENCY AND
MANY OTHERS AND MANY OTHER
CRUCIAL PUBLIC SAFETY MATTERS
BASED IN CALIFORNIA.
REGARDED THE POLICY BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE TODAY RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE ON SB.
TWO THIRTY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
NEXT WITNESS.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS KATHLEEN
MUSTAD ME STORM I'M A UNION SITE
LABOR LAWYER REPRESENTING PUBLIC
SAFETY UNION THROUGHOUT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
LAWN FORCES RECOGNITION OF THE
THINK THE OF WHITE DRIVES SB.
TWO THIRTY I MANY NOT THE
LANGUAGE REGARDING PENAL CODE
SECTION ONE NINETY SIX ENJOY
NEED.
TO EIGHTY THREE NINETY TWO LAW
ENFORCEMENT HAS DEMONSTRATED A
COMMITMENT TO WORKING WITH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEBER. TO REACH
CONSENSUS BILLS GOVERNING USE OF
CHANGE
SB TWO THIRTY SIX ESTABLISH A
NATIONAL PRESIDENT BY SETTING
CONSISTENT USE OF FORCE POLICIES
AND TRAIN REQUIREMENTS. FOR ALL
FIVE HUNDRED LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES IN CALIFORNIA.
USE THE FORCE TACTICS ARE
PERISHABLE SKILLS.
SB TWO THIRTY WILL HELP TO TRAIN
AND ENSURE LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS.
KNOW HOW TO IMPLEMENT DE
ESCALATION AND USE OF FORCE
ALTERNATIVES IN POTENTIALLY
DEADLY USE OF FORCE SITUATIONS.
THREE IMPROVE TRAINING AND SB
TWO THIRTY LIKE SCENARIO BASED
TRAINING OFFICERS ABILITY TO
IMMEDIATELY JUDGE AND REACT WITH
THE APPROPRIATE LEVELS OF FORCE
WILL BE IMPROVED.
ALL LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES WILL BE REQUIRED TO
IMPLEMENT MINIMUM STANDARDS FOR
USE OF FORCE POLICIES AND
REPORTING PROCEDURES.
DEPARTMENTS WILL HAVE THE
DISCRETION TO IMPLEMENT POLICIES
BEYOND THE MINIMUM REQUIREMENTS
TO ACCOUNT FOR THE NEEDS OF THAT
PARTICULAR AGENCIES AND
COMMUNITIES. FOR EXAMPLE EVERY
DEPARTMENT WILL ADOPT A POLICY
REQUIRING OFFICERS CONSIDER
THEIR SURROUNDINGS AND POTENTIAL
RESTED BY STANDARDS BEFORE
DISCHARGING A FIREARM.
AND REQUIRE AN OFFICER TO
INTERCEDE THEY PERCEIVE AN
EXCESSIVE USE OF FORCE.
AND THAT THAT POTENTIAL
EXCESSIVE FORCE BE REPORTED TO A
SUPERIOR OFFICER.
THIS CREATES A HIGHER
RESPONSIBILITY RESULT IN HIGHER
ACCOUNTABILITY.
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL FOUND
DEVELOPING OFFICERS CAPACITY TO
MAKE DECISIONS ON HOW AND WHEN
TO USE FORCE BEGINS WITH HIS OR
HER INITIAL TRAINING.
AT THE POLICE ACADEMY.
SB TWO THIRTY EIGHT AND A FIVE
SPECIFIC COURSES OF BASIC
TRAINING WHICH INCLUDE DE
ESCALATION IMPLICIT AND EXPLICIT
BIAS.
CULTURAL COMPETENCY USE OF FORCE
AND RENDERING MEDICAL AID.
THEY NEED SKILLS ARE MAINTAINED
AND IMPROVE IMPROVE THROUGH
ANNUAL CONTINUE TRAINING.
BY INCREASING STANDARDS AND
TRAIN AS A SENATE COMMITTEE NOW
SAYS NOTES THE QUALITY OF A
REASONABLE OFFICER INCREASES AS
WELL.
CALIFORNIA LAW ENFORCEMENT IS
COMMITTED TO ACHIEVING
MEANINGFUL CHANGE AND THIS BILL
WILL PROVIDE THE TOOLS TO DO SO.
PLEASE VOTE I THANK YOU DO WE
HAVE OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
THAT CAN COME TO THE MY CAN JUST
INDICATE YOUR NAME AFFILIATION
IN YOUR SUPPORT.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS SHANE LEVINE
ON BEHALF OF THE TERM OR OF
POLICE AND THE CALIFORNIA
STATEWIDE LAW ENFORCEMENT
ASSOCIATION SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS -- AND READ
REVIEWS AND CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF I'VE A PATROLMAN
CO SPONSORS OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU.
RANGERS SEIZING RANCHERA WITH
THE RESEARCHER ASSOCIATION OR
MANAGER MEMBERS CHORUS ALSO ON
BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION SUPPORT.
NICOLE WATERMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
SAN BERNADINO COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND SUPPORT.
LAURIE JOHNSON THE BEHALF OF
CITY OF SALINAS AND SUPPORT.
TROUT SORRY ON BEHALF OF LEAGUE
FOR CALIFORNIA CITIES IN SUPPORT.
CODY BUT ALSO BEHALF THE CHEAPER
VERSION OFFERS OF CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT.
GRAHAM WARD THE PRESIDENT OF THE
ASSEMBLY -- COUNTY SURE SIMPLY
BENEFITS ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
PHIL JONAS FOSTER FROM SEMINOLE
COUNTY SURE SUPPLIES BENEFITS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS SHAUN UNDER
THE CALIFORNIA PEACE OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION SUPPORT.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS MATTHEW
CYBERLINK WE HAVE THE LOS
ANGELES POLICE PROTECTIVE LEAGUE
IN THE ASSOCIATION FOR LOS
ANGELES DEPUTY SHERIFF'S BOTH IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
RIGHT SO BEFORE WE START OUR
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION I JUST
WANNA -- OUR AUTHORS OPENING SHE
INDICATED SHE WOULD BE TAKING
THE AMENDMENTS -- THAT THE
COMMITTEE HAS SUGGESTED SO I
JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
EVERYONE -- WHO IS LISTENING IN
IN HE ROOM UNDERSTANDS WHAT
THOSE AMENDMENTS ARE -- AND ALL
INDICATE THEM AND THEN SENATOR --
COVER YOUR IF THERE'S ANY ISSUE
BETWEEN WHAT I'M.
NOT CONVEYING IN YEAH IF THERE'S
A CLARIFICATION PLEASE.
SO -- WHAT THE -- COMEDIAS
PROPOSED IN WHAT THE AUTHORS
ACCEPTING IS THAT.
THE SB TWO THIRTY IF APPROVED BY
THE COMMITTEE AS AMENDED WOULD
REMOVE THE PROVISIONS IN THE
BILL THAT RELATE TO THE STANDARD
FOR JUSTIFIABLE HOMICIDE BY
PEACE OFFICER -- IN IN FACT THE
USE OF DEADLY FORCE BY POLICE
OFFICERS.
WOULD CONFORM THE FINDINGS AND
DECLARATIONS TO THAT REMOVAL OF
THE LEGAL STANDARD.
WOULD LEAVE THE PROVISIONS
RELATED TO TRAINING.
AND TO THE MINIMUM STANDARDS
THAT LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES WOULD USE RELATED TO
USE OF FORCE [inaudible]
AND THERE'S ALSO A FEW
CONFORMING CHANGES THESE ARE
MORE TECHNICAL -- BUT EDITION
ONLY WOULD ADD A PROVISION TO SB
TWO THIRTY THAT MAKES SB TWO
THIRTY CONTINGENT.
ON SO IN OTHER WORDS BEFORE IT
COULD BECOME LAW IT WOULD BE
CONTINGENT.
ON AB THREE NINETY TO BECOMING
LAW.
I'M SO IN EFFECT TO THE THE
PURPOSE OF THE AMENDMENTS WOULD
BE THAT -- BECAUSE SB TWO THIRTY
AS PRESENTED -- ADS IN PRINT.
WOULD CODIFY IN EFFECT A USE OF
STORE FOR STANDARD THAT IS
ALREADY IN PRACTICE DUE TO A
COURT RULING.
THAT THE COMMITTEE FELT THERE
WAS NOT NECESSITY TO CODIFY.
THAT USE OF FORCE STANDARD SINCE
IT IS WHAT IS IN EFFECT NOW.
IN CALIFORNIA BUT INSTEAD
BECAUSE THERE IS A BILL THAT IS
UP.
BEING MOVING THROUGH THE
LEGISLATURE NOW THAT MIGHT READ
VICE USE OF FORCE STANDARD.
THAT.
THESE WOULD BE CONJOINED SO THAT
IF THERE IS  REVISION TO THE
POLICE OF USE A STANDARD IN
CALIFORNIA.
THEN OBVIOUSLY THE APPROPRIATE
TRAINING.
THAT IS SUGGESTED IN THIS BILL
WOULD PROCEED AND WOULD OF
COURSE BE BASED ON THAT -- SO
THERE'S A A LOT OF BY.
WHICH WE SAY -- IT CREATES THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR ALL OF THE
PARTIES INVOLVED TO CONTINUE TO
HAVE CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THIS
VERY IMPORTANT SUBJECT.
WHICH WE'VE OBVIOUSLY BEEN
ENGAGED IN CONVERSATION NOW FOR
SOME TIME.
AND MY HOPE AND WE'LL SEE IF TO
HAVE THE COMMITTEE FEELS BUT MY
HOPE AND LITTLE CLEARLY HEAR
FROM THE OPPOSITION.
IS THAT THERE WOULD BE
PRODUCTIVE CONVERSATIONS AND WE
MIGHT COME TO A PLACE WHERE WE
BOTH HAVE REVISED USED TO FOR
STANDARD AND GOOD ASSOCIATED
TRAINING.
SO THAT ONE CALIFORNIA COULD
MOVE FORWARD -- CENTER MITCHELL
WOULD YOU LIKE TO MAKE A COMMENT
BEFORE WE HEAR FROM THE
OPPOSITION NOT WAIT. FOR THE
PERFECT TIME OKAY OPPOSITION IS
FINE OKAY GREAT AND SENATOR --
ZERO DID I CLEAR DID I CONVEY
THOSE APPROPRIATELY YES TO YOUR
UNDERSTANDING OKAY.
ALL RIGHT EXCELLENT SO THEN --
WE WILL -- HAVE OUR WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION FANS WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
ONCE WE ARE CONCLUDING AND WE'RE
IN CONVERSATION OBVIOUSLY YOU
CAN COME BACK TO THE TAPE.
AND THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING
HER.
SO -- THE PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT IF YOU COULD COME TO THE
TABLE I'M SORRY EXCUSE ME
APOLOGIES.
IN OPPOSITION.
BEFORE WE HEAR FROM THE PEOPLE
STANDING AT THE MIKE THERE.
DO WE HAVE [inaudible]
THREE YEAH.
DO WE HAVE THREE PRIMARY --
SPEAKERS IN [inaudible]
OPPOSITION.
OKAY GREAT EVEN COME TO THE
TABLE AND THEN OBVIOUSLY
EVERYONE ELSE CAN -- INDICATE AT
THE MIKE THEY ARE ME TO USE --
AFTER WEEK INCLUDE THEIR
DISCUSSION.
TIME AND IF THERE IS ANY -- ANY --
CLARIFICATION THAT THE
OPPOSITION NEEDS AS TO WHAT THE
COMMITTEES PROPOSED FOR THE
MOMENT SO WHAT THE AUTHORS
ACCEPTED WEEK BE HAPPY TO GO
OVER THOSE AGAIN.
AND PLEASE PROCEED.
GIVE ME MY NAME IS THERESA SMITH --
AND I'M THE MOTHER OF CAESAR
CREWS -- I'M STILL NOT SURE
ABOUT THE THE AMENDMENT SO I'M
JUST HERE.
IN OPPOSITION TO THE TWO THIRTY
MY SENSE IS OUR CRUISE.
WAS SHOT FIFTEEN TIMES IN THE
BACK.
DECEMBER ELEVENTH. TWO THOUSAND
AND NINE BY FIVE POLICE OFFICERS
WELL HE WAS JUST REFERENCE THE
BILL.
HE WASN'T COMMITTING A CRIME HE
WAS NOT.
ON PROBATION OR PAROLE ANYWAYS
THERE WAS JUST NO NEED TO TO
SHOOT AND KILL THEM.
IT'S GOING TO BE TEN YEARS THIS
YEAR THAT -- TOOK MY SON'S LIFE.
HE LEFT BEHIND FIVE BOYS.
WE'RE NOT HAVING TO GROW UP
WITHOUT A FATHER.
AND HAVING HIM THERE FOR THEIR
BIRTHDAY FOR CHRISTMAS.
WHEN THEY TURN EIGHTEEN WHEN
THEY GRADUATE FROM HIGH SCHOOL?
THIS IS HARD TO DO BECAUSE EVEN
THOUGH IT'S GOING TO BE TEN
YEARS.
THIS IS MY SON THIS IS.
THE CHILD THAT I CARRIED FOR
NINE MONTHS BROUGHT INTO THIS
WORLD AND THEN HAD TO PUT IN THE
GROUND.
HANNAH NOT HAVING OFFICERS HELD
ACCOUNTABLE FOR THAT IS LIKE
REALLY DIFFICULT.
YOU KNOW MY SON WAS A FOOT LIKE
I SAID A FATHER OF FIVE BOYS AND
AND HE WAS JUST.
OF ALL THE THINGS THAT HE DID IN
LIFE THE BEST THING HE DID WAS
JUST BEING SUCH A GREAT FATHER
TO HIS FATHER TO HIS CHILDREN --
WEEK SAID I DON'T THINK ANYBODY
SHOULD HAVE TO DIE IN THE MANNER
IN WHICH HE DID YOU KNOW.
POLICE OFFICER SHOULD BE
SHOOTING PEOPLE FOR NOT AN
IMMINENT DANGER.
THE CALIFORNIA LAW IT'S POLICE
OFFICERS USE DEADLY FORCE AND
KILL SOMEONE EVEN WHEN OFFICERS
HAVE OTHER OPTIONS.
THAT MEANS WELL MANY POLICE
SHOOTINGS LIKE THE ONE THAT TOOK
MY SON'S LIFE ARE LEGALLY
JUSTIFIED.
THEY MAY NOT ACTUALLY HAVE BEEN
NECESSARY.
SO LET THAT SINK IN.
POLICE CAN SHOOT AND TAKE
SOMEONE'S LIFE EVEN WHEN THEY
DON'T HAVE.
TO KNOWING THIS DEPENDS MY PAIN
BUT IS ALSO STRENGTHENED MY
RESOLVE. TO HAVE TO DO
EVERYTHING IN MY POWER TO
ADVOCATE FOR REFORMS THAT WILL
HELP PREVENT MORE UNNECESSARY
TRAGEDIES.
AND UNFORTUNATELY SB.
TWO THIRTY AS FAR AS THAT I'M
CLOSING RIGHT NOW BECAUSE I
HAVEN'T I DON'T KNOW ABOUT THE
AMENDMENTS.
IT DOESN'T CHANGES BY THE
KEEPING THE REASONABLE STANDARD
INTACT SB TWO THIRTY WILL
CONTINUE TO ALLOW OFFICERS TO
KILL PEOPLE LIKE CAESAR.
EVEN WHEN THERE IS NO IMMEDIATE
THREAT.
AND EVEN WHEN OFFICERS HAVE
OTHER ALTERNATIVES.
HUMAN LIFE HUMAN LIFE IS A VERY
PRECIOUS THING.
THAT MUST BE PRESERVED AND
PROTECTED.
ESPECIALLY BY PEOPLE WHO ARE
SUPPOSED TO SERVE AND PROTECT
THE PUBLIC.
THAT SHOULDN'T BE UP FOR DEBATE
AND WE CAN'T PUT OFF ADDRESSING
THIS PROBLEM ANY LONGER.
ESPECIALLY WHEN WE KNOW THAT
THERE ARE SOLUTIONS THAT WORK TO
SAVE LVES.
AND KEEP BOTH THE PUBLIC AND
POLICE OFFICERS SAVE.
UPDATING CALIFORNIA'S USE OF FOR
STANDARD FROM THE REASONABLE
STANDARD TO THE NECESSARY
NECESSITY STANDARD IS A COMMON
SENSE SOLUTION.
BUT A GLARING OMISSION AND SB.
TWO THIRTY RESEARCH SHOWS THAT
OFFICERS AT AGENCIES WITH
STRICTER USE OF POLICE -- POLICY
FORCED USE OF FORCE POLICIES
KILL FEWER PEOPLE AND ARE LESS
LIKELY TO BE KILLED OR SERIOUSLY
INJURED THEMSELVES.
MY SON SHOULD BE ALIVE TODAY.
UNFORTUNATELY NOTHING ANYONE.
DOES WILL BRING HIM BACK.
BUT I'M NOT GOING TO STOP
FIGHTING FOR THIS.
UNTIL PEOPLE ARE USE THE UNTIL
THEY STOP KILLING PEOPLE.
WHEN THEY ARE NOT IN IMMINENT
DANGER OR UNTIL I TAKE MY LAST
BREATH?
YOU KNOW IT WE HAVE A LOT OF
EXPERTS AND YOU KNOW THEY DO A
LOT OF RESEARCH.
BUT A LOT OF THIS TOPIC GOES ON
REALLY DON'T TALK TO IMPACT OF
FAMILY MEMBERS YOU KNOW ON WE
BECOME THE EXPERTS.
SO YOU GUYS REALLY SHOULD.
PROBABLY MEET WITH IMPACTED
FAMILIES AND NOT JUST WITH YOUR
EXPERTS ON DATA.
YOU KNOW ON MY SON IS NOT DATA
MY SON WAS A HUMAN BEING.
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
NEXT WITNESS GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS DOMINIC ARTICLE IS A
ACID BEFORE YOU IN THREE
CAPACITIES.
FIRST TIME THE MOTHER NATHANIEL
NATE HERIS PICK IT THE SECOND MY
ONLY CHILD WAS GUNNED DOWN ON
NOVEMBER NINETEENTH.
TWENTY FIFTEEN AT HIS HOME IN
BARSTOW CALIFORNIA BY SAN
BERNARDINO COUNTY SHERIFF'S.
MY SON WAS NOT ARMED HE HAD NOT
COMMIT A CRIME AND THERE WERE NO
REPORTS OF CRIME IN THE AREA.
THE DEPUTY CAL HAYDEN WOODS WHO
HAS BEEN WHO HAD BEEN A SHARE
FOR LESS THAN EIGHTEEN MONTHS.
STATED THAT HE WAS MAKING A
CONSENSUAL STOP SOMETIMES DURING
HIS DEPOSITION HE ALSO USE THE
TERM COMMUNITY POLICING.
AGAIN EIGHTEEN MONTHS FRESH OUT
OF THE CURRENT TRAINING.
EITHER TURN CONVEY THE MY SON
WOULD HAVE TO HAVE AGREED WITH
THE STOP OTHERWISE HE WAS
AUTHORIZED TO WALK AWAY.
AT THE END OF SAID CONSENSUAL
STOP THIS COMMUNITY POLICING MY
SON LAY DEAD FROM TWO BULLET
WOUNDS AT CLOSE RANGE.
W. WOULD USE THE PHRASE I FEARED
FOR MY LIFE HE SAID THAT MY SON
LOOKED AT HIM SEVERAL TIMES
WHILE CROSSING.
THE STREET IN THE CROSSWALK WITH
THE LIGHT.
THAT HE JUMPED THE FENCE THAT HE
MADE WAS UNCOOPERATIVE RESISTING
AND THAT HE STRUCK HIM
REPEATEDLY AND THEREFORE HE HAD
TO USE DEADLY FORCE.
DEBBIE WAS WAS NEVER PLACED ON
ADMINISTRATIVE LEAVE HE WAS NOT
INTERVIEWED FOR MONTHS AFTER THE
SHOOTING AT APPROXIMATELY ONE
YEAR LATER HE SHOT ANOTHER ON
OUR CITIZEN A LATINO MALE SIX
TIMES.
NOT UNLESS YOU BELIEVE THAT I
HAVE MY FACTS ALL WRONG ABOUT
THIS CASE BUT I AM JUST A
GRIEVING MOTHER TALKING NONSENSE
PLEASE KNOW THAT THERE WERE
SIXTEEN WORKING CAMERAS AT MY
SON'S RESIDENTS THAT COUGH THIS
MURDER FROM ALL ANGLES.
THERE WERE AYE WITNESSES THERE
HAS BEEN A CIVIL TRIAL WHICH THE
COUNTY'S EXPERT TOLD THE TRUTH
AND CONSEQUENTLY WHAT OUR BEST
EVIDENCE.
PROVING OVER AND OVER AGAIN THAT
THE DEPUTY LIFE WAS NOT
ENDANGERED AND WAS IN FACT THE
AGGRESSOR BEATING MY SON WHO
AGAIN ACCORDING TO COUNTY
EXPERTS.
WERE VIEW WHO VIEW THE VIDEO
SLIDE BY SLIDE NEVER JUMPED THE
FENCE AND NEVER STRUCK THE
OFFICER ONE TIME.
THE RESULT OF THE CIVIL TRIAL
WAS.
AN AWARD IN THE AMOUNT OF THIRTY
THREE POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
A YOU KNOW I HAVE NOT SEEN.
BUT I WANT YOU TO KNOW THAT
BASED ON THE EGREGIOUS NATURE OF
THIS CASE THAT A JURY COMPOSED
OF MANY PEOPLE OF ALL WALKS OF
LIFE.
DETERMINE THAT THIS WAS AN
EGREGIOUS ACT.
AND THEY STATED THAT WITH THE
JUDGMENT.
BUT THERE WAS NEVER A DISCUSSION
NOT EVEN A DISCUSSION OF AN
INDICTMENT OR CONSEQUENCE FOR
THE DEPUTIES WERE REASONABLE
ACTION.
IN MY SECOND CAPACITY I SIT HERE
BEFORE HE WAS A RETIRED ARMY
COLONEL A TWO TIME COMBAT
VETTING YES I WAS STATIONED AT
THE PENTAGON ON THE DAY THAT IT
WAS HERE.
I UNDERSTAND WILL FEARING FOR
YOUR LIFE MEANS.
AND HAVING TO MAKE A DECISION
UNDER DURESS I HAVE STATED
BEFORE REITERATE THAT THE
MILITARY HAS MORE STRINGENT
RULES OF ENGAGEMENT.
AGAINST THE KNOWN ENEMY THAT OUR
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES HAVE ON
THE STREETS OF AMERICA.
PRISONERS OF WAR GOVERNMENT AYE
INTERNATIONAL HUMAN RIGHTS LAWS
THE STATE THAT THEY MUST BE
TREATED HUMANELY.
IN ALL CIRCUMSTANCES THEY ARE
PROTECTED AGAINST ANY ACT OF
VIOLENCE AS WELL AS INTIMIDATION
AND FURTHERMORE THEY ARE
PROTECTED AGAINST MURDER.
TORTURE AS WELL AS CRUEL
HUMILIATING AND DEGRADING
TREATMENT.
THERE APPEARS TO BE A DIRECT
CORRELATION OF THE
MILITARIZATION OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND THE ESCALATION
OF VIOLENCE TOWARD OUR COMMUNITY.
HOWEVER DOES NOT RESULT IN
APPROPRIATE RULES OF ENGAGEMENT
ARE HONORING CIVIL AND HUMAN
RIGHTS OF BLACK BROWN AND NATIVE
AMERICAN COMMUNITIES.
FINALLY I'M HERE IS AN EDUCATED
VOTER WHO HAS TAKEN THE TIME TO
READ SB TWO THIRTY AND DO MY
RESEARCH ON LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
DEADLY FORCE.
SB TWO THIRTY IS A BILL BY LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES WHO ARE
INTERESTED IN HOLDING THEMSELVES
ACCOUNTABLE.
THIS IS THIS EXTRA THE
STATISTICS SHOW THAT BETWEEN
TWENTY THIRTEEN AND TWENTY
EIGHTEEN CALIFORNIA POLICE HE
ONE THOUSAND SEVENTY ONE PEOPLE
THE LARGEST NUMBER OF ANY STATE
OF THE TEN HIGHEST RATE WHEN
ACCOUNTING FOR POPULATION. FIVE
ONE ELEVEN GUN HOMICIDES ARE
COMMITTED BY POLICE.
IN THIS STATE. TO COUNT THEM TWO
SHOOTINGS RESULTED IN CHARGES
BUT NOT ONE CONVICTION ZERO
ACCOUNTABILITY ZERO JUSTICE AND
THIS IS NOT CHANGED BY A. B.
EXCUSE ME SB TWO THIRDS.
AND ABOVE ALL IT BEARS REPEATING
OUR COMMUNITIES ARE NOT WAR
ZONES IN OUR FAMILIES ARE NOT IN
ANY COMBATANTS BY LAW
ENFORCEMENT CONTINUE TO TREAT US
LIKE THIS.
NOT WITH A GUARDIAN MINDSET OF
SERVING AND PROTECTING WORSE THE
BAR FOR WHEN LAW ENFORCEMENT CAN
USE DEADLY FORCE AT HOME IS
LOWER THAN THE BAR FROM THE
MILITARY CAN USE DEADLY FORCE
BROUGHT.
THIS BILL IS TOO LITTLE TOO LATE.
THIS IS THE WAY THAT IT SHOULD
HAVE BEEN ALL THE TIME.
THIS BILL DOES NOT PROTECT OR
BENEFIT ANYONE EXCEPT THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT 1%.
WHO WITH THE MANDATE OF
PROTECTING AND SERVING?
ARE ONLY PROTECTING IS SERVING
THEIR OWN INTEREST SO I SIT HERE
BEFORE YOU RESPECTFULLY URGING A
NO VOTE ON SB TWO THIRTY AND A
YES ON THREE NINETY TWO NEXT TO
IT.
A GOOD MORNING -- MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS A HELLO CHEN I'M A
PROFESSOR OF LAW AT LOYOLA LAW
SCHOOL I TEACH CRIMINAL LAW.
AND I'M ALSO THE VICE CHAIR OF
THE CIVILIAN OVERSIGHT
COMMISSION FOR THELOS ANGELES
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT I'M HERE ON
MY INDIVIDUAL CAPACITY AND NOT
ON BEHALF OF THE COMMISSION -- I
DO HAVE A CLARIFYING QUESTION IS
IT.
IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING FROM FROM
THE CONVERSATION EARLIER THAT --
ANY AMENDMENTS TO A PENAL CODE
ONE NINETY SIX THAT WERE
CONTAINED IN SB TO THIRTY ARE
BEING.
DISTRICT OKAY SO LET ME CLEAR
LET ME MAKE SURE.
YES.
AND AND THOSE ARE. TO CLARIFY
PENAL CODE ONE NINETY SIX IS THE
USE OF FORCE STANDARD YES SO.
THEY ARE BEING STRIPPED FROM
THIS BILL SINCE THIS BILL
PROPOSES ONLY TO CODIFY THAT
WHICH IS ALREADY IN PRACTICE.
SO.
THAT'S WHAT THE K. HOW THE
COMMITTEE WITH A RECEIPT RIGHT --
SO MOST OF MY COMMENTS I
PREPARED WERE RELATED TO THOSE
PROVISIONS SO I'M GOING TO SHIFT
AND TALK A BIT MORE BROADLY
ABOUT.
THE NEED FOR SIGNIFICANT REFORM
TO POLICE USE OF FORCE STANDARDS
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
SO THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA HAS
ONE OF THE HIGHEST RATES OF
DEADLY POLICE SHOOTINGS IN THE
COUNTRY.
ACCORDING TO THE WASHINGTON POST
A HUNDRED AND SIXTY ONE PEOPLE
WERE KILLED IN CAP BY CALIFORNIA
POLICE IN TWO THOUSAND AND
SEVENTEEN THAT WAS UP FROM ONE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY EIGHT IN TWO
THOUSAND AND SIXTEEN HALF OF
THOSE PEOPLE WHO WERE KILLED
WERE NOT ARMED.
AND THREE FORCE FOR PEOPLE OF
COLOR -- PARTICULARLY OTHERS
SIGNIFICANT INCREASING
VULNERABILITY TO POLICE VIOLENCE
FOR PEOPLE WHO HAVE DISABILITIES
PARTICULARLY PEOPLE OF COLOR SO
I THINK THAT THAT'S RELEVANT
ESPECIALLY GIVEN THAT THE
CONVERSATION RELATED TO THE
PREVIOUS BILL.
PEOPLE OF COLOR PARTICULARLY
AFRICAN AMERICANS ARE THREE
POINT TWO TIMES MORE LIKELY TO
BE KILLED NOT BY LAW ENFORCEMENT
CALIFORNIA THAN THEIR WHITE
COUNTERPARTS IN LA COUNTY WE
HAVE SOME OF THE HIGHEST RATES.
OF A USE OF FORCE.
CALIFORNIA HAS ONE OF THE MOST
ANTIQUATED STANDARDS OF OF
POLICE USE OF FORCE IT WAS
ENACTED IN EIGHTEEN SEVENTY TWO
AND IT'S BEEN CALLED THE SINGLE
OLDEST UNAMENDED LAW ENFORCEMENT
USE OF FOUR STATUTE IN THE
COUNTRY.
IT'S IN CONSISTENT WITH
CONSTITUTIONAL STANDARDS ADOPTED
BY THE SUPREME COURT RELATED TO
GENERAL USE OF FORCE AND IT AS
IT RELATES TO USE OF FORCE
AGAINST WILL QUOTE UNQUOTE
FLEEING FELONS.
I TEACH CRIMINAL LAW ONE OF THE
BASIC TENANTS OF SELF DEFENSE
LAW IS THAT THE USE OF FORCE
MUST BE IMMINENT.
THAT IT MUST BE NECESSARY AND
THAT THE USE OF FORCE MUST BE
PROPORTIONAL NONE OF THOSE ARE
PRESENT IN CURRENT LAW AND THEY
SHOULD BE CIVILIANS ARE HELD TO
THE STANDARD POLICE SHOULD BE
HELD TO THE STANDARD.
THE CHANGES IN THESE POLICIES
PARTICULARLY A PROPOSED BY AB
THREE NINETY TWO WILL SAVE LIVES.
ONE STUDY FOUND THAT AMONG LARGE
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES IN
NEARLY SO FOR STANDARD HAD
RESULT IN FEWER I USE OF FORCE --
USE OF USES OF FORCE AND FEWER
POLICE SHOOTINGS.
IN SOME IT ACTUALLY INCREASES
POLICE OF SAFETY AND INCREASES
PUBLIC SAFETY.
CALIFORNIA CAN AND SHOULD FOLLOW
SUIT AND WE SHOULD ADOPT
STANDARDS THAT ARE MANDATORY AND
THAT AT THAT EXIST ACROSS THE
STATE FOR EXAMPLE IN THE PRIOR
VERSION OF SB -- TO THIRTY THESE
WERE SORT OF THEY WERE GENERAL
MINIMUM STANDARDS BUT THEY COULD
VERY ACROSS THE STATE.
ONCE HONOR ABILITY TO POLICE
VIOLENCE SHOULDN'T DEPEND ON
WHAT ZIP CODE YOU LIVE IN RIGHT
WE SHOULD ALL HAVE UNIFORM
STANDARDS THAT PROTECT US
AGAINST UNNECESSARY POLICE USE
OF FORCE PARTICULARLY WHEN THE
OFFICERS ARE ESCALATING.
THE VIOLENCE AND THAT SHOULD BE
TAKEN INTO CONSIDERATION SO I
THINK THAT'S AN IMPORTANT PIECE
OF AB THREE NINETY TWO WHICH IS
NOW BEEN JOINED WITH SB.
TWO THIRTY WE SHOULD DEMAND THAT
IN ORDER FOR THE STATE OR AGENTS
TO TAKE A LIFE THAT THERE SHOULD
BE NO REASONABLE ALTERNATIVE
THEN TO USE DEADLY FORCE.
RIGHT THIS DOESN'T MEAN THAT
POLICE HAVE TO USE ANY AND ALL
UNDER REASONABLE ALTERNATIVES
BUT IT DOES MEAN THAT THEY HAVE.
TO THANKS FOR ALL REASONABLE
ALTERNATIVES TO THE USE OF FORCE
IF WE SAY THAT WE HAVE A
REVERENCE FOR LIFE THEN WE HAVE
TO MEAN IT WE CAN'T TAKE LIFE
AND WE CANNOT ALL THREE TO STOP
THE REST OF STATE TO TAKE LIFE.
WHEN IT IS UNNECESSARY?
I DON'T WANNA CLOSE WITH WITH
THIS CALIFORNIA CO QUARTS OF
REPEATEDLY EMPHASIZED THAT ANY
CIVILIZED SYSTEM OF LAW
RECOGNIZES THE SUPREME VALUE OF
HUMAN LIFE.
ANY EXCUSES OR JUSTIFIES TAKING
ONLY IN CASES OF APPARENT
ABSOLUTE NECESSITY IT IS TIME
THAT WE HAD TO USE A FOR
STANDARDS RELATED TO THE POLICE
THAT EXEMPLIFY THESE VALUES IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU LET US AND NOW SEE WHO
ELSE IS HERE IN OPPOSITION THEY
CAN COME TO THE MIKE.
GOOD MORNING LIZZIE BEAT WITH A
SILLY OF CALIFORNIA WE ARE
OPPOSED TO THE BILL AND PRINT --
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THE WORK OF
THE COMMITTEE ON THIS AND I'M WE
WILL BE WERE LOOKING FORWARD TO
REVIEWING THE MAN THANK YOU.
SUMMARIES LEBRON OF THE LEAGUE
OF WOMEN VOTERS OF CALIFORNIA IN
OPPOSITION OF SB.
TWO THIRTY THE ANGEL MAC WITH
PUBLIC HEALTH ADVOCATES -- ALSO
IN OPPOSITION BUT WILLING TO
LOOK AT THE AMENDMENTS.
GOING BACK AS FOR DRUG POLICY
ALLIANCE AND FOR THE ELEVATOR
CENTER FOR HUMAN RIGHTS OPPOSE
THE BILL AND PRINTABLE REVIEW
AMENDMENTS IF THE BILL MOVES
FORWARD.
FIFTH UNCLE BOBBY X. THE UNCLE
OF OSCAR GRANT.
ARMONK CO FOUNDER FAMILIES
UNITED FOR JUSTICE WE DEFINITELY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
TWO THIRTY I'M PETER BROTHERS
FATHER OF MY SON WAS KILLED --
BY POLICE I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
IS TO FURTHER DELAY.
TAKES AWAY FROM THE INTEGRITY OF
THE POLICE.
I AM PT BRIDGES GRANDMOTHERS HE
WAS KILLED UNARMED BY RICHMOND
POLICE SEPTEMBER FOURTEENTH.
TWENTY FOURTEEN NO
ACCOUNTABILITY I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
LYNN BERKELEY BASKIN EXECUTIVE
COMMITTEE SACRAMENTO AND W. C.
P. AND WE OPPOSED TO THIRTY AS
IT IS WRITTEN.
VERONICA NELSON MEMBER OF BAY
PACK BUT WAPA SACRAMENTO
REALTORS AND WE OPPOSE THIS BILL
IS WRITTEN.
NAME'S DAVID PHILLIPS I DROVE UP
FROM CHICO CALIFORNIA MY SON WAS
MURDERED IN FRONT OF ME MY TWO
GRANDCHILDREN WITHIN FIVE
SECONDS NO COMMANDS NO KNOCK ON
THE DOOR.
IF YOU COULD PLEASE ON THE DOOR
NONE OF THAT DOOR OPEN THEY
TASTE MY SON NO NO COMMANDS
RAISE YOUR HANDS YOU'LL BE TASTE.
GET ON THE GROUND YOU'LL BE DAYS
NONE OF THAT KICKED THE DOOR IN
TATE'S DAY I'M.
WITHIN THREE SECONDS OVER
SIXTEEN GOT SHOT. TO MY SON THIS
IS REALITY THIS IS WHAT I DO
WHEN I LEAVE HERE TODAY.
I'M GOING TO SAVE MARY'S.
SAY MERRILEES.
THE BOOK GRAY ENVELOPE FOR OUR
MUSCLES GRAY THAT MURDERED HIM
IN FRONT OF ME.
FACE NECK MOUTH.
THEY SAY A WORD NO COMMANDS NO
NOTHING THEY DISCONNECTED DORIAN
TATUM AND MURDERED HIM THIS ALL
HAPPENED IN FRONT OF ME AND WANT
TO READ CHILDREN.
NO ACCOUNTABILITY WHAT SO EVER.
SB TWO THIRTY THAT'S JUST A
LITTLE THING FOR YOU GUYS JUST
JUST TO KEEP YOU GUYS FOR NOT
BEING HELD ACCOUNTABLE.
I DO OPPOSE THE BILL
[inaudible]
RIGHT.
A GOOD MORNING SENATORS MY NAME
IS RUSS SCHOOL K. ON YOUNG
REPRESENTING FORMER RICHMOND
COUNCIL IMAGE OF AKA BECKLES WE
OPPOSE SB TWO THIRTY WE MUST
PASS A AB THREE NINETY TWO THANK
YOU.
GOOD MORNING DARCY BONTA JUNIOR
ON BEHALF OF THE GREATER
SACRAMENTO URBAN LEAGUE WE ARE
IN OPPOSITION.
SB.
TWO THIRTY HELLO MY NAME IS
CAPTAIN WORK ON THE MOTHER GOOD
SHAHRIL MAC -- KILLED IN THE
INITIAL BONE HEALS MOLD A
FOURTEENTH OF THIS YEAR OF TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN GO TO OFFICES
WAS HELD OUT OF POWER TO FOR
KILLING MY SON SO HIS BILL.
IF YOU'RE TRYING TO PASS RIGHT
NOW CANNOT BE PASSED BECAUSE YOU
GIVE ME GOT TO BE PROSECUTED FOR
KILLING MINE.
BECAUSE IF THEY DON'T HASN'T
DOWN HERE THEY ARE ASKED HIM OF
ABOVE IN AGAIN TO YOU.
THEY'RE GONNA HAVE TO PAY FOR
WHAT THEY DID TO MY SON.
BECAUSE I'M A MOTHER THAT'S FINE
FOR THE RIGHT TO MY BABY.
BETTER RIGHT TO KILL MY SON THEY
SHOT HIM FIVE TIMES WHEN HE WAS
DOWN ALREADY HE TAKES ADAM FIVE
POUNDS.
EFFORTS AND ANY TIME ON A SHOT
AND JAZZ MORE WHY HE WAS DOWN
YOU TELL ME YOU WANT TO PASS HIS
BILL WOULD HAVE BEEN HELD.
OUT OF POLICY WOULD KILL MY BABY
COME ON NOW.
GET READY FOR THE BIG PLAY BACK.
DON'T.
SAID BE ON MY NAME IS JUDY EVENS
I'M FROM BAKER SO CALIFORNIA.
BAKER COPD MURDERED MY SON SHOT
HIM SEVEN TIMES IN THE BACK IN
TWO THOUSAND AND FIFTEEN I DO
POSES BAIL.
SAVE A LIFE.
MARIO GUERRERO ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION
AND WE REMAIN OPPOSED AS WE
BELIEVE THERE NEEDS TO BE
STATEWIDE STANDARDS.
MY NAME IS SHANNON GROWN FROM
LOS ANGELES CALIFORNIA.
ON THE BECAUSE NO JOHN TIME
CERTAIN THIRD.
WAS BEATEN TO DEATH BY TEN LOS
ANGELES SHIP THE PIZZA MAN
CENTER JAMIL.
THIRTY TWO THOUSAND NINE THESE
OFFICERS DISTORTING TODAY.
THIS BILL SHOULD NOT BE PASSED
BECAUSE IT DOES NOT PROTECT THE
BLACK BROWN ADMITTED COMMUNITY
THERE'S SUPPOSED TO PROTECT TO
KEEP THEM ALIVE.
ALSO FOR FOR MY SON WHO IS MIXED.
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU WOULD END UP
BEING DOWN WHAT MY COUSIN DID OR
SHOT.
ME NO SB THREE THIRTY AND YES AB.
THREE NINE TWO DONNAMANDEL
REPRESENTING SAN FRANCISCO
PUBLIC DEFENDER'S OFFICE IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL IN PRINT.
OR MY LOOK US DOWN ALSO COMING
FROM SALINAS CALIFORNIA WITH
ORGANIZATION TO ME BY AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL --
RIGHT SHE CITY LIFT UP LOVE
ALWAYS AS OPPOSED THIS BILL.
GUN VIOLENCE IS GUN VIOLENCE AND
MURDER IS MURDER [inaudible]
ACCOUNTABILITY.
LESLIE CALDWELL CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION
WERE IN THE SAME POSITION AS THE
ACLU.
REMAIN CLOSED -- PENDING REVIEW
OF THE AMENDMENTS.
MALINA DEALER WITH BLACK LIVES
MATTER WE OPPOSE THE BILL AS
WRITTEN AND LOOK FORWARD TO
SEEING THE AMENDMENTS AND STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB.
THREE NINETY TWO ANY BANKS OF
THE JUSTICE TEAMS NETWORK AN
ANTI POLICE CHAIR PROJECT --
SIMILAR TO BLACK LIVES MATTER
LOS ANGELES WE OPPOSE TWO THIRTY
AS IT IS WRITTEN -- AND WILL
LOOK AT THE AMENDMENTS AND WHERE
IN STRONG SUPPORT AND ARE BOTH
CO SPONSORS OF AB THREE NINETY
TWO PLEASE VOTE YES ON AB THREE
NINETY TWO THANK YOU -- STEFAN
ANISH FAN OF BROTHERS GOOD
SHARIA MAC AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
WHAT ARE STRONGLY WITH A. B.?
THREE NINETY TWO I DON'T
REPRESENT AN ORGANIZATION BUT
I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF THE ALL
THE FAMILIES.
AND I'D AND POST.
SB.
TWO THIRTY HI MY NAME IS LAUREL
DOES A NINE THE FAMILY THAT'S
IMPACTED BY POLICE VIOLENCE AND
I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO WHATEVER
AMENDMENTS ARE GOING TO BE MADE
ON THIS BILL BUT TO STRONGLY
SUPPORT.
AB THREE NINETY TWO THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS ALICE CORLEY MY SON'S
NAME IS LINE OF VINCENT GIPSON
JUNIOR HE WAS MURDERED BY LONG
BEACH POLICE DEPARTMENT.
I STRONGLY OPPOSE A. B.. TWO
THIRTY BUT AS WRITTEN.
BUT I LOOK FORWARD TO A. B..
THREE NINETY TWO HI MY NAME IS
PAMELA FAILS OF THE MOTHER OF
DANTE JORDAN WAS KILLED BY LONG
BEACH POLICE DEPARTMENT I AM THE
ON A DANTE PARKER WHO WAS KILLED
BY VICTORVILLE POLICE DEPARTMENT.
I'M ALSO THE COUSIN OF DEREK
COUNTLESS HEREBY LONG BEACH
DEPARTMENT THIS BILL HAS TO GO.
MY NAME IS SHIRLEY MANSON.
I'M A MOTHER OF CHRISTOPHER DE
ANDRE MITCHELL.
TORRANCE POLICE DEPARTMENT
MURDER MY ONLY CHILD.
DECEMBER NINTH [inaudible]
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN ANNA
OPPOSED HIS BAIL.
AS THE TWO THIRTY ONE OF THE
OFFICERS WAS TOP KEVIN ARGUED.
MY NAME IS ROSY CHAVEZ ALSO
ACCOUNTABILITY BUDGET BUT I'M
ALSO AN ANTI THAT WAS --
IMPACTED FROM MY NEPHEW WHO WAS
KILLED BY SAN JOSE PD AND NINE
OPPOSING THE SB TWO THIRTY AM
STRONGLY IN FAVOR SB
[inaudible]
TWO THREE NINE TWO THE MORNING.
THIS IS REALITY HERE.
MY NAME S FUHRMAN VINCENT
VALENZUELA.
MY SON IS FUHRMAN'S AROUND THE
WITH A JUNIOR.
HE WAS MURDERED BY THE ANA
POLICE DEPARTMENT [inaudible]
JULY SECOND [inaudible] TWENTY
SIXTEEN THEY CHOKED ON THE DEATH.
AND IT'S ALL CAUGHT ON VIDEO.
AND I PRAY THAT.
EACH AND EVERYONE OF YOU
[inaudible]
VOTE NO.
ON SB.
TWO THIRTY IT DOES NOTHING. TO
PROTECT THE CITIZENS
[inaudible]
OF THIS.
GREAT STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
LOOK AT MY SON HERE SUFFERING.
BEGGING FOR HIS LIFE.
EVEN THE UNIVERSAL SO.
TAP THAT HE GIVES UP
[inaudible]
I'M DYING.
AND THEY KILL THEM.
I OPPOSE THE BILL. THREE NINETY
TWO MUST BE PASSED.
I AM THE ACCOUNT OF FUHRMAN
VINCENT BALANCE WAY LIKE THIS
WITH MY BROTHER.
SEVEN HIS ONLY SON.
ANAHEIM PD ARE MURDERS THE
MURDER MY NEPHEW HE DIDN'T
COMMIT A CRIME HE WAS UNARMED.
THIS IS THE REALITY THIS IS
POLICE VIOLENCE IT HAS TO STOP.
I VOTE NO ON SB.
TWO THIRTY LET OUR PEOPLE LIVE.
YOU HAVE TO BE YOU HAVE TO
RETRAIN THESE OFFICERS ARE IT'S
NOT GOING TO STOP IT'S GOING TO
GET WORSE.
REMEMBER THIS.
HOW CAN THE OFFICERS SLEEP AT
NIGHT KNOWING THAT THE MURDER
THEY'RE NOT DOING A JOB THEY'RE
NOT?
ACTING IN SERVING WE PAY THEIR
SALARIES.
IT MUST STOP.
HI MY NAME IS MARISSA MULLIN
SWELTERING KILL I AM THE AM THE
FUHRMAN VINSON VIOLENCE WELL A
JUNIOR.
WHO WAS MURDERED BY ANAHEIM
POLICE ON JULY SECOND?
TWENTY SIXTEEN I OPPOSE THIS
BILL AND DOES VIOLENCE MUST STOP
WE NEED TO CHANGE IMMEDIATELY.
THANK YOU.
I'M TO ROW TRAILER.
ON THE LOCAL [inaudible]
OF CHRISTOPHER'S.
THE ANDREA MITCHELL THAT WAS
MURDERED BY TOWARDS -- JUST TO
HEAR MY NEPHEW ALL -- TAKE SAY
STOP STOP STOP AN OFFICER SO I'M
SIX MORE TIMES.
OUR STATE HERE.
AND JUST PRAY.
THAT YEAH I DON'T PASSED THE
BILL [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS CHRISTINE BANG I
AM THE MOTHER.
OF GENERAL RICHARD.
NO TWO SB.
TWO THIRTY GOOD MORNING TO ALL
OF YOU.
MY NAME IS JIM MILLION LAND.
TODAY I STAND HERE BEFORE YOU TO
SPEAK ON BEHALF OF STUFF ON
CLARK.
AS YOU ALL KNOW STEFAN CLARK WAS
GUNNED DOWN IN HIS GRANDMOTHER'S
BACKYARD.
I STAND HERE IN SUPPORT OF AB.
THREE NINETY TWO AND IN DIRECT
OPPOSITION OF SB.
TWO THIRTY BUT MOST IMPORTANTLY
WHAT I WOULD LIKE TO SHARE WITH
YOU.
IS THAT THOUGH I AM IN
OPPOSITION OF SB.
TWO THIRTY I'D LIKE TO MAKE IT
CLEAR THAT ALL OF THESE FAMILIES
[inaudible]
ARE HURTING.
WE'RE TIRED OF LOSING OUR LOVED
ONES WE ARE TIRED OF SEEING NO
ACCOUNTABILITY.
AND WHILE WE CONTINUE TO HAVE
THESE DISCUSSIONS AROUND
TRAINING.
I WOULD LIKE TO SAY.
THE DE ESCALATION TACTICS ARE
NOT NECESSARILY THE PROBLEM.
BECAUSE WE HAVE SEEN TIME AND
TIME AGAIN WHEN IT IS A WHITE
SHOOTER.
WHO IS KNOWN? TO HAVE A WEAPON.
WHO IS KNOWN TO HAVE JUST
MURDERED SOMEONE?
HE'S NOT TASTY IS NOT BEATEN HIS
NOT DRAGGED HIS PEACEFULLY
ARRESTED.
HE MAY EVEN BE TAKEN TO FIND HIS
FAVORITE MEAL.
YET WHEN IT IS A BLACK ON ON
ARMED [inaudible]
SPEC.
HIS BURLY GUN DOWN.
WE'RE NOT IN OPPOSITION OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
WE'RE IN OPPOSITION OF HUMAN
BEINGS LOSING THEIR LIVES.
TO SENSELESS GUN VIOLENCE.
I WOULD LIKE TO MAKE IT VERY
CLEAR.
THAT POLICE MURDER.
MY FIRE ARMS.
GUN VIOLENCE IN THIS COUNTRY.
THEN WE HAVE HAD ABSOLUTELY NO.
AND WE'RE ASKING YOU TODAY
[inaudible]
PLEASE [inaudible]
THIS BILL.
THE PAST SB THREE NINETY TWO
POLES SB TWO THIRTY GIVE THESE
FAMILIES.
HAVE BEEN FIGHTING FOR THIS
[inaudible] FIFTEEN YEARS.
SOME SENSE OF JUSTICE.
BECAUSE IT WAS YOUR LOVED.
ONE YOU WOULD WANT.
GOOD MORNING EVERYONE MONIES ARE
DANTE IVORY.
WITH THE BLACK LIVES MATTER.
AND ARE ACTUALLY SPEAKING
OPPOSITION OF A SB TWO THIRTY
AND FATHER FAMILIES.
THAT HAD DEAL WITH UNFAIR
TREATMENT IN TRAUMA -- BUT ON I
JUST -- JUST THE HOME.
FROM ALL THE VIOLENCE.
AND I JUST WANNA SPEAK ALSO
BOUGHT THE WHOLE FAIR TREATMENT.
OF THE POLICE -- THAT THEY GIVE
US SOME SAUCE FROM A VICTIM.
WELL IF YOU'RE TREATING THE
BECAUSE YOU KNOW.
HAVEN'T UNFAIR TREATMENT.
A TO HAVE IMPACT ON THE CARS.
IN IT ALSO BE EMBARRASSING IT'S
NOT FAIR. TO THE FANS AND THAT
THEY HAVE TO COMPARE.
AND HAVE TO SUFFER FROM TRAUMA.
AFTER COME HERE.
EVERY MORE OFTEN SPEAK.
AND HAVE TO DEAL WITH THESE.
THAT THERE IS SOMETHING THAT HAS
TO BE DONE ABOUT THIS.
IT'S NOT FAIR OF THIS AT ALL.
WE DESERVE BETTER.
WE ARE DESERVES SAYING TREATMENT
THANKS TO MEET THE POLICE WON'T.
WHICH HE DID AS WELL.
WE DESERVE THIS CENTURY
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
A ARE SPOKEN.
TO OPPOSITION OF SB COULD START.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME'S KIA BILL
ROE.
MY HUSBAND WAS FRANCISCO BILL
ROE HE WAS MURDERED BY
BAKERSFIELD POLICE DEPARTMENT
AUGUST EIGHTEENTH -- TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN HE WAS SHOT
SEVENTEEN TIMES TWELVE HOURS
AFTER THE POLICE OFFICERS TOLD
ME MY CHILDREN AS SOON AS WE
FIND WE'RE KILLING HIM.
I STRONGLY OPPOSE TWO THIRTY
I'LL DO LOOK FOR TO THE
AMENDMENTS.
AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT AB THREE
NIGHT AB THREE NINETY TWO THANK
YOU.
THANK SKEWS ME MY NAME IS SERRA
LENORA.
MY BROTHER IN LAW MY SISTER'S
HUSBAND WAS KILLED IN.
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN I STAND IN
OPPOSITION OF THIS BILL.
THE ONLY THING I HAVE TO SAY IS
THAT MY MILITARY TERRY TRAINING.
GAVE ME WAY MORE THAN MANY OF
THE POLICE OFFICERS HAVE COME
ACROSS IN MY LIFE AND I DON'T
SEE HOW THAT'S FAIR [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
VALERIE VERA AND I AM THE MOTHER
OF ERIC RIVERA WHO WAS.
SALLY LOST HIS LIFE -- AT THE
YOUNG AGE OF TWENTY YEARS OLD
WHEN TO VERY NEGLIGENT AND
HONESTLY VERY INCOMPETENT POLICE
OFFICERS -- WRONGFULLY MURDERED
HIM THEY SHOT HIM SEVEN TIMES
WITH ONE SHOT TO THE HEAD WHICH
IS WHAT.
WHAT KILLED HIM INSTANTLY NOT
ONLY THAT IF THAT WASN'T BAD
ENOUGH AS IT WAS THEY FAILED TO
PUT THEIR PATROL CAR IN PARK?
WHEN THEY JUMPED OUT THE SHOT MY
SON IN A MATTER SEVEN SECONDS IN
A MATTER? ELEVEN SECONDS THE
PATROL CAR WAS ON TOP OF HIS
BOND DEAD BODY -- HIS WHOLE FOR
HIS WHOLE BODY WAS UNDERNEATH
THE WHOLE FRONT OF THEIR THEIR
BUMPER -- THERE WAS A METAL GATE
THAT ACTUALLY STOP THE CAR A AND
IF IT WASN'T FOR THE GATE THE
CART WOULD HAVE ROLLED OVER MY
SON'S FACE -- AND AS THE COP.
ACTUALLY ONE OF THE THE
PASSENGER COP WHEN HE JUMPED OUT
HE SHOT FIRST -- AND AFTER HE
DITCHED GOT FINISHING MY SON
DOWN HE ENDS UP TRIPPING OVER
HIS OWN TWO FEET.
SCRIPPS IS OUT ON THE STREET AND
TRIES TO CLAIM THAT HE WAS
POSSIBLY SHOT WHEN MY SON WAS ON
ARM SO HE MADE A FALSE CLAIM OF
BEING SHOT.
ALSO WHEN HE REALIZED THAT HIS
PARTNER FELT THAT CAR IN PARK HE
TELLS HIS PARTNER.
THE CAR THE CAR STEP IN AND STEP
ON THE BRAKE AS THE OFFICER
DEBRA DRIVERS JOHNSON CATCHES UP
TO THE CAR.
ATTEMPTS TO GET IN AND INSTEAD
OF STEPPING ON THE BRAKE HE
STEPS ON THE GAS.
OUR BIG SELLER IN THE CAR TO
COMPLETELY AND MY SON UNDERNEATH
IT.
THEY LEFT AMONG COVER FOR THREE
HOURS FOR THE COMMUNITY WHICH IS
THE COMMUNITY THAT I WAS BORN
REYES THEY WHICH IS THE
COMMUNITY THAT MY SON WAS BORN
AND RAISED IN. TO BE SEEN THEY
LEFT THE CAR ON TOP OF A TWELVE
HOURS.
AND THEY HAD TO HAVE A CRANE
COME AND PICK IT UP OFF HIS BODY.
SO ICE IN AND THEY WENT BACK TO
WORK THE NEXT DAY WITH NO
ACCOUNTABILITY AT ALL AND I AND
I THAT SO WRONG.
SO I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
AND I URGE YOU AYE BABY I PLEAD
WITH YOU PLEASE PASS.
AB. THREE NINETY TWO FOR US
FAMILIES TO BE ABLE TO GET SOME
KIND OF PEACE BECAUSE RIGHT NOW
I DON'T FEEL SAFE AT ALL BEING
AROUND ANY OFFICERS AND I NEVER
WILL UNTIL I KNOW.
MY SENSE JUSTICE COMES AND
THERE'S ACCOUNTABILITY AND THAT
NO OTHER LIVES WERE TAKEN AWAY
EVER AGAIN THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS JESS RODRIGUEZ ON
HERE -- REPRESENT MY COUSIN
JAMES OUT OF ROSA HE WAS
MURDERED NOVEMBER THIRTEENTH TWO
THOUSAND FOURTEEN BY BIG SHOW
POLICE DEPARTMENT.
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE SB THREE
TWENTY THREE DOT.
TWO TWO THIRTY HI MY NAME IS AN
CORTES AND THIS IS MY SON'S
ANTINEUTRINO.
WHO WAS KILLED BY LOS ANGELES
POLICE DEPARTMENT? TWELVE
OFFICERS AND A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
ROUNDS.
HE ONLY CAUGHT FIFTY EIGHT
LITTLE ONES IS WHAT I WAS TOLD.
AFTER BEING OVER A BALCONY FOR
SIXTEEN AND A HALF HOURS FOR THE
WORLD SEATING CALL ME FOR THREE
DAYS TO LET ME KNOW.
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL FOR
SB.
TWO THIRTY MY NAME'S BENICIA
HARM WITH SILICON VALLEY DEBUG
WE OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME'S JOEL SECRETARIES AND
ALMOST SILICON VALLEY DEBUG AND
I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS SHERRY SYMINGTON WAS
SILICON VALLEY DEBUG WE OPPOSE
THIS BILL WE WANT TO LIFT UP THE
FAMILIES HERE WHO ARE HERE AND
TESTIFYING TODAY WITH ALL YOUR
BRAVERY.
WE WANT TO LIFT UP CERTAIN
FAMILIES FROM SAN JOSE WHO
COULDN'T MAKE IT TODAY AND ON
YOUR BECAUSE MY LOPEZ RUDY
CARDENAS AJ PHILLIPS JENNIFER
VASQUEZ ANTHONY NOON YES JACOB
DOMINGUEZ.
DIANA SHOW MANY PSYCHE LOPEZ
RICHARD HAWKINS AS SOON AS
MONDAY JUNE NAY AND FOR THE
POCKETS.
HELLO MY NAME IS JOY RODRIGUEZ
FROM SILICON VALLEY DEBUG AND I
OPPOSE SB.
TWO THIRTY HI MY NAME IS ALL THE
WHILE I WAS SILICON VALLEY DE
BOOK AS A VICTIM OF POLICE
BRUTALITY AND ADVOCATE FOR
PRISONERS HUMAN RIGHTS AS WELL
AS VIOLENCE OPPOSES BILL.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS SUSAN
WOLF I'M WITH SILICON VALLEY
DEBUG TODAY AND THE FAMILIES OF
THE SOUNDS AREA AND IN
CALIFORNIA WHO'VE LOST LOVED
ONES.
I'M STRONG OPPOSITION OF THIS
BILL.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS MARLENE
SANCHES ON WITH COMMUNITIES
UNITED FOR RESTORATIVE JUSTICE
IN OAKLAND -- I'M HERE IN
OPPOSITION OF TWO THIRTY THIS IS
JESSE ROMERO A YOUNG MAN WHO WAS
SHOT AND KILLED BY LAPD WHO WAS
SCARED AND WAS RUNNING AWAY AND
SB TWO THIRTY WOULD NOT PROTECT.
HIM.
THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS TI ERA MCCOY
THOMPSON.
I'M WITH COURAGE OF OAKLAND.
MY NEPHEW DANTE DOING PARKER WAS
KILLED BY VICTORVILLE SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL AS IT IS WRITTEN.
MY NAME IS HAYDEN MILIEU HUMM
FORMALLY INCARCERATED AND I'M
WITH -- COMMUNITIES UNITED FOR
SORT OF YOUTH JUSTICE IN OAKLAND --
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THIS
IS NOT DOUBLE OH SEVEN PLEASE DO
NOT NEED A LICENSE TO KILL.
HELLO MY NAME IS BRIANNA ROGER
HOME WORKERS NATIONALLY OPPOSES
NEW.
MY NAME IS JOAN BENOIT I'M WITH
COMMUNITIES UNITED FOR YOUTH
RESTORATIVE JUSTICE IN OAKLAND I
AM A MOTHER OF TWO SMALL
CHILDREN AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
GOOD MORNING I'M SIERRA HAMILTON
FIRST COUSIN CITY ON TEH ARBOR
HE WAS SHOT IN THE BARSTOW
PARKING LOT.
IN.
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN HE WAS
SHOT AT OVER THIRTY TIMES HE
TOOK TEN OF THOSE BULLETS.
OF FOR THE OFFICES FOR THE
OFFICERS THEY SHOT ON THIRTY
TIME AND THEY WANT IT.
ALSO ANOTHER LADY THAT WAS IN
THE CAR -- DION TAKES A TEN OF
THOSE SHOTS IN THE POLICE DID
NOTHING TO PRESERVE HIS LIFE
THEY DIDN'T EVEN WANT TO
RESUSCITATE HIM HE DIED OF
EXPLORATION.
I DO NOT AGREE WITH THIS BILL NO
TO SB.
TWO THIRTY HELLO MY NAME IS
MILLIE CAULKINS ANOTHER COLOR
COUSIN OF DANTE BUT YARBER.
AND WE SUPPORT THE AB TWO NINETY
TWO PROGRAM AND WE OPPOSED TO
THIS PRICE.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS ERICA
FAMILY OF DEONTIC EVER AND I SAY
NO TO SB.
TWO THIRTY GOOD MORNING
BEATRICE'S CALIFORNIA FAMILIES
UNITED FOR JUSTICE I JUST WANT
TO SAY OUR FAMILY'S KNEE CAP
ACCOUNTABILITY WE NEED TO HAVE
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR POLICE.
THEY DON'T NEED MORE TRAINING
BECAUSE WHEN THERE'S A PERSON
THAT'S NOT OF COLOR THAT
TRAINING KICKS RIDING IN AND
THOSE PEOPLE ARE ALIVE SO I
THINK WE SHOULD STOP SAYING THEY
NEED MORE TRAINING.
WHAT WE NEED IS POLICE
ACCOUNTABILITY POLLY'S CHILI IS
JUST THE BEGINNING BECAUSE THEY
RATE THEY BE THEY DO EVERYTHING
AND THEY ARE NOT HELD
ACCOUNTABLE SO NO TO THIS BILL
AND YES A THREE NINETY TWO
BECAUSE POLICE NEED TO BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE?
LIKE EVERYONE ELSE WE HAVE TO
SAY ACCOUNTABILITY WE GOT A HAVE
IS SO WE CAN SAVE OUR LIVES NO.
TWO TO THIRTY ON MARCH FIRST OF
THIS YEAR THE SALINAS POLICE
DEPARTMENT ASSASSINATED A TWENTY
YEAR OLD YOUNG LADY.
SUFFERING FROM MENTAL HEALTH
SUFFERING FROM POST POST PARTUM --
SO MY NAME IS HE'S VERY WE ON
THE PROGRAM POLICY DIRECTOR WITH
ME BY IN SALINAS CALIFORNIA.
IN STRONG OPPOSITION OF SB TWO
THIRTY THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING ON THE RIVER DOCTOR
MERRY WESTFALL I STAND IN
OPPOSITION TO SENATE BILL TWO
THIRTY IN STAND IN SUPPORT.
OF ASSEMBLY BILL THREE NINETY
TWO WE CONTINUE TO SEE THE DEATH
OF TOO MANY PEOPLE IN OUR
COMMUNITY AND THROUGHOUT THE
NATION.
AND WE HAVE TO COME TO TERMS
WITH THE FACT THAT AS MUCH AS
THERE ARE NO DOUBT PEOPLE OF
INTEGRITY WITHIN OUR LAW-ENFORCEMENT THE SYSTEM ITSELF IS
A WHITE SUPREMACIST ORGANIZATION
AND WE CANNOT HAVE JUSTICE UNTIL
WE ACTUALLY.
BEGIN TO TRANSFORM THE
INSTITUTION FROM WITH IN THE WE
ASK YOU -- TO TO NOT TO TAKE
THIS BILL UP BUT SUPPORT THREE
NINETY TWO AS WE TRY TO BRING
ACTUAL CHANGE TO OUR STATE THAT
WILL SAVE LIVES.
HI I'M ANNA SAYING FROM IRVINE
I'M REPRESENTING US MARK FOR A
LIVES CALIFORNIA WE STAND IN
OPPOSITION OF THIS BILL BECAUSE
A UNIFORMED IS NOT MEAN YOU
SHOULD HAVE IMMUNITY FROM
ACCOUNTABILITY.
MY NAME IS ADAM WORKING ON THE
CHAIR OF THE SOCIAL AND
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE COMMITTEE
THE UNIVERSALIST UNITARIAN
CHURCH OF RIVERSIDE.
I'M A LEADER WITH INLAND
CONGREGATIONS UNITED FOR CHANGE
AND PEOPLE CALIFORNIA.
AND IN STRONG OPPOSITION TO SB
TWO THIRTY WE NEED REAL
ACCOUNTABILITY LIKE AB.
THREE NINE TWO LET US LIVE.
HELLO MY NAME IS GROW FURRY AND
I'M PART OF THE SAN BERNARDINO
COUNTY FOR YOUNG DEMOCRATS.
AND I'M AND AND STRONG
OPPOSITION TO THIS HAVE FAST
BILL AT OF AS SPEED.
TO THIRTY COPS ARE CITIZENS TOO
AND THEY NEED TO BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE AND THEY FOLLOW THE
LAW JUST LIKE THE REST OF US.
MY NAME IS JULIA AND I'M A
MEMBER OF THE SAN BERNARDINO
COUNTY YOUNG DEMOCRATS AND YOUNG
PEOPLE ALL OVER THE COUNTRY ARE
LOOKING AT WHAT OUR GOVERNMENT
IS DOING BECAUSE WHAT OUR
GOVERNMENT IS DOING IS A MORAL.
SO I'M HERE TO ASK YOU TO DO THE
RIGHT THING FOR ALL OF THE
FAMILY MEMBERS THAT ARE FORCED
TO RELIVE THEIR TRAUMA EVERY
TIME THEY COME UP TO THIS MIKE
AND ASK YOU GUYS TO DO THE MORAL
THING.
MY NAME IS KAT CARELL I'M A
MEMBER OF THE LOCAL CHAPTER OF
THE ACLU.
I AM ALSO HERE ON BEHALF OF
INDIVISIBLE CALIFORNIA STRONG
AND INDIVISIBLE SACRAMENTO.
AND WE ARE AS WE ALL STAND IN
STRONG OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL
AND IN SUPPORT OF AB. THREE
TWENTY NINE I'M HOLDING UP THE
SIGNED UP THE NAME OF AN
INDIVIDUAL THIS IS AN INDIVIDUAL
WHO WOULD BE HERE TODAY.
IF IT WERE NOT FOR POLICE
VIOLENCE THIS PERSON DID NOT
DESERVE TO DIE.
IF AB THREE TWENTY NINES
PROVISIONS THREE NINETY TWO OF
PROVISIONS WERE IN EFFECT AND
FOLLOWED THIS PERSON WOULD STILL
BE ALIVE.
AND WITH US THIS PERSON SHOULD
STILL BE ALIVE MANY SHOULD BE
POLICE MUST BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE.
JUST LIKE EVERYONE ELSE THANK
YOU.
MY NAME IS NATALIE LAMAR I'M
VERY NERVOUS TODAY.
I'M A MEMBER OF THE ACLU.
I'M IN STRONG OPPOSITION OF THE
SENATE BILL.
BUT I'M AND VERY VERY VERY VERY
STRONGLY A PROPONENT OF AB THREE
NINETY TWO THAT ONE WORD
NECESSARY.
NECESSARY WHAT SAVE MANY LIVES I
COULD SAVE MY FATHER.
THEN KILLED WHAT IS A BLACK MAN.
I COULD SAVE MY HUSBAND BECAUSE
LIKE MY SONS BECAUSE THEY MY
NEPHEWS IT'S ONE WORD IT'S
NECESSARY.
AND I'M PHIL JACKSON WITH BILL
IN LA -- I'M STRONGLY OPPOSE
AGAINST SB TWO THIRTY LIVE IN A
CITY WHERE.
THE PUBLIC SCHOOL SYSTEM HAS A
SMALL A BUNCH IN THE POLICE.
THAT'S A BAD SYSTEM WE'RE
INVESTING MORE IN CRIMINALIZING
PEOPLE THAN INVESTING IN OUR
FUTURE MEETINGS THAT.
MY NAME IS SURGERY MARSHALL I'M
HERE WITH BLACK LIVES MATTER
ALLY I'M HERE TO ASK YOU NOT TO
SUPPORT A. B.. TWO THIRTY I'M
DAVID MOCAMA CONCERNED EXHAUSTED
CITIZEN OF LOS ANGELES AND I
STAND IN STRONG OPPOSITION TO SB.
TWO THIRTY THERE CAN BE NO
JUSTICE WITHOUT ACCOUNTABILITY
THAT'S THE STARTING POINT.
THANK.
HI MY NAME IS ANSWER THEM OF
BLACK LIVES MATTER LA IN A
GRADUATING SENIOR AT USC I'M
MISSING MY LAWSUIT ACROSS THE
STATE BECAUSE THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT'S IMPORTANT TO ME AND I'M
HERE TO OPPOSE SB. THIRTY HI
THERE MY NAME IS ANDY AND I AM
WITH -- Y. G. C. I'M HERE FOR
MICHAEL NIDA -- RAINY SOMETHING
IS SOMETHING THAT DOESN'T WORK
AND THEN PASSING IT OFF HIS
BRAND NEW DOESN'T CHANGE
ANYTHING.
AND TRYING TO PASS IT OFF HOW IS
IS KIND OF LAZY ND IN MY
OPINION.
SO WE'RE STRONG THING AGAINST
TWO THIRTY AND FOR THREE NINETY
TWO SO I HOPE YOU REALLY DO GIVE
A **** ABOUT THE CITIZENS YOU'RE
SERVING.
HELLO MY NAME IS ASIA CLOWNEY --
I AM REPRESENTING BLACK SITTING
UNION AT CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY LOS ANGELES AND ON
BEHALF OF US WE ARE IN STRONG
OPPOSITION.
SB.
TWO THIRTY HI MY NAME IS
SAVANNAH GUARDAR FROM LOS
ANGELES AND I'M STANDING IN
OPPOSITION OF SB TWO THIRTY BY
FAMILY MEMBERS WITH AN ALLEY PDF
TO SET THEMSELVES THAT TRAINING
A MORE MONEY TO THE SYSTEM THAT
KILLS PEOPLE.
ALL OVER THE STATE WILL NEVER
AND THE WHITE SUPREMACIST
ORGANIZATION ITSELF SO IF PEOPLE
WITHIN.
THE SYSTEM ARE EVEN SAYING THAT
THEY NEED TO SHUT IT DOWN THEN
YOU'LL STOP FUNDING.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS THE ANSWER FOR I'M
WITH BEND THE ARC OF JEWISH
PARTNERSHIP FOR JUSTICE AND I
JUST WANT TO SAY.
IN THE HOLIDAY OF PASSOVER WE
WERE TALKING ABOUT PLAGUES.
THAT POLICE VIOLENCE IS A PLAGUE
THAT LACK OF ACCOUNTABILITY IS A
PLAGUE.
AND SB TWO THIRTY IS A PLAY
THAT'S WHY I'M STANDING OUT
AGAINST SB TWO THIRTY AND IN
FAVOR OF AB THREE NINE TWO THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU AND BEFORE WE HAVE A
LOT MORE PEOPLE WHO WANT TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION WHICH OF
COURSE WE ALLOW EVERYONE -- TO
BUT I JUST WANTED TO ALERT
EVERYONE I'M SURE MANY OF THE
FOLKS WHO ARE OUT SO I DIDN'T
NECESSARILY HERE.
THAT THE AUTHOR IS ACCEPTED
AMENDMENTS IN THE COMMITTEE IS
SUBSTANTIALLY AMENDING THE BILL
WE ARE GETTING COPIES OF THE
MOCK UP OF WHAT THE BILL WOULD
LOOK LIKE AS AMENDED.
AND WE'VE ALREADY DISTRIBUTED A
GOOD NUMBER OF THEM WE ARE
GETTING MORE SO THEY CAN BE
DISTRIBUTED SO FOLKS CAN.
SEE ON THAT THE BILL IF THIS
COMMITTEE MOVES ON IT -- WILL BE
VERY SIGNIFICANTLY AMENDED --
AND THEN WHAT -- WHAT?
I WOULD LIKE IS FOR THOSE OF YOU
WHO REMAIN AND I DO APPRECIATE
HOW MUCH YOU'VE TRAVELED.
AND THE SERIOUSNESS OF WHICH YOU
HAVE TAKEN THIS AND ALSO.
THE TRAGEDIES ANY OF YOU MAY
HAVE PERSONALLY EXPERIENCED OR
YOUR FAMILIES.
BUT WHAT I WOULD HOPE -- BECAUSE
WE NEED -- TO WE WILL HAVE TO
CLOSE THIS COMMITTEE DOWN AT NEW
NOT FOR GOOD BUT WE HAVE
OBLIGATIONS AT NOON THAT MEMBERS
HAVE TO ATTEND.
TO SO WHAT I'M HOPING IS THAT WE
CAN CONCLUDE OUR DELIBERATIONS
ON THIS BILL BY NOON.
AND SO IF -- IF YOU CAN HELP ME
AND JUST INDICATE YOUR NAME YOUR
AFFILIATION IN YOUR OPPOSITION
FROM THIS POINT ON IT WOULD BE
VERY APPRECIATED -- AND LATER I
CAN REPEAT WHAT THE AMENDMENTS
REMOVE THE PORTIONS OF THE BILL
THAT REFER TO THE USE OF FORCE.
THE ONLY AT THE AMENDMENTS WOULD
ONLY RETAIN THOSE PORTIONS OF-THE BILL THAT DEAL WITH --
TRAINING AND ALSO DEAL WITH A
COUPLE OF THE LOCAL STANDARDS
THE AMENDMENTS WOULD RETAIN THE
SECTIONS FOR EXAMPLE.
THAT WOULD REQUIRE OFFICERS TO
PROMPTLY PROVIDE MEDICAL
ASSISTANCE AND WOULD ALSO RETAIN
THE REQUIREMENT THAT OFFICERS
HAVE TO INTERCEDE THEY SEE --
INAPPROPRIATE USE OF FORCE AND
REPORT IF THEY SEE ANOTHER
OFFICER IN INAPPROPRIATE USE OF
FORCE BUT THE OTHER MOST
IMPORTANT ASPECT I THINK TO SOME
OF YOU WHO OPPOSE.
IS THAT THE BILLS -- BECOMING
LAW IS CONTINGENT ON THE PASSAGE
OF AB THREE NINETY TWO SO THAT
IS.
THE THE AMENDMENTS THAT THIS
COMMITTEE WOULD BE -- ACCEPTING
IN THE AUTHOR IS ACCEPTED SO IF
THIS COMMITTEE ACTS ON THE BILL
THAT'S WHAT THE BILL WOULD.
WOULD -- BE AND COPIES OF THE
MARKUP WILL BE DISTRIBUTED OKAY
SO NOW YOU MAY PROCEED.
HI MY NAME'S ADAM SMITH -- AN
ORGANIZER WITH WHITE PEOPLE FOR
BLACK LIVES IN LOS ANGELES WHERE
THE LOS ANGELES POLICE
DEPARTMENT CURRENTLY GETS
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS PER YEAR.
TO CONDUCT -- DE ESCALATION
TRAINING WHICH DIDN'T SAVE THE
LIFE OF GROUPS ARE YOU MAC
DIDN'T SAVE THE LIFE OF JESSE
ROMERO DIDN'T SAVE THE LIFE.
OF ALBERT RAMON DORSEY OR OMAR
GONZALEZ SIR RICHARD WISHER
CARDINALS NOW WE DON'T NEED MORE
MONEY GOING TO TRAINING FOR THE
PLACE WE NEED SUBSTANTIVE LAW
CHANGE.
I OPPOSE SB TO FIX [inaudible]
THE NOT.
HELLO MY NAME IS SAM THE YOUNG
WITH CO FOUNDER MAPPING POLICE
VIOLENCE IN CAMPAIGN.
ZERO I OPPOSE SB TWO THIRTY IN
PART BECAUSE WHEN YOU LOOK AT
THE DATA OVER ONE THOUSAND AND
SEVENTY PEOPLE WERE KILLED BY
POLICE IN CALIFORNIA BETWEEN.
TWENTY THIRTEEN TO TWENTY
EIGHTEEN OF FEWER THAN HALF OF
1% OF THOSE CASES RESULT IN A
PROSECUTION AN 87% OF ALL CASES
IN WHICH POLICE SHOT SOMEBODY IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA BETWEEN.
TWENTY SIXTEEN TO TWENTY
SEVENTEEN THEY DID NOT EVEN
ATTEMPT ANY FORM OF NON LETHAL
FORCE BEFORE DECIDING TO SHOOT
FIRST AND ASK QUESTIONS LATER.
THAT MEANS UNDER THE EXISTING
STANDARD SHOOT FIRST ASK
QUESTIONS LATER IS LEGALIZED THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND WE NEED
TO AND THAT BY PASSING AB THREE
NINETY TO A AN OPPOSING SB --
TWO THIRTY AND AND STOPPING WITH
THIS PRACTICE OF HAVING THESE
VAGUE.
REQUIRE THESE VAGUE.
GUIDELINES ON VARIOUS THINGS
LIKE DADLY FORCE THAT ARE
IMPOSED THANK YOU REQUIREMENTS
I'M GOING TO START IN THE WORST.
SHAPE LIVE -- THANK YOU I WOULD
GREATLY APPRECIATE.
YOUR FINISHED -- JUST TO STICK
TO YOUR OFFICE.
Q. COMMENTARY NOW THANK YOU
AUDREY GEORGE WHITE PEOPLE FOR
BLACK LIVES IN LOS ANGELES
OPPOSING THIS BILL SB -- TWO
THIRTY OMAR GONZALEZ AND JUST
REMEMBER WOULD BE ALIVE TODAY IF
THE STANDARD WAS NECESSARY THE
KILLER COP WHO KILLED BOTH OF
THEM WITHIN TWELVE DAYS WOULD
HAVE BEEN CRIMINALIZED INSTEAD
OF LET GO [inaudible]
RIGHT.
MY NAME IS A KILLER I'M WITH
BLACK LIVES MATTER AS LA AND THE
SOUTHERN CHRISTIAN LEADERSHIP.
CONFERENCE AND WE OPPOSE SB TWO
THIRTY BECAUSE WE WANT
ACCOUNTABILITY RESPONSIBILITY
AND CONSEQUENCES IF YOU DON'T DO
THAT YOU CONTINUE TO SEND THE
MESSAGE THAT IT'S OKAY TO GIVE
US THE WE OPPOSE IT THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS ZACH SURE WHEN I'M
WITH WHITE PEOPLE FOR BLACK
LIVES IN LOS ANGELES -- EVEN AS
DESCRIBED IN THE AMENDED FORM I
OPPOSE SB -- TWO THIRTY WE DON'T
NEED ME OFF MORE MONEY FOR
TRAINING IT DOESN'T WORK
[inaudible]
OPPOSED.
HI MY NAME IS MICHAEL HAMMERSLEY
I'M ALSO WITH WHITE PEOPLE FOR
BLACK LIVES AYE OPPOSED SB TWO
THIRTY ON EVEN AS AMENDED THAT
MONEY THAT COULD BE GOING FOR
pWITH EDUCATION HOUSING MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES [inaudible]
THANK.
THE ROUBLE WITH THE INDIVIDUAL
SACRAMENTO IN INDIVISIBLE
CALIFORNIA STATE STRONG OPPOSE.
MY NAME IS BEN CORPS I'M FROM
LOS ANGELES -- I'M HERE WITH
YOUTH JUSTICE COALITION AND I'M
AN EMPLOYEE OF THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA -- I'M HERE TO OPPOSE --
SB TWO THIRTY AND I'M ALSO HERE
ON BEHALF OF KENDRICK MCDADE.
WHO IS KILLED UNARMED -- BY
PASADENA POLICE ON MARCH TWENTY
FOURTH [inaudible]
TWENTY TWELVE THANK YOU.
AND STEVE ROGERS WITH LEE AVENUE
CHURCH ST TAKE HIM POWER NOW --
UNTIL WE ACTUALLY ARE ABLE TO
SEE THE AMENDMENTS AND PRINCE
YOU KNOW HERE TO OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
HI MY NAME IS BRIANNA.
I'M HERE FOR A VEHICLE OF THE
WAS KILLED BY AT LEAST SHARES IN
I'M HERE TO OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS DAMIEN KUZMIN
ON FROM SOUTH CENTRAL LA -- FROM
THE YOUTH JUSTICE COALITION AND
I'M HERE IN REMEMBRANCE OF
RICHARD TYSON.
WHO WAS KILLED BY INGLEWOOD
POLICE MAY NINTH OF TWO THOUSAND
SEVEN AND I'M HERE TO A POST
UNTIL WE SEE AMENDMENT?
MY NAME IS ASHLEY VELSEN I'M
HERE WITH THE YOUTH JUSTICE
COALITION.
HALF OF JOSE MENDEZ WHO SHOT BY
LAPD AND WE OPPOSE THE SENATE --
THIS BILL UNTIL THEIR AMENDMENTS.
HI MY NAME IS MATEO I AM A
MEMBER OF BLACK LIVES MATTER LOS
ANGELES AND DIGNITY AND POWER
NOW.
I AM AN ABOLITIONIST AND I'M A
CONSTITUENT OF HOLLY MITCHELL.
AND WE ARE DEMANDING THE END. TO
POLICE MURDERS BECAUSE THEY ARE
HATE CRIMES.
TRAINING HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH
IT IT'S ABOUT PRESERVING LIFE.
THIS IS A SEA CHANGE AND YOU ALL
BETTER GET.
ONBOARD AND MICHAEL G. MYSKINA
TELLING US WHAT WE CAN SAY OR
WHEN WE CAN SAY IT OR HOW THE
BILL'S GOING TO LOOK.
IT WILL BE ABOUT THE PEOPLE OR
YOU'LL BE PRIME LAST YEAR
PRIMARY JR OUTSIDE HERE.
OKAY THANKS FOR ALL OF YOU.
I STRONGLY OPPOSE.
TWO THIRTY OKAY.
HAVING IS FATIMA FOR AMERICAN
FRIENDS SERVICE COMMITTEE A WE
OPPOSE THE BILL UNTIL THERE ARE
FOR THE MEN'S.
HI MY NAME IS OSCAR PENA WITH
AMERICAN FRIENDS SERVICE
COMMITTEE OPPOSED TO THIRTY BUT
ALSO PAY ATTENTION TO WORK
CALIFORNIA ATTORNEY GENERAL EXAM
HERE BY CO.
TO RECOMMEND THIS SACRAMENTO
POLICE DEPARTMENT THE FORTY NINE
RECOMMENDATIONS.
OF THE USE OF FORCE A POLICY
THAT IS -- DEFINITELY SOMETHING
THAT WE SHOULD BE LOOKING AT HOW
THAT ALSO APPLIES TO ALL POLICE
DEPARTMENT'S USE OF FORCE POLICY
STINKY.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS MEAN
ELSTER LEGAL SERVICES ARE
PRISONERS OF CHILDREN ALL OF US
ARE NINE AND WE OPPOSE THIS BILL
UNTIL WE CAN SEE AMENDMENTS.
HELLO MY NAME IS SABINA PRO CITY
I'M THE POLICY MANAGER AT LEGAL
SERVICES FOR PERSONS WITH
CHILDREN WE ALSO OPPOSE THIS
BILL WE BELIEVE THAT WEBER SPIEL --
THREE NINETY TWO DEALS WITH THE
SITUATION APPROPRIATELY THANK
YOU.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS KATIE
DIXON ON THE POLICY FELLOW ELLIS
PC AND ALL OF A SUDDEN AND WE
OPPOSED TO THIRTY AND WE HOPE
YOU GUYS DO NOT VOTE FOR IT
THANK YOU.
BLENDING CROWDY LEGAL SERVICES
FOR PERSONS WITH CHILDREN ALL OF
US AND NINE AND WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL YOU GUYS ARE SO
STRONG.
YOU CAN MONO WITH PEAK OF
CALIFORNIA WE OPPOSE SB TWO
THIRTY INTO WAS IMMINENT THANK
YOU.
GOOD MORNING MARC FILL PART WITH
THE ALLIANCE FOR BOYS AND MEN OF
COLOR POLICY THANK THANK YOU TO
THE COMMITTEE IN MADAM CHAIR --
WE OPPOSE THIS BILL TO WE CAN
SEE AMENDMENTS -- BECAUSE IT
ALLOWS PEOPLE TO KILL EVEN IF
NOT NECESSARY TO THE DEFEND
THEMSELVES OR THE PUBLIC THANK
YOU.
THE AXES VOICE TO THE YOUTH
CHILL SB.
TWO THIRTY WHY MCLEAN SECOND A
WHACK PEOPLE CALIFORNIANS
STRONGLY OPPOSE TE BILL IN
SUPPORT OF AB.
THREE NINETY TWO YEAH MY NAME IS
ROSHAN IRVINE INGLEWOOD
CALIFORNIA STRONGLY OPPOSES BILL
WITH THE UNDERSTANDING THAT THIS
IS A COLONIAL INSTITUTION.
OF ORGANIZED OPPRESSION.
MY NAME IS JOHN TO MICHELLE I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
ALLEN MARLING FROM ALAMEDA
CALIFORNIA -- AYE OPPOSED TO
THIRTY AND SUPPORT. THREE NINETY
TWO THANK YOU -- HERNANDEZ FROM
THE LM LOTS A TO A STRONG A POLL
TO BE A IT'S TIME FOR THE PEOPLE
BE RESPONSIBLE FOR THE ACTION
WHAT DO YOU DO TO OUR PEOPLE CHU
MIN A BAT.
I STRONGLY OPPOSE ISSUED OUT
RIGHT NOW. FIVE OH ROCKY MURDOCH
OPPOSES BILL AND SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THREE NINETY TWO THANKS.
MY NAME SERVING.
A YOUTH JUSTICE COALITION AYE
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL BECAUSE
EVERYBODY OVER YEARS TRYING TO
COVER UP OTHER THINGS WITH LIES
SO WE NEED JUSTICE FOR ALL THESE
FAMILIES.
I'M JOHN SMU'S USED AS HIS
COALITION HERE -- REPRESENT AND
DEREK COLLINS WHO IS SHOP AND
THROUGH HIS GATE PINE ROUTINE
TRAFFIC STOP NOT FLEEING THE
SCENE.
BUT I'M I STRONGLY OPPOSE.
CHEMICAL FROM THE JUSTICE
COALITION PROUD CO SPONSORS OF
THREE NINETY TWO AN URGE TO PASS
THIS BILL AND OPPOSE THIS BILL
AND ONCE HIS BILL CRUSHED.
I'M HERE FOR JUST TWO ROMERO WHO
IS RUNNING AWAY WHEN HE WAS SHOT
BY LAPD HE'S FOURTEEN YEARS OLD.
HELLO GOOD MORNING I'M HERE TO
POSE AS BE TWO THIRTY AMIR BUT A
WOODROW PLAYERS IS THIRD HE WAS
SOUTHERN A TRAFFIC STOP.
HE WAS SHOT SERVES AS A FRIEND.
HI MY NAME IS EMILY I'M WITH THE
YOUTH JUSTICE COALITION AND I'M
HERE ARE FROM MY COUSIN JUNIOR
RODRIGUEZ WHO WAS -- FOURTEEN
WHEN HE WAS TRYING KILLED BY
SOMETHING A PD STRONGLY --
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
AND TO DO ALL THE DIGESTIVE
COALITION -- OPPOSE SB TWO
THIRTY SUPPORT AB THREE NINE TWO
AND THE POUND I DID REALLY WELL
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING JANA MY NAME IS
MICHAEL SURVEY DRUM WITH YOUTH
JUSTICE COALITION AND IN MEMORY
OF DEVON BROWN.
A YOUNG MAN THIRTEEN YEARS OLD A
KID WHO WAS KILLED BY LAPD FROM
BEHALF FOR HIM AND HIS FAMILY I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
ALSO WITH THE YOUTH JUSTICE
COALITION -- OPPOSE THIS BILL I
DON'T EVEN HAVE WORDS TO SAY
CITY PENA WAS EIGHTEEN MONTHS OF
WHICH IS KILLED BY THE PD.
HI MY NAME IS JENNIFER ROMAS I
LIVE IN SANTA ANA AND I OPPOSE
SB TWO THIRTY AND WITH A SEAL
YOU OF CALIFORNIA.
HELLO MY NAME IS KEVIN BOTH SOME
WITH THE ALIANCE FOR COMMITTEE
ACTIVATION AND BUILDING I OPPOSE
SB TWO THIRTY REST IN PEACE
SHOWS A MAN.
MY NAME IS -- EUGENE I'M WITH A
BUNCH OF ORGANIZATION THE IS A A
POOR PEOPLE'S CAMPAIGN ME TO
INTERNATIONAL AND I AM HERE
SPEAKING TODAY.
OFF OF A LINE OR GIPSON PUSH ON
KILLED BY LAPD AND IN STRONG
OPPOSITION TO SB.
TWO THIRTY HAVE A GOOD DAY.
ARE YOU DOING MY NAME IS ARE
CAME HANGS MY NEPHEW WAS
CHRISTOPHER DE ANDRE MISSILE HE
WAS MURDERED AND TOWERS.
THE CITY OF TORRANCE BY THE
TAURUS PT AND I'M AGAINST IS BO.
I'M WILL USE JUSTICE COALITION.
MY NAME IS CURRENTLY BRANDON I
AM HERE TODAY IN OPPOSITION OF
SB TWO THIRTY IT DOES NOT CREATE
ANY SORT OF ACCOUNTABILITY.
AND AS EVIDENCED BY WHAT
HAPPENED WHEN MAYOR DEL DARRELL
STEINBERG MANDATED CRISIS
INTERVENTION TRAINING FOR SOCK
PD.
IT'S CLEAR THAT IT DOESN'T WORK.
HELLO MY NAME IS LINDA I'M FROM
COMMUNITY COALITION HERE WITH
EQUAL VOICES IN OPPOSITION OF
TWO THIRTY SB TWO THIRTY IS A
FAKE DEADLY FORCE REFORM THE
SENATE SHOULD SHELVE IT IN THE
COMMITTEE.
MY NAME IS TOM ZEBRA HER
STRONGLY OPPOSES BILL.
NAME IS JEREMY WAITING WITH THE
MANY FIRST COALITION THE ME TWO
SURVIVORS MARCH SB TWO THIRTY IS
YET ANOTHER ATTEMPT BY LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO AVOID
ACCOUNTABILITY AND MY
ORGANIZATIONS ARE IN STRONG
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS AMANDA YOUNG I
LIVE IN SAN FRANCISCO I'M WITH A
SILLY OF CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS MAHMOUD SEVERAL FAR
I'M THE DIRECTOR OF MARCH FOR
LIFE CALIFORNIA.
WE STRONGLY OPPOSE SB TWO THIRTY
ONE THOUSAND ONE HUNDRED AND
SIXTY FIVE PEOPLE WERE TAKING AT
THE HANDS OF LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
TWENTY EIGHTEEN YOU ARE THREE
TIMES MORE LIKELY TO GET KILLED
IF YOU ARE A PERSON OF COLOR. TO
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS ONE IN
ELEVEN GUN RELATED HOMICIDES ARE
DUE TO POLICE ACTIVITY SB TWO
THIRTY WILL JUSTIFY THESE ACTS
IF IT GETS PAST.
THAT IS WHY I OPPOSE SB TWO
THIRTY AND WE NEED TO HOLD A LAW
ENFORCEMENT ACCOUNTABLE.
JUST BECAUSE YOU ARE A POLICE
OFFICER AND HAVE.
A LAW ENFORCEMENT BADGES NOT
MAKE YOU ABOVE THE LAW THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
HELLO MY NAME IS ERIN BRATTON
I'M ASSEMBLY NO COUNTY RESIDENT
A PROUD PEPPERED ON SCHOOL LAW
GRADUATE.
I'M HERE TO SAY THAT I STRONGLY
OPPOSES BILL ANY AB THREE NINETY
TWO PASSED -- IT DOES NOT DO
ENOUGH -- WITH JUST THE
ESCALATION WE MUST CHANGE THE
LEGAL STANDARD TO PROTECT THE
LIVES OF PEOPLE IN MY COUNTY
LIKE OF THE YOUNGER YARBER
NATHANIEL PICKET LE WANNA
PHILLIPS I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS MIL
EXCEPT THE END WITH THE YOUTH
JUSTICE COALITION IN SOLIDARITY
WITH ALL THE FAMILIES HERE.
WANTED TO LIFT UP THE FAMILY OF
JONATHAN QUICK OF US HE WAS
KILLED BY SHARES IN LYNWOOD
CALIFORNIA.
OPPOSES BILL LOOKING FORWARD TO
SEEING THE AMENDMENTS THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS JAN FOURTH I AM A
FOUNDING PARTNER OF MEDINA OR
TWINE L. P. AND WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS BAMBI CENTER THOUGH
I'M THE PRESIDENT OF THE CEO OF
THE TRANSLATE TO NOW COALITION A
NATIONAL ADVOCACY ORGANIZATION
THAT SUPPORTS.
THE LIVELIHOOD OF TRANCE
INTERNET CONFIRMING PEOPLE
ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
I STRUGGLING -- OPPOSED HIS BILL --
AS WE KNOW IT TURNS PEOPLE
CONTINUE TO BE CRIMINALIZED
SIMPLY FOR WHO WE ARE AND IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE CONTINUE TO
GIVE DIGNITY TO PEOPLE IN
GENERAL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS MISS A PULLEY THAT I
AM ALSO AT THE TRANSFER FEE NOW
COALITION AND WE STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS RICHARD PEREZ.
ON THE GRANDFATHER OF PT PARADE
IS HE WAS MY ONLY GRANDSON.
AND I OPPOSES BILL A ONE THING I
DON'T UNDERSTAND IS QUIET THIS
CALL KNOWING.
THAT MY GRANDSON DIDN'T HAVE A
KNIFE A GUN UP PENCIL OR
ANYTHING WHY DID HE KILL ON JEAN.
STILL GETTING EIGHTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS PLUS [inaudible]
HOLIDAYS WHATEVER.
SB LIVE IN HIS LIFE.
THANK YOU.
I OPPOSE THE BILL [inaudible]
RIGHT YEAH.
ALL RIGHT -- WE WILL NOW BRING
THIS BACK -- TO COMMITTEE
DISCUSSION AND I REALIZE THAT --
IN OUR DESCRIPTION THAT WE YOU
KNOW I SHOULD USE REGULAR
LANGUAGE I'M NOT A LAWYER SO I
REALIZE WHEN WE NOT THAT THE
WORD CONTINGENT REQUIRES LEGAL
BACKGROUND UNDERSTAND BUT EVEN I
DON'T ALWAYS.
KNOW WHEN I USE THE WORD
CONTINUE WHAT EXACTLY THAT MEANS
SO.
ALLOW ME TO REPEAT ONCE AGAIN --
RATHER TO CLARIFY -- WHAT THE
COMMITTEE HAS PROPOSED AND WHAT
THE AUTHORS AGREED?
THAT.
SB TWO THIRTY IF THE COMMITTEE
ADOPTS IT MOVING FORWARD.
WOULD NOT CONTAIN.
THE LANGUAGE THAT WOULD PUT INTO
LAW.
THE USE OF FORCE STANDARDS AS IT
IS CURRENTLY IN HI UTILIZED IN
CALIFORNIA NOW SO THE BILL WOULD
NOT -- MAKE THAT PART LAW AND
LEAVES OPEN THE POSSIBILITY FOR
REVISIONS TO THE USE OF FORCE
[inaudible]
STANDARD -- WHICH AS HAS BEEN
DISCUSSED BY BOTH SIDES -- IS
CURRENTLY BEING -- PROMULGATED
THROUGH OUR IS CURRENTLY IN.
MS WEBBER'S BILL AB -- THREE
NINETY TWO THE THE TWO THIRTY SO
WOULD REMOVE.
ANY LANGUAGE REGARDING USE OF
FORCE WOULD RETAIN THE LANGUAGE
REGARDING TRAINING.
BUT FOR TWO THIRTY TO GO INTO
LAW.
THERE WOULD ALSO HAVE TO BE AB
THIRD NINETY TWO WOULD HAVE TO
GO INTO LAW.
SO IN OTHER WORDS THE TRAINING
WOULD BE DEPENDENT ON A NEW USE
OF FORCE STANDARD.
SO AB SB TWO THIRTY DOES NOT
MOVE IF WE APPROVE IT AS AMENDED
IT DOES NOT.
BECOME LAW UNLESS THERE'S ALSO.
A BILL THREE NINETY TWO THAT
REVISED IS CALIFORNIA'S USE OF
FORCE.
I HOPE THAT I EXPLAINED THAT.
ADEQUATELY -- CERTAINLY OTHER
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MAY SPEAK
ABOUT IT.
I HAD [inaudible]
CONSIDERED.
JUST ASKING THE AUTHOR TO PUT
THE NEW LANGUAGE IN THE NEW BILL
NUMBER TO HELP REMOVE THE
CONFUSION THAT OBVIOUSLY IS
STILL AVAILABLE TO THE AUTHOR --
BECAUSE WE DO NOT INTEND TO
CREATE CONFUSION THROUGH THE
THROUGH THE AMENDMENTS.
OF WHAT WE ARE WILL WHAT AT
LEAST -- I THINK I CAN SPEAK FOR
THE AUTHOR BUT AT LEAST WHAT WE
ARE TRYING TO DO IS.
CREATE A THE OPPORTUNITY.
FOR THE DIFFERENT SIDES TO COME
TOGETHER AGAIN AND HAVE A
DISCUSSION AROUND.
THE CHANGES.
TO THEIR USE OF FOR STANDARD IN
CALIFORNIA -- BECAUSE I THINK WE
CLEARLY.
HAVE AS IT'S BEEN TALKED ABOUT
MANY MANY MANY.
PEOPLE UP AND DOWN THE STATE AN
EXPERT TO FEEL THAT CALIFORNIA'S
USE OF STAND USE OF FORCE
STANDARD SHOULD BE REVISED.
AND SO THE WAY THIS BILL AS
AMENDED AT LEAST CREATES THAT
OPPORTUNITY FOR THAT
CONVERSATION TO CONTINUE AND TO
SEE IF.
I MISSED WEBER SPELL CAN MOVE
FORWARD -- AND I'LL LEAVE MY
COMMENTS TO THAT FOR THE MOMENT
AND LET ME SEE -- COMMENTS AND
QUESTIONS BY COMMITTEE MEMBERS
SENATOR MORE LACK.
THANK YOU MANAGER THANK YOU
SENATOR COVER EURO -- IN IN JULY
OF TWENTY ELEVEN WE HAD AN
INCIDENT ORANGE COUNTY.
WE'RE A HOMELESS INDIVIDUAL --
WAS ENCOUNTERED BY THE FORTUNE
POLICE DEPARTMENT.
AND THEY NOT NOT UNDERSTANDING
THAT HE WAS MENTALLY ILL
SCHIZOPHRENIC DAY.
DECIDED THAT PERHAPS THEY WOULD
TEACH HIM A LESSON.
AND SO THEY PUMMELED HIM.
AND HE WAS -- YELLING FOR HIS
DAD.
DAD WAS A RETIRED POLICE OFFICER
[inaudible]
AND WAS CAUGHT ON VIDEO.
YOUR TRAIN STATION.
FOR TEN SO THOSE POLICE OFFICERS --
HAD TO GO ON TRIAL FOR MURDER.
AND OUR OUR OUR DISTRICT
ATTORNEY ACTUALLY TRIED THE CASE
HIMSELF BUT THE THE JURY RULED
THAT HE WAS INNOCENT THEY WERE
INNOCENT.
THEY WERE NOT.
THEY WERE NOT CONVICTED OF OF
HAVING THE TAKING KELLY THOMAS
BUT KELLY THOMAS'S CERTAINLY
CHANGED THE LANDSCAPE OF ORANGE
COUNTY.
AND SO I APPRECIATE THE FACT
THAT YOU'RE TRYING TO DO
SOMETHING.
THAT -- SEMI WOMAN WEBER TRYING
TO DO SOMETHING -- SO I JUST --
WANTED TO AFFIRM THAT WE'VE GOT
TO START LOOKING AT HOWARD.
HOWARD DEALING.
WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT IN THE
PRIVATE SECTOR I APPRECIATE ALL
THE HARD WORK.
THANK YOU MANAGER.
CENTER BRADFORD -- CENTER
MITCHELL POLICIES YOUR LIFE HAS
BEEN ON THE WHOLE TIME YEAH I
JUST HAVE NO YEAH.
BUT IT'D BEEN ON EVEN WHEN I
ASKED PREVIOUSLY AND YEAH.
I APPRECIATE THAT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MADAM CHAIR -- LET ME START
BY SAYING THAT WE FROM AT LEAST
FROM MY PERSPECTIVE REMEMBER.
BEING IN THIS COMMITTEE A YEAR
AGO -- WE'VE WE'VE COME A LONG
WAY.
IN THE DISCUSSION TO HEAR -- HE
REPRESENTATIVE -- FROM LAW
ENFORCEMENT -- A KNOWLEDGE.
THAT THAT WE HAVE A SYSTEMIC
PROBLEM WAS.
SIGNIFICANT.
AND I HEARD YOU AND I APPRECIATE
THAT.
ON THOSE THEIR LEADERSHIP THAT
WAS REPRESENTED HERE TODAY.
I AM A CO AUTHOR OF AB.
THREE NINETY TWO BOB I
APPRECIATE -- THE WORK THAT HAS
BEEN PUT INTO THIS BILL.
BUT MISS CABALLERO YOU HAVE A
PUBLIC RELATIONS PROBLEM.
AND THE PUBLIC RELATIONS PROBLEM
IS WE WHO WORK IN THIS FEAR
EVERY DAY UNDERSTAND THE RHYTHM
AND THE PACE IN THIS IS THE
DEADLINE HEARING.
AND WE APPRECIATE YOU WERE
PROBABLY NEGOTIATED INTO LATE
LAST NIGHT.
ON AMENDMENTS BUT THERE IS A
HOPE FORGET NUYS THE EFFORT
AROUND THIS ISSUE THE POLICE
ACCOUNTABILITY AND CLEARLY WE
DIDN'T FACTOR THAT IN. TO GIVE
PEOPLE THE RESPECT THEY ARE DUE
TO SEE LANGUAGE IN PRINT TO
UNDERSTAND THE DRASTIC.
CHANGE -- THAT YOU ARE PUTTING
FORWARD IN THIS BILL AND SO WE
HEARD SOME PEOPLE SAY WE OPPOSE
THE BILL AS IMPRINT.
WHICH IS THE APRIL ELEVENTH
VERSION OF THE B. L. -- WE WERE
GIVEN.
AMENDMENTS TODAY THAT WILL
DRASTICALLY CHANGE THE CONTENT
OF THE BILL AND SO YOUR PUBLIC
RELATIONS PROBLEM IS THAT PEOPLE
WEREN'T AFFORDED THE OPPORTUNITY
OTHER THAN THOSE WHO CLEARLY
WERE INVOLVED IN NEGOTIATING THE
BILL. TO SEE LANGUAGE IMPRINT.
YOU KNOW QUITE FRANKLY WE HAVE A
SEVENTY TWO HOUR RULE THAT THAT
WE ARE HELD ACCOUNTABLE TO
BEFORE WE CAN VOTE ON BILLS ON
THE FLOOR.
THAT BILLS ARE IN PRINT AND SO
WE CAN SEE IT READ AND DIGEST IT
AND SO THAT'S THE PUBLIC
RELATIONS PROBLEM WE HAVE SPENT
OVER AN HOUR HEARING TESTIMONY --
HEARTFELT TESTIMONY THE PEOPLE
PREPARED AND TRAVELED APPEAR.
WHO WOULD KNOWLEDGE THE FACT
THAT THEY EXPERIENCED TRAUMA
EVERY TIME THEY HAVE TO TELL THE
STORIES AND SAY THE NAME OF
THEIR LOVED ONES AND WE GET IT?
AND I'M NOT SURE THAT THEY ARE
CLEAR ABOUTTHE CHANGES THAT
HAVE BEEN MADE. FOR NO FAULT OF-THEIR OWN SO WE HAVE A PROBLEM --
MADAM CHAIR I DON'T KNOW IF
WE'RE IN A POSITION -- TO AND
WHEN I SAY MARK UP YOU KNOW I'M
OLD SCHOOL BECAUSE I'VE BEEN
AROUND A LONG TIME.
BACK I AND I WAS STAFF HERE
BEFORE WE HAD COMPUTERS A WE DID
MOCK UP WE WOULD MOP UP.
A. B. L..
YOU KNOW.
EVEN NORMAL SCHOOL IN AND STAFF.
FORMER STAFF I TOO AM TRYING TO
LOOK AT BLAKE WAS AS I TELL SIZE
IS NO LONGER ITALICIZED.
SO I DON'T KNOW WHAT WE CAN DO.
TO MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE CAN SEE.
AND DIGESTED UNDERSTAND THE BILL
THAT'S TRULY BEFORE US TODAY THE
WE'RE GOING TO TAKE ACTION ON I
DON'T KNOW IF IT'S A MATTER OF
WE HOLD THE VOTE UNTIL THE END
OF COMMITTEE.
THEREBY ALLOWING PEOPLE TIME AND
PEOPLE TO TALK AND PEOPLE TO
DIGEST.
AND PEOPLE TO BREAK OUT IN
GROUPS THAT HAVE PEOPLE EXPLAIN
WHAT'S IN THE BILL I DON'T KNOW
HOW WE DO IT.
THOSE ARE ALL SUGGESTIONS WE
HAVE A PUBLIC RELATIONS PROBLEM
THIS COPY HERE IN TERMS OF
HUNDREDS OF PEOPLE NOT
UNDERSTANDING.
THE TRUE BILL THAT'S BEFORE US
TODAY LET ME SAY THAT.
LET ME SAY THAT ON TO THE
OPPOSITION TO THE CHAIR.
THAT I DISAGREE ON ONE POINT.
WHEN PEOPLE SAY?
NO TO TRAINING I DISAGREE.
WE HAVE TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO
CREATE A CULTURE SHIFT IN LAW
ENFORCEMENT IN THE STATE IN THIS
COUNTRY.
AND SO WHY SUPPORT
ACCOUNTABILITY I SAID I'M A CO
AUTHOR BABY.
THREE NINETY TWO WE ALSO HAVE TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE CREATE
OPPORTUNITIES. FOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO CHANGE.
THE AMENDED LANGUAGE AND I'VE
HAD THE PRIVILEGE OF THING.
NOT ONLY TALKS ABOUT.
DE ESCALATION STRATEGIES.
BUT SOME IMPORTANT WORDS THAT WE
ARE USING QUITE LIBERALLY
THROUGHOUT THIS LEGISLATIVE
SESSION.
AROUND IMPLICIT AND EXPLICIT BY.
IT'S CLEAR TO ME THAT'S
NECESSARY BECAUSE WE DO SEE A
DIFFERENCE IN THE TREATMENT OF
SORT OF CERTAIN.
RESIDENTS OF THE STATE
[inaudible]
BASEBALL COMPLEXION.
SO IMPLICIT BIAS TRAINING I
BELIEVE IS FUNDAMENTAL AND
IMPORTANT.
AND I WILL NEVER NOT SUPPORT
TRAINING [inaudible]
THOSE WHO.
BY COLOR OF AUTHORITY HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PROTECT
[inaudible]
ANSWER.
SB THIRTY THREE NINETY TWO
DOESN'T HAVE A TRAINING
COMPONENT.
IT HAS THE ACCOUNTABILITY PLEASE
AS IT IS CURRENTLY IN PRINT.
AND SOLD TO LOOK AT THESE TWO
BILLS TOGETHER.
IS A POWERFUL POWERFUL
COMBINATION FROM MY PERSPECTIVE.
THREE NINETY TWO EXCUSE ME SB.
TWO THIRTY BASED ON THE LANGUAGE
THAT I'M READING HERE.
IN A MINUTE LANGUAGE SAYS.
SECTION SIX AND I WILL READ.
THE PROVISIONS OF THIS BILL
SHALL NOT BECOME LAW ABSENT THE
SIGNING OF AB.
THREE NINETY TWO THE WEATHER IS
CONTINGENT CALL JOINT WHATEVER.
THE PROVISIONS OF THIS BILL
SHALL NOT BECOME LAW.
ABSENT THE SIGNING OF AB. THREE
NINETY TWO ONE COULD ASK IF THE
PROPONENTS NOW THIS BE TWO
THIRTY ARE NOW GOING TO BECOME
PROPONENTS OF AB.
THREE NINETY TWO I DON'T KNOW
I'LL ASK THEM THAT UESTION WHEN
AB THREE NINETY TWO COMES BEFORE
US IN THIS COMMITTEE IT'S NOT
HERE TODAY.
BUT I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT
WE UNDERSTAND WHAT'S CURRENTLY
IN FRONT OF US.
AND IT IS NOT WHAT YOU READ IN
THE APRIL ELEVENTH VERSION OF
THE BILL.
IT'S STRIKINGLY DIFFERENT.
I SEE THE CHAIR HAVING THE SIDE
BAR WITH THAT OUT -- I THINK
IT'S FAIR THAT THAT THE
OPPOSITION GIVEN THE A MOTION OF
THIS BILL.
GIVEN THE FACT THAT THIS IS A
PUBLIC POLICY DISCUSSION WE'VE
NOW BEEN ENGAGED IN.
WELL OVER A YEAR GIVEN THE
AMOUNT OF COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZING THAT'S TAKEN PLACE WE
HAVE TO RECOGNIZE THAT THIS IS A
THIS IS NOT.
OUR AVERAGE BILL WHERE.
HEY THAT THE KIDS.
AND US NEGOTIATE COME UP WITH
LANGUAGE AND WE SPEAK KIND OF AN
ABBREVIATED TERMINOLOGY THAT'S
NOT THE CASE WITH THIS ISSUE
IT'S TOO PERSONAL IS TO DATE.
AND SO IF MINIMALLY MADAM CHAIR.
YEAH COPIES OF THE MEMBERS CAN
BE DISTRIBUTED AND PEOPLE BE
GIVEN TIME TO READ AND DIGEST
AND THEN THE VOTE TAKEN LATER
THAT WOULD BE MY REQUEST ABSENT
THAT.
I'M NOT GONNA BE ABLE TO TAKE
ACTION ON THE BILL.
MISTER BRADFORD.
THANK YOU AND FIRST LET ME THANK
ALL THE WITNESSES WHO'VE COME
BEFORE IS TO DATE.
TO LEND THEIR VOICES ON WHAT IS
A VERY EMOTIONAL AND PERSONAL
ISSUE -- AS IT RELATES.
TO LAW ENFORCEMENT IN THIS
COUNTRY AND I WON'T HAVE NOTHING
BUT THE UTMOST RESPECT FOR THE
AUTHOR.
AND I THANK YOU FOR WORKING WITH
EACH YEAR IN THIS COMMITTEE.
TO AMEND THE BILL AND BRING IT
FORTH THAT.
IT MIGHT BE SOMETHING THAT.
I CAN VOTE.
FOR BUT THE REAL ISSUE THAT.
WE SHOULD TAKE AWAY FROM HERE
TODAY.
IS NOT THE NEED OF TRAINING PER
SE.
IT'S THE CHANGING OF ONE'S HEART
[inaudible]
EMPIRE'S.
IF WE HAD NOT TAKING ANYTHING
AWAY FROM HERE TODAY.
WE SHOULD WALK AWAY WITH
UNDERSTANDING.
OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT IS THE
BEDROCK.
OF WHAT THIS COUNTRY IS AND IT'S
THE BEDROCK IS RACISM.
THE MAJORITY OF FOLKS WHO'VE
COME HERE BEFORE US TODAY ARE
PEOPLE OF COLOR.
IF IT WAS ABOUT TRAINING YOU SEE
THE SAME NUMBER A WHITE FAMILIES
HERE TODAY TALKING ABOUT THEIR
LOVED ONES BEING LOS BUT THEY'RE
NOT HERE WE APPRECIATE THE ONE
TO COME AND SUPPORT.
BUT THE MAJORITY OF PEOPLE WOULD
COME BEFORE THIS COMMITTEE AND
CONTINUE TO COME AND SPEAK OUT.
AGAINST LAW ENFORCEMENT IN THIS
COUNTRY ARE BLACK AND BROWN
PEOPLE.
THE ORIGIN OF THE USE OF DEADLY
FORCE WAS IMPLEMENTED IN.
EIGHTEEN SEVENTY TWO IT WAS A
DIRECT RESPONSE TO THE MANTA
PATIENT PROCLAMATION.
LAW ENFORCEMENT NEEDED A NOTHER
TOOL AFTER BLACK FOLKS WERE
FREED IN THIS COUNTRY TO
SUPPRESS AND CONTROL THERE WAS
NO NEED FOR USE OF DEADLY FORCE
PART.
TWO THE ENDING OF SLAVERY SO WE
SHOULD UNDERSTAND THE ORIGIN AND
THE BEDROCK ALL WHITE THE USE OF
DEADLY FORCE WAS EVER
IMPLEMENTED IN THE STATE AND IN
THIS NATION IT WAS NOT ABOUT
PUBLIC SAFETY.
AND UNTIL WE START EDUCATING
PEOPLE ON WHO THIS COUNTRY IS.
AND WHAT WE WERE FOUND IN ON
TELL THE TRUTH THE REAL TRUTH
ABOUT RACISM AND IMPLICIT BIAS
IS STILL EXISTS TODAY.
I DON'T FAULT LAW ENFORCEMENT
BECAUSE IT'S INGRAINED IN OUR
NATION.
BUT AT THE SAME TIME BASED ON
THE F. B. I. REPORT THE HIGHEST.
NUMBER OF RECRUITMENT AND
EMPLOYMENT IN THIS COUNTRY RIGHT
NOW IN THE LAST FIVE YEARS A
WHITE SUPREMACIST.
ARE IN LAW ENFORCEMENT.
IT'S IN LAW ENFORCEMENT THAT'S
REALITY THAT'S FBI REPORT THAT
PROVIDES THAT DATA.
AND WE NEED TO ACCEPT IT AND
START TALKING ABOUT IT BECAUSE
THAT'S TO CORPS WHERE THE
PROBLEM IS ROW RIGHT NOW.
WE'RE WE'RE DEALING WITH A
RACIST SOCIETY AND WE WANT TO
HIDE BEHIND ALL THESE OTHER.
WALLS ANYTHING ELSE BUT THE DATA.
SPEAKS CLEARLY TO IT AND IF I
COULD QUOTE A GREAT URBAN
PHILOSOPHER.
JZ MEN LIE.
WOMEN LIE BUT NUMBERS DON'T THE
NUMBERS DO NOT LIE THIS IS
STRAIGHT ABOUT RACE.
AND ALL THE TRAINING IN THE
WORLD.
UNLESS YOU CHANGE YOUR HEART IN
YOUR MIND WILL NOT HAVE ANY
EFFECT ON HOW ARE POLICING
HAPPENS IN THIS COUNTRY
[inaudible]
SENATOR WIENER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR.
AND I WANT.
TO GIVE ME ALLERGIES.
OUR FIRST I WANT TO THANK -- ALL
OF THE FAMILIES AND COMMUNITIES
ARE CAME OUT -- IN THE MEMORY OF
OF THEIR LOVED ONES.
I KNOW THAT IT'S HARD AND PEOPLE
TRAVEL TO YOUR A LONG WAY -- TO
TO MAKE THAT -- TESTIMONY AND
THIS IS NOT ALWAYS THE BEST
PROCESS EVERYTHING IS VERY FAST --
AND YOU KNOW THE IDEA OF BOILING
DOWN -- THE DEATH OF A LOVED ONE
TWO YOU KNOW A FEW SECONDS OR A
FEW MINUTES I DON'T KNOW IF I
COULD EVER DO THAT -- SO I JUST
WANT TO SAY THANK YOU TO
EVERYONE WHO DID THAT.
ON MY SUPPORT AB THREE NINETY
TWO AND I LOOK FORWARD.
TO KNOCK ON WOOD -- VOTING FOR
IT WHEN IT COMES TO THIS
COMMITTEE JUST LIKE I VOTED FOR
A. B. -- NINE THIRTY ONE LAST
YEAR -- I THINK THAT IS THE
RIGHT.
DIRECTION.
AND I WANNA THANK -- THE CHAIR
CENTER SKINNER AND THE COMMITTEE
STAFF.
AND ALL THE STAKEHOLDERS WHO
WERE INVOLVED FOR WORKING -- TO
HARMONIZE THESE BILLS AND JUST
TO BE CRYSTAL CLEAR AFTER THESE
AMENDMENTS WHAT WE WILL HAVE IS
THE USE OF FORCE STANDARD.
STANDARD FOR USE OF DEADLY FORCE
WILL BE AN EIGHTY THREE NINETY
TWO AND THEN THE TRAINING
REQUIREMENTS WILL BE AN SP TWO
THIRTY PERIOD.
ALL OF THE USE OF FORCE LANGUAGE
IS BEING STRIPPED OUT OF SB
THREE THIRTY SO THOSE ARE THE
TWO APPROACHES AND THEY ARE
COMPLEMENTARY TO ONE ANOTHER
SETTING THE USE OF FORCE STANNIS
MAYBE.
THREE NINETY TWO AND THEN
REQUIRING TRAINING -- AND THE
OUR PROCESS IS IN PERFECT
SOMETIMES -- IN TERMS OF
LANGUAGE BEING TAKEN IN
COMMITTEE AND SO IT HASN'T BEEN --
IMPRINT BEFORE -- BUT THAT'S
WHAT THIS WILL DO.
NOW AND AGAIN I DO LOOK FORWARD
TO AB THREE NINETY TWO ARE
COMING TO THIS COMMITTEE AND
VOTING FOR AND I WANT TO THANK
THE CHAIR FOR WORKING -- WITH
THE AND THANK THE AUTHOR OF FOR
WORKING AND EVERYONE WORKING
TOGETHER -- TO REMOVE THE USE OF
FORCE LANGUAGE FROM SB TWO
THIRTY AND TO MAKE INTO
TRAINING BILL -- AND I DO AGREE
WITH US CENTER MITCHELL TRAINING
IS IMPORTANT IT'S NOT THE ONLY
THING WE NEED TRAINING BY ITSELF
DOES NOT SOLVE THE PROBLEM.
OF THE TRAINING IS A PIECE OF
THE PUZZLE.
IN SOLVING.
THE PROBLEM THANK YOU.
THE OTHER COMICS OKAY
[inaudible]
I'M.
I APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS BY.
MY COLLEAGUES AND HOPE NO ONE'S
DEPARTING YET -- BECAUSE WE
OBVIOUSLY HAVE A COUPLE OF
THINGS -- BEFORE US -- THE FIRST
[inaudible] FIVE AS I EXPLAINED
IN THE OPENING AND PERHAPS NOT --
WITH ENOUGH CLARITY.
WHAT WE ARE DOING TODAY OR WHAT
WE ARE ENTERTAINING TO DO TODAY
[inaudible]
IS.
I APPRECIATE CAN BE.
ON DIFFICULT -- TO TO EXCEPT
BECAUSE MANY FOLKS AND
LEGITIMATELY HAVE BEEN
ORGANIZING AGAINST THE BILL AS
IT IS IN PRINT.
BECAUSE OF THE FEELINGS THAT.
IN FACT BY JUST PUTTING INTO LAW.
THE WHAT MANY PEOPLE FEEL IS A
VERY ANTIQUATED IN ADEQUATE AND
I'M JUST USE OF FORCE STANDARD.
THAT IF SB TWO THIRTY WERE TO
PROCEED AS IT WAS WRITTEN THAT
IT WOULD JUST BE ALLOWING THE
POLICE TO CONTINUE TO DO
BUSINESS AS USUAL.
AND I WHAT I'D LIKE TO CONVEY IS
I THINK YOU'VE HEARD FROM AT
LEAST THE MAJORITY OF THE
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE IS
THAT THAT IS NOT WHAT THEY WANT
TO DO SO IN OTHER WORDS THIS
SENATE PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE
THE MAJORITY OF ITS MEMBERS.
ARE NOT WILLING.
TO PUT INTO LAW.
THE USE OF FORCE STANDARD AS IT
EXISTS TODAY -- BUT WE DO NOT
HAVE BEFORE US A BILL THAT
PROPOSES THE REVISED MEANING
TODAY IN THIS COMMITTEE.
THE BILL THAT PROPOSES A REVISED
USE OF FORCE IS -- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WEBER SPELL SO IN WORKING
WITH THE AUTHORS.
WHAT THIS COMMITTEE THOUGHT WAS
REASONABLE WAS?
TO LINK THE BILLS.
SO THAT.
THIS BILL WOULD ONLY BECOME LAW.
IF THERE IS A REVISED USE OF
FORCE MEANING AB.
THREE NINETY TWO AND THE REASON
THAT I IS THE COMMITTEE CHAIR.
WAS WILLING TO HAVE A PORTION OF
SB.
TWO THIRTY MOVE FORWARD IS
BECAUSE IF WE DO RE VICE OUR USE
OF FORCE STANDARD.
THEN WE WILL REQUIRE NEW
TRAINING BECAUSE RIGHT NOW.
THE ONLY TRAINING THAT OUR STATE
WIDE AGENCY OFFERS IS ON THE
EXISTING STANDARD.
AND SO IF WE ARE SUCCESSFUL IN
REVISING THE STANDARD.
AND MAKING IT MORE FAIR OR
HOWEVER ANYONE WANTS TO
CHARACTERIZE.
THE REVISION.
THEN WE WOULD NEED NEW TRAINING
BECAUSE IF WE DON'T GET NEW
TRAINING THEN OFFICERS WOULD
STILL BE OPERATING UNDER THE OLD
ONE SO THAT'S WHY AT LEAST AS
CHAIR I WAS WILLING. TO HAVE THE
TRAINING PORTION CONTINUE BUT
ONLY IF IT IS BASED ON A REVISED
USE OF FORCE STANDARD.
SO -- AND I WANTED TO SPEAK TO
ALSO.
THE THE ISSUE AROUND -- AROUND
THE BIAS.
AND CITING FROM A STUDY THAT I
WAS NOT FAMILIAR WITH UNTIL JUST
RECENTLY [inaudible]
BUT FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO ARE --
INTERESTED IN THIS STUDIES
DATING BACK TO AT LEAST TWO
THOUSAND AND ONE FOUND THAT THE
SAME AS REGULAR RESIDENTS.
POLICE OFFICERS CIVILIANS RESIN.
ANYONE EVERYONE HERE IN OUR
CULTURE ARE CONSISTENTLY MORE
LIKELY TO ASSOCIATE BLACK FACES
WITH CRIMINALITY.
ENTER MISIDENTIFIED COMMON
OBJECTS AS WEAPONS.
AFTER BEING SHOWN PHOTOS OF
BLACK FACES.
SO IN OTHER WORDS.
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS OR ANY
OF US.
THE STUDY SHOW.
REACT AFTER WE SEE.
PICTURES OF BLACK FACES.
WE REACT BOTH AN ASSOCIATE
CRIMINALITY.
AND ASSUME THAT OBJECTS THAT ARE
NOT WEAPONS OUR WEAPONS.
SO THIS AND THIS IS WHAT WE
REFER TO AS IMPLICIT BIAS.
WHICH FEW NONE OF US ARE FREE OF
AND SO IN OUR WORK. TO CREATE A
MORE JUST.
LAWS AND MORE JUST.
APPLICATION OF THEM WE HAVE TO
HAVE THE TRAINING.
BOTH ON THE IMPLICIT BIAS IN ON
WHATEVER NEW REVISED USE OF
FORCE STANDARD THAT WE HOPEFULLY
THIS YEAR WILL BE ABLE TO
SUCCESSFULLY ADOPT [inaudible]
I'M [inaudible]
NOW.
I WOULD BE WILLING TO ENTERTAIN.
I WOULD BE WILLING TO ENTERTAIN
HAVING THE VOTE.
TAKEN AFTER CAUCUS.
I DO NOT WANT TO HAVE IT TAKEN
AT THE END OF THE HEARING
BECAUSE I DON'T KNOW WHEN THE
HEARING WILL END.
TODAY GIVEN THAT WE HAVE SO MANY
MORE BILL STILL TO ENTERTAIN.
BUT I EXPECT THE CAUCUS TO GO
FOR AT LEAST AN HOUR AND A HALF.
AND THAT WAY MANY OF THE FOLKS
THAT HAVE COME TODAY WHETHER.
IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSE COULD THEN
SEE THE MARK UP AND IN ADDITION.
TO THE PRINTED OUT HERE IN THE
THE BILL PLEASE.
IN ADDITION TO YES THANK YOU IN
ADDITION TO THIS VERSION.
WE WILL HAVE.
THESE WHICH ARE AS YOU FEAR ALL
OVER THE PLACE [inaudible]
WE HAVE.
USE THE PEN AND STRUCTURE ROOF
THE PORTIONS THAT ARE BEING
DELETED IF THE COMMITTEE ACCEPTS
THE AMENDMENTS.
WHICH ARE IT'S CAN BE MUCH
EASIER -- TO READ AND TO SEE.
SO W WILL.
DO THAT WITH AS MANY OF THESE AS
POSSIBLE AND OF COURSE YOU CAN
ASSIST IF YOU -- USE THIS TO
ALSO DO THAT SO THAT.
AGAIN THOSE FOLKS HERE EITHER IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION WILL KNOW
WHAT IS GOING TO BE BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE AT LEAST ONE OF THE
MOTIONS THERE MAY BE ANOTHER
MOTION.
THAT IS TO ACCEPT THE BILL AS
WRITTEN I HAVE NO CONTROL OVER
THAT BUT AT LEAST THE
COMMITTEE'S RECOMMENDATION WOULD
BE. FOR THE BILL TO BE ACCEPTED
IN THE AMENDED VERSION THAT IS --
STRUCK THROUGH HERE AND I WILL
MAKE SURE THAT THE PUBLIC SAFETY
STAFF -- MARK UP ENOUGH OF THE
SO AT LEAST LOTS OF FOLKS CAN
SEE THEM.
SO.
XEROX IT HOWEVER ALL RIGHT NOW.
LET ME SEE IF THERE'S ANY OTHER
COMMENTS BY MY COLLEAGUES.
BUT ADDITIONALLY WHETHER --
OBVIOUSLY.
THE AUTHOR MAY HAVE AND IS
ENTITLED -- TO RESPOND -- BUT I
ALSO JUST WANT TO SAY THAT --
EVEN IF WE HAD PUT THE BILL IN
PRINT.
AS A AND AGREED TO AMENDMENTS
EARLIER I THINK THAT MANY OF YOU
WOULD HAVE WANTED TO BE HEARING
YOU MAY OPPOSED OR NOT OPPOSED.
I DO GREATLY APPRECIATE HOW
TRAUMATIC IT IS TO TALK ABOUT.
THE LOSS OF YOUR LOVED ONES.
AGAIN AND TO DO IT IN PUBLIC AND
IT'S INCREDIBLY COURAGEOUS AND
BRAVE BUT I ALSO WANT TO RESPECT
THAT.
IT IS AS DIFFICULT AS IT IS I
THANK ALL OF YOU WANT US TO BEAR
PUBLIC WITNESS TO IT.
AND SO I THINK THAT EVEN IF WE
HAD.
THE BILL -- AVAILABLE FOR ALL OF
YOU TO SEE YOU WOULD HAVE WANTED
TO COME AND SPEAK TO US ANYWAY
BECAUSE IT THIS CONVERSATION IS
NECESSARY FOR US TO HAVE.
AS WE CONTINUE TO GRAPPLE WITH
WHAT IS THE APPROPRIATE REVISION
TO OUR USE OF FORCE STANDARDS
SOMEONE OF HONOR YOUR COMING
HERE AND YOU'RE SPEAKING.
AND I AM THE DIFFICULTY OF IT
AND YET I THINK ALSO THAT.
AS MUCH AS IT'S DIFFICULT THAT
YOU WANT US TO BE OUR THAT
WITNESS AND I HONOR THAT
[inaudible]
SENATOR COPIER.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE OMMITTEE.
I REALLY APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS
THAT AVE BEEN MADE -- BY THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS -- AND AND I
AND I THINK IT'S A REALLY GOOD
SUGGESTION TO GIVE EVERYBODY AN
OPPORTUNITY TO TAKE A LOOK AT
THE AMENDMENTS I SOMEONE AT
THINK EVERYBODY THAT CAME HERE
TODAY -- I KNOW THAT -- IT HAS
BEEN DIFFICULT TO COME.
AND TO CONTINUE TO TESTIFYING TO
CONTINUE.
TO TALK ABOUT THINGS THAT ARE
VERY VERY DIFFICULT -- AND IT'S
EQUALLY AS DIFFICULT FOR ME TO
SIT HERE AND TO I EXTEND TO YOU
MY AT MOST CONDOLENCES FOR THE
LOSS OF LIFE.
AND OF YOUR LOVED ONES AND I
UNDERSTAND COMPLETELY YEAR --
YOUR ENERGY AND YOUR COMMITMENT
TO MAKING CHANGE AND I WANT YOU
TO KNOW THAT I HONOR THAT IN
THAT I RESPECTED GREATLY.
AND THAT THAT'S THE REASON I'M
HERE IS BECAUSE WE WANT TO BE
ABLE TO MAKE SOME CHANGE AND IT
HAS TO BE SUBSTANTIVE CHANGE --
THE BILL AS IT IS AND IT'S
DIFFICULT TO TALK ABOUT BECAUSE
WE END UP TALKING ABOUT IT IN
TERMS OF THE HOW WE DEAL WITH
BILLS HERE IN SACRAMENTO BUT THE
BOTTOM LINE.
IS THE PART THAT PERTAINS TO AB
THREE NINETY TWO HAS BEEN TAKEN
OUT.
OF MY BILL.
AND SO THE ONLY PART THAT TALKS
ABOUT THE USE OF FORCE -- YET
IT'S STANDARD IS IN DOCTOR
SHIRLEY WEBER SPELL.
AND THAT WAS DONE AS A WAY.
AND MY BILL IS LINKED WITH HERS
SO OF HERS DOESN'T GET THROUGH
THEN IT IT ALL DISAPPEARS I
DON'T THINK ANY OF US WANT IT
ALL TO DISAPPEAR I THINK WE WANT
TO GET SOME RESOLUTION.
AND SO WHAT THIS DOES IS IT
KEEPS EVERYBODY AT THE TABLE.
NEGOTIATING IN GOOD FAITH TRYING
TO WORK TOWARDS A SOLUTION AND
THAT'S THAT THAT WAS MY
COMMITMENT TO THE CHAIR AND THAT
WAS REALLY -- WHY WE DECIDED TO
MAKE THE AMENDS AT THIS POINT --
SO THAT WE COULD -- CONTINUE THE
DISCUSSIONS CONTINUE WORKING ON
I'M SO I'M COMMITTED TO THAT --
I KNOW THAT ALL OF MY SPONSORS
ARE COMMITTED TO DOING THAT --
AND WE'VE HAD SOME GOOD
CONVERSATIONS WITH THAT DOCTOR
WEBER AND IT IT'S GOING THAT
WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE TO WORK
ON IT SO -- I WANT TO THANK
EVERYBODY BECAUSE THIS THIS IS
PART OF THE THIS IS PART OF A
DEMOCRACY IS HAVING THESE
DISCUSSIONS IN THESE AND WORKING
THROUGH THIS AND I REALLY --
HONOR AND RESPECT -- BUT WHAT
WHAT DONE SENATOR -- AT BRADFORD
AND SENATOR MITCHELL I HAVE TO
SAY ON THE WHOLE ON THE WHOLE
ISSUE OF THEIR THEY ARE -- GREAT
COLLEAGUES AND I TRUST THEM
IMPLICITLY AND WE'RE GOING TO
GET TO A RESOLUTION ON THIS SO --
WITH THAT I WOULD RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE BUT WILL MOVE
THIS ON AGAIN I'M GOING TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE DOCTOR
WEBER ON ON HER BILL.
AS WELL AND AND AND AND
HOPEFULLY WE CAN COME TO A
RESOLUTION SO WE CAN WE CAN
RESOLVE THIS ISSUE THIS YEAR
[inaudible]
RIGHT SO.
WE ARE -- GOING TO GOING RECESS
NOW.
THE PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE WILL
TAKE RECESS BECAUSE WE HAVE OUR
**** MEETINGS WHEN THE CAUCUS
MEETINGS CONCLUDE WE'LL RETURN.
AND WE WILL THEN -- ENTERTAIN --
WHATEVER MOTIONS -- AND I EXPECT
THERE WILL BE A MOTION.
ON THE AMENDMENTS.
AND THEN THE BILL WITH AS
AMENDED.
OF BUT WE WILL DO THAT WHEN WE
CAN -- COME BACK AND THAT WILL
BE AT ONE THIRTY AND WE WILL BE
IN THIS ROOM OKAY.
THANK YOU ALL
ACTUALLY.
PORTANTINO'S SO SORRY MR NO
JONES AFTER HE'S AFTER OKAY SO
CENTER PORTANTINO AYE TO TO
START UP.
SORRY CENTER JONES YOU ARE
GEORGIANNE WE ARE GOING FILE
ORDERING HE'S BEFORE YOU.
AND ALSO -- WE ARE GOING TO HOLD
OFF ON THE VOTE I'D PROMISED
BEFORE INTO WE HAVE MORE THE
MEMBERS IN THE ROOM.
AND I AM GOING TO ENSURE -- DO
MY BILL DIRECTLY FOLLOWING YOURS
BECAUSE OF LATER AND I WILL NEED
TO LEAVE TO GO TO CHIU DISH FOR
SHORT PERIOD OF TIME SO THE
ORDER WILL BE CENTER PORTANTINO.
MINE AND THEN WHATEVER AUTHORS
IN THE ROOM THAT'S FILE ORDER
OKAY GO AHEAD CENTER PORTANTINO.
THANK YOU ARE MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I REALLY APPRECIATE MORE
IF YOU MORE PEOPLE IN THE ROOM I
REALLY APPRECIATE YOU LETTING ME
GO I HAVE -- AT A TOWN --
WITNESSES WHO HAVE TO CATCH A
FLIGHT AND I WOULD LIKE TO BEGIN
BY TAKING THE AMENDMENTS
PRESENTED BY THE COMMITTEE AND
THANK THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
THEIR CONTINUED WORK WITH MY
OFFICE -- TODAY I AM PRESENTING
SB SIX TWENTY WHICH WOULD
AUTHORIZE SPECIFIED LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES TO FURNISH
LIMITED.
INFORMATION ABOUT A PERSON ON
SUPERVISED RELEASE WITHIN THEIR
JURISDICTION TO NONPROFIT
PROVIDERS OF SERVICES.
THIS BILL WOULD REQUIRE PERSON
ON SUPERVISED RELEASE TO BE
NOTIFIED THAT THEIR INFORMATION
CAN BE RELEASED FOR THE PURPOSE
FOR THAT PURPOSE AND WHEN ALLOW
THOSE PERSONS STOPPED IN TO
HAVING THEIR INFORMATION.
RELEASED SO THEY CAN IF THEY
CHOOSE WHEN SOMEONE IS RELEASED
FROM INCARCERATION THEY ARE
RETURNED TO THEIR CITY OF
RESIDENCE WITHOUT FRANKLY -- THE
GUIDANCE OR NEEDED RESOURCES
OFTEN TIMES TO GET.
HER LIFE BACK ON TRACK IN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY 47% OF COMMUNITY
MEMBERS WHO RETURNED FROM
INCARCERATION REPEAT.
OFFENDER IN A RE INCARCERATION
RE INCARCERATED WITHIN THREE
YEARS.
THIS RESULTS FRANKLY IN A
PREVENTABLE -- SITUATION IF WE
PROVIDE SERVICES AND OPPORTUNITY
TO THOSE INDIVIDUALS I THINK.
THEY'D BE BETTER OFF AND WE'D
ALL BE BETTER OFF SO.
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICIALS HAVE
RELEASED DATA AND THE PERSONNEL
INFORMATION OF EVERY PERSON ON
PAROLE -- WHO SUPERVISED BY
PROBATION HOWEVER THEY CANNOT
CONNECT THESE PREVIOUSLY
INCARCERATED COMMUNITY MEMBERS
TO SERVICE PROVIDERS -- IN
PARTICULAR MY DISTRICT WE HAVE A
ROBUST -- SUPPORT SYSTEM OF
NONPROFITS WHO DESPERATELY WANT
TO HELP AND OFTEN ARE PREVENTED
FROM KNOWING WHO.
IS IN NEED OF THAT HELP SO IT'S
HARD TO BREAK THE CYCLE OF
RECIDIVISM IF WE CAN'T CONNECT
PEOPLE TO THE SERVICES SO BY
HAVING.
CONTACT INFORMATION OF THOSE
RETURNING TO SOCIETY SERVICE
PROVIDERS CAN FOCUS THEIR
EFFORTS AND GRANT FUNDS ON
PREVIOUSLY INCARCERATED
COMMUNITY MEMBERS.
WITH THE HELP OUR JOB
OPPORTUNITIES AND OTHER SUPPORT
SERVICES THAT ARE AVAILABLE THIS
BILL WOULD ALLOW THOSE LEAVING
THE SYSTEM TO HAVE GREATER
ACCESS TO CASE MANAGEMENT
FINANCIAL LITERACY MENTAL HEALTH
SUBSTANCE ABUSE TREATMENT.
AND FRANKLY WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT SERVICES AND WITH ME
TODAY I HAVE PASSED ANY AS CHIEF
OF POLICE JOHN PRESS AND
LIEUTENANT JASON CLAWSON ALSO
FROM THE PAST NEEDED POLICE
DEPARTMENT TO TESTIFY ON BEHALF
OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU CAN PRETTY.
THANK YOU SO WE APPRECIATE THIS
OPPORTUNITY.
SB SIX TWENTY REALLY A GAME
CHANGER WE BELIEVE IT'S ABILITY
TO YOU KNOW JORDAN THE GAP AND
CONNECT PEOPLE -- INTO THE
RESOURCES THAT THEY NEED IN THE
SERVICES THAT WE PROVIDE FOR
THOSE OUT OF INCARCERATION AND
IT IS A A TWELVE YEAR JOURNEY
THAT WE'VE HAD IN PASADENA WITH
A GRASSROOTS EFFORT.
A DURING A RECESSION WHEN WE
WHEN THE BUDGET -- WE'RE BEING
CUT AND REDUCE OF THOSE
ELIMINATION OF THE A COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT PEOPLE WERE OUT OF
INCARCERATION FOR THE LONG FOR
SPENT AND COMMUNITY GROUPS MET
TO PROVIDE RESOURCES IMPOSSIBLE
JOBS.
THAT WENT AWAY IN TWO THOUSAND
NINE OR TEN LEAVING US A WITH
NOTHING SO THE FASHION POLICE
DEPARTMENT IS COMMUNITY MEMBERS.
PUT TOGETHER AS A SAID A
GRASSROOTS EFFORT TO REALLY
BRING IN NON PROFITS TOGETHER
AND GIVE AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
THOSE THAT ARE OUT OF JAILS AND
PRISONS A CHANCE TO PUT THEIR
LIVES BACK IN TRACK.
AND IT WAS TOUGH IN THE EARLY
YEARS THERE WAS NO MONEY --
THERE WAS NOTHING AVAILABLE FOR
US -- OVER TIME WE DID -- BUILT
A REPUTATION LOCALLY AND IN
GETTING THIS DONE NOT JUST FOR
PASADENA BUT THE REGION.
AND WERE ABLE TO GET CAL GRIP
FUNDING OF PROP FORTY SEVEN
FIGHTING CAL BIT FUNDING TO
REALLY HAS PROVIDED THAT MODEL
TO BE PUSHED OUT LITTLE BIT
FURTHER AND BRING IN OTHER TYPE
OF ORGANIZATIONS.
AND RECEIVE THIS MONEY CURRENTLY
WE HAVE A PROP FORTY SEVEN GRANT
LIEUTENANT CLAUSSEN HAS BEEN
OPERATING WITH ONLY POLICE
DEPARTMENT HAS BEEN GRANTED THIS.
THIS GRANT SO IT'S IT'S IT'S AN
OFFERING A REALLY IS BENEFICIAL
FOR US -- AT THE END OF THIS
EFFORT.
THERE ARE STILL GAPS THAT WE
NEED TO IMPROVE -- THIS CAN
CHANGE THE SUBJECT REFER PEOPLE
ARE NOT JUST SOULS COMING OUT OF
PRISON BUT THEIR FAMILIES.
WHEN YOU SIT IN FRONT OF PEOPLE
AS I HAVE AND THEY'RE OUT OF
INCARCERATION AND YOU ASK THEM
WHAT THEY NEED AND THE BEEN IN
JAIL FOR VIOLENT CRIME AT FIRST
IS VERY DIFFICULT? TO MAKE THAT
STEP OVER TO SAY WELL DO YOU
KNOW YOU'RE IN FOR VIOLENT CRIME
WAS IT YOU NEED TO KEEP YOU OUT
SOMETIMES A SIMPLE IS JUST
SERVICES.
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES TO ROOM
FOR THEIR KIDS THINGS TO GIVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO DO BETTER AND SO
WE PROVIDED THEM OVER THE YEARS.
WE'VE HAD SIXTEEN HUNDRED PEOPLE
GO THROUGH OUR PROGRAM.
AND WE KNOW THAT THE STATE
RECIDIVIST I'M RATES IT'S AT
ABOUT 60% JUST ABOVE THAT THE
COUNTY WAS ABOUT.
FORTY SEVEN OF PASADENA IS IT.
RECIDIVISM RATES ABOUT 35% THOSE
THAT GO TO THIS PROGRAM IT SEEMS
TO BE ABOUT 15% AS A WE KNOW IT
MAKES A DIFFERENCE WE KNOW WE
HAVE IMPACT.
WHEN YOU SIT IN A ROOM AND AND
SPEAK TO PEOPLE IT IS A WHO'S
BEEN TO PRISON AND THEY'RE
COMING OUT THEY NEED SERVICES IT
MAKES A DIFFERENCE THE BEST PART
WE HAVE SIGNED IT WITH THIS?
IS THE FACT TAT -- THE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN OUR POLICE
OFFICERS AND PEOPLE COMING OUT
OF PRISONS AND JAILS HAS
IMPROVED WE WANT TO SEE A A
POSITIVE OUTCOME OF THIS IS THE
CONSTANT CONNECTION THAT THEY
HAVE ONE ANOTHER. TO GET TO KNOW
ONE ANOTHER AND I THINK IN THE
LONG RUN THAT'S GOING TO BENEFIT
SOCIETY SO I APPRECIATE THE
EFFORT AND AND YOUR SUPPORT AS
WELL [inaudible]
THANK YOU -- YEAH I WOULD JUST
LIKE TO SAY THAT THE VERY
IMMERSED INTO. FIVE I'M.
SORRY SORRY HOW MANY DAYS LIKE
LAWSON.
I'M A LIEUTENANT WITH PASSED IN
THE POLICE DEPARTMENT OF A BEING
IMMERSED IN THIS PROGRAM FOR THE
PAST ALMOST TEN YEARS NOW --
I'VE DEVELOP RELATIONSHIPS WITH
PEOPLE GETTING OUTOF PRISON I
KNOW THE RESTATEMENT GREET
RESOURCES WE HAVE A FRIENDSHIP
PREPARATION PROGRAM WHICH
ACTUALLY ALLOWS PEOPLE TO GET
TRAINED INTO THE CONSTRUCTION
TRADES.
AND THEY ACTUALLY GET JOBS AND
IT FEELS GOOD THAT SOMEBODY WHO
WILL YELL OUT MY NAME DROPPED ON
THEIR REGULAR CELL AND RUN OVER
TO ME AND GIVE ME A HUG TO SAY
LOOK YOU GUYS CHANGED MY LIFE.
I DON'T HAVE A JOB ANYMORE I
HAVE A CAREER SO THESE ARE THE
THINGS THE BENCHMARKS OF SUCCESS
THAT I SEE EVERY DAY FROM THE
PEOPLE.
AND WE LEAVE.
WE UNDERSTOOD THAT THERE WAS A
GAP BECAUSE ON MY PHONE RIGHT
NOW I HAVE EVERY PAROLE LEE IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA I KNOW
WAS MOM'S NAME.
AND NO WORRIES LIVE IN I HAVE A
CELL PHONE NUMBER BUT BY LAW I
CANNOT CONNECT THOSE RESOURCES
THAT I'M INVOLVED IN TO THESE
PEOPLE WHO ARE MOST IN NEED AND
I BELIEVE I BELIEVE THAT THIS IS
GOING TO BREAK THAT GAP.
AND GET PEOPLE AT THE TO THE
SERVICES THAT THAT TO PROVIDE
THEM TO GET ON WITH YOUR LIFE
AND I COULD NOT RETURN TO
INCARCERATIONS.
THANK YOU ARE THERE OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ALL RIGHT LET'S SEE IF THERE'S
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
OKAY. TO BEGIN WITH A SILLY OF
CALIFORNIA WE APPRECIATE ON THE
AUTHOR IN THE COMMITTEES WORK ON
THIS AND WE ARE REMOVING OUR
OPPOSITION.
GREAT THAT'S BASED ON THE
AMENDMENT.
YES GREAT THANK YOU OKAY.
ALL RIGHT SO WE HAVE A MOTION
AND AS INDICATED BY THE AUTHORED
THERE -- THE BILL WILL BE VOTING
ON WILL BE AMENDED TO MAKE THIS
BE -- AN OFTEN.
AND WITH THAT IF THERE'S NO
OTHER COMMENT I WILL ASK FOR A
CALL I'VE POLICIES TYPICALLY
ASTRONOMICAL THANK YOU.
MOTION IS THE FAST AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS SKINNER.
HI SKINNER AYE MOORLACH.
BRADFORD.
BRADFORD I'VE JACKSON MITCHELL
AYE MITCHELL AYE MORALE.
WIENER.
WIENER HIGH.
RIGHT THE BILL WILL BE ON CALL
NOW YOU MUCH THANK YOU SO --
CENTER RUBIO BEFORE YOU AT WE WE
ARE GOING TO TAKE UP.
BACK TO THE BILL THAT WE HAD --
GONE INTO RECESS [inaudible]
A AND THEN -- WE NEED TO
CONCLUDE.
ROOM TRYING TO DETERMINE WHETHER
WE'RE GONNA HAVE TIME TO HAVE
YOUR BILL IN MY BILL AND HAVE
CONCLUDED BY TWO THIRTY BUT
MAYBE WILL RISK IT AND DO IT
ANYWAY BUT SO WE'LL LET YOU.
PROCEED AFTER WE TAKE -- DISPONE
IN AND I WILL PRESENT MY BILL.
I'M.
RIGHT SO IT'S RETURNED BACK TO
SB.
TWO THIRTY AND HOPEFULLY --
FOLKS THAT CAME TO THE COMMITTEE
EITHER IN SUPPORT OF OR OPPOSED
TO TWO THIRTY HAVE NOW HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SEE THE MARK UP
OF THE BILL.
WHICH THE COMMITTEE AND THE
AUTHOR.
ARE NOW RECOMMENDING AND WHICH I
WILL ENTERTAIN.
I'M WELL I WILL ENTERTAIN
WHATEVER MOTION ANY COMMITTEE
MEMBERS LIKE TO MAKE SINCE THAT
IS YOUR RIGHT.
ARM.
MEMBERS IS THERE A MOTION.
SENATOR WIENER.
I'M A MOVE THE BILL AS AMENDED.
RIGHT AS AMENDED BY -- BOTH WHAT
THE AUTHOR STATED IN WHAT I IS
THAT YOUR READ.
CORRECT RIGHT AND OF THE CRYSTAL
CLEAR AGAIN I MOVING THE BILL IN
THE IN THE FORM WITH THE
AMENDMENTS MEANING THAT THE USE
OF FORCE PROVISIONS HAVE BEEN
COMPLETELY STRIPPED OUT OF THE
BILL.
AND THIS BILL FOCUSES
EXCLUSIVELY ON REQUIRING
TRAINING -- FOR OFFICERS THAT
WOULD THEN BE DEPENDENT ON THE
PASSAGE OF AB THREE NINETY TWO
YES -- AS SB TWO THIRTY ASKING
FRIENDS WHO ARE NOW LINKED AND
IF SB THREE NINETY TWO FAILS.
SB TWO THIRTY IS AUTOMATICALLY
AT THAT BILL -- SO MY MOTION IS
TO PASS A BILL WITH ALL OF THESE
AMENDMENTS INCLUDED [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
NOW BEFORE WE DO A ROLL CALL.
IS THERE ANY OTHER COMMENT OR
QUESTION BY ANY ONE ON COMMITTEE.
ALL RIGHT WILL NOW HAVE A ROLL
CALL ON THOSE THE AMENDED BILL
SB.
TWO THIRTY MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
SKINNER AYE SKINNER AYE MORE
LOCK.
MORE LIKE AYE BRADFORD.
JACKSON.
MITCHELL HI MITCHELL AYE MORALE.
WIENER ALL RIGHT WIENER AYE.
THE BILL IS ON CALL.
I'M.
SO WE WILL RETURN TO IT WE HAVE
OTHER MEMBERS.
AND WILL NOW HEAR FROM CENTER
RUBIO
.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS TODAY I'M HERE TO
PRESENT SB.
TWO SEVENTY THREE THE DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE PROTECTION ACT ALSO
KNOWN AS THE PHOENIX ACT.
I WANT TO FIRST THINK THAT CHAIR
IN HER COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
WORKING WITH ME AND MY OFFICE
AND I WILL ACCEPT THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS TO EXTEND THE STATURE
LIMITATIONS TO TENURE.
SB TWO SEVENTY THREE WOULD NOT
ONLY EXTEND THE SPATULA
MEDITATION FOR SURVIVORS.
WE NEED TIME TO HEAR TO HEAL
PRIOR TO COMING FORWARD BUT THIS
BILL WILL ALSO PROVIDE CRITICAL
NEEDED TRAINING FOR PEACE
OFFICERS TO BE ABLE TO IDENTIFY
VICTIMS OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
THIS BILL REQUIRES CLAIMS TO BE
EVIDENCE BASED AT THAT INCLUDES
AUDIO VIDEO RECORDING SUPPORTER
GRASS WERE WRITTEN AND
ELECTRONIC COMMUNICATION THAT
PROVIDE EVIDENCE SUFFICIENT TO
CHARGE THE PERPETRATORS.
WE ARE HERE BECAUSE WE BELIEVE
IT IS TIME TO EMPOWER DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE SURVIVORS TO COME OUT
OF THE SHADOWS I HAVE THE GREAT
HONOR TO BE JOINED BY COURAGEOUS
LEADERS AND ADVOCATES IN THE
FIGHT AGAINST DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
WE MUST ENSURE THE SAFETY OF
VICTIMS ALLOW THEM TO SEEK
JUSTICE WITH ENOUGH TIME TO HEAL
FROM THEIR TRAUMA.
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE IS A HORRIBLE
CRIME THAT INFLICTS A HEAVY TOLL
ON ITS VICTIMS.
AS I ADDRESS HERE YOU HERE TODAY.
I CAN'T HELP BUT RECALL MY OWN
EXPERIENCE MY OWN TRAUMA.
AS I TOO AM A VICTIM OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE.
WHEN IT COMES TO DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE THE STATISTICS ARE
GRAHAM?
IN AMERICA AN AVERAGE OF FIFTY
WOMEN ARE SHOT TO DEATH BY THEIR
INTIMATE PARTNERS EVERY MONTH.
AND MANY MORE ARE INJURED.
ACCORDING TO THE AMERICAN CYCLE
THE PSYCHOLOGICAL ASSOCIATION
MORE THAN ONE AND MORE THAN ONE
IN THREE WOMEN.
AND MORE THAN ONE OF FOUR MEN IN
THE UNITED STATES HAVE
EXPERIENCE RATE PHYSICAL
VIOLENCE FOR STOCKING.
RIGHT INTO MY PARTNER IN THEIR
LIFETIME.
WOMEN WITH DISABILITIES HAVE A
40% GREATER RISK OF AN INTIMATE
PARTNER VIOLENCE IT ALSO AFFECTS
MARGINALIZE PEOPLE OF COLOR AT A
GREATER NUMBERS.
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE ALSO AFFECTS
CHILDREN.
BACK IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN IN THE
SANGRO VALLEY A WOMAN NAMED ANNA
STATUS A CONSTITUENT OF MINE.
LOST HER FIVE YEAR OLD SON.
WHO WE NOW REFER TO LOVE ANY AS
PEAKY?
HE WAS MURDERED BY ON US EX
HUSBAND DESPITE HONEST EFFORTS
TO GAIN SOLE CUSTODY DUE TO THE
ALLEGATIONS OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
WHEN HE COULDN'T HURT HER?
HE TURNED TO HER SON.
DATA SHOWS MULTIPLE REASONS WHY
SURVIVORS OF ABUSE MAY NOT COME
OVER IT WITHIN THE STATUTE OF
LIMITATIONS INCLUDING THEIR AGE
AT THE TIME OF THE USE.
ON GOING TRAUMA THREATS FROM THE
PERPETRATOR OR LACK OF EVIDENCE.
AS I SHARED EARLIER THIS ISSUE
IS VERY PERSONAL TO ME.
MY STORY WAS PUBLICIZING THE
MEDIA HUNDREDS OF WOMEN CAME
OVER TO TELL ME ABOUT THEIR
TRAUMA. ONE WOMAN IN PARTICULAR
SHARED HER STORY ABOUT AN
EIGHTEEN YEAR.
ABUSE THAT SHE HAD TO INDOOR.
AND EVEN AFTER HER RELATIONSHIP
ENDED SHE NEVER HAD THE TO TELL
ANYONE.
LET'S NOT MAKE THE STATUE OF
LIMITATION ONE MORE HURDLE.
THEN AND ALREADY BROKE.
TRAUMATIZED BIG DUMB STILL HAS
TO JUMP.
THIS IS WHY SB TWO SEVENTY THREE
IS A VERY CRITICAL PIECE OF
LEGISLATION.
BUT WHEN THEY DO FIND THE
COURAGE TO SEEK JUSTICE WE MUST
ALLOW THEM THE OPPORTUNITY. FOR
THE FUTURE SAFETY OF OTHERS.
ME HERE TODAY IS EVAN RACHEL
WOOD A SURVIVOR AN ADVOCATE. FOR
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE ISSUES.
THANK YOU SENATOR RUBIO.
CENTER SKINNER AND THE COMMITTEE --
WHEN I WAS A TEENAGER I MET A
MAN?
I LOOKED UP TO HIM IN MANY WAYS
INFO LIKE WE HAD A SPECIAL BOND
AND I HAD NO INTENTION OF
TURNING INTO SOMETHING ROMANTIC.
WHEN IT EVENTUALLY DID I WASN'T
SURE HOW TO STOP IT AS HE HAD A
CERTAIN CHARISMA AND POWER IN A
QUICKLY SURRENDERED TO HIS
CHARMS?
IN THE BEGINNING HE TREATED ME
LIKE A PRINCESS I WAS SMART BUT
SMART EIGHTEEN YEAR OLD TO STILL
IN EIGHTEEN YEAR OLD AND I
THOUGHT I HAD PHONE LOVE.
IT WASN'T UNTIL MUCH LATER THAT
I REALIZED EVERYTHING YOU TOLD
ME WAS A LIE AND PART OF WHAT IS
CALLED THE GROOMING PROCESS HE
DIDN'T A TERRIBLE DRUG AND
ALCOHOL PROBLEM FOR ME.
FAST IN A RELATIONSHIP ASKING ME
TO MOVE IN WITH HIM ALMOST
IMMEDIATELY THERE'S A CERTAIN
WAY HE WANTED ME TO LOOK
OTHERWISE I WOULDN'T OR NAME
CALLING AND RITUAL.
HE CUT ME OFF FOR MY CLOSE
FRIENDS AND FAMILY ONE BY ONE BY
EXHIBITING RAGE IN SOME FORM OR
ANOTHER WHEN I WAS IN CONTACT
WITH THEM.
THE ONLY WAY NEWT ECONOMIST A
GIVEN WHAT HE WANTED WHICH WAS
ME ALL TO HIMSELF IN TOTAL
ISOLATION.
HE HAD BOUTS OF EXTREME JEALOUSY
WHICH WOULD OFTEN RESULT IN HIM
WRECKING OUR HOME CORNING ME IN
A ROOM AND THREATENING ME.
I WOULD MISS MY VIEWS ARE
STARTING PEOPLE WITH FORCE OR
LEGAL ACTION IF YOU WORRIED THEY
WOULD EXPOSE HIM HE BRAGGED
ABOUT BEING ABLE TO HAVE PEOPLE
KILLED BECAUSE HE WAS ALLEGEDLY
FRIENDS WITH MULTIPLE GANGS AND
I WATCHED ILLEGALLY COLLECT DATA
ON PEOPLE THAT HE COULD USE HIS
BLACKMAIL.
BY THE TIME I REALIZED I WAS IN
A BAD SITUATION I FELT
COMPLETELY TRAPPED IN TERRIFIED
FOR MY LIFE.
HE GIFTED ME A CELL PHONE WHICH
I FOUND OUT HE WAS MONITORING E
DOWNLOADED SPY WARE ON TO MY
COMPUTER AND HACKED INTO MY
EMAILS AND SOCIAL MEDIA ACCOUNTS
SO I COULD NOT REACH OUT FOR
HELP.
MY FRIENDS AND FAMILY TRY TO
INTERVENE I SIMPLY TOLD THEM TO
LEAVE BECAUSE I WAS AFRAID OF
WHAT HE WOULD DO.
HE BROKE ME DOWN THROUGH MEANS
OF STARVATION SLEEP DEPRIVATION
AND THREATS AGAINST MY LIFE
SOMETIMES WITH DEADLY WEAPONS
WHICH WOULD RESULT IN ME HAVING
SEVERE PANIC ATTACKS WHERE I WAS
UNABLE TO BREATHE OR STOP
SHAKING.
SOMETIMES YOU WOULD NOT ALLOW ME
TO SLEEP UNTIL I PARTICIPATED IN
ACTS OF FEAR PAIN.
TORTURE AND HUMILIATION WHICH I
FELT POWERLESS TO STOP.
IN SOME OF THESE TAPES.
WHICH HE ALSO VIDEOTAPED.
IN SOME OF THESE TAPES HE CAN BE
HEARD THREATENING TO KILL ME
THREATEN MY FRIENDS ARE
THREATENING TO KILL MEMBERS OF
MY FAMILY.
HE ALSO THREATENED TO LEAK PARTS
OF THE FOOTAGE OR PHOTOGRAPHS
YOU TAKEN AS A WAY TO KEEP ME
QUIET.
I MUSTERED THE COURAGE TO LEAVE
SEVERAL TIMES BUT HE WOULD CALL
MY HOUSE INCESSANTLY AND
THREATENED TO KILL HIMSELF.
ON ONE OCCASION I RETURNED TO
TRYING TO FUSE THE SITUATION HE
CORNERED ME IN OUR BEDROOM AND
ASKED ME TO KNEEL WELL HE TIED
ME UP BY MY HANDS AND FEET.
ONCE I WAS RESTRAINED HE BEAT ME.
AND SHOT SENSITIVE PARTS OF MY
BODY WITH A TORTURE DEVICE
CALLED A VIOLENT. ONE TO HIM IT
WAS A WAY FOR ME TO PROVE MY
LOYALTY.
THE WORST PART WAS I STILL FELT
IT WAS SOMEHOW MY FAULT BECAUSE
SOCIETY HAD TOLD ME I SHOULD
JUST LEAVE WHEN SOMEONE HITS ME
BUT THIS WAS SO MUCH MORE
COMPLICATED AND SO MUCH SCARIER
THAN ANYTHING HAD EVER PREPARED
ME FOR I DIDN'T KNOW WHAT TO
CALL IT.
AFTER THIS INCIDENT I PLAYED
ALONG WITH WHATEVER HE WANTED
AND DURING CONSTANT DAILY ABUSE
AND ON OCCASION RIGHT UNTIL I
FOUND A WAY TO ESCAPE SAFELY.
YEARS LATER MY THERAPIST WOULD
IDENTIFY THIS A STOCKHAM
SYNDROME.
ONCE I WAS FINALLY OUT OF MY
FEEL SAFE WHICH MEANT PUTTING
TIME AND SPACE BETWEEN ME HIM IN
THE ABUSE.
THE SHAME IS STILL OVERWHELMING
AND IT'S TAKEN ALL OF MY
STRENGTH TO SPEAK PUBLICLY AND
TO PURSUE THIS EVEN TODAY.
THE FEAR BEING JUDGED BY SOCIETY
IS DEBILITATING AND THE FEAR OF
RETALIATION FROM MY ABUSER IS
PARALYZING.
BY SPEAKING TO YOU TODAY AND
EVERYDAY I PUT MYSELF AT RISK AS
I HAVE NO PROTECTION.
I HAD TO GO THROUGH INTENSE
THERAPY TO EVEN FULLY UNDERSTAND
WHAT HAS HAPPENED TO ME AND I'VE
BEEN DIAGNOSED WITH COMPLEX PTSD.
I'M STILL IN THE PROCESS OF
WORKING THROUGH THIS.
THE FINAL PUSH INTO CREATING THE
PHOENIX ACT WITH THE CRUSHING
REALIZATION YEARS LATER THAT HE
HAD DONE THIS TO SEVERAL PEOPLE
AND IT WAS VERY LIKELY THEY WERE
MORE VICTIMS.
SO I TRIED TO TAKE MY EVIDENCE
TO THE STATE AN ATTEMPT TO STOP
THIS FROM HAPPENING TO ANYONE
ELSE.
MY EVIDENCE INCLUDED PHOTOGRAPHS
AND VIDEO NOT JUST RELYING ON
MEMORY.
CANNOT BE VIEWED BY THE STATE
BECAUSE THE SUCH A LIMITATION SO
MANY CASES RUN OUT.
AND I'VE LIVED TO WITH THE
SILENCE AND SHAME FOR TOO LONG
AND IT HAS BEEN UNBEARABLE.
IT'S TAKING YEARS FROM MY LIFE
BECAUSE I WAS TOO AFRAID TO TELL
ANYONE.
I KNOW THAT THIS BILL WILL NOT
AFFECT MY CASE BUT I URGE YOU TO
VOTE YES ON THE PHOENIX ACT TO
CREATE A CUSHION FOR VICTIMS TO
LEAVE THEIR DANGEROUS SITUATIONS.
GET THE HELP THEY NEED I COME
BACK FROM THE TRAUMA IN ORDER TO
PURSUE JUSTICE AND STOP SERIAL
ABUSERS AS LONG AS THEY HAVE
UNDENIABLE EVIDENCE.
WE DO NOT WISH TO CREATE NEW
LAWS ARE HARSHER PUNISHMENTS
ONLY MORE TIME IF THE EVIDENCE
MEETS THE CRITERIA WE ARE
PUTTING FORWARD.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME FOR
HEARING US TODAY.
ADAM SHARE I'M SORRY I FEEL TO
TO ALSO SAY THIS SHE BACK ACROSS
ANOTHER SURVIVOR SPHERE WITH ME
TO TELL HER.
STORY THANK YOU GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU SENATOR IN COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU SENATE COMMITTEE.
I JUST WANTED TO SAY I'M HERE
ALSO IN SUPPORT OF THE PHOENIX
AT SB.
TWO SEVEN THREE I'M INTRODUCED
BY SENATOR RUBIO BECAUSE I
BELIEVE IT WAS DRAFTED IN
RESPONSE TO THE OUTCRY FROM
PEOPLE LIKE ME SURVIVORS AN
EVENT. FOR THE NEED TO X..
GO AND EXTEND SUCH OF LIMITATION
AS IT PERTAINS TO PROSECUTION OF
OF PERPETRATORS OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE.
I THINK WE REALLY NEED TO SHIFT
THE FOCS ON THE INTERPRETATION
OF THIS LAW.
FROM.
PROSECUTION OF PERPETRATORS TO
BEING A TOOL FOR CURRENT VICTIMS
AND SURVIVORS OF INTIMATE
PARTNER VIOLENCE IPV.
I SHARE MY STORY BECAUSE I HOPE
THAT I CAN SHOW THE IMPORTANCE
OF THIS CHANGE NOT ONLY FOR ME.
BUT FOR THE THOUSAND NAMELESS
AND FACELESS WOMEN THAT ARE
CURRENTLY FACING WHAT I FACE AT
THE YOUNG AGE OF TWELVE CAN YOU
IMAGINE ME AT TWELVE MY
EXPERIENCE MY FIRST PUNCH MY
FIRST LAP MY FIRST TASTE OF
STRANGULATION BECAUSE IPV
EXTENSIVE THOSE WHO TARGET YOUNG
GIRLS LIKE ME.
FORCING ME TO BECOME AN INTIMATE
PARTNER AS WELL AS A VICTIM
VICTIM OF HUMAN AND SEX
TRAFFICKING.
I STARTED HERE BECAUSE I HAD
DEVELOPED AT A YOUNG AGE WHAT
RELATIONSHIPS AND ABUSE LOOK
LIKE AS NORMAL.
AT EIGHTEEN BOYFRIENDS AND
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE CONTINI PEOPLE
PART OF EVERY RELATIONSHIP.
VIOLENCE WAS NOT DOMESTIC IT WAS
JUST MY BOYFRIEND AND THAT'S HOW
BOYS TO GIRLS.
AT TWENTY I CONTINUE THE CYCLE
HAVING FROM ONE RELATIONSHIP TO
THE NEXT BEING BEATEN TO THE
GROUND.
AND I STILL DIDN'T REALIZE THAT
WAS VIOLENCE.
I'M EMBARRASSED TO SHARE AS AS
SOMEONE WHO'S VERY STRONG
RESPECTED IN MY COMMUNITY AND
ELECTED OFFICIAL.
THAT WAS UNTIL TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN THAT I REALIZED THAT I
WAS ALSO A VICTIM OF AN INTIMATE
PARTNER VIOLENCE.
I'M HERE TODAY BECAUSE IT TOOK
ME TWENTY SEVEN YEARS TO REALIZE
THAT IT WAS VIOLENCE IT WAS
AGAINST ALONG.
AND I KNOW I HAD THE POWER TO DO
SOMETHING.
IF I HAD STARTED THIS INFAMOUS
CLOCK.
AN ACTIVATED THE STATUE OF
LIMITATIONS TIMER I WOULD HAVE
LAPSED THE CURRENT LAW TWENTY
SIX TIMES.
ACCORDING TO THE CURRENT LAW I
ONLY HAD ONE THREE YEARS TO STEP
ONE COME TO TERMS THE FACT MY
RELATIONSHIP WAS VIOLENT TEP.
TO UNDERSTAND WHAT HAPPENED TO
ME WAS AGAINST THE LAW STEP
THREE HOW TO NAVIGATE THE LEGAL
SYSTEM AND THE HARDEST STEP STEP
FOR THE MOST CONSUMING AN
INDIVIDUALIZED AFTER.
GATHERING THE COURAGE TO GO TO
THE POLICE WHICH NORMALLY
DOESN'T HAPPEN COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR.
I AM SHOWING THAT IT TOOK ME
TWENTY SEVEN YEARS TO WRITE TO
STEP.
AND NOW A FEW FEW MORE YEARS
HAVE PASSED AND I CREEP TOWARDS
THAT.
FOR NO I WHAT I KNOW TODAY I
CAN'T IMAGINE GETTING TO THIS
FINAL STEP ESTABLISH THE COURAGE
TO FILE CHARGES AND BE TOLD THAT
THE LAW TO PROTECT BECAUSE I
PASSED THE STATUE OF LIMITATIONS.
IT WOULD JUST AGAIN RE TRIGGER
MY TRAUMA AND TRAUMATIZED ME.
I'M HERE TO SAY IN SACRAMENTO
BEING VULNERABLE.
AND IF I WOULD HAVE HAD THE
RESOURCES THAN. TO BE ABLE TO
COME UP AND TALK ABOUT THIS IN
THE PAST I WOULD HAVE.
BUT I'M ASKING YOU TO TAKE THE
FIFTH STEP WITH ME.
AND THAT STEP IS TO PUT A HOLD
ON DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
AND I HOPE THAT ALL THE
LEGISLATORS TO HEAR ME AND WATCH
THESE VIDEOS TODAY.
AND TAKE A STEP IN VOTING YES TO
SUPPORT SB TWO SEVENTY THREE
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ARE THERE OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
YOUR NAME TO STATE YOUR NAME.
MY NAME IS ELAINE WHITE FEATHER
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR COMMUNITY
FOR PEACE.
LARGELY MARTIN THIRTY TWO YEARS
SURVIVOR OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE --
YES PLEASE.
MY NAME IS REGINA RENEE AND I'M
A DOMESTIC VIOLENCE SURVIVOR.
AND IFOUND OUT THAT I MISSED MY
WINDOW FOR JUSTICE AND I SUPPORT --
SB TWO SEVENTY THREE THE PHOENIX
ACT.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR DON CAP
KEY ON BEHALF OF CRIME VICTIMS
UNITED OF CALIFORNIA ALSO IN
SUPPORT.
I'M KATE RANTA AMID DOMESTIC
INCOME VIOLENCE SURVIVOR PLEASE
VOTE YES.
I'M ACTUALLY GOAL -- I'M A
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE VIA AND I FOR
YES.
OKAY THRILL SURVIVOR OF SEVERE
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
PLEASE VOTE YES.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
DO WE HAVE WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
IF. ONE OR TWO OF YOU LEAVE THE
TABLE WHICHEVER [inaudible]
SURE.
GOOD AFTERNOON LESLIE CALDWELL
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION -- OUR CALIFORNIA
SUPREME COURT HAS HELD THAT
STATUTES OF LIMITATIONS SERVE A
VITAL HUMBLE PUBLIC FUNCTION BY
PROTECTING CALIFORNIA CITIZENS
AND I QUOTE.
FROM DEFENDING STATE CLAIMS WERE
FACTUAL OBSCURITY THROUGH THE
LOSS OF TIME MEMORY OR
SUPPORTING DOCUMENTATION MAYBE
PRESENT.
PRINT MAY PRESENT UNFAIR
HANDICAPS TO QUOTE FROM THE
COURTS.
UNDER CURRENT LAW THE
PROSECUTION IS GIVEN THREE YEARS
FROM THE DATE OF AN ALLEGED
OFFENSE TO INVESTIGATE AND
DETERMINE WHETHER CHARGES ARE
WARRANTED.
THE STATUTE OF LIMITATIONS
INSURES THAT THE STATE ACTS
PROMPTLY TO INVESTIGATE A
COMPLAINT WHILE ALSO
GUARANTEEING THAT ANY PERSON
FALSELY ACCUSED OF SUCH AN
OFFENSE NEED NOT SPEND A DECADE
OR MORE.
PRESERVING EVIDENCE OR WAITING
THE LATEST WHIM OF FILING
PROSECUTORS.
SB TWO SEVENTY THREE PROPOSES TO
REPLACE THIS CAREFUL CALCULUS
WITH THE NUMBER.
WITH NO RHYME OR REASON IN SO
DOING SB SEVEN TO SEVENTY THREE
OF THREATENS THE ABILITY OF
THOSE FALSELY ACCUSED TO DEFEND
THEMSELVES.
THIS RESULTS.
THIS RESULT THREATENS THE
INTEGRITY OF THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM AND IS BAD PUBLIC
POLICY.
WE DON'T HAVE TO SAY DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE IS OKAY BUT WE DO NEED
TO ESTABLISH REASONABLE RULES OF
LAW.
AND THAT IS WHAT WE'RE ASKING
YOU TO DO AND WE REQUEST A NO
VOTE.
ON SB.
TWO SEVENTY THREE GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR MIGHT AND MEMBERS
MIKE A DOCTOR OFF ON BEHALF OF
THE ACLU OF CALIFORNIA -- WE
APPRECIATE.
THE IT AMENDMENTS TO THE BELL
AND THE AUTHORS WILLINGNESS TO
CONSIDER OUR CONCERNS AND AND
NARROW THE SCOPE.
HOWEVER UNFORTUNATELY WE REMAIN
OPPOSED. TO THE BILL UNLESS IT
IS AMENDED TO REMOVE THE
EXTENSION OF THE STATUTE OF
LIMITATIONS -- ENTIRELY -- WE
CERTAINLY SUPPORT THE GOAL OF
PROMOTING JUSTICE FOR SURVIVORS
OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE HOWEVER WE
FEAR THAT THE EXTENSION OF THE
STATUTE OF LIMITATIONS PROPOSED
BY THIS BILL.
WILL BOTH TO THREATEN
DEFENDANT'S RIGHTS AND REMOVE
THE INCENTIVE FOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND PROSECUTORS TO
MORE SWIFTLY ADDRESS REPORTS OF
DOMESTIC PARTNER VIOLENCE IN THE
FIRST INSTANCE.
AS MY COLLEAGUE EXPRESSED AT A
FUNDAMENTAL LEVEL STATUTES OF
LIMITATIONS HELP TO ENSURE THAT
DEFENDANTS RECEIVE A FAIR TRIAL.
HOWEVER IN ADDITION TO ENSURING
FAIRNESS THIS OF CALIFORNIA
SUPREME COURT HAS ALSO NOTED
THAT STATUTES OF LIMITATIONS
ENCOURAGE THE SWIFT AND
EFFECTIVE ENFORCEMENT OF THE LAW.
HOPEFULLY PRODUCING A STRONGER
DETERRENT EFFECT.
SURVIVORS OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
ALREADY FACE SIGNIFICANT
BARRIERS WHEN ATTEMPTING TO
ACCESS THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM.
IN A STATEWIDE STUDIED MORE THAN
30% OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE CASES
INVOLVING AGGRAVATED PHYSICAL
ASSAULT WE'RE NOT PROSECUTED.
OTHER RESEARCH HAS SHOWN THAT
WHILE POLICE TEAM JUST A
FRACTION OF SEXUAL ASSAULT CASES
WORTHY OF INVESTIGATION.
PROSECUTORS HAVE APPROACH
SUSPICIOUSLY EVEN THOSE CASES
THAT POLICE DEEMED TO HAVE THE
STRONGEST EVIDENCE OF SEXUAL
ASSAULT.
EXTENDING THE STATUTE OF
LIMITATIONS IN THESE CASES WILL
NOT IMPROVE THESE OUTCOMES AND
MAY SERVE ONLY TO FURTHER
DISCOURAGE THE SWIFT AND
EFFECTIVE.
ENFORCEMENT OF THE LAW.
AND MAY WEAKEN THE THREAT OF
PROSECUTION FOR THOSE WHO DEMAND
WHO COMMIT DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
CRIMES SO FOR ALL OF THESE
REASONS WE EAT RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE THE BILL AND LESS AMENDED
TO REMOVE THE EXTENSION OF THE
STATUTE OF LIMITATIONS THANK YOU.
ARE THERE OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION [inaudible]
RIGHT [inaudible]
GO AHEAD.
FUNDAMENTAL REPRESENTING THE SAN
FRANCISCO PUBLIC DEFENDER'S
OFFICE IN OPPOSITION OKAY ANY
OTHERS.
ALL RIGHT -- BEFORE I CALL ON
ANY COLLEAGUES -- I WANT TO
SPEAK -- TO THIS BILL
[inaudible]
I'M.
I APPRECIATE THE PUBLIC DEFENDER
CITATION OF THE SUPREME COURT'S --
EXPRESSION ON STATURE
LIMITATIONS AND I APPRECIATE THE
ACLU'S POINT OF VIEW.
HOWEVER I THINK THAT.
WHAT WE HAVE TO RECOGNIZE?
IS THE ABILITY FOR VICTIMS TO
COME FORWARD.
AND IF WE LOOK AT THE HISTORY
FOR EXAMPLE AROUND RATE.
WE ORIGINALLY HAD A STATUE OF
LIMITATIONS SOMETIME AGO AT
THREE YEARS.
THEN LATER WAS TEN YEARS.
AND NOW ONLY JUST I THINK IT WAS
THREE YEARS AGO ANDERSON RELAVIS
BILL.
WE REMOVED THE STATUE
LIMITATIONS ENTIRELY.
NOW CLEARLY THERE HAS TO BE VERY
CLEAR EVIDENCE BUT IT WAS
RECOGNIZED THAT. FOR ANY NUMBER
OF A WELL I WANT TO SEE ANY
NUMBER LET'S BE LET'S JUST BE
REALLY CLEAR AROUND.
THE PREJUDICE TOWARDS VICTIMS OF
RAPE COMING FORWARD FOR THEIR
BEING BELIEVED AND FOR EVEN LAW
ENFORCEMENT TAKING THEIR CRIME
SERIOUSLY.
ALL OF THOSE THINGS LED INTO.
I BELIEVE THE LEGISLATURE WHILE
I WAS NOT THERE AT THE TIME BUT
I WOULD HAVE SUPPORTED IT HAD I
BEEN HERE.
WILLINGNESS TO LIFT THAT STATUE
OF LIMITATIONS.
THEN WHEN WE LOOK AT SEXUAL
MOLESTATION OF CHILDREN. FOR FOR
YEARS WE HAD A STATUE
LIMITATIONS ON THAT NOT
RECOGNIZING THAT. FOR MOST
CHILDREN.
THE VERY CIRCUMSTANCE THAT.
THAT LED TO THEIR BEING ABLE TO
BE SUBJECT TO THAT.
ABUSE.
WAS.
WAS A CIRCUMSTANCE WHERE.
THEY HAD NOT PERSONALLY AN
INABILITY TO TELL BUT A SETTING
FOR WHICH IT WAS EITHER POWERFUL
INDIVIDUALS OR CIRCUMSTANCES
WHERE.
THEY WERE THREATENED OR THEY
KNEW THEY COULD NOT TELL AND SO
THAT'S IT WAS INTERNALIZED THAT
THEY THEMSELVES EITHER ASKED FOR
IT.
OR DESERVED IT.
AND WHAT WE NOW KNOW IS THAT FOR
PEOPLE IN THOSE CIRCUMSTANCES IT
TAKES YEARS FOR THEM TO FINALLY.
ACCEPT.
THAT THEY THEMSELVES WERE THE
VICTIMS OF EAST OF A CRIME.
AND THEN TO BE ABLE TO REPORT
AND SO WE'VE NOW LIFTED THAT
STATUE REVOCATIONS UP TO A
PERSON TO BEING UP TO FORTY
YEARS OLD.
SO WE MADE MANY CHANGES THAT.
FIVE BY A STRICT READING OF THE
COURT'S OPINION ONE COULD SAY
WAS VERY CONTRARY AND YET I
THINK WE ALWAYS HAVE TO WEIGH.
THE CIRCUMSTANCE WERE MAKING A
CHANGE.
AND WHEN WE LOOK AT DOMESTIC
PARTNER ABUSE.
IT TO MY PARTNER VIOLENCE INNER
INTIMATE PARTNER ABUSE.
WHILE IT IS NOT A 100% THE
CIRCUMSTANCE WHERE THE
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS THE ABUSER
GROOMS THE PARTNER.
IS VERY COMMON. TO THE POINT
WHERE.
EITHER BECAUSE OF THEIR GROOMING
OR BECAUSE OF THE PARTNERS
DEPENDENCE.
ON THE ABUSER EITHER FINANCIAL
OR OTHERWISE.
OR ANY NUMBER OF OTHER FACTORS.
IT IN WE KNOW INDEPENDENT OF
BEING ABLE TO REPORT IT IS A
CRIME.
IT IS VERY COMMON THAT PEOPLE IN
THOSE CIRCUMSTANCES STAY IN THEM
FOR A LONG TIME.
THAT IS WELL DOCUMENTED.
AND NOT BECAUSE THEY WANT THE
ABUSE BUT BECAUSE THEY FEEL
POWERLESS TO GET OUT OF IT.
AND EVEN WHEN THEY GET OUT OF IT
THEY STILL FEEL POWERLESS TO
REPORT.
OR TO ACT ON IT THEY STILL FEEL
THAT EITHER IT WAS THEIR FAULT.
OR THAT THE CONSEQUENCES FOR THE
SHAME.
SO I THINK ALL OF THAT LENDS
ITSELF TO A LEGITIMACY FOR OUR
LIFTING A THREE YEAR STATUTE OF
LIMITATIONS.
NOW THE BILL HAD RECOMMENDED
TWENTY YEARS.
I PERSONALLY WOULD BE
COMFORTABLE WITH THAT TWENTY
YEARS.
BUT BECAUSE OF THE BALANCING OF
TRYING TO WAY.
ON THE VALIDITY OF STATUTE OF
LIMITATIONS.
I FELT IT WAS APPROPRIATE.
TO THIS FIRST STAGE BRING IT TO
TEN YEARS AND I APPRECIATE THAT
THE AUTHOR WAS WILLING.
AND I HOPE THAT THE BILL AS IT
MOVES FORWARD IF IT MOVES
FORWARD TODAY CAN BE RETAINED AT
THAT AND ISN'T SHRUNK FURTHER.
BUT OF COURSE WE KNOW SOMETIMES
THESE THINGS HAPPEN AND WE MAY
HAVE TO ENTERTAIN THIS AGAIN BUT
IF WE CERTAINLY LOOK AT THE
HISTORY.
OF SIMILAR.
TYPES OF CRIMES IN THE STATE'S
HISTORY OF STATUTE OF
LIMITATIONS AROUND THOSE.
SOMETIMES WE HAVE.
TO HAVE SOME EXPERIENCE BEFORE
WE CAN.
POTENTIALLY GET TO THE POINT
WHERE.
WE BALANCE IT EXACTLY RIGHT.
BUT I THINK THAT THIS IS A
APPROPRIATING GOOD FIRST STEP.
BECAUSE IT RECOGNIZES THAT.
PERSONS WHO ARE SUBJECT TO
INTIMATE PARTNER ABUSE ARE IN
VERY VULNERABLE CIRCUMSTANCES.
AND ALL OF THOSE VULNERABILITIES.
CONTRIBUTE TO THEIR BOTH
INABILITY TO GET OUT OF THAT
ABUSIVE SITUATION AND THEN TO
REPORT IT.
AND I WANT TO CREATE.
BETTER JUSTICE SYSTEM OR PEOPLE
IN THOSE CIRCUMSTANCES AND GIVE
THEM THE TIME TO HEAL.
SO THAT THEY CAN THEN COME
FORWARD.
AND THAT WE DO NOT HAVE A LEGAL
BARRIER THAT PREVENTS THEIR
PERPETRATOR FROM.
FROM THAT HAVING TO GO BEFORE
JUSTICE.
SO I APPRECIATE THE BILL AND AS
YOU'VE HEARD ME EXPRESS MY
OPINION ON IT I WILL BE
RECOMMENDING TO THE CANADIAN AYE
VOTE.
AND SENATOR WIENER GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU -- MAN CHAIR IOWA
THANK.
YOU AND ALSO CENTER RIVER FOR
BEING SO OPEN ABOUT -- YOUR OWN.
EXPERIENCES INTO THE WITNESSES
TODAY I KNOW THAT IT'S NOT EASY --
AND I SOME.
I CAN'T EVEN IMAGINE IT'LL BE
LIKE HAVING TO RELIVE EVERYTHING
IN PUBLIC BEFORE STRANGERS OF
THANK YOU.
FOR YOUR COURAGE ON AND ON
SUPPORTER OF THIS BILL I ALSO
WOULD HAVE BEEN OKAY WITH THE
WITH THE TWENTY YEARS BUT I
THINK THIS IS A GOOD -- GOOD
RESOLUTION -- AND I THINK IT'S A
BIG STEP.
AND I AND I KNOW THAT FOR MANY
VICTIMS IT DOES TAKE THEM A LONG
TIME. TO COME FORWARD THIS IS.
NOT IT IS.
AND WENT WHEN IT'S A A STRANGER
COMING ACROSS AGAINST YOU ON THE
STREET THAT'S ALSO TERRIBLE.
BUT PEOPLE ARE MUCH MORE LIKELY
TO COME FORWARD TO MAKE AN
IMMEDIATE REPORT -- WHEN IT IS --
THIS TYPE OF CRIME PEOPLE IT IS
SO MUCH MORE COMPLICATED
PSYCHOLOGICALLY FOR EVERYONE
INVOLVED.
AND SO I KNOW THIS IS A LIFE.
BUT ON TO THE AUTHOR COULD YOU
JUST CLARIFY IT IT IS OUR DATA
ON HOW LONG ON AVERAGE IT TAKES
VICTIMS OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
FIVE TO COME FORWARD AND MAKE
THAT REPORT.
I HAVE AN EXPERT HERE IF SHE
MASTER THAT QUESTION.
GO AHEAD ELAINE MY FEATHER FROM
A COMMUNITY FOR PEACE AND ALSO A
SURVIVOR THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR COMMENTS.
AS A SURVIVOR OF IPV.
I AM CURRENTLY GETTING OUT OF AN
IPV EVEN AS A DIRECTOR SO I'M
HAVING TO OUT MYSELF HERE TODAY.
AS A MEMBER OF THE COMMUNITY AND
MARGINALIZE COMMUNITIES I CAN
TELL YOU IT'S BEEN THREE YEARS
I'VE BEEN GETTING OUT I AM ONLY
JUST NOW ABLE TO TELL YOU THAT.
SO ON AVERAGE WE KNOW THAT MOST
OF OUR CLIENTS THAT WE SERVE
WILL BE ANYWHERE FROM THREE TO
FIVE YEARS.
BEFORE WE ARE EVEN ABLE TO
REMEMBER THE TRAUMA IN
SEQUENTIAL ORDER WITH ENOUGH
DETAIL FOR YOU TO BE ABLE TO
PROSECUTE ANYTHING.
SO WHEN YOU UNDERSTAND THAT ALSO
WITHIN THE CONTEXT.
YOU UNDERSTAND THAT.
IN AFRICAN AMERICAN COMMUNITIES
IT'S 35% HIGHER AMONG MY MOTHER
TINA'S COMMUNITIES IS 22% HIGHER
IN THE LGBT COMMUNITY FOR WOMEN
OF COLOR AND COMMUNITY.
IT IS 48% AND 57% TRANSAMERICA.
WE ACCESS SYSTEMS WE WILL NOT
CALL THE LAW ENFORCEMENT WE WILL
NOT GO TO THE DA I OUTED MYSELF
TO LAW ENFORCEMENT. TO THE DA'S
OFFICE AND GOT NO SUPPORT WHICH
IS WHY MY AGENCY NOW IS
DIRECTING SERVICES TO THIS
COMMUNITY IT TAKES A VERY LONG
TIME. TO REMEMBER ITTHAT WE
WANT TO REMEMBER IT FOR THAT WE
CAN EVER SPEAK IN PUBLIC
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
WE ARE MOTION ON THE UNIT DID
SORRY SENATOR WE ARE POLITICS
OKAY.
SO WE HAVE A MOTION -- AS
AMENDED AND CENTER RUBIO I'D BE
PLEASED TO BE ADDED A SICK
[inaudible]
THANK YOU -- BROKEN -- I'M SORRY.
TO RUBIO WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
AT WHAT WHAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
TODAY -- AS I MENTIONED TODAY
THIS IS VERY PERSONAL TO ME BUT
YOU KNOW I I DO APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMENTS AND TO KNOW YOUR INTENT
HERE BUT AS I HEARD SOME OF THE
COMMENTS RIGHT NOW I HEARD AND
AND 30% OF CASES WERE NOT
PROSECUTED.
I ALSO HEARD EARLIER IN A LETTER
THAT THEY SENT OF OPPOSITION
THAT -- PLEASE ENTER YOU FAILED
TO RESPOND TO DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
REPORTS AND SO TO THAT I SAY
THAT CLEARLY THE SYSTEM IS
FLAWED AND DESIGNED. TO PROTECT
THE ABUSER NOT THE VICTIM.
AND DOM AND I HOPE THAT DIE SOME
DAY WE'LL GET TO THE TWENTY
YEARS BECAUSE IT IS A VERY
DIFFICULT AND PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE. TO TALK ABOUT IT AND
AND PUBLIC AND SO I WANT TO
THANK RETOOL IN WOODS AND THE
OTHER VICTIMS SURVIVORS.
THAT HAVE JOIN ME HERE TODAY
BECAUSE IT TAKES A LOT OF
COURAGE TO SPEAK ABOUT THIS.
SO WITH THAT MADAM CHAIR I ASKED
FOR AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR NOW DO ROLL CALL
MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS SKINNER HI
SKINNER I'M MORE LIFE.
BRADFORD AYE BRADFORD AYE
JACKSON.
MITCHELL AYE MITCHELL AYE MORALE.
WIENER WIENER AYE.
BILLS ON CALL.
BUT WE WILL -- CONTINUE THAT
VOTE ONCE PEOPLE RETURNED AND
NOW I'LL BE PRESENTING.
ON SB.
FIVE SIXTEEN AND I WILL ASK
SENATOR WIENER
[inaudible]
THANKS.
ALL RIGHT.
THANKS SO MUCH YES AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS -- SB FIVE SIXTEENTHS SO
ARE COURTS KICK MANY MEASURES TO
ENSURE THAT JURIES ARE NOT
BIASED IN THAT THEY DELIBERATE
FAIRLY -- SB FIVE SIXTEENS
PURPOSE IS TO ASSIST THAT
OBJECTIVE.
EVIDENCE OF A CRIME PRESENTED
DURING TRIAL IS THE BASIS ON HOW
JURIES ARE SUPPOSED TO DECIDE
GUILT OR INNOCENCE.
CURRENT LAW.
GIVES THE COURT'S DISCRETION TO
EXCLUDE EVIDENCE IF IT CREATES
UNDUE PREJUDICE CONFUSES THE
ISSUES OR MISLEAD THE JURY.
HOWEVER JUDGES RARELY ACT TO
EXCLUDE EVIDENCE PARTICULARLY
GANG EVIDENCE.
THE CALIFORNIA SUPREME CURT
ITSELF WEIGHED IN STATING AND I
QUOTE.
GANG EVIDENCE EVEN AS IT RELATES
TO THE DEFENDANT MAYBE SO
EXTRAORDINARILY PREJUDICIAL AND
IF SO LITTLE REVEL INSTIGATE ALT
THAT IT THREATENS TO SWAY THE
JURY TO CONVICT REGARDLESS OF
THE DEFENDANTS ACTUAL GUILT.
SO WHAT SB FIVE SIXTEEN DOES IS
ADDRESSES THIS PREJUDICIAL
EVIDENCE BY REQUIRING A
DEFENDANT TO BE CONVICTED OF THE
UNDERLYING CRIME FIRST.
BEFORE.
THERE IS.
EVIDENCE RELATED TO THEIR
POTENTIAL INVOLVEMENT IN THE
GANG.
AND THEN SECONDARILY THE JURY
WOULD DETERMINE.
IF THE DEFENDANT IS GUILTY OF A
GANG ENHANCEMENT OR GANG OFFENSE
AND WITH ME.
TO ADD TO THE SUPPORT IS DOCTOR
MITCHELL EISEN WHO IS A
PROFESSOR OF PSYCHOLOGY AT CSU
LA.
AND A PREVENT I CRUZ A PUBLIC
DEFENDER.
THANK YOU FIRST WITNESS.
HI MITCH EISEN PROCESS I COUNTY
COUNCIL DELAY.
MY PRIMARY AREA OF RESEARCH IS
REALLY AN EYEWITNESS MEMORY BUT
WHEN I STARTED -- WAS WORKING ON
A LOT OF CASES IN WHICH I FOUND
THAT THE EVIDENCE WAS REALLY
WEAK.
BUT YET THE PROSECUTORS USED THE
DISCRETION OF BRINGING IN GANG
TESTIMONY AND HAVING LENGTHY
TESTIMONY FROM A GANG EXPERT
TALKING ABOUT.
YOU KNOW THE HEINOUS CRIMES
COMMITTED BY THE GROUP.
AND THEN FOR SOME REASON THEY
WERE SECURING GUILTY VERDICTS
AND I WAS SURPRISED IN THESE
PARTICULAR CASES.
NOW IN SOME CASES THE DEFENDANT
WASN'T IN A METAGAME MEMBER.
BUT IN OTHER CASES WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT A KID WITH A SINGLE F. I.
KERR TO FIELD IDENTIFICATION
CARD BECAUSE HE'S HANGING OUT
WITH SOME.
FRIENDS WHO GOT IN TROUBLE AND
PLAYED BASKETBALL WITH THEM AND
GOT STOPPED BY THE POLICE AT
SOME POINT IN IN INDEED.
THAT CARD LED TO HIM SUSPICION
OF HIS CRIMINAL INVOLVEMENT IN
OTHER CASES IT WAS FOLKSWHO'VE
BEEN TRYING TO GET OUT OF THIS
LIFE AND PULL THEIR LIVES
TOGETHER.
BUT THEY HAD A HISTORY OF BEING
KNUCKLE HEADS WHEN THEY WERE
KIDS AND GETTING INVOLVED IN
TROUBLE.
SO I WAS CONCERNED THAT PERHAPS
THAT.
ALTHOUGH THIS.
THIS TESTIMONY WAS IN. TO SHOW
MOTIVE IT HAD THE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES OF BASICALLY
INFERRING THAT THE DEFENDANT WAS
ACTUALLY PARTICIPATING IN THE
AXE BEING DESCRIBED BY THE GANG
EXPERT WITH GANGS PARTICIPATING.
SO WE DID SOME RESEARCH.
AND IN OUR FIRST STUDY PUBLISHED
IN TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN WE
SIMPLY HAD TO SIMULATE TRIAL
VIDEOTAPE TRIAL THE FOLKS WATCH
WHERE THERE WAS EITHER NO
MENTION OF GANG.
OR THE INVESTIGATING OFFICER
SAID THE KID WAS HANGING OUT
WITH GANG MEMBERS BEFORE THE
CRIME OR IF THEY WERE SELF
METAGAME MEMBER.
AND INDEED IN THIS FIRST
EXPERIMENT WE FOUND THAT JUST
MENTIONING GANG LED TO INCREASE
GUILTY VERDICTS.
SO WE REDID IT.
IN TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN WITH
ANOTHER EXPERIMENT WHERE WE
VIDEOTAPE THE TRIAL BUT THIS
TIME WE ACTUALLY HAD GANG
TESTIMONY IN THE AREA A GETTING
US WHERE TO DOES IT FREQUENTLY
FOR THE SHERIFF'S OFFICE DOING
ITS PART OF THE TRIAL.
CLEARLY REASONABLE THAT WAS
CLEARLY ESTABLISHED.
AS EVIDENCED BY THE FACT THAT
WHEN NO GAME WAS MENTIONED IN
THIS TRIAL AFTER DELIBERATIONS
THERE WERE ZERO GUILTY VERDICTS.
HOWEVER WHEN THE GANG EXPERT AND
THE GANG TEST WHEN HE WAS
ADMITTED WE GOT 10% GUILTY.
GUILTY VERDICTS AND WE ARE
WANTING HOW'S THIS POSSIBLE SO
WE RE DID IT AGAIN.
AND THIS TIME WE MADE IT IT'S
MORE SERIOUS CRIME.
FIGHT OVER A GIRL THAT RESULT IN
A SHOOTING AND A CHILD WAS
KILLED WITH A STRAY BULLET.
AND AGAIN.
WE FOUND THE SAME THING WHEN THE
GANG TESTIMONY WAS ADMITTED WE
HAD 20% GUILTY VERDICTS AND WHEN
NO GANG TESTIMONY WAS OMITTED.
ONE PERSON OUT OF ABOUT TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY AFTER
DELIBERATIONS VOTED GUILTY.
AND WE HAVE THIS ON FINDING AND
WE FOUND THAT ACROSS THE STUDIES
WHEN THE GANG EVIDENCE WAS
ADMITTED.
WE FOUND THAT DURING
DELIBERATIONS PEOPLE WERE
DISCUSSING THAT ONE OF THE
REASONS THEY WANT TO VOTE GUILTY
WAS EVIDENCE OF THE DEFENDANT'S
PRIOR CRIMINAL CONDUCT.
BUT NO SUCH EVIDENCE WAS EVER
ADMITTED.
WHEN WE ARE WANTING WHAT IS THE
ORIGIN OF THIS FALSE MEMORY SO
WE DID ANOTHER COUPLE OF STUDIES
MORE RECENTLY WHERE WE DID THE
EXACT SAME PROCEDURES BUT AFTER
DELIBERATIONS WE ASK THEM?
ABOUT THEIR MEMORY FOR THE
EVIDENCE AND WE SPECIFICALLY
ASKED.
DO YOU REMEMBER EVIDENCE BEING
PRESENTED A PREVIOUS CRIMINAL
CONDUCT AND DO YOU REMEMBER
EVIDENCE OF PREVIOUS CONVICTIONS.
FOR SIMILAR CRIMES VERY
PREJUDICIAL EVIDENCE O TIGHTLY
CONTROLLED BY THE COURT.
AND INDEED WE FOUND THAT IN THE
GANG CONDITION IT WAS NOT
UNCOMMON FOR PEOPLE TO REPORT
THESE FALSE MEMORIES.
NOW WHY.
WELL BASICALLY THERE'S THE
STRONG INFERENCE OF THE GANG
TESTIMONY THAT IF THE GANG IS
PARTICIPATING THESE CRIMINAL
ACTIVITIES AND THIS PERSON IS A
MEMBER OF THE GANG THEN THEY
MUST BE.
SO IT COULD BE JUST AN INFERENCE
AND PEOPLE WERE JUST HAVING
TROUBLE WITH THAT AND IN
MISTAKENLY UNDERSTANDING WHAT
THE WHAT THE EVIDENCE WAS.
HOWEVER THIS COULD NOT EXPLAIN
THE OTHER FINDING OF WHY PEOPLE
WOULD FALSELY RECALL HEARING
EVIDENCE OF PREVIOUS CONVICTIONS
FOR SIMILAR CRIMES.
THIS IS IMPOSSIBLE BECAUSE THIS
WAS NEVER EVEN INFERRED IN THE
TESTIMONY.
ESSENTIALLY OUR PROPOSAL -- OUR
THEORY ON THIS BECAUSE THIS IS
REPEATED NOW FOR SEVERAL
EXPERIMENTS.
IS THAT.
IT'S HARD TO ORGANIZE ALL THIS
INFORMATION FROM A TRIAL.
THE FACT IS YOU'RE ASKING PEOPE
TO DO A LOT YOU'RE ASKING JURORS
TO ORGANIZE HUGE AMOUNTS OF
EVIDENCE IN THIS CASE IT WAS
ONLY AN HOUR LONG TO SIMULATED
TRIAL.
AND TAPE MANY TRIALS LAST DAYS
OR WEEKS.
AND INDEED PEOPLE WILL CONFLATE
SOME OF THE EVIDENCE OF THEIR
HEARING.
LEADING TO THESE MISTAKEN
PROPOSITIONS SO WITH OUR DATA
SENSUALLY SHOW IS IT NOT ONLY
THIS IS THE INFERENCE OF THE
GANG MEMBERSHIP.
BIAS FOLKS AGAINST THE
INDIVIDUAL WHICH IS I THINK
COMMONSENSE.
BUT ALSO IT APPEARS TO AFFECT
PEOPLE'S MEMORY FOR THE EVIDENCE
WHERE THEY ACTUALLY START TO
BELIEVE THAT THEIR HEARING.
TESTIMONY EXPERT DESCRIBING THE
PERSON AS COMMITTING CRIMINAL
ACTS.
EVEN HAVING CONVICTIONS FOR
SIMILAR CRIMES.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M APRIL VANDYKE
CAM OF DEPUTY PUBLIC DEFENDER IN
SAN JOAQUIN COUNTY I'M SB FIVE
SIXTEEN IT WILL FIX THESE ISSUES --
AS ILLUSTRATED BY DOCTOR EISEN'S
RESEARCH -- SB FIVE SIXTEEN WILL
RESTORE DUE PROCESS AND ENSURE A
FAIR TRIAL PROCEDURES WHEN GANG
ENHANCEMENTS AND OFFENSES ARE
CHARGE.
THIS BILL WOULD MERELY SEPARATE
THE TWO I TWO SETS OF EVIDENCE
ONE OF THE ACTUAL CHECK.
CRIME THAT IS CHARGED THERE WILL
BE A DETERMINATION OF WHETHER OR
NOT THAT INDIVIDUAL IS GUILTY OF
THE ACTUAL.
CRIME CHARGED BEFORE ANY
EVIDENCE OF GANG AFFILIATION OR
CONTACTS IS PRESENTED TO THE
JURY.
WE ALREADY HAVE PROCEDURES LIKE
THIS IN COURT ROOMS TODAY.
SOMEONE FOR EXAMPLE WHO IS
CHARGED WITH A PRIOR STRIKE
CONVICTION COURTS REGULARLY
BIFURCATE THIS EVIDENCE FIRST
THEY DETERMINE WHETHER OR NOT
THE PERSON IS CONVICTED.
ARE GUILTY EXCUSE ME OF AT THE
UNDERLYING OFFENSE AND THEN THE
JURY IS TO DETERMINE THE PRIOR
CONVICTION -- GANG EVIDENCE IS
SO HIGHLY INFLAMMATORY AND
PREJUDICIAL.
EVEN UTTERING THE WORD GANG TO A
JURY CREATES A BIAS IN THE MIND
OF THE JURORS. FOR EXAMPLE IN A
RECENT TRIAL -- THE GANG EXPERT
TESTIFIED.
THE COURT HAD TO TAKE A BREAK.
BECAUSE THE A JUROR HAD A PANIC
ATTACK.
AND THIS EXPERT WHO TESTIFIED
NOT TO ANY ACTS THAT THIS
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS ON TRIAL HAD
DONE.
BUT TO ACTS OF OTHER PEOPLE HAD
DONE YEARS AND YEARS PRIOR.
EVEN ACTS OF THIS.
OF OTHER PEOPLE WHO HAD
COMMITTED ACTS WHEN THIS PERSON
WAS A CHILD.
I'M THIS EVIDENCE IS SO
INCREDIBLY INFLAMMATORY THAT IT.
IS A DETRIMENT TO DUE PROCESS
AND FAIRNESS IN JURY TRIALS.
IMAGINE.
NOT ONLY.
EVIDENCE OF THINGS THAT YOU HAD
DONE IN YOUR PAST COMING INTO
YOUR TRIAL TO DETERMINE WHETHER
OR NOT YOU ARE GUILTY OF OFFENSE.
BUT EVIDENCE OF WHAT SOMEBODY
YOU MET POTENTIALLY ONE TIME HAD
DONE EVEN AFTER YOU HAD
INTERACTED WITH THIS INDIVIDUAL
HEINOUS CRIMES THAT THE
PROSECUTORS ARE USING -- TO
MUDDY UP THE EVIDENCE IN THIS
CASE IN IN AN INDIVIDUAL CASE
THIS BILL WILL RESTORE DUE
PROCESS IN THESE.
CASES I'M AND THAT'S WHY I URGE
THE COMMITTEE TO PASSES THROUGH.
MY POLITICS -- IS THERE ANY
ADDITIONAL -- SUPPORT.
KEEP FORGETTING I'M SHARING --
NOT.
FOR ALL THE GOOD AFTERNOON.
MY CA.GOV ON BEHALF OF THE ACLU
OF CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
THE ROLE OF THE DIGESTIVE
COALITION OPPOSED GOLD
COSPONSORED ON THIS BILL --
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
CAN MIGUEL COSPONSORED BILLS
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD PLEASE SUPPORT.
DONNA MANDEL SEPARATE CISCO
PUBLIC DEFENDER'S OFFICE PROUD
CO SPONSOR OF THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
MY NAME IS MICHAEL SURVEY TRUTH
YOUTH JUSTICE COALITION AND I
WAS HIGHLY IMPACTED BY A GANG
ENHANCEMENT.
AND IT WAS WRONG FULL AND
WITHOUT DUE PROCESS SO I ASK
THAT YOU PLEASE.
I SUPPORT THIS BILL NOW BE
PASSAGE.
LESLIE CALDWELL -- CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT.
MY NAME IS BEEN A VET HARDWOOD
SILICON VALLEY DEBUG MY HUSBAND
WAS CONVICTED ON IT CAN GET
HUNTSMAN I ASK.
THAT YOU SUPPORT THIS BILL.
KAELIN DEAN WITH THE ALLIANCE
FOR BOYS AND MEN OF COLOR OUT
POLICY LINK -- CO SPONSORING
THIS BILL AND WE ASK THAT YOU
SUPPORT THIS.
HELLO MY NAME IS JOY RODRIGUEZ
MY BROTHER WAS SENTENCED ON IN
FIVE YEARS TO LIFE WITH WITHOUT
ANY PRIOR.
CRIMINAL HISTORY AND HE WAS
HIGHLY IMPACTED BY INFLAMMATORY
GANG -- TESTIMONY IN HIS TRIAL I
URGE YOU TO PLEASE.
PLEASE [inaudible]
PASSES BILL.
IS HIGHLY IMPORTANT HE IT'S HIM
AGAIN [inaudible]
EXCEPT THROUGH [inaudible]
PRISON VISITS.
BECAUSE OF HIGHLY INFLAMMATORY
GANG TESTIMONY HAD NOTHING TO DO
WITH THE CASE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
A GOOD AFTERNOON ERIC ANDERSON
AS A REPRESENTING THE SAN
FRANCISCO KNOWING JUNCTIONS
COALITION AS A PROD COAST.
BEHALF OF INITIATE JUSTICE SAYS
IN STRONG SUPPORT. FOR MY LOOK
AT THE ANNALS FOR SALINAS
CALIFORNIA WITH ORGANIZATION TO
MEET BOTTOM FOR SUPPORT.
HELLO GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
JOSEPH AND SALAS LOS ANGELES
CALIFORNIA AREA PART OF FOR THIS
BILL.
IT WAS MY JUSTICE.
GOOD AFTERNOON ANNA JOHNSON FROM
THE NATIONAL CENTER FOR YOUTH
LAW THESE PRACTICES
DISPROPORTIONATELY HURT CHILDREN
AND USE OF COLOR AND CHILDREN TO
USE WITH DISABILITIES AND FOR
THAT REASON WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS ROSY TRAVIS WAS
SILICON VALLEY DEBUG.
MY LATE NEPHEW AT EIGHTEEN WAS
IMPACTED BY THE I'M GETTING
ENHANCEMENT SO I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL. TO LISTEN TO
TEARS WITH SILICON VALLEY DEBUG
AND I'M SUPPORT THIS BILL.
GOOD AFTERNOON DEREK MORGAN WITH
THE ELEVATOR CENTER FOR HUMAN
RIGHTS HERE IN SUPPORT.
I'M THE CENTER WITH A
CONFLICTING -- COALITION A PLACE --
TO PASS THIS BILL FOR MY MEMBERS
OF MY FAMILY HAVE BEEN AFFECTED
FOR MY TESTS -- SORRY PLACE FOR
THE YEAR.
TO PASS HIS BILL THANK YOU.
KELLY LIEU DANS WHERE WITH THE
TRANS GENDER GENDER VARIANT
INNER SIX JUSTICE PROJECT IN
SUPPORT.
GEN FOURTH WINE WITH MEDINA ORTH
ONE LP WE STRONGLY SUPPORT.
OKAY THRILL OF ACLU OF NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
LIMóN THIS FROM RESTORE JUSTICE
AND WE SUPPORT THIS BILL THANKS.
DANIEL SILVA WITH SELF AWARENESS
AND RECOVERY IN FULL SUPPORT OF
THE BILL.
THANK YOU IS THERE ANY
ADDITIONAL -- SUPPORT OF
TESTIMONY.
OKAY SAYING NINE IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
PLEASE COME FORWARD.
ARE YOU CAN SIT RIGHT THERE YEAH.
THE MICROPHONE FOR THE YOU CAN
SIT DOWN AND PUSH A BUTTON TO
TURN THE MICROPHONE YEAH.
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS MY NAME
IS RYAN COUSINS I SUPERVISE
MAJOR CRIMES WITH THE YOLO
COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
OFFICE.
THANK YOU FOR HEARING ME.
THERE'S THERE'S TWO ISSUES THAT
I'D LIKE TO ADDRESS WITH THE
BILL -- WON THE IS HOW THE BILL
AFFECTS EVIDENCE OF MOTIVE AND
THEN TO IS.
WHAT HERE -- IN TWO THOUSAND
FIVE THERE WAS A GENTLEMAN FROM
SACRAMENTO TRAVELING -- FROM A
BACHELOR PARTY THROUGH
BAKERSFIELD A AT A PART OF
BAKERSFIELD.
IT WAS OVER RUN BY GANGS AND
WHAT THIS GENTLEMAN DIDN'T
REALIZE IS THAT HE WAS WEARING
AT SHIRT THAT WAS THE COLOR.
OF A RIVAL.
GANG SET IN THAT NEIGHBORHOOD --
AND HE SIGHED CRIP MEMBER MEMBER
NAMED TED BLACK MEN APPROACHED
THE CAR IN WHICH SHE WAS
SLEEPING MOTHER GASSING UP ON
THE WAY BACK TO SACRAMENTO.
SAID I SEE YOU.
AND SHOT HIM AND KILLED HIM AND
THEN SHOT SOMEBODY ELSE IN THE
CAR BECAUSE HE WAS WEARING THE
WRONG.
SHADE OF BLUE IN THE WRONG PLACE.
I RECOGNIZE THE CONCERNED BY
THIS BILL BECAUSE GANG EVIDENCE
IS INCENDIARY NO DOUBT ABOUT IT
THAT WOULD BE A WRD I WOULD USE
TO DESCRIBE BUT IT'S ALSO HIGHLY
RELEVANT IN THESE TRIALS IF THIS
LAW WERE TO BEEN PASSED THAT DAY.
THEN TED BLACKMUN'S ATTORNEY AND
I KNOW MR EYES INSTANTLY WITH
THIS CASE BECAUSE HE TESTIFIED
IN THAT CASE -- MR BLACKMUN'S
ATTORNEY WOULD HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
STAND THERE AND SAY LADIES AND
GENTLEMAN.
MY CLIENT DIDN'T HAVE ANY REASON
TO SHOOT THIS PERSON HE HAS HE
HAS NO MOTIVE.
IS THE OLDEST AND ONE OF THE
MOST POBATIVE TYPES OF EVIDENCE
THEY WOULDN'T BE ABLE TO HEAR
ABOUT THE FACT THAT HE WAS A
GANG MEMBER THAT.
THE VICTIM WAS WEARING THE RIVAL
GANG MEMBERS COLOR AND THAT THEY
WERE IN GANG TERRITORY.
AND THE REASON WHY THIS IS SO
IMPORTANT IS BECAUSE GANG CRIMES
ARE SO SENSELESS IF THERE LOOKED
AT FROM THE PERSPECTIVE OF
REGULAR PEOPLE THEY DON'T HAVE
ANY REASON TO THEM.
WHY WAS A FIRST GRADE PREGNANT
SCHOOL TEACHER STABBED BY THREE
GANG MEMBERS IN HER DRIVEWAY ON
MARCH TWENTY FIRST OF THIS YEAR --
IT DOESN'T MAKE ANY SENSE BUT
THEN IN THE GAME CONTEXT IT CAN.
IT WOULD BE LIKE IN A MURDER
CASE WHERE A HUSBAND IS ACCUSED
OF KILLING THEIR WIFE.
KEEPING OUT THE FACT THAT THE
HUSBAND MAY HAVE TAKEN ON A LIFE
INSURANCE POLICY A WEEK PRIOR AS
EVIDENCE OF MOTIVE THE BE LIKE
KEEPING UP THAT TYPE OF EVIDENCE.
POWERFUL EVIDENCE OF MOTIVE.
AND THE THING THAT'S MOST I
THINK DANGEROUS ABOUT THIS IS AS
DOCTOR RISING ALLUDED TO THERE'S
DIFFERENT LEVELS OF EVIDENCE.
SO TAKING THE POWER AWAY FROM
THE JUDGE TO DECIDE WHETHER OR
NOT THINGS COULD OR COULDN'T
COME AND JUST LEAVES ONE ANSWER
TO EVERY GAME CASE IT COMES OUT.
EVEN I IT COULD BE VERY
PROBATIVE AND NOT OVERLY
PREJUDICIAL EVIDENCE SOMETIMES
THE LINE BETWEEN PREJUDICE AND
RELEVANCE IS SO CLOSE.
THE COMING UP WITH JUST ONE
ANSWER WHICH IS EXCLUSION IS IS
NOT GOING TO BE THE RIGHT ANSWER.
THE SECOND POINT REGARDING
BLOODIER AND I'VE EXPERIENCED
THIS AND THERE IS THE PREVIOUS
TESTIMONY ON THIS REGARDING A
JUROR'S.
I'M.
IF WE ARE NOT ALLOWED TO OF WHAT
YOU'RE ASSUMING THE TRIAL GETS
DIVIDED INTO TWO PHASES IF WE
ARE NOT ALLOWED TO WATER DEAR
THE JURY.
DURING PHASE ONE OF THE CASE AND
THESE ARE GOING TO BE VERY
SERIOUS CRIMES.
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO HEAR A WORD
ABOUT GANG.
WHEN YOU COULD HAVE?
PREVIOUS VICTIMS OF GANG CRIME
SITTING ON THE JURY YOU CAN HAVE
PEOPLE OF ALL KINDS OF BIASES
FOR THE EXACT REASON THE EARLIER
TESTIMONY STATED.
GANG EVIDENCE CAN HAVE AN EFFECT
ON PEOPLE WHICH MEANS YOU BE
PICKING JURIES FOR TRIED FOR
CRIMES AND TRIALS THAT COULD
LAST MONTHS.
HAVING NO IDEA THAT THERE
SOMEBODY HARBORING DEEP BIAS
AGAINST GANGS OR FOR GANGS
SITTING IN THE JURY IS GOING TO
RESULT IN A MISTRIAL.
IT'S GOING TO RESULT IN A HUGE
WASTE OF TAXPAYER TIME AND
DOLLARS DOING TRIALS FOR MONTHS
ONLY TO HAVE JURORS BE TOLD AT
THE BEGINNING OF PHASE TWO DO
YOU LIKE DOING A DEATH PENALTY
CASE.
AND NOT TELLING THE JURY THAT
THE CASE HAD ANYTHING TO DO WITH
THE DEATH PENALTY UNTIL THE
PNISHMENT PHASE IT WILL RESULT
IN A MISTRIAL.
SO I I THINK THAT THERE IS A LOT
TO BE SAID REGARDING GANG
ENHANCEMENTS I THINK THAT THERE
CAN BE A DIFFERENT APPROACH IS
MADE THEY CAN ADDRESS THE GANG
ISSUES.
BUT COMING UP WITH JUST A ONE
SIZE FITS ALL THE GANG EVIDENCE
GETS EXCLUDED I'D I'D
RESPECTFULLY SUBMIT WILL RESULT
IN A HIDING FROM THE TRUTH FROM
THE JURY.
AND WILL HEAL SOME BAD RESULTS.
THANK YOU FOR HEARING ME OUT
[inaudible]
OFFICE [inaudible]
BACK -- THE ISSUE OF WHAT.
MAKES.
SORRY I'M IN A ALLOW -- MY A
PUBLIC DEFENDER EXPERT -- TO TO
RESPOND TO SOME OF THE ISSUES
THAT WERE RAISED BY FIFTY EIGHT
THE YOLO COUNTY DA'S OFFICE.
I'M IN PARTICULAR CASES WE WE
DECIDE.
FAIRNESS AND DUE PROCESS THERE
IS IN FACT A JURY INSTRUCTION
THAT ADDRESSES MOTIVE I'M IT
JUST SAYS THAT THE DA IS NOT
REQUIRED TO PROVE THE MOTIVE OF
THE ACT.
MANY TIMES THERE ARE CASES WHERE
YOU CAN.
WHY DID THIS HAPPEN WHO KNOWS
BUT IF THEY?
IF THE FAX.
OF THE UNDERLYING CHARGER STRONG
ENOUGH.
THERE WILL BE A CONVICTION.
SO BRINGING IN THE INFLAMMATORY
GANG EVIDENCE.
DOES NOT.
MAKE.
A CASE THAT IS PROVED BEYOND A
REASONABLE DOUBT LESS LIKELY TO
HAVE THE CONVICTION.
MY OTHER WITNESS WANTED TO ADD
SOMETHING.
NOT HE DIDN'T THE STATE.
THE ONLY ISSUE IS THE IS THE CAR
BLUNTS DISCRETION OF THE
PROSECUTOR'S OFFICE TO INTRODUCE
THE GANG TESTIMONY THIS IS
REALLY WHAT'S AT ISSUE SO --
WITHOUT ANY POLICING WITHOUT ANY
JUDGMENT FROM THE COURT THEY
THEY ARE ALLOWED TO BRING IN.
WHAT WAS I THINK DESCRIBED
ACCURATELY AS INCENDIARY?
TESTIMONY -- AND THE AND THE
SOME RESTRICTION ON THIS
DISCRETION IS WOULD BE AWFUL
USEFUL IN ACHIEVING -- DUE
PROCESS.
OKAY I THANK YOU ANY QUESTIONS
SENATOR MITCHELL AND SENATOR
BRADFORD OR VICE VERSA.
THE QUESTION IS WAS THERE ANY
VARIANCE IN YOUR MOCK TRIALS
WHEN RACE WAS INJECTED LIKE A
WHITE GANG MEMBER PURCHASE A
BLACK OR BROWN GANG MEMBER IT
WAS DURING VARIOUS THERE'S WELL.
WE COULDN'T DO THAT BECAUSE OF
CHALCEDONIANS WHERE YOU'RE DOING
THESE THINGS VERY LIBERAL YOUNG
LATINA X. POPULATION WHERE.
BY OUR BY OUR MEASUREMENTS ABOUT
38% OF THEM HAD FRIENDS OR
FAMILY THAT WERE INVOLVED IN
GANGS IS A LIBERAL SAMPLE AS YOU
CAN GET THEM WE ARE STILL
GETTING THESE THESE VERDICTS --
BUT WE COULDN'T VERY RACE
BECAUSE OF THE RESTRICTIONS WE
ARE USING FULL DELIBERATIONS
THESE THESE STUDIES TAKE YEARS
TO DO.
SO.
OKAY ABSENT YOUR MOCK TRIALS IS
YOUR ANY IOS TO PUBLIC DEFENDER
IS THERE ANY DIFFERENCE AND
CONVICTION RATE FOR WHITE GANG
MEMBERS ARE JUST WALKING AROUND.
I'M IN MY COUNTY I HAVE NEVER --
EXPERIENCED IN MY PERSONAL USE
OR IN HEARD OF OTHERS IN MY
COUNTY WHO HAVE HAD A WHITE
INDIVIDUAL CHARGED WITH THINKING
CRIME -- I IN FACT REPRESENTED A
WHITE MAN WHO WAS.
EASILY VERIFIABLE AS A
MOTORCYCLE GANG MEMBER AND HE
WAS NOT CHARGED WITH THE GANG
ENHANCEMENT.
OKAY.
I DO YOU WANNA.
MAKE MEMBER OF THE RIVER.
THANK YOU AND WITH RESPECT TO
THE TWENTY FOR THE PUBLIC
DEFENDER -- THAT WAS HALF OF THE
JURY INSTRUCTION REGARDING
MOTIVE.
AS FAR AS SHOWING THE FDA DOES
NOT HAVE TO PROVE MOTIVE BUT
THAT INSTRUCTION ALSO SAYS THAT
THE ABSENCE OF A MOTIVE CAN ALSO
SHOW THAT THE PERSON DID NOT DO
THE CRIME.
AND AGAIN YOU WOULD BE HIDING
FROM THE JURY AND WE WOULD ALLOW
A DEFENSE ATTORNEY TO SAY
THERE'S NO REASON WHY MY CLIENT
WOULD DO SOMETHING CRAZY LIKE
GOING TO A NEIGHBORHOOD IN.
AND SHOULD UP NO MATTER WHAT THE
EVIDENCE IS SIMILAR TO THE
EVIDENCE I DESCRIBE FOR MISTER
BLACK.
THANK YOU THANK YOU AND
ARMADILLO.
THANK YOU -- THANK YOU FOR THE
BILL -- SENATOR -- WHILE I
HAVEN'T HAD EXTENSIVE EXPERIENCE
IN COURT ROOM SETTINGS IT IT
STILL STRIKES ME THAT --
PROSECUTORS AND DEFENSE
ATTORNEYS WOULD HAVE.
AND T. OF OPPORTUNITY TO EXPLAIN --
A CRIME OR A CRIME SPREE WITHOUT
USING THE TERM GANG AND BE ABLE
TO JUSTIFY.
NOT JUSTIFIED BUT BUT TO EXPLAIN
A SERIES OF CIRCUMSTANCES
WITHOUT USING THAT -- ONE
PIVOTAL ROLE WORD THAT CREATES A
A VISION AND IDEA CLEARLY -- AS
EVIDENCED BY YOUR EXPERIENCE.
I WAS JUST STRUCK BY THE LINE
THAT THE OPPOSITION STATED THAT
THE LINE BETWEEN PREJUDICE AND
RELEVANCE IS SO CLOSE.
AND IF THAT IS INDEED THE CASE
IT SEEMS TO ME THAT WE SHOULD --
ERR ON THE SIDE OF AVOIDING --
ANY PRESENT PREJUDICIAL ACTIONS
AT ALL COSTS AND SO WE HAVE TO
TILT AS FAR TOWARD RELATIVELY
POSSIBLY CAN -- AND WITH THAT
I'LL MAKE A MOTION TO SUPPORT
THE BILL.
OKAY ROOM MOTION BY SENATOR
MITCHELL AND I ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
IS THAT YOUR CLOTHES YES OKAY.
WE HAVE A MOTION AND WE HAVE A
VERY BRIEF CLOSE -- AND WILL
CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS SKINNER.
SKINNER AYE MOORLACH.
BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE JACKSON MITCHELL HI
MITCHELL ARMERO WIENER RIGHT
WIENER HIGH.
WE'LL PUT THAT ON CALL FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS.
AND BELIEVE SIX WILL HAVE THE
GAVEL BACK TO THE CHAIR
WE HAVE --
SENATOR GALGIANI HERE YOU MAY
PROCEED CENTER GALGIANI IN THIS
IS ITEM FOURTEEN SP.
FOUR FIFTY NINE AS FOR FIFTY
NINE ADDS CONSISTENCY TO THE
PENAL CODE BY APPLYING THE
EXISTING FIVE YEAR SENTENCE
ENHANCEMENT. FOR THE INFLICTION
OF GREAT BODILY INJURY DURING A
RATE TO EARN -- SPOUSAL RAPE I
ALSO WANT TO BEGIN BY ACCEPTING
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS.
UNDER CURRENT LAW A PERSON
CONVICTED OF RAPING SOMEONE WHO
ISN'T THEIR SPOUSE IS GIVEN A
FIVE YEAR SENTENCE ENHANCEMENT.
WHEN THE SURVIVOR HAS SUFFERED
GREAT BODILY INJURY UNDER ONE
FORCE VIOLENCE ARRESTS OR MENACE?
TO INTOXICATION OR UNDER
ANESTHETIC OR CONTROLLED
SUBSTANCES AND THREE UNDER THE
THREAT OF RETALIATION.
SIMILARLY A PERSON CONVICTED OF
RAPING SOMEONE WHO IS THEIR
SPOUSE IS GIVEN THE SAME FIVE
YEAR ENHANCEMENT ONLY WHEN THE
SURVIVOR.
HAS SUFFERED GREAT BODILY INJURY
AFTER ONE FORCE VIOLENCE DRESSER
MINUTES OR TWO UNDER THREAT OF
RETALIATION.
BUT NO FIVE YEAR ENHANCEMENT
EXISTS IF THE SURVIVOR SUFFERED
GREAT BODILY INJURY AT THE HANDS
OF A SPOUSE.
WHILE UNDE INTOXICATION OR
UNDER ANESTHETIC OR CONTROLLED
SUBSTANCES.
SB FOUR FIFTY NINE WOULD FIX
THIS INCONSISTENCY.
I UNDERSTAND THEIR SHARED
CONCERNS REGARDING PRISON
OVERCROWDING IN ADDING MORE
SINCE ENHANCEMENTS.
HOWEVER WE SHOULD NOT BE TELLING
VICTIMS THAT THEIR RAPE IS NOT
AS SERIOUS AS OTHERS BY GIVING
THE PERPETRATORS LAST TIME.
AS SOMEONE WHO COMMITTED THE
SAME ACT IN A DIFFERENT
SITUATION.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU IS THERE -- ANY
WITNESSES HERE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL.
ALL RIGHT ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT. ONE OF OUR E. ZERO
CIRCUMSTANCES OKAY SO.
YOUR YOU'RE TAKING THE
AMENDMENTS THAT YES YES THANKS
SO MUCH -- I IN NERO'S THE BILL
SOME BUT I THINK IT STILL SERVES
THE PURPOSE FOR WHICH YOU WERE
INTENDED.
SO WITH THAT LET ME SEE IF
THERE'S A MOTION ON THE BILL.
THANK YOU SO WE HAVE A MOTION
AND YOU CAN BRIEFLY CLOSE I
WOULD DEFINITELY ASK YOUR AYE
WERE NINE BRIEFLY HOW YOU CHOOSE.
POLICIES.
RIGHT LET'S DO A ROLL CALL ON
THAT ONE IT'S TO AS AMENDED.
MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS SKINNER HI
SKINNER AYE MOORLACH.
AT FIRST.
BRADFORD AYE JACKSON.
MORALE.
WIENER BY WIENER AYE.
THANKS SO MUCH THE BILLS ON CALL
BUT WE WILL AND WHEN WE GET FROM
YOU -- ADDITIONAL MEMBERS WILL
REOPEN IT.
AND WHAT I'M GONNA DO NOW -- I'M
SORRY POLICY CENTER GALGIANI YOU
HAVE TO BILLS.
YOU MAY PROCEED WITH YOUR NEXT
BILL.
THE FORTY BECAUSE HE HAS SOME
WITNESSES THAT HAVE.
TO YES GO AHEAD HE CAN
[inaudible]
BECAUSE OF OKAY GO AHEAD CENTER
GUARDIAN SB FIVE NINE ONE WOULD
REQUIRE HEALTH RECORDS SUCH AS
MEDICAL DENTAL AND MENTAL HEALTH
FOR INCARCERATED PERSONS. TO
FOLLOW THEM AS THEY TRANSFER
BETWEEN STATE COUNTY OR FEDERAL
FACILITIES TO ENSURE CONTINUITY
OF HEALTH CARE AND COMPLETENESS
OF HEALTH RECORDS.
ADDITIONALLY SB. FIVE NINE ONE
WOULD PROVIDE SPECIFIED STATE
PERSONNEL ACCESS TO THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION
PRISONERS AND THEIR HEALTH
RECORDS FOR THE PURPOSE OF
EVALUATION DURING PERIODS OF
TIME WHEN THE PRISONER.
DISABILITY. TO ENSURE THAT
MENTALLY DISORDERED OFFENDERS
ARE PROPERLY EVALUATED AND
TREATED PURSUANT TO PENAL CODE.
TWO NINE SIX TWO IT IS
IMPERATIVE THAT PSYCHOLOGISTS
AND PSYCHIATRISTS EMPLOYED BY
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION.
AND DEPARTMENT STATE HOSPITALS
HAVE ACCESS TO THE INMATES
HEALTH RECORDS AND TO THE INMATE.
HAVING HEALTH RECORDS
TRANSFERRED WITH THE INMATE WILL
PROVIDE BOTH CONTINUITY OF CARE
AND CONSISTENT COMPLETE RECORDS
REQUIRED FOR EVALUATION PURPOSES
WITH ME TODAY ARE THE SPONSORS.
MEMBERS OF ASKED ME FOR ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THREE WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M DOCTOR
ALLISON STANLEY I'M AN EMPLOYEE
OF THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION
I'M ALSO A MENTALLY DISORDERED
OFFENDERS EVALUATOR -- THE
STATUTE VERY SPECIFICALLY
DIRECTS US TO EVALUATE CERTAIN
INMATES PURSUANT TO PENAL CODE
TWENTY NINE SIXTY TWO WE'RE
SIMPLY ASKING FOR THE TOOLS
NECESSARY TO BE ABLE TO
ADEQUATELY EVALUATE THESE
INMATES.
WE ARE NOT IN ANY WAY ASKING TO
CHANGE THE CRITERIA BY WHICH THE
STATUTE DIRECTS US TO EVALUATE
THE INMATES.
NOR ARE WE SUGGESTING THAT ANY
ADDITIONAL INMATES.
BE REFERRED FOR MENTALLY
DISORDERED OFFENDERS VALUATIONS
THANK YOU [inaudible] FOR SURE
MEMBER COMMITTEE OF MEMBERS OF
THE AMERICAN FEDERATION OF STATE
COUNTY MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES ARE
FIRST I JUST LIKE TO THANK THE
MEMBER FOR BRINGING THIS VERY
IMPORTANT ISSUE -- FOR THIS I
KNOW HAS BEEN A LABOR.
OF LOVE FOR HER OFFICE FOR A
NUMBER OF YEARS NOW -- THIS IS
ONE FOR US THAT WAS BROUGHT TO
OUR ATTENTION THIS YEAR BY.
OUR MEMBERS AND STATE SERVICE
WHO WOULD JUST SIMPLY LIKE THAT
THE ABILITY TO HAVE THE TOOLS.
AS OUR MEMBER MENTIONED -- TO DO
THEIR JOBS EFFECTIVELY OP WITH
[inaudible]
BY.
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST NEVADA ALSO
LIKE TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
CONSULTANT FOR THEIR VERY SHARP
ANALYSIS.
ARE THERE ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF THIS
MEASURE CHAU.
COMPORT TO THE MICROPHONE.
SEEN TEARING NINE WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
LESLIE CALDWELL CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION --
I'M NOT AWARE OF ANY LAST MINUTE
AMENDMENTS ON WHEN THE SPEAK ON
ONE PIECE OF THIS.
LEGISLATION -- SB FIVE NINETY
ONE RECOMMENDS OR AMEND CIVIL
CODE SECTION FIFTY SIX POINT ONE
NO.
EXPANDING THE ABILITY OF COUNTY
CORRECTIONAL FACILITIES ETCETERA
TO SHARON INMATES MEDICAL
RECORDS WHEN HE OR SHE IS BEING
TRANSFERRED BETWEEN NAME TO
FACILITIES.
THIS IS COST EFFECTIVE AND
SENSIBLE IT'S BENEFICIAL TO BOTH
PRISONER AND PATIENT.
AND THE TAXPAYERS HOWEVER.
THE BILL'S REQUIREMENT THE
PRISONERS BEING RELEASED ON
PAROLE AND WHO SUFFER FROM A
MAKE A SEVERE MENTAL DISORDER BE
OF VALUE.
TO BUY A CD C. R. PSYCHOLOGIST
IS A HUGE EXPANSION OF SCREENING
PURSUANT TO PENAL CODE SECTION
TWENTY NINE SIXTY TWO FOR
INVOLUNTARY COMMITMENT AS
MENTALLY DISORDERED OFFENDERS.
I'LL REFER TO THEM AS EMBRYOS.
IT EXPANDS THE SCREENING TO
LOCAL JAILS MEDICAL FACILITIES
AND FEDERAL PRISONS BEFORE AN
INMATE IS RELEASED ON PAROLE.
UNDER EXISTING LAW ONLY IN MADE
SUFFERING FOR MAJOR MENTAL
ILLNESS WHO ARE IN STATE PRISON
OR ALREADY IN STATE HOSPITALS
FOR TREATMENT.
PURSUANT TO PENAL CODE SECTION
TWENTY SIX EIGHTY FOUR ARE
SCREENED FOR INVOLUNTARY.
COMMITMENT.
AND LET ME EMPHASIZE THIS IS
INVOLUNTARY COMMITMENT.
SB FIVE NINE ONES --MDO
EXPANSION IS A WASTE OF
TAXPAYERS' MONEY SHORT SIGHTED
PUBLIC POLICY AND ULTIMATELY
ENDANGERS PUBLIC SELF SAFETY.
HOSPITALIZED IN STATE HOSPITALS
OUR STATE HOSPITAL BEDS ARE
ALREADY SH IN SHORT SUPPLY AND
THERE'S CURRENTLY A WAITING LIST --
FOR OF OVER A THOUSAND PEOPLE --
FOR PERSONS WHO ARE --
INCOMPETENT TO STAND TRIAL.
THEY ARE LANGUISHING IN COUNTY
JAILS WAITING FOR BEDS IN THE
SAME HOSPITALS IN WHICH THESE.
NEW EMBRYOS WOULD BE PLACED WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST A NO VOTE.
ARE THERE OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION [inaudible]
RIGHT.
COMMENTS BY -- OR QUESTIONS BY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
OKAY -- SENATOR OF GALGIANI.
I'M I WOULD LIKE TO RESPOND TO
THE OPPOSITION IT WAS NOT OUR
INTENT TO EXPAND THE INVOLUNTARY --
COMMITMENTS AT ALL AND SO IF I
WOULD WELCOME YOUR HELP IN
HELPING US CRAFT LANGUAGE THAT
MAKES IT CLEAR THAT THAT IS NOT
OUR INTENT BECAUSE IT CERTAINLY
WAS NOT THE GOAL -- BUT I WOULD
VERY MUCH WELCOME YOUR HELP IN
AND HOPE YOU WILL WE WOULD LIKE
TO WORK WITH THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR RIVAL.
I'M THANK YOU CENTER GALGIANI --
FOR HATCH EXPRESSING A
WILLINGNESS TO WORK WITH OUR
PUBLIC MANNERS OFFICE IN TERMS
OF THEIR SITUATION IN TERMS OF
THEIR OPPOSITION -- THE OUR READ
OF THE BILL.
WAS THAT IT IS NOT QUITE AS
BROAD AS THE ASSOCIATION FELT
BUT CERTAINLY MRS.
WHICH IS WHY ARE COMMITTEES
RECOMMENDING I ON IT.
AND AS ALWAYS THE EIGHT WE KNOW
THAT.
I AT INTERFERE INTERPRETATIONS
IN OF LANGUAGE OF LEGAL
DOCUMENTS CAN VERY AND IT COULD
BE THAT ARE READ IS IS.
TIME.
WHATEVER IS THAT.
THE ASSOCIATION'S READ IS MORE
ACCURATE AND THIS IS PART OF THE
PROCESS OF A BILL MOVING THROUGH
THERE WILL BE OTHER -- THE OTHER
ALL EYES ON IT AND YOUR
EXPRESSION OF WILLINGNESS TO
WORK WITH THE ASSOCIATION CAN --
HELP US IF THERE IS A PROBLEM.
AND I DON'T MEAN IF THERE IS
FIGHT. TO DRESS ANY OF THOSE SO
WITH THAT.
WE WILL -- TAKE THE ROLL CALL ON
THE MOTION.
MOTIONS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS SKINNER HI
SKINNER I'M MORE LOCKED.
BRADFORD. FOR AYE JACKSON.
MORRELL.
MORRELL AYE WIENER.
WIENER AYE.
GREAT BILLS ON CALL.
I'M IN NOW THANK YOU SO MUCH --
CENTER GALGIANI WE'RE NOW GOING
TO GO -- TO SB FORTY SENATOR
WINNERS BECAUSE HE IS -- HAS.
POSSIBILITY OF LOSING SOME OF
HIS WITNESSES WHICH WE WOULD NOT
WANT TO HAVE HAPPEN.
SINCE THEY PRIDE BEEN HERE ALL
DAY.
SO WE'LL GO TO SB FORTY AND THEN
WE STILL HAVE -- ON THE DOCKET --
UNTIL BY.
ENTER STONE A BILL BY SENATOR
GLACIER A BILL BY SENATOR JONES
AND THEN A COUPLE BY SENATOR
WIENER BUT IF THERE ARE AUTHORS
IN THE ROOM SENATOR WINNER WHEN
YOU.
THIS WILL GO TO THEIR ALL RIGHT.
BUT YOU MAY PROCEED ON SB
[inaudible]
FORTY SIX OKAY
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR -- FIRST I
WANT TO THANK THE CHAIR IN THE
COMMITTEE STAFF. FOR HELP ON THE
AMENDMENTS -- TO THIS BILL AND
I'M HAPPY TO ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS.
I SENATE BILL FORTY IS -- AN
EFFORT TO ENSURE.
THAT THE HOUSING CONSERVATORSHIP
PILOT PROGRAM.
THAT THE LEGISLATURE PASSED LAST
YEAR CAN BE IMPLEMENTED -- IN
ORDER TO SAVE LIVES OF PEOPLE
WHO ARE LITERALLY.
DYING ON OUR STREETS.
THE BILL MAKES IMPORTANT
MODIFICATIONS.
ARE TO THE HOUSING
CONSERVATORSHIP PROGRAM TO MAKE
IT MORE EFFECTIVE AND TO ENSURE
A STRONG I DO PROCESS
PROTECTIONS AROUND THE ON IT SO
IT'S CLEAR STANDARDS FOR
INITIATING A CONSERVATORSHIP FOR
RENEWING THE CONSERVATORSHIP --
AND FOR TERMINATING THE
CONSERVATORSHIP.
RECENT AMENDMENTS REQUIRE --
NOTIFYING POTENTIAL
CONSERVATIVES -- AT THEIR SEVEN
SEVEN FIFTY ONE FIFTY IN A
TWELVE MONTH PERIOD.
BUT THEY WILL BE POTENTIALLY
ELIGIBLE FOR THE PROGRAM AFTER
IN A FIFTY ONE FIFTY BECAUSE THE
BILL ONLY APPLIES IF SOMEONE HAS
BEEN. FIFTY ONE FIFTY EIGHT
TIMES I IN A TWELVE MONTH PERIOD.
THE BILL REQUIRES PARTICIPATING
COUNTIES TO MAKE CONCERTED
EFFORTS TO EMPLOY VOLUNTARY
SERVICES -- TO HELP A
CONSERVATIVE E..
OF LONG BEFORE -- THAT E..
FIFTY ONE FIFTY BECAUSE
VOLUNTARY SERVICES ARE OF COURSE
ALWAYS THE PREFERRED ROUTE.
BUT UNFORTUNATELY THEY DON'T
WORK FOR EVERYONE.
I THE AMENDMENTS ALSO -- CREATE
THE OPTION FOR COUNTY TO PURSUE.
A TWENTY THE TWENTY EIGHT DAY
TEMPORARY CONSERVATORSHIP.
I AFTER THE A FIFTY ONE FIFTY SO
COUNTY WILL BE OPTION INSTEAD OF
GOING RIGHT TO THE LONGER
CONSERVATORSHIP.
I TO START WITH A TWENTY EIGHT
THE CONSERVATORSHIP.
ARE WHICH COULD BE A BETTER
OPTION FOR THE INDIVIDUAL.
I SB FORTY ALSO CLARIFIES THAT.
THE LEGAL PROCESS FOR
CONSIDERING THE USE OF
ASSISTANCE OUTPATIENT TREATMENT --
I TO ENSURE A DIET A. O. T. I
HAS TO BE EMPLOYED FOR PEOPLE
FOR WHOM IT IS MEDICALLY.
APPROPRIATE AND THAT WE'RE NOT
FORCING OUR COUNTIES TO SEEK A
O. T..
OFFER PEOPLE FOR WHOM IT IS
MEDICALLY.
INAPPROPRIATE.
AND THEN THE RECENT AMENDMENTS
ALSO REQUIRE THE CONSERVATIVES
OFFICE TO SUBMIT A STATUS REPORT
OF EACH CONSERVATIVE THE TO THE
CORE EVERY SIXTY DAYS -- SO
THERE IS -- A REGULAR CHECK AND
AND THE POTENTIAL TERMINATE THE
CONSERVATORSHIP NO LONG --
PROGRAM.
I WANT TO BE VERY CLEAR THIS IS
A PILOT PROGRAM.
WE KNOW FROM EXPERIENCE THAT THE
CURRENT CONSERVATORSHIP LAWS.
PRE SB TEN FORTY FIVE FREE WHAT
WE DID LAST YEAR ARE NOT WORKING.
FOR A SMALL SUBSET OF OUR
POPULATION WHO WERE SEVERELY
MENTALLY ILL SEVERELY DRUG
ADDICTED DYING ON OUR STREETS
INCAPABLE.
OF ACCEPTING VOLUNTARY SERVICES.
WE ALL SUPPORT VOLUNTARY
SERVICES BUT FOR SOME PEOPLE
THEY ARE NOT CAPABLE OF
ACCEPTING THEM I AND IT IS NOT
PROGRESSIVE OR COMPASSIONATE OR
HUMANE -- TO ALLOW PEOPLE TO DIE
ON OUR STREETS WHEN YOU TO HELP
PEOPLE.
GET THEM HEALTHY GIVEN THE
HOUSING THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL IS
ABOUT MAKING SURE THAT.
SB TEN FORTY FIVE FROM LAST YEAR
CAN WORK -- SO -- WITH ME --
TODAY -- OR DR GRANT COLFAX WHO
IS THE NEWLY APPOINTED DIRECTOR
OF PUBLIC HEALTH FOR THE CITY OF
SAN FRANCISCO.
AND CAPTAIN SIMON PAYING FROM
THE SAN FRANCISCO FIRE
DEPARTMENT WHO HAS SUBSTANTIAL
EXPERIENCE RESPONDING. TO PEOPLE
WHO ARE IN CRISIS ON OUR STREETS.
THANK YOU YOU MAY PROCEED.
THANK YOU I'VE GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR SKINNER AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS I'M DR GRANT COLFAX
DIRECTOR OF PUBLIC HEALTH IN THE
CITY AND COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO.
AND ON BEHALF OF MERE BREED AND
THE CITY AND COUNTY OF SAN
FRANCISCO.
I THANK YOU ALL FOR HEARING THIS
BILL AND I WANT TO THANK SENATOR
SCOTT WEINER FOR HIS CONTINUED
SUPPORT.
AND LEADERSHIP IN CALLING
ATTENTION TO THIS IMPORTANT
ISSUE.
AS YOU KNOW WELL WE HAVE A
HOMELESS CRISIS ON OUR STREETS.
WE ALSO HAVE A MENTAL HEALTH
CRISIS IN A SUDDEN SHE'S CRISIS
ON OUR STREETS AND ACROSS OUR
STATE.
AND OUR COUNTRY.
AND THERE ARE MANY INDIVIDUALS
HUNDREDS OF INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
SUFFERING FROM A COMBINATION OF
HOMELESSNESS MENTAL HEALTH AND
SUBSTANCE USE ISSUES.
AND AS YOU'VE HEARD IN NO SB
TENT FORTY FIVE WHICH WAS SIGNED
BY GOVERNOR BROWN LAST YEAR.
CREATES AN OPTIONAL DO
CONSERVATORSHIP TO SERVE OUR
MOST ACTORS RESIDENTS THOSE
EXPERIENCING THE COMBINED IN
HEAVY WEIGHT.
OF CHRONIC HOMELESSNESS SERIOUS
MENTAL ILLNESSES AND SUBSTANCE
USE DISORDERS. FOR PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING JUST ONE OF THESE
ISSUES IT IS CHALLENGING TO HELP
THEM BUT THE COMBINATION OF ALL
THREE PRESENTS UNIQUE
COMPLICATED CHALLENGES.
THE REALITY IS A SAD REPEATING
CYCLE WHERE PEOPLE WHO ARE
LIVING ON THE STREET.
IN AND OUT OF THE EMERGENCY
ROOMS AND IN SOME CASES.
AND IN MANY CASES BEING SENT TO
JAIL OVER AND OVER AND OVER
AGAIN.
THIS IS DAMAGING TO THEIR
PHYSICAL AND EMOTIONAL HEALTH
AND OVERALL WELL BEING.
THIS IS AN ISSUE WE ARE
STRUGGLING WITH EVERY DAY TO
ADDRESS AT THE LOCAL LEVEL.
THERE ARE NUMBER OF PEOPLE IN
SAN FRANCISCO WHO WE'RE TRYING
OUR BEST TO HELP BUT OUR CURRENT
TOOLS ARE INADEQUATE.
THE STATUS QUO DOES NOT MEET THE
NEEDS OF EITHER THE INDIVIDUAL
OR THE COMMUNITY IT DOES NOT
ADDRESS THE ROOT CAUSES OF PLAY.
IT ALLOWS PEOPLE'S CONDITIONS TO
DETERIORATE AND THE PLACE IS A
TREMENDOUS FINANCIAL STRAIN ON
CITY RESOURCES.
SB FORTY HELPS ADDRESS A
CRITICAL NEED IN SAN FRANCISCO.
BECAUSE IT OFFERS US A WAY TO
HELP SOME OF THOSE MOST
VULNERABLE RESIDENTS.
IN THE LAST NUMBER OF MONTHS AS
WE STARTED TO PREPARE FOR
IMPLEMENTATION OF SB TEN FORTY
FIVE WE'VE IDENTIFIED A FEW
AREAS OF THAT BILL THAT NEED
SOME MODIFICATION TO ENSURE WE
CAN SERVE THE POPULATION THAT WE
INTENDED TO SERVE UNDER.
TEN FORTY FIVE SB FORTY VERY
IMPORTANTLY INCLUDES THOSE
MODIFICATIONS SB FORTY DOES NOT
EXPAND THE POPULATIONS OF
INDIVIDUALS ELIGIBLE FOR HOUSING
CONSERVATORSHIP IN SAN FRANCISCO.
THAT NUMBER WOULD REMAIN BETWEEN
FIFTY AND SEVENTY FIVE RATHER.
THIS BILL REINFORCES THE
ORIGINAL INTENT OF TEN FORTY
FIVE THERE'S A QUOTE POPULATION
OF INDIVISIBLE INDIVIDUALS WHO
WE CAN'T HELP TODAY.
WE WANT TO HELP THROUGH A
HOUSING CONSERVATORSHIP AND SB
FORTY WILL ENSURE THAT WE REACH
THEM.
AS DRAFTED TODAY. TEN FORTY FIVE
WOULD ALLOW US TO HELP FEWER
THAN FIVE INDIVIDUALS COMPARED
TO THE FIFTY OR SEVENTY FIVE SB
FORTY WOULD ALLOW US TO REACH.
OUR CITY HAS A LONG HISTORY OF
PROVIDING COMPASSIONATE CARE AND
NEITHER I NOR MERE PRE TAKE
LIGHTLY THE IDEA OF LIMITING
ANYONE CIVIL LIBERTIES.
WE SHOULD ALWAYS TRY TO HELP
PEOPLE IN THE LEAST RESTRICTIVE
WAY IT IS OUR MORAL OBLIGATION.
BUT WHAT PEOPLE DON'T ACCEPT
HELP AND THE ALTERNATIVE IS THAT
THEY DIE ON OUR STREETS OR GO TO
JAIL IT IS OUR OBLIGATION TO
STEP IN.
WE MUST NOT TURN OUR BACKS ON
THOSE IN NEED.
I AM HERE BECAUSE WE HAVE THE
CHANCE TO MAKE A MEANINGFUL
DIFFERENCE BY PROVIDING MUCH
NEEDED SERVICES TO OUR HARDEST
REACH POPULATIONS.
ON AND ON A PERSONAL AND
PROFESSIONAL NOTE AS AN INTERN
IN RESIDENT AT WHAT IS NOW
SOCCER BURKE SAN FRANCISCO
GENERAL HOSPITAL.
THERE WAS LITTLE WE COULD DO FOR
PEOPLE ON THE STREET SUFFERING
FROM MENTAL HEALTH AND SUBSTANCE
USE DISORDERS.
NOW WE HAVE SO MANY MORE TOOLS.
AND THIS BILL WILL ALLOW US TO
ACCESS THE TOOLS IN OUR TOOLBOX
TO HELP THE PEOPLE MOST IN NEED.
THIS BILL HELPS OUR SYSTEMS
CATCH UP WITH THE SCIENCE.
AND MOTHER IS THE LIVES OF ALSO
WHAT AND WHETHER IT HELPS THE
LIVES.
OF THOSE WHAT AND WHETHER IT
HELPS THE LIFE OF ONE SAN
FRANCISCAN OR MANY IT IS MY DUTY
AS DIRECTOR OF PUBLIC HEALTH TO
HELP.
WITH THIS COMMITTEE SUPPORT.
WE LOOK FOR TO DOING JUST THAT I
WANT TO THANK HER SKINNER
SKINNER AND I WANT TO THINK THIS
ENTIRE COMMITTEE FOR YOUR TIME
AND CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
SENATORS MY NAME IS SIMON BANG
AND I WORK IN A SAN FRANCISCO
FIRE DEPARTMENT UNIT THAT
RESPONSE TO FREQUENT NINE ONE
ONE USERS.
SHEPHERDING PEOPLE TO SHELTER
DETOX TREATMENT.
MENTAL HEALTH CARE IN SUPPORT OF
HOUSING -- THOSE DEPENDENT ON
NINE ONE ONE FOR THEIR DAILY
SURVIVAL A SMALL NUMBER.
OF THOSE THAT I KNOW I ESTIMATE
SIX INDIVIDUALS.
HAVE SUCH SEVERE SUBSTANCE USE
THIS ORDER AND MENTAL
DISORGANIZATION.
THAT THEY CANNOT PERFORM ROUTINE
ACTS OF DAILY LIVING. ONE MATH
USER SITS IN HIS WHEELCHAIR AND
EXCREMENT ALL DAY.
SOMETIMES HE WILL TRY TO GET OUT
OF HIS WHEELCHAIR TO DEFECATE IN
THE OPEN.
FIRST RESPONDERS FIND HIM
COVERED IN FECES.
UNABLE TO PULL UP HIS PANTS AND
GET BACK IN HIS WHEELCHAIR.
THESE INDIVIDUALS WILL USE UNTIL
THEY ARE INCOME PATH
INCAPACITATED STUMBLE OUT OF AN
E. R. SOON AS THEY CAN WALK OR
ROLL OUT IN A WHEELCHAIR AND YOU
SOME MORE. ONE PERSON ACTIVATED
NINE ONE ONE OVER TWO HUNDRED
TIMES LAST YEAR.
WHILE IT IS TRUE THERE ARE NOT
SUFFICIENT QUALITY SERVICES FOR
ALL OF THE PEOPLE WITHOUT HOMES
IN SAN FRANCISCO. FOR THE
POPULATION PRIORITIZE BY THIS
LAW.
THE SERVICE IS OFFERED.
WE CASE CONFERENCE WITH CLINICAL
PROVIDERS AND OFFER SHELTER.
EMERGENCY HOUSING WITH
SUPPORTIVE CARE.
FOOD.
THERAPY DRUG TREATMENT.
IT IS CONTINUOUSLY REFUSED. ONE
OF THESE INDIVIDUALS HAS BEEN
HOSPITALIZED FOR LIFE
THREATENING CONDITIONS FIFTEEN
TIMES SINCE JANUARY.
YET HE INSISTS ON LEAVING SO HE
CAN USE METH AND HEROIN.
WE ARE TOLD THAT THEY CAN'T KEEP
HIM AGAINST HIS WILL.
HE HAS BEEN RELEASED AND RE
ADMITTED THE VERY SAME DAY.
ADMITTED JANUARY SECOND TO
RELEASED JANUARY SECOND ADMITTED
JANUARY THIRD RELEASE JANUARY
SEVENTH.
ADMITTED AGAIN ON JANUARY
SEVENTH RELEASE JANUARY EIGHTH
ADMITTED JANUARY NINTH.
YOU GET THE PICTURE.
HOW ARE WE ALLOWING THIS
WRETCHEDNESS TO CONTINUE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS SYLVIA
SOLUTION ON BEHALF OF THE CITY
OF SANTA MONICA OVER IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE MEASURE AND WE
THINK SENATOR WIENER FOR HIS
CONTINUED WORK ON THIS THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MICHELLE WRASSE
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
TRAVEL ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITE.
WHERE THEY HAVE? TO AT THE DESK
THANK YOU.
WE MAY HAVE YOU BACK IF THERE'S
QUESTIONS.
HER CHILD DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA UNFORTUNATELY WE
REMAIN OPPOSED TO THIS BILL --
WE WON'T RELITIGATE TO THE
COURSE OF SB TEN FORTY FIVE
CERTAINLY AS THAT PASSED THE
THIS -- LEGISLATURE LAST YEAR
HOWEVER A CRITICAL PART OF SB
TEN FORTY FIVE FROM OUR
PERSPECTIVE AND AS IT WORKED ALL
THE WAY THROUGH THE LEGISLATURE
WAS THE PROVISION.
THAT BEFORE USING THE
CONSERVATORSHIP THAT WOULD BE
AUTHORIZED BY THIS BILL THERE
HAD TO BE AN OFFER OF A T. IN
THE FIRST.
PLACE THAT'S WHAT SB FORTY NOW
DOES.
IT REMOVES THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
THE VOLUNTARY THE OFFER A
VOLUNTARY SERVICES.
AND ALL OF THE SERVICES THAT
COME ALONG WITH THAT THE
WRAPAROUND SERVICES THE
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING IS -- IS NOT
NECESSARILY AVAILABLE -- UNDER
THIS BILL WHICH I THINK IT WAS
THE INTENT WAS TO ACTUALLY AND
DO -- THAT PROVISION SO WE
CERTAINLY HAVE -- LOOKED AT THE
NOW THE FACT THAT WITH THAT OUT
THE THE AMENDMENTS THAT WERE
MADE IN THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
WHICH I THINK WERE SIGNIFICANT
AND WE SUPPORTED AS THOSE --
WERE MADE IN THE BILL HOWEVER
LEFT.
TO A VERY IMPORTANT PROVISION --
AND FLAW WE THINK IN THAT IN
THAT WAS THEN IT SINCE THERE WAS
NO LONGER A MATTER OF RIGHT FOR
THE REFERRAL FOR A T. SERVICES.
THERE WAS NOW THERE IS NOW IN
THAT PLACE TO READ THE ABILITY
FOR THE DEPARTMENT AND IS
ESSENTIALLY A BUREAUCRAT MAKING
THE DETERMINATION OF WHETHER A
OR T. WOULD BE APPROPRIATE OR
NOT.
NOW IF I DID HEAR SOME
AMENDMENTS I HAVEN'T SEEN THOSE
AMENDMENTS YET BUT IT SOUNDED
LIKE THAT THOSE WERE ADDRESSING --
THAT PROVISION AND WE THINK THAT
WOULD BE VERY HELPFUL -- TO TO
THE BILL -- I JUST WANNA KNOW
ONE OTHER PIECE THAT WE THINK IS
STILL A SIGNIFICANT PROBLEM IF
YOU READ THE SAN FRANCISCO
CHRONICLE IN THE LAST WEEK OR SO --
THEY DETAILED THE IN ONE REPORT
WOULD ESSENTIALLY WAS DESCRIBED
AS A BROKEN BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
SYSTEM.
IN IN SAN FRANCISCO.
AND THE LOSS OF THE LICENSED
RESIDENTIAL FACILITIES SO
SIGNIFICANTLY -- AND SO WHAT WE
AND THEY NOTED THE FACT THAT
THERE WOULD BE MORE --
CONSERVATORSHIP COMING INTO THE
SYSTEM YET WE'RE IN A SYSTEM
THAT CAN'T SUPPORT -- THESE
ADDITIONAL CONSERVATORSHIP SO
FOR THAT REASON WE WE REMAIN
OPPOSED TO THE BILL [inaudible]
THERE.
ENTER MEMBERS MICHELLE CAPITA
WITH THE SERVICE EMPLOYEES
INTERNATIONAL UNION AND WE HAVE
AN OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
POSITION ON THIS BILL -- ARE WE
HAVE WORKED WITH THE UTHOR --
AND THE SPONSORS ALL ALONG LAST
YEAR AND THIS YEAR AND BECAUSE
WE REPRESENT PUBLIC GUARDIANS
AND CONSERVATIVES WE REPRESENT
FRONTLINE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
WORKERS WHO STRADDLE BOTH THE
MENTAL HEALTH AND THE S. U. D.
SIDES OF THE EQUATION.
AND OUR MEMBERS HAVE.
A LOT OF EXPERIENCE WORKING WITH
THESE POPULATIONS THEY KNOW WHAT
WORKS AND WHAT HASN'T THEY HAVE
CONSERVE PEOPLE THEY'VE SEEN
WILL COME IN THE DOORS OF
CONSERVATORSHIP -- GET BETTER AT
TIMES THEY'VE ALSO NOTED TO US
IN PART OF THE REASON FOR
OPPOSITION HAS BEEN THAT WITH
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDERS -- IT IS
VERY HARD TO IMPOSSIBLE TO
COMPEL.
TREATMENT FORCE TREATMENT WHEN
AN INDIVIDUAL IS NOT READY FOR
RECOVERY.
LOCKED BEDS FOR SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDERS DO NOT EXIST -- AND SO
WHEN WE STEPPED DOWN IT IS OFTEN
THE CASE SOMEONE HAS NOT CLEARED
UP ON THE MENTAL HEALTH SIDE.
AND WE INTRODUCE THEM TO
SUBSTANCE USE RECOVERY SERVICES --
IF THEY'RE NOT READY THEY WILL
LEAVE THOSE FOR A STEP DOWN
FACILITIES AND SO.
WHAT WE ARE EMBARKING ON HERE BY
CREATING A NEW CONSERVATORSHIP
THAT IS SPECIFICALLY TARGETED AT
A COAL OCCURRING -- POPULATION
WITH BOTH A CD AND MENTAL
ILLNESS IS THAT WE'RE GOING TO
BE EXPERIMENTING WITH WHAT DOES
IT LOOK LIKE TO TARGET A
CONSERVATORSHIP THAT HAS AS ITS
BASIS BOTH CONDITIONS.
AND WE BELIEVE THAT IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT TO STUDY THIS QUESTION
SO ONE OF OUR REQUESTED
AMENDMENTS IS FOR A THOROUGH
EVALUATION TO SEE WHAT ARE THE
SERVICES THAT ARE PROVIDED TO
THIS POPULATION WHILE THEY'RE IN
THIS CONSERVATORSHIP.
HOW DO THEY FAIR IN THE END --
BUT WE KNOW THAT COMPULSORY DRUG
TREATMENT IN OTHER REGIONS OF
THE COUNTRY AND AROUND THE WORLD
HAVE HAD OFTEN SOME NEGATIVE
WERE NOT READY. TO GET CLEAN --
THEY OFTEN GO RIGHT BACK TO
USING AND ARE UP TO FORTY TIMES
MORE LIKELY TO DIE WITHIN TWO
WEEKS OF RELEASE -- THAT IS
SIGNIFICANT WE KNOW THAT -- FOR
MATHEMATICS THEIR PSYCHOSIS CAN
GET.
DEEPENED AND SO I'M ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT WE LIKE TO SEE IS
HOW DO PEOPLE FARE AND WHAT ARE
THEY GETTING WHEN THEY'RE IN
THIS SPECIAL KIND OF
CONSERVATORSHIP THAT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT WE ALSO BELIEVE IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT TO FRONT LOAD.
ACCESS TO THOSE VOLUNTARY
SERVICES OUR MEMBERS SAY THAT
WHEN WE OFFER WHEN WE PROVIDE WE
REALLY ENGAGE FOLKS AND DEVELOP
A RELATIONSHIP OVER TIME. TO GET
THEM INTO VOLUNTARY SERVICES
FOLKS ARE MORE OFTEN THAN NOT
WILLING TO DO TO AVAIL
THEMSELVES BUT IT TAKES TIME.
IT'S NOT A QUICK FIX AND IT'S
ALSO NOT A SILVER BULLET MANY OF
THESE INDIVIDUALS DESPITE OUR
BEST EFFORTS AND EVEN WITH
CONSERVATORSHIP WILL BE BACK --
IT'S JUST THAT HARD THAT IS THE
NATURE OF RECOVERY AND SO WE
URGE YOU TO WORK WITH US.
AND YOU HAVE HER TO CONTINUE TO
REFINE THIS POLICY AND REALLY TO
LEARN FROM IT TO SEE OVER TIME
IF THIS REALLY IS A GOOD
SOLUTION FOR THIS POPULATION
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
LESLIE CALDWELL CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION.
AS A LAWYER WHO WORK.
A NUMBER OF YEARS ON MENTAL
HEALTH CALENDARS AND ON THE
CONSERVATORSHIP CALENDARS -- AND
WITH GREAT RESPECT TO THE
SENATOR IN THE COMMITTEE -- I
HAVE TO SAY THAT IT IS WRONG TO
USE CONSERVATORSHIP SAYS IN THE
ANSWER TO OUR HOUSING CRISIS.
SUBSTANCE ABUSE AND MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES.
THIS BILL SUGGEST THAT DEPRIVING
PEOPLE OF THEIR LIBERTY BY WAY
OF CONSERVATORSHIP ISN'T
APPROACH WE SHOULD TAKE.
IT DOES NOT ADDRESS THE
HOPELESSNESS OF THE LACK OF
HOUSING FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS
PEOPLE NOR DOES IT PROVIDE
FUNDING FOR THE ADDITIONAL NEED.
OF MENTAL HEALTH TREATMENT
INVOLUNTARY IN A CON
CONSERVATORSHIP.
OR SERVANTS OF USE TREATMENT.
UNDER GOVERNOR REAGAN THE STATE
HOSPITALS WERE ESSENTIALLY EMPTY
AND PERSONS WERE SENT TO THEIR
COMMUNITIES FOR TREATMENT AND
CARE.
THIS IS BOTH GOOD AND BAD IT WAS
GOOD IN THAT IT MITIGATED THE
OVER USE -- OF THE HOSPITALS IN
THE ABUSE WITHIN THE MIDDLES
HOSPITALS.
THE BAND IS THAT THE MONEY FOR
THE COMMUNITIES TO PROVIDE THIS
CARE HAS DIMINISHED WELL THE
NEED HAS EXPLODED.
BETWEEN THE LACK OF ADEQUATE
FUNDING THE GROWING ISSUES OF
SUBSTANCE ABUSE AND THE HOUSING
CRISIS WE NOW HAVE MAJOR
PROBLEMS ON OUR HANDS.
PROBLEMS THAT ARE NOT ADDRESSED
LIKE STAND EXPANDING
CONSERVATORSHIP.
I WOULD LIKE TO APPOINT ANOTHER
ISSUE WITH THIS BILL.
THIS IS -- MISDEMEANORS HELD IN
IN LOCAL JAILS WHEN THEY ARE
FOUND TO BE INCOMPETENT TO STAND
TRIAL.
THE LINE THE SITUATION AS IT
DOES IN SB FORTY CALLS FOR THE
LEAST RESPECT DESTRUCTIVE
PLACEMENT.
WHAT THAT MEANS -- IN MANY
COUNTIES IS THEY SAID IN JAIL
FOR THE DURATION OF THEIR TERM
WAITING FOR A BED IN THE STATE
HOSPITAL.
THAT LIST THEY ARE ON LAST THEY
SIT IN JAIL BECAUSE THERE ARE NO
LESS RISK GIVE PLACEMENTS FOR
THEM.
DUE TO THE FAILURE FUNDING.
BUT THE INCOMPETENT TO STAND
TRIAL FELONS THE STATE HAS
CHOSEN TO TREAT THEM IN THE
JAILS INSTEAD OF THE STATE
HOSPITALS FOR THE LEAST RESTRICT
STRICT OF STE.
WE HAVE TURNED OUR COUNTY JAILS
IN THE MENTAL HEALTH
INSTITUTIONS.
AND ISSUE WHICH MOST OF US HAVE
BEEN AWARE OF FOR MANY YEARS.
MENTAL HEALTH PLACEMENTS UNDER
CONSERVATORSHIP CAN BE EVEN MORE
LIMITING OF LIBERTY THEN THE
JAILS CONSERVATORSHIP AN
INVOLUNTARY CIVIL COMMITMENTS
ARE POWERFUL TOOLS.
USE OF THEM MUST BE TIGHTLY
CONTROLLED.
EXPANDING THEM WOULD ALWAYS GIVE
IT SHOULD ALWAYS GIVE US PAUSE.
SB FORTY TAKES AN UNTESTED NEW
FORM OF CONSERVATORSHIP AND
MODIFIES IT IN WAYS THAT ARE
COUNTERPRODUCTIVE AND
POTENTIALLY DANGEROUS.
WELL WE FULLY SUPPORT ENDING
HOMELESSNESS.
DEALING WITH -- SUBSTANCE ABUSE
AND BETTER TREATING MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES.
WE BELIEVE THERE'S A LOT OF WILL
GOALS THE EXPANSION OF
CONSERVATORSHIP ARE NOT AN
APPROPRIATE VEHICLE TO ACHIEVE
THEM AND CPD A RESPECTFULLY
URGES A NO VOTE.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
GOOD AFTERNOON GENTLER ON BEHALF
OF WESTERN CENTER AND ONLINE
POVERTY IN OPPOSITION AS WELL.
ENTER MEMBERS KEVIN BACK OF
AMERICAN CIVIL LIBERTIES UNION
OR CALIFORNIA ALSO IN OPPOSITION
LOOKING FORWARD TO SEEING
MINUTES [inaudible]
MANY OTHERS.
ALL RIGHT -- COMMENT BY.
THE AMENDMENTS THAT ARE TAKEN.
VERY AGREED TO TAKE IN OUR
CLARIFYING THAT THE COURT MUST
MAKE SUBSTANTIVE DETERMINATION
AS TO WHETHER THE PERSON IS
INELIGIBLE FOR OUTPATIENT
TREATMENT OR WOULD NOT BENEFIT
FROM IT.
AND ALSO SPECIFYING THE
VOLUNTARY TREATMENT CAST HAVE
BEEN OFFERED AT THE EARLIEST
TIME POSSIBLE TO PREVENT
WORSENING OF THE PERSON'S
CONDITION SO IT THOSE ARE
AMENDMENTS BETTER.
THE AUTHOR HAS TAKEN.
I'M CENTER BRADFORD YES AS CO
AUTHOR.
GEN FORTY FIVE I'M TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND TH.
THE NEED FOR THE VERSES TO PILOT
PROGRAM THAT WE ALREADY HAD IN
PLACE.
SO THE DE THE REASON THAT WE
INTRODUCED THIS BILL THERE THERE
WERE SOME **** THE BILL OVER
CLARIFICATIONS AND CLEAN UP AS
OFTEN HAPPENS.
AS YOU KNOW HIM WHEN LEGISLATION
HAPPENS.
BUT THE CORE OF A AND I HAVE TO
SAY I JUST I HAVE TO TAKE ISSUE
WITH.
AS I SAT UP AND LISTENED TO THE
OPPOSITION IS ARE ALL GROUPS
THAT I WORK WITH ALL THE TIME
AND CARRY BILLS FOR A TIMES
ETCETERA.
ON I HEARD A LOT OF TALK ABOUT.
ABOUT A BILL THAT IS NOT THIS
BILL.
I SO TO SAY THAT THIS BILL IS
REMOVING THE AIR WITH.
REQUIREMENT.
IS TO IS JUST INACCURATE. TO THE
WHAT HAPPENED WAS LAST YEAR
AFTER THE BILL CAME OUT OF THIS
COMMITTEE AND SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS.
AND A MEMO WAS PUT IN AN AT AND
AS WE ALL KNOW AND AND
APPROPRIATIONS ONE OF ALL KINDS
OF SUSPEND SOMETIMES AMENDMENTS.
I MEAN THAT YOU ARE SEEING FOR
THE FIRST TIME WHEN THEY'RE
BEING PUT INTO THE BILL AND YOU
DON'T HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
GIVE FEEDBACK ON AND MEMBER ONE
IN THE BILL.
SAYING THAT THAT YOU MUST SEE A
T..
EVERYONE IF YOU'RE CONSIDERING
THEM BEFORE YOU SEE SERVICE.
AND THE PROBLEM WITH THAT IS
THAT FOR SOME OF THESE PEOPLE A.
O. T. IS PERFECTLY APPROPRIATE
AND WE WOULD DO THAT ANYWAY.
BUT THERE ARE PEOPLE. FOR WHOM
A. O. T. IS MEDICALLY
INAPPROPRIATE.
AND SO WHAT THAT AMENDMENT DID
WAS PUT.
PUBLIC OFFICIALS IN A POSITION
OF POTENTIALLY FILING FRIVOLOUS
A. O. T. PETITION SEEKING AOTI
FOR PEOPLE. FOR WHOM THEY KNOW
IT'S MEDICALLY APPROPRIATE AND
PROBABLY NEVER BEING ABLE TO GET
THAT INTO A CONSERVATORSHIP.
SO WHAT WE'RE DOING THIS BILL IS
NOT REMOVING THE A. O. T. --
PROVISION WERE SAYING THAT YOU
TO HAVE TO DO A T. UNLESS THE
SERVICES TO THE POSITION NOT A
BUREAUCRAT.
CERTIFIES THAT A WHICH IS NOT
APPROPRIATE FOR THIS PERSON AND
THEN EVEN BEFORE THE AMENDMENT
THIS COMMITTEE WHO.
PUT IN SOMEONE COULD ALWAYS
CHALLENGE OF FINDING IN COURT.
I SAID THAT THAT'S THE MAIN
THING AND I I'LL BE ON LAST YEAR
AFTER THAT AMOUNT WENT IN.
I TRIED TO GET PERMISSION TO
MODIFY IT BUT AS AS YOU KNOW.
A MODIFY AND APPROPRIATIONS
AMENDMENT IS EXCEPTIONALLY HARD.
AND SO WE WERE UNABLE TO DO IT.
THAT THAT'S THE REASON WHY.
WE'RE HERE I'VE THE THE BILL WAS
ALWAYS INTENDED TO APPLY IN SAN
FRANCISCO TO ABOUT FIFTY TO
SEVENTY FIVE OR MAYBE A HUNDRED
PEOPLE AT THE MOST.
I AND WITH THAT A. O. T.
AMENDMENT THAT WAS PUT IN LAST
YEAR -- AS DOCTOR COLFAX SAID ON
IN NOW PLACE TO AT MOST FIVE
PEOPLE.
BECAUSE IT TOOK OUT A WHOLE
BUNCH OF PEOPLE WHO ARE IN NEED
OF THIS [inaudible]
CHAU.
WHAT BEARING TO NUMBER FIFTY ONE
FIFTY HOLDS OUT WHEN THIS BILL?
I'M SO IN ORDER TO BE I HAVE
BASS LINE ELIGIBILITY. FOR FOR
THIS FOR THE COUNTY SEAT
CONSERVATORSHIP PETITION.
YOU HAVE TO BE. FIFTY ONE FIFTY
EIGHT TIMES WITHIN A TWELVE
MONTH PERIOD.
AND YOU HAVE TO BE SUFFERING
FROM SEVERE MENTAL HEALTH.
CONDITION -- AND A SEVERE
SUBSTANCE ABUSE.
DISORDER I AM AND THEN THERE ARE
A WHOLE BUNCH OF OTHER
REQUIREMENTS YOU HAVE TO BE
OFFERED VOLUNTARY SERVICES YOU
HAVE TO BE GIVEN NOTICE AFTER
THE SEVEN FIFTY ONE FIFTY THERE
ARE MORE -- AND ALL THE DUE
PROCESS PROTECTIONS OF
CONSERVATORSHIP.
YOU GET A JUDGE YOU CAN DEMAND
TRIAL BY JURY YOU GET AN
ATTORNEY IN SEVERAL OF THE
PUBLIC DEFENDER AND WE HAVE ONE
OF THE BEST TO THE OFFICES IN
THE COUNTRY.
AND OUR IT AND WE ACTUALLY
SHORTEN IT FROM A YEAR SIX
MONTHS -- AND THEN YOU OFFER THE
OPTION OF TWENTY EIGHT DAYS
INSTEAD OF SIX MONTHS INSTEAD OF
THE FULL SIX MONTHS -- AND YOU
HAVE TO DO REPORT EVERY SIXTY
DAYS AND IF WE TERMINATED EARLY
TO THERE ARE ENORMOUS GUARD
RAILS -- AROUND.
AND I'M SURE PERSONALLY THE
REASON I SUPPORT BILL LAST YEAR
IS ON THE SON OF THE PSYCH NURSE
WHO CONSULTED BUT I DID NOT
CONSULT YOUR ON THIS MEASURE BUT
SHE CLEARLY.
HAS STATED MY MOTHER'S STATED
THAT MANY TIMES FIFTY ONE
FIFTIES ARTISTS HOLDS FOR PEOPLE
WHO.
MIGHT HAVE SEVERE DRUG PROBLEMS
AND ONLY COUNTY THEY WERE JUST
KIND OF LIKE.
HOLDING FOLKS JUST BE OLD UNTIL
THEY SOBERED UP SOULS SAY THAT'S
THE CASE OF SOMEONE WHO.
JUST AS ON A DRUNKEN BINGE AND
YOU'VE BEEN HELD EIGHT MONTHS ME
EIGHT TIMES IN A YEAR BUT REALLY
DON'T HAVE IT.
A SEARCH OF YOUR DRUG PROBLEMS
THAT'S WHAT.
MY MOTHER'S FRUSTRATION WAS MOST
THE TIME THEY WERE JUST HOLDING
FOLKS SILLY SO WE'RE NOT BEFORE
RELEASING BACK OUT WELL SO THE
THE BILL ON HAVING EIGHT FIFTY
ONE FIFTIES BY ITSELF IS NOT
ENOUGH.
THAT'S JUST LIKE STEP -- ONE AND
YOU ALSO HAVE TO HAVE -- YOU
HAVE TO HAVE A SEVERE SUBSTANCE
ABUSE IS ORDER.
HAVE A SEVERE.
MENTAL ILLNESS I IN ADDITION TO
ALL THE OTHER THINGS SO JUST
BEING FIFTY ONE FIFTY IT IS NOT
ENOUGH.
BUT ONE OF THE ISSUES YOU RAISE
IS AN INTERESTING ONE FOR PEOPLE
WHO ARE IN IN THESE VERY.
WHO WHO ARE AT PARTICULAR WHO
ARE ADDICTED AND THE REASON WHY
CURRENT LPS LAWS ARE NOT
ADEQUATE TO READ SOME?
IS THAT YOU HAVE PEOPLE WHO ARE
GET SAY.
FIFTY ONE FIFTY AND THEN BY THE
ENDS.
DAY IN OF A DATE THERE'S NO
BASIS TO HOLD THEM ANYMORE EVEN
THOUGH AS YOU HEARD BEFORE.
PICKED UP EVERY DAY WERE
SLEEPING IN THEIR FECES WHO ARE
YOU RUNNING IN THE MIDDLE OF
TRAFFIC YELLING AT CARS.
AND WHO ARE NOT CAPABLE OF
ACCEPTING VOLUNTARY SERVICES
EVEN THOUGH WE OFFERED TO THEM --
AND AND THEY NEED HELP AND SO
YOU KNOW THERE THERE ARE.
THE FIFTY ONE FIFTIES BY
THEMSELVES ARE NOT ENOUGH THESE
PEOPLE HAVE TO BE DIAGNOSED WITH
A SEVERE THIS ORDER.
AND EVEN THEN THEY GET A TRIAL
TO GET A PUBLIC DEFENDER
ETCETERA.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS.
SO DO WE HAVE A MOTION ON THE
BILL [inaudible]
THE BILL -- CENTER WINNER UNTIL
IT CLOSED I THANK YOU I'M I'M
I'M SURE I DO THIS ONE IS A NOTE
ON AND YOU HEARD THIS I CAN'T
REMEMBER WHICH WHEN THE SENATE --
BUT WE DO HAVE WHAT IS
EFFECTIVELY A CONSERVATORSHIP
PROGRAM.
TODAY IT'S A VERY ROBUST ONE IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND IT'S
CALLED JAIL -- BECAUSE THESE
PEOPLE WHO WERE EXTREMELY SICK
CYCLE THROUGH OUR CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM OVER AND OVER
AGAIN.
CONSTANT INTERACTIONS WITH THE
POLICE WHICH IS NOT WHAT WE WANT
TO HAPPEN.
AND THE AS I UNDERSTAND OF THE
LOS ANGELES COUNTY JAIL IS THE
LARGEST MENTAL HEALTH PROVIDER
IN OUR COUNTRY WHICH IS.
TERRIBLE I AND WE NEED
ALTERNATIVE TO JAIL AND A
HOUSING CONSERVATORSHIP.
TURN OF TO HELP PEOPLE GET
HEALTHY AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR RIVAL.
THANK YOU WHAT'S SEVERAL CALL
MOTIONMOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
SKINNER BY SKINNER AYE MORE LOCK.
BRADFORD.
RIGHT FOR AYE JACKSON MITCHELL
MORALE HI MORRELL AYE WIENER.
WIENER AYE.
RIGHT THE BILL'S GOING CALL --
IS THERE NO OTHER AUTHOR IN THE
ROOM.
CHECK IS THERE ANY OTHER I DON'T.
OKAY CENTER WINNER YOU CAN GO
AHEAD THEN.
YOUR NEXT BILL SB [inaudible]
ONE THIRTY TWO OKAY [inaudible]
WE HAVE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THAT STARTED OUT A LITTLE BIT.
OKAY I THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
CHAIR ON COLLEAGUES -- SP ONE
THIRTY TWO ADDRESSES A VERY REAL
PROBLEM -- FACING --
INCARCERATED TRANS GENDER
INDIVIDUALS SPECIFICALLY.
TRANSGENDER PEOPLE WHO ARE BEING
HELLS ACCORDING TO THEIR SEX AS
A SIGN OR GENDER AS ASSIGNED AT
BIRTH -- AS OPPOSED TO THEIR
GENDER IDENTITY -- OR THE
PERCEPTION OF THEIR OWN
PERCEPTION OF THEIR SAFETY.
WHICH RESULTS IN A SIGNIFICANT
RISK OF VIOLENCE -- THE SUPREME
COURT HAS CORRECTLY RECOGNIZE
THAT -- TRANSGENDER PEOPLE WHO
ARE INCARCERATED ARE
PARTICULARLY VULNERABLE TO
ASSAULT SEXUAL ABUSE SEXUAL
HARASSMENT -- AND THAT READ
DISREGARDING KNOWN RISKS -- TO
TRANSGENDER.
PEOPLE WHO ARE INCARCERATED
CONSTITUTES DELIBERATE
INDIFFERENCE AND VIOLATION OF
THE CONSTITUTION. TO ADDRESS
THESE PROBLEMS SB ONE THIRTY TWO
DOES A FEW THINGS.
IT REQUIRES SAID DURING THE
INITIAL INTAKE.
MUST RECORD I THE INDIVIDUAL'S
SELF REPORTED GENDER IDENTITY
PREFERRED FIRST NAME PREFERRED
PRONOUNS AND HONORIFICS AND THE
PREFERRED GENDER IDENTITY OF AN
OFFICER WHO WOULD CONDUCT ANY --
BODY SEARCH OF THE INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUAL.
THE BILL REQUIRES THAT ALL STAFF
AND CONTRACTORS OF CDC ARE
CONSISTENTLY -- USE -- THE
GENDER PRONOUN HONORIFIC AMBER
FOR NAME SPECIFIED BY THE
INDIVIDUAL.
THE BILL REQUIRES CDC ARE TO
HELD A TRANSGENDER PERSON AT A
CORRECTIONAL FACILITY --
DESIGNATED FOR MEN OR WOMEN
ACCORDING TO THE PERSON'S GENDER
IDENTITY OR ALTERNATIVELY
ACCORDING TO THEIR TO THEIR SEX
ASSIGNED AT BIRTH IF THE
INCARCERATED INDIVIDUAL BELIEVES
THAT THAT IS THE SAFEST OPTION.
IT WILL REQUIRE CDC ARE TO
ASSIGN HOUSING PLACEMENT WITHIN
A CORRECTIONAL FACILITY --
ACCORDING TO A TRANSGENDER
PERSON SAID SENSE OF HEALTH AND
SAFETY.
AND IT DOES PROVIDE FLEXIBILITY
FOR CDC ARE IF IT HAS A SPECIFIC
SECURITY -- CONCERNED THAT CAN
EXPRESS AN ARTICULATE -- TO
GRANT FLEXIBILITY IN TERMS OF
HOUSING IN IN CONSISTENT WITH A
PERSON'S GENDER IDENTITY.
WE KNOW THAT ALMOST 40% OF
TRANSGENDER INDIVIDUALS HAVE
REPORTED EXPERIENCING SEXUAL
VICTIMIZATION WHILE INCARCERATED
COMPARED TO JUST 4% OF THE
OVERALL INCARCERATED POPULATION.
IN CALIFORNIA STUDY OF THE
STATE'S PRISONS DESIGNATED FOR
MEN FOUND THAT THE RATE OF
SEXUAL ASSAULT FOR TRANSGENDER
WOMEN IN THOSE -- PRISON FOR MEN
I WAS THIRTEEN TIMES HIGHER.
THAN -- FOR CONFERRED THAN FOR
MEN IN THE SAME PRESENCE.
I TO HOUSE TRANSGENDER PEOPLE
AND FACILITIES THAT DO NOT
CORRESPOND WITH THEIR GENDER
IDENTITY.
THESE INDIVIDUALS.
OF SEXUAL ASSAULT AND OTHER
VICTIMIZATION.
AND THEN THEY ARE TIMES ARE
PLACE -- INTO ISOLATION QUOTE ON
QUOTE FOR THEIR OWN PROTECTION
BECAUSE THEY HAVE NOT BEEN MIS
CATEGORIZED AND THEY LOSE ACCESS
TO SERVICES -- SP ONE THIRTY TWO
WILL BE A SIGNIFICANT STOP
ENSURING THAT WE ARE TREAT
TREATING OUR TRANSGENDER --
INCARCERATED INDIVIDUALS WITH BE
A RESPECT THAT THEY DESERVE -- I
WILL NOTE THAT WE ARE WORKING
WITH CDC ARE AND I WANT TO
PUBLICLY THANK THE DEPARTMENT OF
FOR COMMUNICATING WITH US AND
I'M HOPEFUL THAT WE CAN GET. TO
A REALLY STRONG -- POINT FOR
TRANSGENDER INCARCERATED
POPULATION -- SO I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE ON A AND WITH
ME TODAY ARE TAMMY MARTIN FROM
QUALITY CALIFORNIA WHEN OUR
SPONSORS -- BAMBI -- WHO IS BEN
HUESO SAID A WHOSE -- FROM
TRANSLATES INTO -- FROM LOS
ANGELES I AM JENNIFER OR FIND A
PARTNER MEDINA ORTH LINE I'LL
PAY.
WITNESSES YOU CAN START.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
I'M I AM MY NAME IS JOHN WITH
ONE AND I AM HERE TO SUPPORT --
SB.
ONE THIRTY TWO I AM A
PSYCHOLOGIST AND AN ATTORNEY
WITH EXTENSIVE EXPERIENCE
WORKING WITH INCARCERATED
TRANSGENDER PEOPLE.
I HAVE A SYSTEM TREATED DOZENS
OF TRANSGENDER PEOPLE IN PRISON
AS WELL AS REVIEW THEIR PRISON
FILES MEDICAL RECORDS
PSYCHIATRIC RECORDS AS BOTH THE
SURF FRIENDS EX I CALL JUST AN
ATTORNEY.
IN REVIEWING THEIR PRISON
RECORDS I CAN'T TELL YOU HOW
OFTEN I'VE READ IN THEIR FILES
YOU'RE BEING PLACED IN
ADMINISTRATIVE SEGREGATION DUE
TO DO BECAUSE YOU CAN DEEMED A
THREAT TO THE SECURITY.
AND SAFETY OF THIS INSTITUTION
FOR AN ARRAY OF ALLEGED RAPE OR
DANGER OF SEXUAL ASSAULT --
DESPITE THE WELL RECOGNIZED ON
ABILITY OF TRANSGENDER PEOPLE IN
PRISON.
THE MOST RECENT ARTISTS IN
ACCORDANCE WITH THE FEDERAL
PRISON RAPE ELIMINATION ACT PRIA
REVEALED THE CALIFORNIA IS STILL
NOT COMPLYING WITH THE ACT.
IN RELATION LGBT Q. AYE
PRISONERS SPECIFICALLY CDC ARE
WAS CITED. FOR FAILURE TO
IDENTIFY LGBT Q. I PEOPLE OR
FACTOR IN THEIR PERCEPTION OF
SAFETY WHEN MAKING HOUSING AND
PLACEMENT DECISIONS.
MY FIRM IS GIVING MY FIRM
REPRESENTS CANDACE CROWDER A
TRANSGENDER WOMAN CURRENTLY
COMMITTED TO CDC ARE.
CANDICE'S STORY IS NOT UNIQUE.
IT'S JUST THE ONLY STORY AT TIME
THIS YEAR WITH YOU TODAY.
CANDICE WAS REPAIRS SELL ME IN
SEPTEMBER OF TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN BUT NO INVESTIGATION OUR
INTERVENTION SUIT. TWO MONTHS
LATER SHE WAS PLACED IN SOLITARY
CONFINEMENT WHERE SHE REMAINED.
TO THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
FACILITY IN SEPTEMBER. TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN TWO DAYS LATER
AN EX BOYFRIEND A POSTER IN THE
GYM AND THREATENED TO KILL HER.
SHE IMMEDIATELY REPORTED THE
THREAT TO A SERGEANT EXPRESSED
HER FEAR FOR HER SAFETY.
THE SERGEANT OLDER THERE WAS
NOTHING HE COULD DO. TWO DAYS
LATER HER EX BOYFRIEND ATTEMPTED
TO KILLER IN THE DINING HALL
SLICING HER HEAD FACE NECK WITH
A BOX CUTTER.
THIS IS A NIGHTMARE IS ONGOING
AS CDC ARE CONTINUES TO IGNORE
HER CONCERNS FOR HER SAFETY.
TRANSFERRING HER MOST RECENTLY
TO THE YARD WHERE HER ASSAILANT
WAS HOUSE.
ON TOP OF ALL THIS SHE CONTINUES
TO BE TREATED AND REFER TO AS A
MAN.
WE'RE TRULY HARASSED
INDISCRIMINATE AGAIN SIMPLY FOR
BEING HERSELF.
PRISONS BINARY GENDERED
INSTITUTIONS BY DESIGN WHERE
GENDER BASED VIOLENCE IS THE
NORM.
THE TRANSGENDER PEOPLE AT GRAVE
RISK.
SB ONE THIRTY TWO WOULD PUT.
TRANSGENDER PEOPLE'S HEALTH AND
SAFETY FIRST AND INCREASE THE
CHANCES OF SURVIVING PRISON AND
SAFELY RETURNING TO SOCIETY. FOR
ALL THESE REASONS I AM PROUD TO
SUPPORT SB.
ONE THIRTY TWO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION [inaudible]
THANK YOU -- GOOD AFTERNOON --
WHEN I STARTED THIS MY NAME IS
BAMBI FESTIVAL AND I DO HAVE THE
PRIVILEGE? TO LEAD A NATIONAL
ADVOCACY ORGANIZATION THAT IS
PROVIDING LIFESAVING SUPPORTING
SERVICES TO TRANCE INTERNET
GOVERNMENT PEOPLE IN LOS ANGELES --
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY. TO BE HERE.
WITH YOU AND SHARE MY EXPERIENCE
AS SOMEONE WHO HAS GONE THROUGH
THE CORRECTIONAL SYSTEM.
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
I AM SOMEONE WHO HAS.
THE OUT THERE WHO IS ONE OF THE
CHOSEN FEW WHO HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO REFORM MY LIFE.
INTERNET AROUND.
OUT TO ADVOCATE FOR A BETTER
QUALITY OF LIFE OF PEOPLE WHO
ARE OF TURN SIX BILLIONS.
IN CALIFORNIA AND ACROSS THE
NATION.
I HAD TO SPEND ABOUT FOURTEEN
YEARS OF MY LIFE IN THE
CORRECTIONAL SYSTEM IN
CALIFORNIA.
STARTING IN COUNTY JAILS AND
ULTIMATELY DOING FOUR DIFFERENT
PRISON TERMS.
I TO SPEND ALL THIS TIME IN
PRISON BECAUSE THEY DO NOT HAVE
ANY TYPE OF OPPORTUNITIES.
WHEN I WAS YOUNGER AND I THINK
TRANS WOMEN I WAS PUSH TO ENGAGE
IN THE STREET ECONOMY AS A WAY
TO SURVIVE?
WHICH LED ME TO THE CORRECTIONAL
SYSTEM.
WHEN I WAS IN PRISON I WAS RAPED
MULTIPLE TIMES BY OTHER
INCARCERATED PEOPLE?
I CONSTANTLY HAVE TO DO SEXUAL
FAVORS TO OTHERS BECAUSE I DO.
NINE FELL [inaudible]
I A BECAUSE I ALSO A CONCERN FOR
THE MY LIFE WAS CONCERNING
DANGER.
EVERY SINGLE DAY THAT I WALK UP
IN THOSE PRISONS.
I DO NOT KNOW WHAT WAS GOING TO
HAPPEN TO ME.
IF I HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO
CHOOSE WHERE I A WEIRD. TO THE
TIME OR WHAT I WOULD HAVE BEEN
HOUSE WHEN I WAS CONVICTED TO
THE TIME FOR THE CRIMES THAT I
WEST CHARGE.
FOR I WOULD HAVE SAID IT WOULD
HAVE SAVED ME FROM ALL THE
HORRIBLE EXPERIENCES.
THAT I SURVIVE WHILE I WAS IN
PRISON.
EVERY SINGLE TIME THAT I WENT TO
PRISON I WAS NEVER ASKED H<c.cyan></c>
WHY US.
HOW I FELT?
ABOUT WHO I AM.
WIFE I WAS SCARE.
NOT EVEN HOW IT WOULD BE FOR ME
IF I WAS GOING TO BE SENT TO AN
ALL MEN'S JAIL OR PRISON.
ALL OF THIS HAPPENED TO ME
SIMPLY BECAUSE THE SYSTEM SEVEN
I AM NOT.
SUPPOSED TO BE WHO I AM.
IT SEEMS I I WAS DOUBLE PUNISHED
SIMPLY BECAUSE I WAS A TRANS
WOMAN.
IF I WAS GIVEN THE OPPORTUNITY
TO CHOOSE MY HOUSING PLACEMENT
THEN I CAN ALMOST ASSURE YOU.
THAT ALL THOSE HORRIBLE
EXPERIENCES THAT I WENT THROUGH.
AND SURVIVE -- FOURTEEN YEARS OF
MY LIFE.
WE HAVE SAVE ME MUCH PAIN.
TRAUMA IN MANY TEARS.
ALL OF THIS HAPPENED TO ME.
THIS IS A UNIT.
EXPERIENCE FOR ME BUT THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT CONTINUES TO
HAPPEN TOO MANY TRANS WOMEN WHO
ARE INCARCERATED.
ANOTHER ONE EXPERIENCE INSIDE IS
SOMETHING THAT CONTINUES TO
HAPPEN TO THE TRANS WOMEN IN
PRISON.
THE CORRECTIONAL SYSTEM.
MUST VALIDATE AN HONOR OUR THAT
OUR IDENTITIES.
GIVING US DIGNITY AS HUMAN
BEINGS.
IN THIS FIVE AND THE FACT THAT
WE HAVE BEEN CONVICTED FOR A
CRIME.
AND WE DESERVE.
RESPECT AND TO BE TREATED AS
HUMAN BEINGS. ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT HAPPENS IS THAT WE ACTUALLY
SENTENCE BY THE SYSTEM TO A LIFE
SENTENCE OF PAIN.
AND TRAUMA.
NOT JUST THROUGH THE
CORRECTIONAL SYSTEM OF THE
ACTUAL SYSTEM HOW IT'S SET UP.
WHEN WE GO TO PRISON AND WE WE
ARE?
WHEN WE HAVE?
TO WHEN WE HAVE TO BE HOUSE
WHERE.
WE ARE CONTINUE HIS BEANS CARE
AND OUR LIFE IS CONSTANTLY --
AND DANGER.
IT'S NOT CONDUCIVE TO FOR US TO
BE BETTER PEOPLE.
PEOPLE WHO ARE IN PRISON THE
SEVER SPECS AGENCY AND DIGNITY
AND IF WE HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO CHOOSE WHERE WE CAN SERVE OUR
TIME IN PRISON.
IT WOULD HAVE SAVE OUR COMMUNITY
SO MUCH PAIN.
AND WE CAN FIND HEALING INSTEAD.
THIS BILL PROVIDES THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR A GREAT STATE TO
SET PRECEDENCE TO SAY THE TRANS
PEOPLE IN THIS STATE MATTER.
AND IT IS A FORM OF REPARATION
TO ALL THE PAIN AND TRAUMA THAT
THIS STATE HAS CREATED IN THE
TRANS COMMUNITY.
IT IS AN OPPORTUNITY TO TAKE TO
SAY TO TRANS GENDER NON
CONFORMING AND INTERSEX PEOPLE.
THAT WE SEE YOU.
AND WE VALUE AS THE HUMANE THING
YOU ARE.
THIS WOUND BILL WOULD DO JUST
THAT.
I URGE FOR YOU DOUBLE JEST ON SP.
ONE THIRTY TWO THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR LETTING
THIS.
MADAME CHIANG COMMITTEE MEMBERS
TAMMY MARTIN ON BEHALF OF
EQUALITY CALIFORNIA THE STATE
WIDE LGBT Q. CIVIL RIGHTS
ORGANIZATION -- AND PROUD
SPONSOR OF SB ONE THIRTY TWO
ALSO ON BEHALF OF OUR CO
SPONSORS TRANSGENDER LAWCENTER
AND LINDA LEGAL WHO WERE NOT
ABLE TO BE HERE TODAY -- FOR THE
VERY COMPELLING REASONS STATED
BY MY FELLOW WITNESSES WE URGE
YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
KELLY LEE DENSMORE WITH THE
TRANS GENDER GENDER VARIANT
INTERSECTS JUSTICE PROJECT
ANOTHER CO SPONSOR ON THE BILL
IN SUPPORT.
MIKE A DOCTOR OFF ON BEHALF OF
THE ACLU OF CALIFORNIA WE ARE
PROUD CO SPONSOR AND SUPPORT THE
SPELL.
WHERE DO WELL ON BEHALF OF THE
CONFERENCE A CALIFORNIA BAR
ASSOCIATIONS AND STRONG SUPPORT?
THEY'RE WORKING FOR THE ELEVATOR
CENTER FOR HUMAN RIGHTS SUPPORT.
MY NAME IS MISS A PULLEY THAT
WHAT THE TRANSIT THE NOW
COALITION AND A MEMBER OF
JUSTICE LA AND WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
DONNA MANDELBROT SAN FRANCISCO
PUBLIC DEFENDER'S OFFICE OF
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU.
ERIC ANDERSON WITH INITIATE
JUSTICE STRONG SUPPORT.
FILL IN THIS FORM INCARCERATED
AND I'VE SEEN HORRIBLE
INJUSTICES -- TO TRANS PEOPLE IN
PRISON AND I SUPPORT WHAT YOU
SAID ABOUT BRINGING -- DIGNITY
AND RESPECT AN AGENCY SENATE
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
I AM FREDDIE FRANCIS I'M HERE
AND ON BEHALF OF THE BAY AREA
LAWYERS FOR INDIVIDUAL.
LESLIE CALDWELL CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
WE HAVE WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
RIGHT.
ANY COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS BY MY
COLLEAGUES.
SENATOR I KNOW WHAT'S THE ISSUE
OF SAFETY AND FORGIVE MY
IGNORANCE.
BUT WOULD A INDIVIDUAL WHO WISH.
TRANSMAT.
BE SAFER AND I'M A MAN TO PRISON
I'M I'M JUST CURIOUS.
THAT SEEMS TO BE FOR ME IT JUST
COUNTERINTUITIVE BUT WITH.
THAT'S WHERE THEY WOULD PREFER
TO BE IN A MEN'S PRISON.
AND ALL STARRED IN AND HANDED
OFF OUR SO THEY MAY OR MAY NOT
AND AND THAT'S WHY WITH THE BILL --
DOES NOT MANDATE.
THAT THE PERSON IF THE PERSON
BELIEVES THAT THEY ARE SAFER.
FOR EXAMPLE IN THAT SITUATION --
IN A WOMEN'S PRISON THAT WOULD
BE -- THEIR CHOICE ALSO THE THE
GET.
THE CHOICE OKAY ARE I JUST WANT.
TO THE WORKFORCE IN A SITUATION
THAT.
I JUST I JUST WANT TO ADD THAT I
THINK.
I'M MISSING POINT THAT PEOPLE
HAVE THE ABILITY AND THE
AUTONOMY TO REALLY -- CHOOSE
WHERE THEY WOULD BE FEEL MORE
SAFELY TO THE TIME THAT THEY
HAVE.
BEEN COMMITTED TO DO -- I THINK
IT'S REALLY IS ABOUT ELECT AND
DIVERT CHOI CHOICE -- MORE LOOK.
TO WINNER DID CDC OUR WAY IN AT
ALL THE BILL.
WE HAVE MET WITH CDC ARE -- AND
AND HAD SOME -- BUT DISCUSSIONS
ARE WITH CDC OUR AND I SEE STARS
NOT WAITIN OR TAKEN A POSITION --
BUT WILL CONTINUE.
TO WORK WITH THEM WORK WITH THEM
ON A THERE'S A DIFFERENT BILL WE
DID LAST YEAR WE WORKED ON THEM.
WITH THEM -- AND I'M I'M HOPEFUL
THAT.
WE CAN CONTINUE -- POSITIVE
DIALOGUE WITH THE DEPARTMENT. TO
THE FEEL LIKE THEY'RE READY
ACCOMMODATING ADEQUATELY.
SO I DON'T WANT TO SPEAK FOR CDC
ARE ON I CAN SAY THAT THEY ARE I
KNOW THAT THEY ARE COMPETING
STAKEHOLDERS.
ON THIS.
I UNDERSTAND FROM WHAT THEY'VE
EXPRESSED TO ME -- DIED THAT
THIS IS AN ISSE THAT THEY NEED
TO LOOK SERIOUSLY AT I SAW HIM
DAY AGAIN I DON'T SPEAK FOR THEM
BUT MY SENSE IS THAT THEY AGREE
THAT THERE IS AN ISSUE THAT
NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED -- AND
WILL CONTINUE TO TALK WITH THEM.
THANK YOU MANAGER CERTAINLY.
SO DO A MOTION.
WE HAVE A MOTION WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE AN AGGRESSIVE.
RESPECT WITH RIVAL SENATOR
WIENER DRY SO.
NO MATTER.
HE WAS MY MOTION DOCTOR THERE ON
A LOT.
I CAN BE WHOEVER YOU WANT --
WILL BE THAT.
ONE I RESERVE WITH RIVAL.
THANK YOU FOR WE DO ROLL CALL
AND WHEN IT THANKS VERY MUCH
THOSE OF YOU WHO TESTIFIED IN.
YOU SPECIALLY BAMBI FOR SHARING
YOUR EXPERIENCE AND APOLOGIES
THAT YOU HAD TO EXPERIENCE THAT
DURING YOUR TIME -- THIS
COMMITTEE AS I THINK THOSE OF
YOU WHO HAVE SAT IN IT TODAY
KNOW THAT -- WE DEAL WITH SOME
VERY -- WE DO SUBJECT MATTER
THAT FOR MANY OF THE WITNESSES
WHO COME -- COURAGE TESTIMONY
THE HAVE TO RELAY THINGS TO US
THAT ARE VERY TO MATIC FOR THEM
AND I THINK FOR ALL OF US --
IT'S IT'S THE I THINK WE GET A
IN EDUCATION OR AN INSTRUCTION
THAT WE ARE OFTEN -- GIVEN
OPPORTUNITY TO SELL.
WHILE IT -- MANY OF THE THINGS
WE HEAR WE WISH WOULD NEVER
HAPPEN TO ANYONE -- IT'S IT'S
VERY USEFUL FOR US IN OUR
DELIBERATIONS ON MAKING PUBLIC
POLICY FOR PEOPLE'S WILLINGNESS
TO BE SEPARATE TO TESTIFY SO.
NOW WITH THE ROLL CALL.
QUESTION IS THE PASTOR
APPROPRIATIONS SKINNER HI
SKINNER I'VE MORE LOCKED.
BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE JACKSON.
MITCHELL MORALE WIENER WIENER
AYE.
ON CALL.
AND LET'S SEE.
GOODNESS.
NO OTHER AUTHOR SHOWED UP.
SO SENATOR WIENER YOU GET YOUR
PRESENT YOUR LAST BILL.
WINTERS ARE ALL THE OTHER
AUTHORS GIVEN UP ON US.
YEAH IT IS.
I STILL HAVE FOR BROKEN UP WITH
THE OTHER COMMITTEES.
BUT YOU KNOW WE'RE HAVING.
OKAY THIS IS ITEM MADE SB
[inaudible]
TWO EIGHTY ONE OKAY SO
YEAH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR.
HI AND THANK YOU -- TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR WORKING WITH US --
THIS BILL WILL IMPART LOOK
FAMILIAR BECAUSE I WE HAD A CAL
TELLS BILL LAST YEAR THAT WAS
VETOED BY THE GOVERNOR.
AND I WANT TO THANK -- MY CO
AUTHORS ON THIS BILL -- WHO ARE
THE ENTIRETYOF THE DELEGATIONS?
SAN FRANCISCO AND SAN MATTEO
COUNTY MYSELF CENTER HILL.
SOME MEMBERS CHIU TING MULLIN
AND BERMAN -- WE ALSO HAVE
UNANIMOUS SUPPORT FOR THE BILL --
FROM THE DALY CITY COUNCIL AND
FROM SAN FRANCISCO BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS -- AND FROM THE
MAYOR OF SAN FRANCISCO AND FROM
THE SUPERVISOR AND SEVENTEEN
COUNTY FOR THE DISTRICT
SUPERVISOR.
THIS BILL WILL DO TWO EIGHT IS A
LONG STANDING ISSUE -- IN.
THE SAN FRANCISCO CEMETERY
COUNTY AREA AND DALY CITY -- OF
THE CAL PALACE -- WHICH SITS ON
SIXTY EIGHT ACRES OF LAND.
A AND A LONG STANDING
FRUSTRATION IN THE COMMUNITY
ODDS CAL PALACE HAS NOT BEEN
RESPONSIVE TO THE NEEDS OF LOCAL
COMMUNITIES.
THE MOST PROMINENT -- AND WELL
PUBLICIZED OF OF THOSE AREAS IN
TERMS OF A LACK OF
RESPONSIVENESS HAS BEEN THE CAL
PALACES LONG TERM INSISTENCE ON
HOLDING MULTIPLE GUN SHOWS A
YEAR.
AT THE COW PALACE AT THE STATE
REQUESTS FROM THE LOCAL
COMMUNITY FOR DECADES INCLUDING
MANY UNANIMOUS VOTES FROM PRETTY
MUCH EVERY GOVERNING BODY IN THE
AREA. TO STOP THE GUN SHOWS AND
DESPITE THOSE DECADES OF REQUEST
THE CALIFORNICUM SHOWS.
IN ADDITION -- FOR MANY YEARS --
DALY CITY HAS WANTED TO WORK
WITH THE CAL PALACE TO ADDRESS
LAND USE IN THE AREA IT'S ON
SIXTY EIGHT ACRES THE BULK OF
WHICH IS -- MAGGOT MASSIVE
PARKING LOT.
THERE ARE A LOT OF ISSUES -- IN
THE AREA AND DALY CITY HAS BEEN
INTERESTED FOR A LONG TIME IN
WORKING TO US BOTH TO SOME SORT
OF DEVELOPMENT OF HOUSING OR
MIXED USE -- AND TO MAKE IT MORE
OF A NEIGHBORHOOD AND SET UP --
OFTEN EMPTY.
SPACE.
AND THE CAL PALACE -- EVEN
THOUGH THERE HAVE BEEN TIMES
WHEN -- DEVELOPMENT IS BEEN
DISCUSSED OTHER THE QUESTION IS
NEVER GONE ANYWHERE -- SO -- A
NUMBER OF TIMES -- I AM NOW THE
THIRD A SENATOR TO BRING A HAS
BROUGHT BILLS IN THE CAL PALACE
JACKIE SPEAR -- MARK LENO THE
MYSELF ALL BOUGHT BROUGHT ALL
INTRODUCED BILLS TO BAN GUN
SHOWS.
HELP HELLO AS THEY WERE ALL --
EITHER VETO OVER ONE DIED ON THE
SENATE FLOOR A NUMBER OF YEARS
AGO.
AND DISPLAY ALL OF THIS --
UNIVERSAL SUPPORT THE CALIPARI
SICKLY IGNORED OBVIOUS REQUEST
IGNORE THE BILL'S IGNORE THE
FACT THAT THERE ARE ELECTED
REPRESENTATIVES ONE THAT THE GUN
SHOWS TO GO AWAY.
AND KEPT ON GOING I THIS YEAR.
WE INTRODUCED OF THE BILL IN A
DIFFERENT FORM IT INCLUDES A GUN
SHOW BAND IT ALSO INCLUDES --
AUTHORIZES AND DIRECTS TGS TO
ENTER INTO NEGOTIATIONS WITH A
NEW LOCALLY FORMED -- JOINT
POWERS AGENCY -- TO CONSIDER BUT
NOT REQUIRED THESE YES -- TO
SELL THE LAND'S LOCAL AUTHORITY
TO DECIDE THE FUTURE OF THE CAL
PALACE.
WE INTRODUCE THE BILL WE HAVE A
NEW GOVERNOR WHO HAS A DIFFERENT
APPROACH I BELIEVE TO GUN SHOWS --
THAT OUR FORMER GOVERNOR A AND
THEN LO AND BEHOLD THE
CALIPARI'S CANCEL THE GUN SHOWS --
AND ANNOUNCED SAID IT WAS
INTERESTED IN PURSUING
DEVELOPMENT OPPORTUNITIES --
WHILE THOSE ARE BOTH OF COURSE
GOOD THINGS AND YOU'LL HEAR THAT --
FROM THE OPPONENTS WILL THAT'S A
REASON TO ABANDON THE BILL LOOK
THEY JUST ANNOUNCED A WEEK OR
TWO AGO THEY'RE CANCELING THE
GUN SHOWS AND WANTED TO
DEVELOPMENT.
THEY SHOULD HAVE DONE THAT YEARS
AGO AND THE ONLY REASON THEY'RE
DOING IT IS THEY KNOW THAT THEY
NOW HAVE THIS BILL MOVING AND
HAVE A GOVERNOR WHO MAY ACTUALLY
SIGNED -- AND SO ALTHOUGH THESE
ARE BOTH POSITIVE THINGS -- I
THE FUNDAMENTAL ISSUE REMAINS
THAT WE NEED HI THIS HUGE PIECE
OF LAND AND THIS AGENCY TO BE
MORE RESPONSIVE TO THE LOCAL
COMMUNITY.
A WE WILL OF COURSE I CONTINUE
TO WORK.
WITH ALL STAKEHOLDERS LOCALLY
AND ALSO WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE IN WITH TGS AND WITH ALL
RELEVANT STAKEHOLDERS ON THE
FUTURE OF THE CALIPARI
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
ON SB -- TWO EIGHTY ONE AND WITH
ME TODAY ARE LET'S SEE ON BEHALF
OF THE CITY OF DALY CITY.
AN EDDIE MCCAFFREY -- ON BEHALF
OF THE CITY AND COUNTY OF SAN
FRANCISCO.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIRMAN AND
SENATORS BUILDER PLUS THE
REPRESENTING THE CITY OF DALY
CITY.
OF FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO AREN'T
FAMILIAR WITH THE AREA THE AREA
WHERE THE COW PALACE IS LOCATED
IN THE BAY SURE NEIGHBORHOOD IS
AN ISOLATED AREA OF DALY CITY
THAT IS.
WITHOUT.
THE AMENITIES THAT WE WOULD ALL
TAKE FOR GRANTED AND PLUS
SENATOR WHEN YOU'RE BRINGING
THIS FORWARD.
IT'S BEEN A STRUGGLE FOR DALY
CITY FOR DECADES TO TRY AND
SERVICE THE BAYSHORE
NEIGHBORHOOD AS IT DOES THE REST
OF THE CITY SO IT CERTAINLY ASK
YOUR SUPPORT. FOR THIS THIS
MAJOR THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CHAIR SKINNER AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THANK YOU
CENTER WINNER FOR THE LEADERSHIP
AND TIRELESS WORK ON THIS BILL.
NOT ONLY DOES MARILYN BREED
SPORTS BILL BUT ALSO OUR LOCAL
SAN FRANCISCO BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS.
AND WHILE THE EXISTING BOARD OF
DIRECTORS HAS RECENTLY MADE THE
DECISION TO END GUN SHOWS THAT
COP POLICY -- THAT DECISION
COULD BE REVERSED AT ANY TIME.
AND SERVICES GO WOULD LIKE TO
ENSURE THAT ANY ABOUT THE EVENT
HELD THERE.
WILL BE SCHEDULED WITH
CONSIDERATION GIVEN THE
SURROUNDING COMMUNITY DESIRES --
AS CENTER WE ARE MENTION
CALIFORNIA'S DEALING WITH -- AND
PRESIDENT HOUSING AFFORDABILITY
CRISIS AND SERVICE IS GOING THE
REGION NEEDS TO CREATE MORE
HOUSING ALL INCOME LEVELS FOR
FAMILIES AND WORKING PEOPLE.
IN THIS BILL DOES EXACTLY THAT.
HOUSE AS AN INCREDIBLE HISTORY.
THIS BILL WILL ENSURE THAT THE
SURROUNDING COMMUNITIES CONTINUE
TO PLAY AN IMPORTANT ROLE TO
FURTHER WHAT IS ALREADY A DEEP
CONNECTION WITH THAT SITE.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
ALL RIGHT WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR FOR A
LONG DAY FOR YOU ALL HI KATHY
LYNCH REPRESENTING.
NO IT'S NOT.
KATHY LET'S REPRESENTING THE
NATIONAL SHOOTING SPORTS
FOUNDATION OUTDOOR SPORTS IS
COALITION CALIFORNIA SPORTSMEN'S
LOBBY SPARKLE OF INTERNATIONAL
ACROSS OF THE WEST.
STRONG OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL.
THE SHOW HAS BEEN AT THE
FACILITY FOR DECADES.
WITH NO PROBLEMS THEY BRING IN A
BURKE -- ALMOST A THREE QUARTERS
OF A MILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY
FOR THE STATE.
AND THE LOCAL COMMUNITY THIS IS
A LEGAL REGULATED ACTIVITY IN
CALIFORNIA COMPLIANCE WITH THE
LAWS THOUSANDS OF CITIZENS OF
THE AREA IN CALIFORNIA TEN THE
SHOW'S SO TO SUGGEST THERE'S NO
DEMAND IS A MISNOMER.
THE ANALYSIS CORRECTLY POINTS
OUT THE HISTORY OF CALIFORNIA
PASSING LANDMARK GUN SHOW
REGULATIONS THAT WE WORKED ON
AND THE ACCORDING. TO TO STUDIES
DONE BY UC DAVIS A WHICH THIS
LEGISLATURE FUNDED TO DO GUN
RELATED RESEARCH AT THE GUN
SHOWS ARE VERY GOOD IN
CALIFORNIA TO SUGGEST THAT ONE
THOUSAND GUNS ARE SOLD IN A
WEEKEND IT'S NOT CLOSE TO
ACCURATE SINCE COMPLIANCE WITH
ALL.
REQUIRED FEDERAL AND STATE LAWS
APPLY WE HAVE A WAITING PERIOD
IN CALIFORNIA FOR A GUN
TRANSACTION.
IT'S NOT GOOD FOR PUBLIC SAFETY.
TO LIMIT ACCESS TO PRIVATE PARTY
TRANSFERS AS THAT WILL DRIVE AN
UNDERGROUND MARKET LAW
ENFORCEMENT SPOKE TO THIS IN THE
PAST ON THIS ISSUE.
THE BOTTOM LINE IS THESE ARE
PUBLIC FACILITIES THAT SHOULD BE
ACCESS BY ALL CALIFORNIANS AND
WATCHING THE SENATE GEOCHEMIST
RING WAS DIFFICULT WATCHING THE
VENUE FLASH.
THE UPCOMING AGENDA TO BAN THE
SHOW AND ASK AT THE SAME TIME
FOR DEFEAT OF THE LEGISLATION
THIS IS A SHAMEFUL ABUSE OF
POLITICAL INFLUENCE OVER LEGAL
ACTIVITY.
THE DISMISSAL OF THE SHOW LAST
WEEK AT THE BOARD MEETING WAS
CAREFULLY WORDED BUT BE AWARE IN
ADDITION TO THE CURRENT LAWSUITS
PENDING IN THE FEDERAL COURT
UNDER THE FIRST AMENDMENT.
GUARANTEE OF FREE EXPRESSION
THIS LEGISLATION REPRESENTS REAL
DISCRIMINATION IMAGINE APPLYING
THE STANDARD TO RENTAL
AGREEMENTS AND HOUSING.
WHILE THERE WILL THERE BE
ACCOMMODATIONS TO THE PARTY'S
BEEN DISCRIMINATED AGAINST SUCH
AS EVERYONE THAT GOES TO SHOWS
THAT OWNS A FIRE ARM TO BE
EXEMPTED FROM PAYING FOR THE
TAXATION FOR THE STATE PROPERTY.
SINCE THEY ARE NOT ALLOWED.
THIS IS NOT A DISTRICT ISSUE
THIS IS A STATE PROPERTY WITH
STATE IMPACTS THERE IS REVENUE
SHARING THAT THIS LEGISLATURE
APPROVED FOR ALL THE D. A.'S SO
THIS IMPACTS ALL THE DA'S.
THIS IS A CRUEL LANDLORD THIS IS
THERE IS ANOTHER BILL COMING
YOUR WAY WITH THE BOARD
SUSPENDED THE SHOW TO DO A STUDY
AND IS NOW RUNNING A BILL TO GET
OUT FROM UNDER THE LAWSUIT THEY
FEEL THEY WILL LOSE.
AND HAVE THE STATE TO ABSORB THE
IMPACT YEAH WE'RE TOLD THE VENUE
IS SPLASH IN IS DOING GREAT.
AGAIN THERE IS REVENUE SHARING
AND ITS IMPACT ARE FELT BY ALL
THE DA FACILITIES IN CONCLUSION
THIS BILL SEEMS TO AND THE AND
THE RECENT ACTIVITY SEEM TO
EXPAND ON LEGAL CHALLENGES.
THAT CAN BE BROUGHT FROM FIRST
AND SECOND AMENDMENT TO
DISCRIMINATION AND CERTAINLY THE
LEGISLATION IS BEING USED AS A
PAWN TO FORCE THE BOARD INTO
ACTION THANK YOU.
A GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIRWOMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
I'M QUITE INCOME OF SAN
FRANCISCO.
I FIRST SAW OF THE COW PALACE
AFTER SERVING IN THE U. S. AIR
FORCE.
DURING THE KOREAN WAR.
DECEMBER OF NINETEEN FIFTY FIVE
IT IS A HISTORICAL LANDMARK.
NOT ONLY IN THE BAY AREA.
BUT IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
BUILT TO BY THE WORKS PROGRESS
ADMINISTRATION.
UNDER FRANKLIN D. ROOSEVELT AND
COMPLETED IN.
NINETEEN FORTY ONE IT IS THOSE
ST OF THE VANCE.
WHICHEVER ENABLED YEAH. TO PAY
FOR ITSELF AND MAKE A PROFIT.
LET ME GIVE YOU SOME HISTORY
[inaudible]
I'M REPRESENTED.
PART OF OF THE HEALTH OF US SAN
MATTEO COUNTY CONSISTING OF TURN
OF THE TWENTY CITIES.
HEY ON THE CITY AND COUNTY OF
SAN FRANCISCO.
IN THIS BODY.
WELL OF YEARS.
THE COW PALACE HAS NOT ONLY
BANNED THOSE SANE [inaudible]
OF DOG SHOWS FLOWER SHOWS.
THE ANNUAL GRAN NATIONAL RODEO
STOCK AND HORROR SHOW.
THE DICKENS FAIR ABOUT WHICH YOU
WILL HEAR FROM KEVIN PATTERSON --
MY WHILE.
BUT DOG SHOWS WHY OUR SHOWS
REPTILE SHOW.
SALES FORCE CONVENTIONS FACE FOR
GOD CONFERENCE SAYS [inaudible]
POLITICAL CONVENTIONS POLITICAL
SPEECH [inaudible]
BASKETBALL.
ICE HOCKEY.
TRACK AND FIELD.
INDOOR BASEBALL.
THE VANCE WHICH ARE MADE
AVAILABLE. TO MIDDLE CLASS
[inaudible]
CALIFORNIANS AND PEOPLE.
WHO ARE?
PERHAPS DEPRIVE.
I'M CALLING THEMSELVES PART OF
THE METAL LATCH.
THE JURISDICTION OF THIS
COMMITTEE.
UPON WHICH I ONCE SERVED IS OF
COURSE LIMITED.
TO OF THAT PART OF THE BILL
WOULD SHOW PROHIBITS GUN SHOWS.
THE BOARD OF THE COW PALACE.
AS INDICATED DEAD DECIDED TO I
GUESS ABOUT A WEEK AGO NOT TO
RENEW.
THE THREE YEAR LEASE OF OF THE
PRESENT OPERATOR OF THE GUN
SHOWS -- AFTERWARD A GAG SPIRES
THE LEASE EXPIRES THE END OF
NINETEEN NINE CHANGE SO THE BILL.
HAS BEEN WRITTEN SO THE
PROBATION STARTS AND TWENTY
TWENTY SO YOU'RE NOT BREACHING A
CONTRACT AND THEN.
SUFFERING A LAWSUIT WHICH YOU'LL
LOSE.
THE BROWN MY UNDER ALL OF THE
BILL IS NOT GERMANE TO THIS
COMMITTEE.
AND I'LL BE BOLD TO PROPOSE THAT
YOU STRIP THAT PART FROM THIS
BAIL.
TAKE IT OUT.
GO AHEAD WITH THE PROHIBITION
AGAINST THE GUN SHOW WHICH IS
ACADEMIC.
UNLESS YOU THANK ALL THE MEMBERS
OF THE GAL PALS BOARD OF
DIRECTORS.
ADDED BY.
THE GOVERNOR ARE LIARS AND WITH
SOME MILD TURN AROUND.
AND REVERSE THERE ARE ACTION
LEVEL WEEK AGO.
YES -- BILL WHICH BELT HAMMER A
GUN SHOWS LAST YEAR WAS VETOED.
BY THEN GOVERNOR EDMUND G. BROWN
JUNIOR.
HERE'S WHAT HE SAID AND BURTON A
PART.
THE DECISION ON WHAT KIND OF
SHOWS ARE KERN AT THE COW PALACE
RESTS WITH THE LOCAL BOARD OF
DIRECTORS [inaudible]
WHICH INCIDENTLY REPRESENTS
BROAD CROSS.
IT'S A BROAD CROSS SECTION OF
THE COMMUNITY.
THEY ARE IN THE BEST POSITION TO
MAKE THOSE DECISIONS.
MEANING THAT HAVE THE DIRECTORS
ARE FROM SAN MATTEO COUNTY.
HALF THE DIRECTORS ARE FROM THE
CITY AND COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO.
THEY KNOW THE COMMUNITY.
AND THEY OPERATED WITH DALY CITY
AND A COUPLE OF WAYS.
A ONE TIME COUNCIL WOMAN WHO ON
FORTUNATELY DIED A COUPLE YEARS
AGO USED TO ATTEND.
EVERY BOARD OF DIRECTORS MEETING
THEIR MONTHLY MEETINGS AND SAID
ON THE DIALS WITH THE COW
BALANCE BOARD OF DIRECTORS.
THERE WAS REFERENCE -- BY THE
AUTHOR OF THOSE BILL. TO THEM
BEGINNING A PROCESS OF USING.
PART OF THE COW PALACE -- FOR
HOUSING.
WHAT IS FORGOTTEN OR NOT NO
[inaudible]
ONE IS THAT. TEN ELEVEN YEARS
AGO THE COW PALACE ENGAGED IN
NEGOTIATIONS.
WITH A LAND USE DEVELOPER OF
NATIONAL RENOWN.
WITH THE OWNER OF VIA COUPLE OF
ACRES OF PRIVATE PROPERTY
ADJACENT.
I'M.
WEST SIDE OF THE ENTRANCE TO THE
GAL PALS SOFTER IN THE WILL HAVE
BEEN YOU.
AND WITH THE CITY OF THE DAILY
STUDY WHICH OWNS A COUPLE OF
ACRES. TO DEVELOP.
SOME HOUSING.
AND SOME RETAIL ESTABLISHMENTS
PROTECT YOU A A GROCERY STORE OR
SUPERMARKET OF SOME KIND.
THE ECONOMIC RECESSION THEN
OCCURRED.
AND THAT IS THE REASON THAT
THOSE NEGOTIATIONS DID NOT
RESULT IN A LAND USE AGREEMENT
BETWEEN ALL THOSE THREE PARTIES.
THIS SAME.
LAND GRAB.
WAS IT TEMPTED TEN YEARS AGO.
BY A PRIOR STATE SENATOR -- FROM.
OF THOSE SAME DISTRICT GATHER
THAT I ONCE REPRESENTED.
WHO I GUESS IS NO LONGER AND --
PRISON.
THAT WAS ARE TRANSFERRED TO THE%
DAILY SAUDI REDEVELOPMENT AGENCY.
IN THE DAYS OF A FLOURISHING
REDEVELOPMENT AGENCY.
WHICH FOR CHERYL LAY GOVERNOR
BROWN BORDER AND AND AND AND TO
THE COW BELLS BOARD.
AS AGAIN.
BEGUN TRYING TO PUT TOGETHER.
A DEAL WITH DALY CITY A DEAL.
WITH THE PRIVATE PROPERTY OWNER.
ODD TO DO EXACTLY WHAT IT TRIED
TO DO BEFORE THE THE ECONOMIC.
RECESSION.
ABOUT THAT SAME TIME OF THE
RECESSION THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA STOP GIVING ANY MONEY.
TO AGRICULTURAL DISTRICTS HOW
MANY AGRICULTURAL DISTRICT.
CALIFORNIA FIFTY FOUR AND THEN
AS THE ANALYSIS NOTES THIS IS
DESPERATE ONE HEY -- FIRST FIFTY
FOUR AG DISTRICTS.
ADD. TO PROVIDE A MEANS FOR
THEMSELVES DOES REPORT
THEMSELVES.
THE COW PALACE HAS NOT ONLY DONE
IT.
BUT IT'S GOT MONEY IN THE BANK.
IT'S GOT OVER FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS IN RESERVES.
IT'S IN BETTER SHAPE MAYBE OR AT
LEAST THE SAME SHAPE AS THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA FINANCIALLY.
I WILL LOG CONCLUDE MADAM
CHAIRWOMAN I THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE.
BUT I AM INDEED -- EMOTIONAL
ABOUT THIS BECAUSE OF THE MESS
THAT INFORMATION WHICH ADDS BAND.
PROVIDE AND TO TRY THE QUESTION.
OF GUN SHOWS TWO ONE ABSOLUTE
[inaudible]
CONVEYANCE. TWO THREE ENTITIES
ONE OF WHICH HASN'T EVEN.
TAKEN A POSITION ON WHETHER IT
WOULD PURCHASE HEY.
IS SIMPLY BEYOND THE PALE.
THOSE PROVISIONS OUT OF THE BILL
NOW.
SAVE PEOPLE TIME AND EFFORT.
AND THE TAXPAYERS THE MONEY THAT
GOES IN TO OF VALUE WAITING THAT
PART OF THE BILL.
AND WHAT THE GUN SHOWS --
PROCEEDS AS THEY ARE.
AND I APPRECIATE YOUR TIME ON
AVAILABLE TO ANSWER.
ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE ALL
WITH ONE LAST I'VE GOTTA GIVE --
MEASURE KENNEDY -- A LITTLE
REASON. TO FOR ATTENTION THERE'S
A DISCUSSION OF EMERGENCY
RESPONSE LOCATION WHICH OF
COURSE IS PRE EMINENT.
BUT THE HELP PELOSI.
IS ONE SUCH LOCATION IN SAN
FRANCISCO THAT LAST LINE IS A
BIT OF OVER STATE.
BECAUSE LESS THAN TWO ACRES IS
IN THE CITY AND COUNTY OF SAN
FRANCISCO.
THE REMAINDER IS IN THE COUNTY
OF SAN MATTEO SPECIFICALLY THIS
STUDY OF DALY CITY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR FROM THE NEXT
WITNESS -- THIS BILL DID HAVE A
IT WAS TRIPLE REFERRED AND SO
THE OTHER SUBJECT MATTER OF IN
THE BILL THAT YOU'RE REFERENCING
WAS HEARD BY -- THOSE COMMITTEES
GEO AND TO GOVERN IN FINANCE AND
IT YOU ARE OUT.
CORRECT THAT ARE.
I'M JURISDICTION IS ON THE GUN
SHOW PORTION OF IT BUT GIVEN
THAT IS ALREADY BEEN HEARD ANY
OTHER COMMITTEES YOU WOULD --
YOU WE DON'T HAVE TO REALLY THE
AUTHORITY DISTRICT THE PART THAT
YOU WOULD SUGGEST STRIPPING AND
THOSE COMMITTEES.
WERE THE PLACE FOR YOU TO TELL
DISTRICT.
ANYWAY SO WE WILL NOW IT YOU DID
I'M SORRY THEN ELICIT SO LET'S
GET TO THE NEXT -- WITNESS.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIRPERSON.
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS KEVIN PATTERSON AND I AM
THE DIRECTOR OF THE COALITION TO
SAVE THE COW PALACE IN IN
DEFERENCE TO THE VERY IMPORTANT
WORK THAT WAS DONE HERE ALL DAY
TODAY I'M GOING TO BE VERY BRIEF.
THE BILL BEFORE US HERE IS FOR
YOU PARDON ME.
IS ACTUALLY TWO BILLS VERY
CLEARLY.
THE FIRST PORTION AS HAS BEEN
STATED AS WE SPEAK AS YOU MAY
WANT.
TO HAVE YOUR TESTIMONY RELATE TO
THE GUN SHOW ONLY SINCE THAT'S
REALLY THE ONLY PART WILL HAVE
JURISDICTION OVER AND SINCE IT
WAS ALREADY HEARD IN THE OTHER --
TWO IT WOULD NOT BE APPROPRIATE
FOR US TO MODIFY ANY OF THOSE
OTHER PORTIONS [inaudible]
I UNDERSTAND.
AND I WILL BE VERY BRIEF
[inaudible]
THE TWO PARTS OF THIS BILL THE
FIRST WHEN DEALING WITH A
CAPITALIST DECISION ALREADY TO
BAN GUN SHOWS CAN CERTAINLY BE
CODIFIED BY THIS BODY INTO LAW
AND WE WOULD SUPPORT THAT IF YOU
DID THAT.
THE SECOND PORTION OF THIS BILL
VERY TROUBLING AND I UNDERSTAND
THAT YOU DO NOT CONSIDER THAT
IT'S PART OF YOUR JURISDICTION
DEAL WITH.
I WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT
YOU CONSIDER THAT THE THE HELLO
THIS IS A STATE FAIRGROUND.
AND THE TRANSFER OF THE STATE
FAIR GROUND TO A PRIVATE.
ALBEIT IT IS A GOVERNMENT ARE
OVERSEEN BODY IT IS NEVERTHELESS
A LOCAL AUTHORITY THAT HAS NO
ABILITY TO PROTECT THIS STATE
FAIRGROUND.
FROM.
THE VERY POWERFUL.
INFLUENCES OF THE REAL ESTATE
MARKET IN THAT AREA SO ALTHOUGH
I RESPECTFULLY STE -- SUBMIT TO
THE YACHT -- POINTS MADE BY THE
SENATOR HERE.
POST THIS BILL.
THAT IT IS OPEN MINDED TO THE
FUTURE THE COW PALACE AND I
CERTAINLY HOPE IT IS I DO NOT
BELIEVE THAT THAT NEW BODY CAN
PROTECT.
THAT OUR PUBLIC ASSET.
FROM THE POWERS OF THE
DEVELOPMENT INTERESTS THAT WILL
BE BROUGHT TO BEAR ON IT.
I THEREFORE RESPECTFULLY ASK
THAT YOU ARE.
MAKE THIS BILL A COM WELL THERE
IS ONE MORE THING AND THAT IS.
TRUTHFULLY THE BOARD OF
DIRECTORS OF THE CAPITALIST
POINTED BY THE BY.
THE GOVERNOR.
IF THE SENATOR IS UNHAPPY WITH
THEM OR OF THE OTHER BODIES IN
THE AREA ARE UNHAPPY WITH THEM
THE GOVERNOR THIS NEW GOVERNOR
CAN APPOINT NEW BOARD MEMBERS.
THAT WILL THEN HAVE THE ABILITY.
TO MOVE FORWARD WITH THE FUTURE
OF THE CAPITALIST WHICH FROM MY
CONSTITUENTS OF WHICH THERE ARE
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE WHO ARE THE
USERS OF THE CAPITALIST AND SEE
THIS IS A VERY.
VERY IMPORTANT FACILITY NOT JUST
TODAY BUT FOR THE NEXT TEN
TWENTY THIRTY YEARS AS THE
DENSITY IN THAT AREA INCREASES
THAT IT NOT JUST BE TURNED INTO
ANOTHER.
MONSTER VERY DENSE HOUSING TRACT
BUT THAT IT RETAINED ITS ABILITY
TO SERVE THE PUBLIC AS A
FAIRGROUND.
AND HAVE AFFORDABLE HOUSING SO I
ASK THAT YOU CONSIDER THAT
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IS JUST. ONE
PIECE OF IT THE AFFORDABLE EVENT
CENTER IS CRITICAL TO CONTINUE
AND AGAIN I AM THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR THE TIME TODAY.
THANK YOU OTHER.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION THEY
COULD HAVE REMEMBER.
AFFAIRS SENSATION WE REMAIN
OPPOSITION BUT WE WOULD LIKE TO
THANK -- THE SENATOR IN A STAFF --
FOR PLEDGING TO CONTINUE TO HAVE
CONVERSATIONS THAT MOVING
FORWARD.
I'M CHAIRMAN MEMBERS A REGRET
THE SPEAKING ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA RIFLE PISTOL
ASSOCIATION ALSO GUNNERS
CALIFORNIA NATIONAL RIFLE
ASSOCIATION WE STAND IN
OPPOSITION OF THIS BILL AND A
LOT OF TALK ABOUT.
UNANIMOUS -- OPPOSITION SAN
FRANCISCO IN PROPOSITION SIXTY
THREE THIRTY TWO THOUSAND SAN
FRANCISCANS.
VOTED AGAINST PROPS AND SIXTY
THREE SOLDIERS WITHOUT THAT
THERE ARE SOME FOLKS THERE THAT
REALLY WOULD LIKE TO USE THIS
ERA.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS BROUGH
PATTERSON I AM A SERVICES GO BAY
AREA NATIVE AND LOCAL BUSINESS
OWNER -- WITHOUT PARKING.
WE CAN HAVE A FENCE.
FENCE IN THE AREA I WOULD HAVE
NO BUSINESS -- O I STRONGLY SB
YOU OPPOSE THIS BILL.
I THINK.
GOOD AFTERNOON JENNIFER EARLY
FROM ALAMEDA CALIFORNIA.
AS A PERSON WHO IS PARTIALLY
RESPONSIBLE FOR BRINGING
HISTORICAL EDUCATION THAT IS
LACKING IN OUR SCHOOL SYSTEMIN
CALIFORNIA AT THIS TIME.
THOUSANDS OF HAPPY CUSTOMERS AT
THE COW PALACE EVERY CHRISTMAS
DURING TECH INSPECTION I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
I AM PATRICK ALL FROM VALLEJO
AND I AM.
IN OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL.
HELLO I'M JOHN GM FROM RICHMOND
CALIFORNIA.
I'M IN OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL
AS IT IS CURRENTLY PROSTITUTE.
I'M ROBERT YOUNG I'M A SAN
FRANCISCO NATIVE AND I
CONSIDERING THAT THIS IS A UP
THE SOLIDITY IN THE AREA WITHOUT
HERE.
A OPPOSE THE BILL AS CURRENTLY
WRITTEN.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM MY COLLEAGUES.
HAVE A MOTION.
SEND YOUR COPY IF YOU SAID
EVERYTHING YOU WANTED TO SAY.
I WAS KIDDING I WAS KIDDING.
GOOD TO HAVE YOU HERE -- THEN --
SENATOR WIENER WOULD -- WOULD
YOU LIKE TO SHOW THAT YOU ARE A
TOUGHER DUDE THEN SENATOR CAUGHT.
HI HE'S PRETTY TOUGH PRETTY
TIGHT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
LIVE A RATES [inaudible]
RIVER MOTION.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL.
THE MOTION IS THE PAST TO
APPROPRIATIONS SKINNER.
MORE LOCKED NO MORE LIKE NOW
BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE JACKSON MITCHELL
MORALE.
AROUND AND WIENER.
WIENER AYE. TWO TWO AND WILL PUT
IT ON HOLD.
THANK YOU ASKED HIM.
HERE WE HAVE STONE IT CAME FIRST
ACTUALLY.
AND YEAH FOR ITEM NUMBER TWENTY
SB SIX SIX SIX SO YOU GOT A GOOD
NUMBER [inaudible]
SENATOR STUFF [inaudible]
YOU HAVE.
I THINK WHAT WE DO HERE AT WE
JUST WE JUST A COUPLE SECONDS
[inaudible]
HONORABLE COLLEAGUES.
THE ROOM WE SHOULD HAVE NICE
PEACE AND QUIET AGAIN.
THANK YOU SIR.
MISTER CHAIR.
HONORABLE COLLEAGUES -- I AM
PRESENTING SB I'M NOT FOND OF
THE NUMBER.
SIX SIX SIX NOT A GOOD WAY TO
START.
LAST YEAR THROUGH THE BUDGET
PROCESS THE LEGISLATURE ENACTED
THE MENTAL HEALTH DIVERSION
PROGRAM THROUGH AB.
EIGHTEEN TEN HOWEVER THE PROGRAM
WAS OVERLY BROAD IN CONTAIN MANY
FLAWS.
IN ORDER TO RECTIFY THAT THE
LEGISLATURE PASSED A FOLLOW A
MEASURE.
SB.
TWO ONE FIVE WHICH INCLUDED MANY
FIXES AND RECEIVED NEAR
UNANIMOUS SUPPORT.
SB TWO ONE FIVE STATED THAT
THOSE WHO ARE CHARGED WITH
SEVERAL VERY SERIOUS CRIME SUCH
AS MURDER AND RAPE.
SHOULD BE EXCLUDED FROM
ELIGIBILITY FOR THE MENTAL
HEALTH DIVERSION PROGRAM.
HOWEVER IN CONSULTATION WITH
PROSECUTORS FOR MY DISTRICT IN
RIVERSIDE COUNTY.
IT IS CLEAR THAT SB TWO ONE FIVE
DID NOT GO FAR ENOUGH.
THERE ARE STILL SEVERAL VERY
DANGEROUS CRIMES STILL LEFT OPEN
FOR POTENTIAL DIVERSION.
MY BILL CLOSES THAT LOW BILL BY
ADDING ARMED ROBBERY.
ASSAULT WITH A DEADLY WEAPON.
CHILD ABUSE.
ELDER ABUSE THE LIST OF
INELIGIBLE CRIMES FOR MENTAL
HEALTH THE VERSION.
IS A VERY SERIOUS AND DANGEROUS
CRIMES IN THOSE ACCUSED OF SUCH
CRIMES SHOULD STAND TRIAL.
AND NOT BE DIVERTED TO A MENTAL
HEALTH PROGRAM TO A SKATE
POTENTIAL PUNISHMENT. FOR THOSE
REASONS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
EUROPE OF WE HAVE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES OR TIFFANY MATTHEW
SOME AFTER THE CALIFORNIA
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS AGENTS PART.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS MIKE A
DOCTOR OFF ON BEHALF OF THE ACLU
OF CALIFORNIA HERE IN RESPECT
OPPOSITION TO THE SPELL.
WHILE WE APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S
GOAL OF PROTECTING PUBLIC SAFETY
WE DO NOT BELIEVE SB SIX SIX SIX
IS NECESSARY TO FURTHER THAT
PURPOSE.
IMPORTANTLY EXISTING LAW
PROVIDES THAT MENTAL HEALTH
DIVERSION WILL BE GRANTED ONLY
F..
AFTER CONSIDERING THE OPINIONS%
OF THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY THE
DEFENSE OR A QUALIFIED MENTAL
HEALTH EXPERTS.
AS WELL IF THE DEFENDANTS
VIOLENCE AND CRIMINAL HISTORY
THE CURRENT CHARGE DEFENSE AND
ANY OTHER FACTORS THAT THE COURT
DEEMS APPROPRIATE.
THE COURT IS QUOTE SATISFIED
THAT THE DEFENDANT WILL NOT POSE
AN UNREASOABLE RISK OF DANGER
TO PUBLIC SAFETY IF TREATED IN
THE COMMUNITY AND QUOTE.
THIS IS ALL TO SAY THAT UNDER
CURRENT LAW A PERSON CHARGED
WITH ANY OF THE OFFENSES NAMED
IN SB SIX SIX SIX WOULD ONLY BE
GRANTED DIVERSION IF THEIR
TREATMENT IN THE COMMUNITY WOULD
NOT JEOPARDIZE PUBLIC SAFETY.
THERE IS NO INDICATION THAT
JUDGES CANNOT EFFECTIVELY WAY
THE RELEVANT FACTORS.
AND APPROPRIATELY APPROPRIATELY
USE THEIR JUDGMENT TURMAN WHO
SHOULD AND WHO SHOULD NOT BE
GRANTED DIVERSION.
A BLANKET EXCLUSION FOR SPECIFIC
CHARGES IS THEREFORE UNNECESSARY
FOR THESE REASONS WE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THE BILL
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER ASHCROFT.
LESLIE CALDWELL CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION --
SB SIX SIX SIX SIX TO REMOVE
OFFENSES FROM THE LIST OF
CHARGES THAT MAY BE CONSIDERED
BY THE COURT OR MENTAL HEALTH
DIVERSION.
THEREFORE UNDER SIX SIX SIX EVEN
IF THE COURT INCLUDES THE VICTIM
DEFENDANT AND COMMUNITY WOULD
BENEFIT FROM THIS COURT
SUPERVISED DIVERSION AND
TREATMENT.
THE COURT WOULD BE POWERLESS TO
ORDER IT.
ROUGHLY A THIRD OF THE INMATES
IN CALIFORNIA JAIL SUFFER FROM
SERIOUS MENTAL ILLNESS. TOO
OFTEN UNTREATED MENTAL ILLNESS
IS THE REASON THESE INDIVIDUALS
ARE INVOLVED WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT IN THE FIRST PLACE.
THE VAST OVER CRIMINALIZATION OF
THE MENTALLY ILL COUPLED WITH
THE DEARTH OF SERVICES FOR THE
MENTALLY ILL AS LEAD TO JAIL AND
PRISON.
OVERCROWDING REPEATED AND COSTLY
LAWSUITS AND THE WAREHOUSING OF
THE MENTALLY ILL PERSONS IN
FACILITIES THAT WERE NOT
DESIGNED TO TREAT THEM.
WE HEARD EARLIER TESTIMONY ABOUT
LOS ANGELES COUNTY BEING THE
LARGEST MENTAL HEALTH
INSTITUTION IN THE NATION.
IT COMPETES ONLY WITH.
COOK COUNTY JAIL.
I TALKED TO THE SOLANO COUNTY
SHERIFF YESTERDAY.
ASKING HIM -- WHAT PERCENTAGE OF
HIS PUBLIC JAIL POPULATION WAS
ON PSYCHOTROPIC MEDICATION?
HE SAID 24% OF HIS JAIL
POPULATION IS ON PSYCHOTROPIC OR
OTHER MENTAL HEALTH.
THE MEDICATIONS AND THAT DOESN'T
INCLUDE THE PERSONS WHO NEED
MEDICATION BUT REFUSED TO TAKE
IT.
THE SHERIFF IN SOLANO LIKE MOST
SHARE OF REFUSES TO FORCE
MEDICATION.
IN JUNE OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN
GOVERNOR BROWN IN THE
LEGISLATURE TOOK STEPS TO
ADDRESS THE PROBLEM OF OUR
PRISONS AND JAILS TURNING INTO
MAKESHIFT MENTAL HEALTH
FACILITIES.
YOU KNOW COULD SECTION ONE
THOUSAND ONE POINT THREE SET.
THIS SECTION ALLOWS BUT DOES NOT
REQUIRE TRIAL COURTS TO DIVERT
MENTALLY ILL DEFENDANTS INTO PRE
EXISTING TREATMENT PROGRAMS.
WHERE THE PROPOSED TREATMENT
PROGRAM IS CONSISTENT WITH THE
NEEDS OF THE DEFENDANT AND THE
SAFETY OF THE COMMUNITY?
BY ALLOWING THIS EARLY DIVERSION
THE MENTALLY ILL.
THE COMING OF THE MENTALLY ILL
THE COMMUNITY IS PROTECTED BY
REDUCING RECIDIVISM RATES FOR
MENTALLY ILL DEFENDANTS.
AND AVOIDS THE UNNECESSARY AND
UNPRODUCTIVE BECAUSE OF TRIAL
AND INCARCERATION.
I WOULD LIKE TO SHARE A COUPLE
OF EXAMPLES OF SUCCESS I EVEN
SERIOUSLY.
MENTALLY ILL -- AND VERY VIOLENT
OFFENDERS WHO WENT INTO VETERANS
COURT.
A VERY SUCCESSFUL DIVERSION
PROGRAM.
ALBERT C. WAS A VETERAN OF THE
IRAQ WAR.
WAS ORIGINALLY CHARGED WITH
ATTEMPTED MURDER.
HE WAS IN A FULL PSYCHOSIS DO DO
IS P. T. S. D..
CAME FROM HIS TOUR OF DUTY IN
IRAQ.
AND BELIEVE HIS ROOMMATE WAS
ATTACKING HIM.
HE REPEATEDLY STABBED THE
ROOMMATE AND STOPPED WHEN HE
FINALLY HEARD HIS ROOMMATE
SCREAMING YOU'RE KILLING ME.
THE CALL FOR EMERGENCY SERVICES
FOR HIS ROOMMATE AND TURNED
HIMSELF IN TO THE POLICE.
HE WAS THAT.
AFTER GREAT DISCUSSION ADMITTED
INTO THE VETERANS -- COURT.
THERE WAS A GREAT DISCUSSION
BETWEEN THE COURT THE DA THE
DEFENSE AND THE SERVICE
PROVIDERS VERY ROBUST DISCUSSION
HE WAS PLACED INTO THE PROGRAM.
HE GRADUATED FROM THE VETERANS
COURT PROGRAM HAVING NO
VIOLATIONS AND NO SANCTIONS.
WHICH MEANS HE DID EVERYTHING
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
HE REMAINS IN COUNSELING AND ON
MEDICATION AND IS A SUCCESSFUL
MEMBER OF OUR SOCIETY TODAY.
JOE SO FAR WAS CHARGED WITH
ASSAULT WITH A DEADLY WEAPON AND
SPOUSAL ABUSE.
DURING THE INCIDENT HE
ULTIMATELY RECOGNIZE THE DANGER
OF HIS ACTIONS UNLOADED HIS GUN
AND TURN HIMSELF INTO THE POLICE.
AS HE WORKS THROUGH VETERANS
COURT YOU REALIZE THE
SERIOUSNESS.
OF HIS MENTAL AND WILL ILLNESS
AND SUBSTANCE ABUSE PROBLEMS KEY
TO GRADUATED FROM VETERANS COURT
WITH NO SANCTIONS NO VIOLATIONS
AND IS A VERY PRODUCTIVE MEMBER
OF OUR COMMUNITY [inaudible]
I CAN.
I CAN GIVE EXAMPLES OF HOW MUCH --
DIVERSION CAN HELP THOSE WHO
HAVE COMMITTED SERIOUS CRIMES IN
TURN THEIR LIVES AROUND THOSE
PROTECTING THE SAFETY OF THE
COMMUNITY SO TO BE CLEAR.
CPT A DOES NOT BELIEVE THAT
EVERY PERSON THAT SUBMITS ONE OF
THESE CRIMES IS SUITABLE FOR
MENTAL HEALTH DIVERSION.
HOWEVER AS WORKERS ON THE FRONT
LINES.
OF THE COMMUNITY OUR CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM WE ALSO KNOW THAT
A RULE PREVENTING A NEUTRAL
JUDGE FROM CONSIDERING THE
INDIVIDUAL BEFORE THEM.
THE FACTS OF EACH CASE.
AND THE COMMUNITY IS A
TREMENDOUS STEP BACKWARDS ON THE
ROAD TO MEANINGFUL CRIMINAL
JUSTICE REFORM AND MENTAL HEALTH
SYSTEM REFORM.
WE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR NO
VOTE ON AS THE THIS CALL.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM [inaudible]
MY COLEY.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO MAKE A MOTION
THEN I'D LIKE THEM ALL.
AND WE HAVE A MOTION.
CENTER STONE YEAH LIKE TO MAKE A
CLOSING ASSIGNMENT -- MISTER
CHAIRMAN FIRST BILL APPRECIATE
THE OPPOSITION -- AND THEIR
VIEWPOINTS -- I WISH ALL THE THE
STORIES THAT THE PUBLIC DEFENDER
DESCRIBED HAD A HAPPY ENDING THE
WAY SHE SAYS THEY DO.
BY HER OWN ADMISSION WITH THE
SOLANO SHERIFF 24% HAD MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES WHICH MEANS THAT
76%.
DID NOT.
NOT TALKING ABOUT TRIVIAL CRIMES
ARE TALKING ABOUT VERY SERIOUS
CRIMES.
ASSAULT WITH A DEADLY WEAPON.
SEXUALLY ABUSING A CHILD.
SEXUALLY OR FINANCIALLY ABUSING
AN ADULT.
THESE ARE THE LIST OF AN
ELIGIBLE CRIMES FOR MENTAL
DIVERSION TODAY.
WHICH I THINK ARE INAPPROPRIATE
I'D RATHER ERR ON THE 75% THAT.
DID THESE CRIMES WITH FULL
MENTAL CAPACITY.
THESE ARE THE TYPE OF PEOPLE
THAT SHOULD BE PUNISHED.
THAT'S WIRED YOUR SUPPORT OF SB
SIX SIX SIX THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE.
THANK YOU CENTER STONE.
I HAVE A MOTION ADAM SECTOR TO
THE CALL THE ROLL.
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS SKINNER.
MORE LOCKED I WOULD LIKE AYE
BRADFORD.
JACKSON MITCHELL MORALE HIGH
MORALE HIGH WIENER.
OKAY WE'LL PUT ON CALL.
WITH A SECRETARY PLEASE NOTE THE
REQUEST FOR RECONSIDERATION.
THAT TAKES THIS TIME.
WHILE I'M TWENTY ONE SENATE BILL.
SEVEN SENATE BILL. SIX SEVEN SIX
SEVEN EIGHT I'M.
HAVING TROUBLE WITH BY SENATOR
GLAZER.
YEAH YOU ONLY HAVE ONE BILL IS
THAT CORRECT.
OKAY SO WELL MAYBE SPEAK FAST
AND TRYING TO GET SENATOR JONES
WITH A FEW OF THESE TWO I THINK
SO LET.
HIM FALL FIVE SO -- WILL TRY TO
BE A VERY CONCISE ALASMY
WITNESSES TO TO BE TO DO THE
SAME.
SO FIRST I'M HAPPY TO ACCEPT THE
THAT THE LEAD THE END CASSIDY
PROVISION.
THIS BILL IMPORTANTLY
ESTABLISHES A FIVE YEAR PILOT
PROGRAMS OF PILOT PROGRAM IN
THREE COUNTIES.
CARRY OUT A RESTORATIVE JUSTICE
PROGRAM AS AN ALTERNATIVE TO
TRADITIONAL INCARCERATION FOR A
LIMITED.
SET OF CRIMES A LIMITED SET OF
CRIMES.
RESTORATIVE JUSTICE IS A CENTURY
OLD ALTERNATIVE TO INCARCERATION.
ALLOWS OFFENDERS TO COME FACE TO
FACE WITH THEIR VICTIMS TO THE
OFFENDER CAN MAKE AMENDS
DIRECTLY TO THE INJURED.
PARTY CAN BEGIN THE HEALING
PROCESS.
RESTORATIVE JUSTICE HAS BEEN
PRACTICING MANY COUNTRIES AROUND
THE WORLD.
AND MY COMMUNITIES IN OUR CITIES
THAT FEEL SHUT OUT OF THE
GOVERNMENT RUN JUSTICE SYSTEM.
EXPLORES HOW THESE PROGRAMS CAN
IMPACT CALIFORNIA'S JUST ASSIST.
THIS DIVERSION PROGRAM WOULD BE
UNIQUE AMONG ANY ADULT DIVERSION
PROGRAM IN THE STATE BECAUSE IT
OFFERS SURVIVORS.
THE OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE THEIR
NEEDS VALIDATED.
AND ADDRESS TO THEIR
PARTICIPATION IN THE PROGRAM. TO
THEIR VOLUNTARY PARTICIPATION
THE SURVIVOR WOULD BE ABLE.
TO BE PART OF THE JUSTICE
PROCESS AND WORK TO THE TRAUMA
THEY'VE EXPERIENCED.
AT THE SAME TIME THE RESPONSIBLE
PARTY WOULD HAVE TO COMPLY WITH
PROGRAM REQUIREMENTS.
INCLUDING BUT NOT LIMITED TO
COUNSELING COMMUNITY SERVICE.
RESTITUTION BUT THIS.
THANK YOU MEMBERS TO ATTEND
SCHOOL OR WORK.
IS THIS PROCESS THAT SIR THE
SURVIVOR WOULD BEGIN THE PROCESS
OF HEALING WHILE THE RESPONSIBLE
PARTY WOULD BE EXPOSED TO REAL
LIFE IMPLICATIONS.
OF THEIR ACTIONS AND HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS THE
UNDERLYING ISSUES THAT LED.
THEM TO COMMIT THE CRIME.
IN THE FIRST PLACE.
SO THERE'S A LOT MORE I COULD
TELL YOU ABOUT RESTORATIVE
JUSTICE PROGRAMS THAT HAVE
HAPPENED AROUND THE COUNTRY.
I EXAMPLES OF PROGRESS WITH OUR
YOUTH IN REGARD TO IT AS WELL.
I HAVE TO WITNESSES THAT I WANT
TO MAKE SURE YOU HEAR THAT HAVE
SOME PERSONAL EXPERIENCES IN
THAT.
IN THE PROGRAM AND SO JOINING ME
TODAY IS FILLED MELENDEZ ROOMS.
AND AND GLENN BECK FROM THE
ELEVATOR CENTER FOR HUMAN RIGHTS
AND I BY THE TO SHARE YOUR
THOUGHTS.
MEMBERS OF THE WE'RE HEARING US
OUT.
AS HE SAID I'M PHILLIP MELENDEZ
WITH RESTORE JUSTICE AND I CAN
PERSONALLY ATTEST TO THE
TRANSFORMATIVE POWER OF
RESTORATIVE JUSTICE AS PUT FORTH
IN HIS BILL -- AND TO SAY WHY AG
I GUESS I COULD GIVE YOU SOME
BACKGROUND IT I WAS.
INCARCERATED FOR NEARLY TWENTY
YEARS -- I WAS ORIGINALLY
SENTENCED TO THIRTY YEARS TO
LIFE PLUS ANOTHER ELEVEN YEARS
ON TOP OF THAT.
HOWEVER I AM A BENEFICIARY OF
SENATE BILL TWO SIXTY ONE WHICH
ADVANCE MY PAROLE HEARING AND
GAVE ME A CHANCE TO REDEEM --
BASED ON THE FACT THAT I WAS A
TEENAGER WHEN I COMMITTED MY
CRIME.
AND IN TWO THOUSAND AND
SEVENTEEN I WAS FOUND SUITABLE
FOR PAROLE WHICH IS.
NO EASY TASK AND IT'S NOT JUST
BECAUSE OF THE CRIMES BUT ALSO
JUST BECAUSE I HAVE TO WORK
PASSED THE TRAUMAS THAT LED ME
TO A CRIMINAL LIFESTYLE IN THE
FIRST PLACE.
AND ANOTHER BARRIER.
TO MY TRANSFORMATION AND HEALING
WAS ACTUALLY THE PRISON
ENVIRONMENT AND WHEN I FIRST
BEGAN MY PRISON SENTENCE.
I WAS PLACED IN A IN AN
ENVIRONMENT WHERE IT WAS.
MORE ABOUT SURVIVAL THAN ANY --
TRANSFORMATIVE PROGRAMS ARE
HEALING AND RESTORATIVE JUSTICE.
BUT FINALLY AFTER GETTING TO US
AND CLINTON.
I WAS ABLE TO TAKE SOME
REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMS AND IN
ONE OF THESE PROGRAMS --
SURVIVOR OF PRIME.
SHARE YOUR STORY WITH US AND NO
THE FIRST TIME I EVER BROKE DOWN
IN A IN A IN A GROUP.
BUT IT WAS REALLY TRANSFORMATIVE
AND HOW FROM FOR ME TO COME FACE
TO FACE WITH THIS WOMAN TO
REALLY LOOK AT THE CRIMES THAT I
HAD COMMITTED INNER IN A REAL
AND HONEST WAY.
AND THAT PUT ME ON A POSITIVE
PATH -- AFTER THAT -- AFTER
TAKING THOSE PROGRAMS I LEARNED --
TO WHAT LED ME TO THE CRIME AS
IS IN -- INSIDE IS NEEDED TO BE
GRANTED PAROLE -- AND ONE OF
THOSE THINGS THAT I FOUND WAS
THAT YOU HAVE TO DE HUMANIZE.
VICTIMS YOU HAVE TO LOOK AT THEM
IS NOT HUMAN BEINGS.
ACTUALLY PERPETRATED CRIME
BECAUSE IT'S HARD TO HOW HARM
ANOTHER HUMAN BEING -- AND THEN
ONCE YOU COMMIT A CRIME.
YOU PUT IN A CAGE AND PUT
THROUGH A VERY IMPERSONAL
PROCESS.
IN THE COURT YOU APPEAR COUGHED
UP -- TOLD TO FACE FORWARD ONLY
LOOK AT THE JUDGE.
AND DON'T LOOK AT THE VIC.
CRIME.
AND AND TO ME THAT'S LOOKING
BACK RIBS.
THAT'S NOT OKAY WITH A PRISON.
PRISON SYSTEM CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM I'M SORRY IT'S A LITTLE
NERVE WRACKING ENOUGH HERE AND
NOT TOO MANY PEOPLE IN THE CROWD
BUT IT'S HARD TO HEAR THESE
THINGS ANYWAY -- BUT YEAH SO
JUST LOOKING AT THE PRISON
SYSTEM -- WE DON'T REQUIRE
OFFENDERS TO SEE THEIR VICTIMS
AND THERE'S NO OPPORTUNITY TO
MAKE AMENDS EVEN IF THE VICTIM
BELIEVES THAT THIS CONTACT WOULD
HELP THEM HEAL AND OBTAIN
JUSTICE.
AND JUST TO BE CLEAR THIS
PROGRAM WOULD NOT INCLUDE --
OFFENDERS ACCUSED OF THE MOST
SERIOUS CRIMES LIKE.
THE ONES THAT I'VE COMMITTED.
BUT I CAN DEFINITELY ATTEST TO
THE FACT THAT FACING THE TRUTH
OF THE HARM THAT YOU'VE CAUSED
IS DEEPLY TRANSFORMATIVE AND CAN
SPARK HUGE SHIFTS.
IN THE WAY WE SEE OTHER HUMAN
BEINGS AND THE WAY THAT WE SEE
OUR COMMUNITIES.
AND IN HAVING THOSE DIALOGUES
BETWEEN SURVIVORS AND THOSE
RESPONSIBLE FOR HARM IS ONE OF
THE KEY COMPONENTS OF THIS BILL
THAT I THINK.
WILL REDUCE RECIDIVISM AND
INCREASED PUBLIC SAFETY SO I ASK
THAT YOU PLEASE SUPPORT SENATE
BILL. SIX SEVENTY EIGHT TO PLAY
SURVIVORS OF CRIME AT THE CENTER
OF THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE PROCESS
AND GIVE THEM A CHANCE IF. TO BE
MADE WHOLE AGAIN.
THANKS THANK YOU MISTER MELENDEZ.
GOOD AFTERNOON GOING BACK AS FOR
ALL BAKER CENTER FOR HUMAN
RIGHTS I'LL BE BRIEF I WANT TO
FOCUS ON HOW THIS BILL IS AN
EXAMPLE OF GOOD GOVERNMENT --
THE SENATOR AND THE SPONSORS OF
IDENTIFIED A PROMISING PRACTICE
SOMETHING THERE'S GOING WELL IN
ANOTHER JURISDICTION FOR TEN
YEARS IN BROOKLYN NEW YORK.
ANOTHER PRETTY FOR THE BUILDINGS
A PILOT SUBJECT TO LOCAL CONTROL
SUBJECT TO A SUNSET.
AND SORRY TO EVALUATION THIS IS
SORT OF HOW WE SHOULD DO
GOVERNMENT THIS IS HOW WE SHOULD
EVALUATE.
AND INNOVATE [inaudible]
THERE'S ALL THE OPTIONS WILL
STILL BE THERE THAT WE HAVE
TODAY.
BUT THE OPTIONS TODAY ARE
GENERALLY INCARCERATE.
PROBATION SUPERVISION OR NOT.
THIS BILL GIVES FOR IN A
JURISDICTION WHERE TO PROVE
BECAUSE AGAIN STILL SORRY TO
LOCAL CONTROL YOU HAVE TO HAVE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT APPROVAL.
AND LOCAL DISTRICT ATTORNEY
APRIL. TO EVEN HAVE THIS PROCESS.
THEN.
THAT ALLOWS THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY TO OFFER THE SURVIVOR
OF CRIME ONE OTHER OPTION.
NOTHING PROBATION JAIL OR AT
WHAT WOULD BE LIKE IF YOU ACT IF
THE PERSON HAD TO FACE YOU.
AND LISTEN TO YOU CAN HEAR FROM
YOU WHAT HOW IT FELT. TO BE
VICTIMIZED.
WHAT WOULD IT FEEL LIKE IF THAT
MAKE AMENDS DIRECTLY TO YOU?
WHERE THEY DO RESTITUTION
DIRECTLY TO YOU BUT IF THEY HAD
TO GROW IN FRONT OF YOU?
AS OPPOSED TO BEING SENT TO A
CELL IN AN ANONYMOUS PROCESS.
AND SO THEN EACH INDIVIDUAL CASE
THIS THIRTY TO THE APPROVAL. FOR
MOST OF THE SURVIVOR THE CRIME.
DOES THE VICTIM WANT THIS.
ACTUALLY THE DEFENDANT ALSO HAS
TO AGREE.
JUST RETURNING THE DEFENSE THE
COURT AND THE PROGRAM THAT WILL
RUN IT ALL HAVE TO AGREE AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL. FOR ANYONE TO
PRODUCE.
SO LIKE I SAID I THINK THIS IS
AN EXAMPLE OF HOW GOVERNMENT
SHOULD WORK.
IDENTIFY PROMISING PRACTICE
BRING IT FORWARD [inaudible]
EVALUATE.
IT WAS WORTH REPLICATING LIKE I
SAID THIS IS A SUNSET.
SOCIAL CONTROL SO YOU TO
EVALUATION I THINK IT'S VERY
PROMISING PRACTICE.
HAVE ALL YOUR WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OKAY SO ARE THERE OTHER
WITNESSES IN THE ROOM THAT ONE I
JUST INDICATE THEIR SUPPORT OF
THE GOOD AFTERNOON ANDRE PERRY
WITH CALIFORNIANS FOR SAFETY AND
JUSTICE AS WELL AS CRIME
SURVIVORS FOR SAFETY AND JUSTICE
WE THINK THE AUTHOR -- FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I'M NOT SURE HERNANDEZ IN HALF
THE CALIFORNIA TRANSFER KAMEL
JUSTICE IN SUPPORT.
JIM LINDBERGH ON BEHALF OF THE
FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION
OF CALIFORNIA AND ALSO HERE
TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CATHOLIC CONFERENCE
IN SOME [inaudible]
ANY OTHER.
ALL RIGHT SO NOW LET'S SEE IF
THERE'S WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SELECT A DATE.
MY TO SINCE I STILL HAVE TO GO
PERCENT THREE MORE.
BILLS AND OTHER COMMITTEE SO
[inaudible]
YOU -- MAKE CLOSE -- AND UNLESS
SENATOR MORTON Là YOU'D LIKE
QUESTION.
OKAY GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU CHAIR AND MEN MEMBERS
FOR HEARING OF ABOUT THIS BILL I
KNOW IT.
IT GETS A LITTLE OUT OF OUR
COMFORT ZONE IN TERMS OF HOW OUR
CURRENT SYSTEMS WORKING TODAY
AND MAYBE NOT WORKING TODAY.
BUT AS THE WITNESSES OF INDICATE
TO PILOT.
IT HAS LIMITED APPLICATION IT
HAS EVALUATION.
COMPONENTS REQUIRES THE
COOPERATION OF EVERYBODY
INVOLVED AND JUST DO IT WITHOUT.
ANY ANY ONE PARTY SAND --
ANYTHING BUT YES.
AND SO I THINK IT HAS A LOT OF
HOPE AND PROMISE IT'S WIDE.
BILLING WHY AM.
I ES GOT ME OUT OF MY OWN
CONVENTIONAL WIFE.
FIND RICARDO.
JUSTICE SYSTEM I WANT TO THANK
BILL COMING AND SHARING HIS
PERSONAL STORY AND THANK YOU FOR
ALL YOUR WORK IN THIS AREA THANK.
STORAGE.
NOW YOU.
WE'VE BEEN INFORMED THAT THE
CHAIR SHOULD NOT BE MAKING
MOTIONS AND I'M.
HESITANT TO MAKE MOTIONS FOR
WHEN IT ASKED SOME QUESTIONS.
BECAUSE OF THAT BECAUSE OF WHERE
I'M GETTING HUNG UP SENATOR
GLAZERS IS THE TERM -- GRANT
PROGRAM I'M.
A FIVE YEAR COMPETITIVE GRANT
PROGRAM THREE COUNTY SAN I'M
WONDERING WORST.
WHERE'S THE GRANT MONEY COME
FROM.
THERE ARE THERE ARE SOME THAT.
NAVIN IS AVAILABLE THAT WOULD GO
THROUGH THE TYPICAL BUDGET
PROCESS WHETHER THAT'S PROP
FORTY SEVEN MONEY OR FOR GENERAL
FUND MONEY.
DON'T KNOW IF THE BILL AT THAT
THE FUNDING MECHANISM IS IS A
PART OF THIS BILL THAT'S BEFORE
YOU.
YEAH SO IT WOULD BE UPON
APPROPRIATIONS SO.
IT SHOULD BE A HOPEFULLY NOT A
HANG UP IN TERMS OF THE VALUE OF
THE POTENTIAL OF THE PROGRAM
DOES STILL NEED TO GO THROUGH
THE BUDGET APPROVAL AND THEN
WHATEVER.
PLACE THAT THE MONEY'S GONNA BE
ACQUIRED.
A WELL I I WILL NOT BE VOTING ON
THIS TODAY JUST BECAUSE I WANT
TO DO MORE RESEARCH.
IN IN THERE FOR AYE AYE
[inaudible]
THE MOTION.
SURE WE CAN WAIT TILL WE CAN
WAIT ON A MOTION.
WE HAVE OTHER MEMBERS BACK.
ROLAND BUT ANYWAY.
IT DOESN'T MEAN THAT YOU WILL BE
HAVE -- NECESSARILY HEALTH
CENTER PLACER JUST MEANS THAT WE
WOULD WAIT UNTIL WE HAVE OUR
MEMBERS.
SCHERING AG CLOSE WITH A COMMENT
YES YOU MAY JUST TO NOTE THAT.
THE COST OF INCARCERATION THINK
ABOUT THE PRICE THERE THIS IS.
SEVENTY FIVE THOUSAND AND
MAINTAIN OUR STATE -- PRISON
SYSTEM.
SEVENTY FIVE THOUSAND AND AND
LOOK WHAT I ALSO WAS LEFT BEHIND
THEIR ABILITY.
TO A RESTORED FAITH AND HUMANITY
OF THE SURVIVOR AND THEIR
FAMILIES.
AND OF COURSE THE PERSON THAT'S
IN CORPORATE AND CARS RATED THAT.
THEIR POTENTIAL AND THEY HAVE
POTENTIAL TO BE GOOD.
AND TO CONTRIBUTE TO ALSO LOST
BEHIND THOSE BARS TO SELL.
THERE IS A COST TO THIS ALTHOUGH
WHAT IT'LL BE DELIBERATING ITS
OWN WAY.
BUT THE POTENTIAL OF IT IS.
IS ENORMOUS AND I WILL BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL AND I DID DO
YOU HAVE A I RECOMMENDATION ON
IT AND WE'LL SEE WHAT.
HE DOES WHEN WE HAVE TO MEMBERS
BACK.
THANK.
THANK YOU.
AND NOW WE WILL GO TO OUR FINAL
BILL.
AND SENATOR JONES HAVE BEEN IN
THE ROOM ALSO ALL TIMES TODAY.
AND SO WILL ALLOW HIM.
TO PRESENT
.
YOU MAY PROCEED THANK YOU.
I APOLOGIZE FOR THE
MISUNDERSTANDING AND HAVE BEEN
IN THE ROOM THREE TIMES WITH
THREE TIMES AS A CHARM I HOPE SO.
WELL I'M AND MY EARLIER BILL I
WAS I CAN SEND AYE AS SO IT WAS
UP ON HIGHER UP ON THE ANYWAYS
OPPOSITE THIS BILL NOW.
SB.
SEVEN OH ONE I'D LIKE TO START
BY ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEES
SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS OUTLINED IN
THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS.
I YOU SHOULD EACH HAVE A MARK UP
IN FRONT OF YOU AND THINKING TO
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THE WORK ON
THE BILL I KNOW IT'S SAID OFTEN
BUT IN THIS CASE IT'S ABSOLUTELY
TRUE THAT THE AMENDMENTS MAKE
THE BILL -- MUCH MORE WORKABLE
AND BETTER SO I THANK YOU FOR
THAT SB SEVEN OH ONE CORRECTS A
DUE PROCESS VIOLATION.
CURRENTLY IN LAW BY CLARIFYING
THAT THE MERE ISSUANCE OF A
WARRANT DOES NOT MAKE A FELON
OUT OF AN OTHERWISE LAWFUL GUN
OWNER.
THE PROVISION ADDING AN
OUTSTANDING WARRANT TO PENAL
CODE SECTIONS.
TWO NINE EIGHT ZERO ZERO AND TWO
NINE EIGHT ZERO FIVE WAS ADDED
IN THE BUDGET TRAILER BILL IN.
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN LATER
THAT SAME YEAR ATTEMPT WAS MADE
IN YET ANOTHER BUDGET TRAILER
BILL. TO CLEAN UP THE
REQUIREMENT BY REQUIRING THE
DEFENDANT HAVE KNOWLEDGE OF THE
WARRANT.
UNFORTUNATELY THE NEW CODE
SECTION ADDED WAS MISS NUMBERED
AND PRETTY MUCH ON FIND OF ALL.
LAST YEAR THE THE NEW CODE
SECTION WITH THE KNOWLEDGE
REQUIREMENT WAS RE NUMBERED
THROUGH THE SENATE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEES MAINTENANCE.
OF THE CODES BILL.
THIS PUT IT CLOSER TO WHERE IT
SHOULD BE BUT SINCE NONE OF THE
AMENDMENTS WENT THROUGH THE
PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE.
THE NEW CODE SECTION WAS
VIRTUALLY UNKNOWN AND OFTEN
OVERLOOKED.
SO NOW WE'RE HERE TO FIX IT WITH
A POLICY BILL IN FRONT OF A
POLICY COMMITTEE.
SB SEVEN OH ONE WILL DELETE THE
ATTEMPTED FIX AND INSTEAD
CLARIFY IN THE CORRECT CODE
SECTIONS.
THAT A PERSON WITH AN
OUTSTANDING WARRANT FOR AN
OFFENSE MUST HAVE KNOWLEDGE OF
THAT WARRANT.
IN ORDER TO BE GUILTY OF A
MISDEMEANOR FOR ILLEGALLY
POSSESSING A FIREARM.
AGAIN I'D LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR THEIR WORK TO
CLEAN UP THIS ISSUE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
TODAY WITH ME IS LAURIE DOYLE ON
BEHALF OF THE CONFERENCE OF
CALIFORNIA BAR ASSOCIATIONS --
SMALL PRESENTATION ANSWER
QUESTIONS.
THEY WILL JUST HOLD IT PRETTY
MUCH ANSWERING QUESTIONS THE
ONLY THING I WOULD SAY IS OF
THIS BILL IS A GOOD REASON WHY
POLICY DECISION SHOULD BE MADE
BY THE POLICY COMMITTEES --
BECAUSE THIS CAME ABOUT BECAUSE
WE HAD THE PUBLIC DEFENDERS WERE
MEMBERS OF THE CONFERENCE -- TO
THOUGHT THAT THE EXISTING LAW.
DIDN'T WORK VERY WELL BECAUSE IT
SET UP A SITUATION WHERE.
YOU CAN BE.
YOU KNOW IF THERE WAS AN
OUTSTANDING WARRANT FOR YOUR
ARREST EVEN THOUGH YOU NEVER
BEEN A YOU DIDN'T KNOW ANYTHING
ABOUT THE WARRANT.
YOU MAY NOT HAVE BEEN GUILTY OF
ANY CRIME OR ANYTHING ELSE YOU
STILL GUILTY OF A FELONY FOR
POSSESSING A AND SO THEY'RE
TRYING TO FIX THAT.
WAS A GOOD WORK OF STAFF.
TO HELP US IDENTIFY WHAT IT
ACTUALLY GONE ON AND THE
AMENDMENTS NO CORRECT THE
SITUATION.
SO THE PEOPLE WHO HAVE NAY NEED
OF USING THE STATUTE WILL BE
ABLE TO FIND OUT WHAT IT DOES.
WITH THE LIMITATIONS ARE AND
IT'S A LOT BETTER POLICY.
AND I HOPE YOU WILL SUPPORT.
ALL RIGHT ARE THERE OTHER ON
ANYONE ELSE HERE IN SUPPORT.
LESLIE CALDWELL CALIFORNIA
DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
GREAT.
I'M ANY OTHERS.
SO ANY IN OPPOSITION -- I
UNDERSTAND THAT THE BRADY
CAMPAIGN OF WAS HERE EARLIER BUT
THEY WERE REMOVING THEIR
OPPOSITION TO THE AMENDMENTS.
THEY'RE NOT HERE NOW.
PARTLY WHAT HAPPENED STORY OVER
REALLY THAT STARTS AT EIGHT
THIRTY YOU WERE STILL HERE BILLS
IN FOR THREE BUT THAT'S OKAY.
AND AS CENTER -- JONES I REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR ARTICULATING THE
MA'AM IT'S EXACTLY AS I HAD THEM --
WRITTEN DOWN HERE SO I'M VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE THAT
[inaudible]
AND YOU MAY CLOSE.
I THINK I THINK YOU'RE MUCH I
APPRECIATE YOUR AYE VOTE OKAY
GREAT AND IS THERE MOTION ON
THIS.
ONE AS AMENDED AS THE MAN WITH
THE MINIMUM YEAH.
THANK YOU EXCELLENT.
THE WITH THAT WILL CALL THE ROLL.
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS SKINNER.
SKINNER I MORE LIKE.
WELL LIKE I BRADFORD.
JACKSON.
MITCHELL MORALE.
WIENER.
RIGHT THE BILLS ON CAL. ONE
MINUTE GET MY MISSING MEMBERS
BACK SO WE CAN.
CLOSE THE ROLE IN A BUNCH OF
THINGS. TO THE ROLE AND I CAN
BOTH YEAH WE CAN DO WE DO YEAH.
YES WE THEIR FIVE ZERO THE
CURRENT VOTE ON SB FORTY IS.
FIVE ZERO NOW WE'LL DO.
OKAY WE WILL GO TO SB -- ALL.
NINE SB ONE FORTY FOUR SENATOR
MITCHELL CURRENT VOTE IS
[inaudible] FIVE ONE MORE LACK
OF THE NOTE.
MOORLACH NOW [inaudible]
BILLS OUT.
OKAY SO SB ONE FORTY FOUR
SENATOR MITCHELL'S BILLS OUT
[inaudible]
FIVE TWO TWO SOON NOW WILL GO TO
S. B. TWO SEVENTY THREE CURRENT
VOTE THAT SENATOR RUBIO THE
CURRENT VOTE IS -- FOR ZERO AND
IT SAYS THE MOTION WOULD BE DO
PASSES AMENDED TO APPROACH.
MOORLACH.
MORE LIKE I SB THREE OR FOUR
HILL THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROACH THE CURRENT
VOTE IS BY.
NOTHING MOORLACH HI MORE LIKE I
WE'LL CONTINUE HAVE THEIR OWN
CALL.
IN THE NEXT -- WOULD BE SB FIVE
FOUR FIVE NINE CINDER GIRL G. ON
YOU WOULD BE DO PASSES AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS CURRENT VOTERS
THREES.
ZERO MOORLACH.
MORE LIKE I AN ON CALL.
ANDTHEN WE HAVE SB FIVE SIXTEEN
SKINNER DO PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS FOR AND VOTERS.
FOUR ZERO MOORLACH NO.
NO.
JACKSON.
FIVE ZERO ONE OF THE LAW
[inaudible]
JACKSON HIGH.
GOLD YANNI IS A FOR OR NOTHING
RIGHT NOW -- CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. FIFTY PASTOR PROBST
MORE LOCK.
MOORLACH HI JACKSON.
JAX HI.
KEEP IT OPEN FOR THE ACTORS. SIX
SIX ZERO SIX ZERO CERTAINLY.
AND THEN WE WILL GO TO SB SIX
TWENTY PORTANTINO IT'S THE
MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS [inaudible]
MOORLACH [inaudible]
JACKSON.
JACKSON HIGH MORALE.
THIS IS SB SIX TWENTY PORTANTINO
[inaudible]
IN.
NO WORRIES WE WILL GIVE YOU A
MOMENT CENTER MORALE WE'RE DOING
THE ROLL CALL ON SB SIX TWENTY
PORTANTINO. TWO PASSES AMENDED
TO A PROBES IN THE CURRENT VOTE
IS. FIVE FIVE BUT IN ONE NOT
VOTING. SIX TWENTY PORTANTINO
[inaudible]
NUMBER
.
NINETEEN NEVER MIND MIGHT WORK.
WE'RE GLAD TO BE OF SERVICE.
WELL.
AROUND NOW THAT'S ALL THAT.
ALL RIGHT SO THE NEXT.
AND YOU CAN KEEP THOSE DIFFERENT
NOW.
FIVE THE SB SIX TWENTY IS OUT
FIVE TWO ONE AND NOW WE'LL GO TO
SB SIX SIX SIX SENATOR STONE
THAT ITEM. ONE TWENTY AND THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS CALLED THE
MISSING MEMBERS SKINNER AYE
SKINNER AYE BRADFORD
[inaudible]
JACKSON.
I WANTED TO VOTE NO EXCUSE ME.
CAN WE ARE RECALL THAT --
MISSING GLASSES OF BUT IT'S OKAY --
WHEN YOU CALL THE ROLL AGAIN ON
SB SIX SIX SIX SURE SKINNER NO
SKINNER NOW [inaudible]
MOORLACH.
BRADFORD.
YEAH HERE OKAY SORRY JACKSON NO
JACKSON NOW.
WIENER [inaudible]
BRADFORD NOW [inaudible] TWO
THREE AND WE'RE GONNA WAIT FOR
WE'RE GONNA HOLD THE ROLE OPEN
FOR SENATOR WIENER TO RETURN.
YES AND WE WILL GRANT -- HIM
ONCE WE HAVE TO CLOSE THE ROLE
WE ALL GRANT RECONSIDERATION.
RIGHT NOW.
WE NEED A MOTION.
YES SIR SB SIX SEVENTY EIGHT IS
GLACIER.
WE HEARD IT.
AND IT CENTER GLACIER -- AGREED
TO THE AMENDMENTS -- THAT WERE
IN THE ANALYSIS.
AND SO THE AM I WOULD LIKE TO
ENTERTAIN A MOTION OF TO DO PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
SO WE HAVE BRADFORD MOTION NOW
WE WILL CALL THE ROLL.%
SKINNER HI SKINNER I'M MORE
LOCKED.
BRADFORD.
HI JACKSON.
JACKSON HIGH MORALE.
AROUND NOW WIENER.
IT'S A THREE ONE RIGHT NOW AND
WE WILL HOLD THAT.
BILL OPEN FOR A CENTER.
RETURN AND NOW WE'RE GONNA OPEN
THE ROLE AGAIN.
I'M NOT MEANING LOW'S THESE WERE
JUST GONNA.
OKAY ALLOW ABSENT MEMBERS.
YEAH.
WE HAVE ONE MORE MOMENT.
ALL RIGHT.
THAT WAS.
THOSE.
WERE YEAH SO THE LONG IT'S THE
LAST ITEM IN IT SENATOR JONES.
I'M SB -- SEVEN ONE IT'S DO
PASSES AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
THE CURRENT VOTE IS.
TO NOTHING LET'S CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS [inaudible]
BRADFORD.
OUR BREEDING CAMPAIGN REMOVE
THEIR OPPOSITION.
SB ENTITIES THAT WERE OPPOSED TO
REMOVE THEIR OPPOSITION BASED ON
THE AMENDMENTS AND THE AUTHOR
AGREED TO TAKE THE AMENDMENTS.
OKAY.
WE WILL NOW FOR THE RULES.
JACKSON I'M AROUND [inaudible]
HI WIENER.
THE OLDER FOR RIGHT NOW ALLOW
WE'RE GONNA WE'RE GONNA OPEN THE
ROLE AGAIN WELL NOT WE NEVER
CLOSE WE ARE GOING.
TO ALLOW FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
SO.
SO SB FORTY WIENER CURRENT VOTE
IS FIVE TWO ZERO JACKSON.
HI JACKSON AYE. SIX THE BILL SB
FORTY IS OUT.
SIX ZERO SB FORTY SEVEN THE
PASTOR OF PROBES CURRENT VOTE
[inaudible]
THREE TO ZERO JACKSON. FORTY
SEVEN YES.
JACKSON HIGH MORALE NO AROUND
NOW WIENER.
RIGHT THE BILL STILL PENDING GO
AHEAD SB ONE TWENTY STERN TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CURRENT CODE IS.
TWO TO ONE JACKSON.
TAX HIGH MORALE.
AROUND NOW WINNER [inaudible]
YOU'RE NOT [inaudible]
BRADFORD.
SB ONE THIRTY TWO WINNER TO PASS
TO APPROPRIATIONS CURRENT BOTH
THREE TO ZERO MORE LOCKED.
JACKSON.
JACKSON HIGH MORALE.
AROUND.
ALL RIGHT SIR SB ONE THIRTY TWO
IS OUT.
FOUR TO ONE SB TWO THIRTY
CABALLERO TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CURRENT BOTH
BORDER ZERO JACKSON.
YOUR VOTING I JACKSON.
JACKSON HIGH.
YOU GOT YOUR ON YOUR NOT A NOT
VOTING ON HI [inaudible]
OKAY.
YOUR CALL RURAL RURAL RURAL
RURAL HIGH.
WILL BE OUT.
THE BILL IS NOW OUT.
SEVEN ZERO BE TWO SEVENTY THREE
RUBIO TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CURRENT VOTE IS
FIVE TWO ZERO JACKSON.
AMENDMENT OF IN YEARS YES.
JACKSON I'M AROUND [inaudible]
WELL I SB TWO SEVENTY THREE IS
OUT.
SEVEN ZERO NEXT BILL SB TWO
EIGHTY ONE WIENER TO PASS AS A
MAN.
THE PASTOR PROGRAM NOT AS
AMENDED JUST NEW PASSED
REPRESSION SKINNER.
BY SKINNER AYE JACKSON
[inaudible]
AND SORRY.
THIS IS.
A NO NO.
THE ROOM THIS IS YES WILL BE TWO
EIGHTY ONE ITEM -- EIGHT THANK
YOU.
FRONT OF JACKSON.
JACKSON JACKSON OUT.
SO DID YOU CALL MORRELL.
YEAH YEAH YEAH OKAY OLOGY SO
THAT SB TWO EIGHTY ONE IS NOW
OUT WERE.
TO TO AND THE CONSENT CALENDAR
YEAH.
NO NO NO YEAH ALL RIGHT SO WE'LL
NOW VOTER AND CONSENT RIGHT NOW
THE CURRENT VOTE IS FOR NOTHING.
JACKSON.
JACKSON HIGH MORALE.
WELL HI [inaudible]
OKAY.
I HAVE TO GET UP TO TREAT SELECT.
TEXT.
ANY LAST WORDS FOR JACKSON
BEFORE WE KNOW SHE AND SHE'S.
NO NO YES I APOLOGIZE YES PLEASE.
RIGHT.
ALL RIGHT NOW.
YOU GUYS SLOW DOWN SLOW DOWN
BECAUSE I NEED TO GO TO
TRANSCEND I DON'T WANT TO KEEP.
A REFORM.
YOU.
KNOW WE GOT MORE YAK.
GALGIANI.
ZERO RIGHT.
NOW.
DO WE FINISH CONSENT FINE SB
THREE OH FOUR ITEM.
TEN DO YOU PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS AS AMENDED
CURRENT VOTE IS SIX SIX ZERO
BRADFORD.
SB THREE ZERO FOUR IS NOW OUT.
SEVEN ZERO ITEM FIFTEEN SB FIVE
SIXTEEN IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS THE CURRENT VOTE.
IS.
FIVE ONE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
MORALE [inaudible]
NOW.
ALL RIGHT SB FIVE SIXTEEN IS NOW
OUT.
FIVE TWO OKAY YES HE YEAH IT
DOESN'T RURAL SPENDING
[inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
EVERYBODY ELSE BUT WHEN.
OKAY.
NOW.
CAN WE TAKE A TEMPORARY RESOURCE
RECESS SO I CAN GO VOTE.
RIGHT BUT IF THEY NEED ME TO
VOTE UP ENTRANCE. FIVE THREE SIX
OH FIVE THREE SIX WAS PULLED.
THANKS.
YEAH IF SO IN -- BUT CENTER
BRADFORD WE NO CENTER WINTERS
HERE OKAY DON'T WORRY YOU'RE
FINE YOU'RE FINE.
OKAY CAN WE PLEASE JUST OPEN
THOSE THAT SENATOR WIENER NEEDS
TO ADD ON TO WHAT.
YES YOU HAVE.
OKAY WE NEED TO GO BACK YOU KNOW
OKAY SO WE ARE NOW GOING OPENED --
L. OUT THE ABSENT MEMBERS TO ADD
ON TO SB FOUR SEVEN ITEM TO THE
CURRENT VOTE IT'S SENATOR ALLEN.
THE CURRENT VOTE IS.
FOR ONE WIENER [inaudible]
WIENER AYE.
SB FOUR SEVEN IS NOW OUT.
FIVE ONE WE WILL NOW OPEN SB ONE
TWENTY SENATOR STERN THE MOTION
IS TO PASTOR APPROPRIATIONS THE
CURRENT VOTERS.
FOR TWO WIENER [inaudible]
WIENER AYE.
SB ONE TWENTY IS NOW OUT.
FIVE TWO YES HE SKEWS ME THE
CONSENT CALENDAR THE CURRENT
VOTE IS SIX NOTHING.
WE NOW ABSENT MEMBER.
WHERE I CAN SEND CALENDARS NOW
OUT?
SEVEN ZERO RIGHT NOW WE HAVE.
SB SIX SIX SIX ITEM TWENTY
CURRENT VOTE IS. TWO TO THREE TO
ONLY TWO YESES THREE KNOWS WE
NAM [inaudible]
YEAH CORRECT.
WE WE ARE NOW.
SB -- SIX SIX SIX FIELD.
WE ARE FAILED TO TO FOR WE ARE
GRANTING RECONSIDERATION.
ALL RIGHT AND THEN SB SIX SEVEN
EIGHT SENATOR GLAZERS ITEM
TWENTY ONE DO PASSES AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CURRENT VOTE IS.
THREE ONE CALL THE UP TO MEMBER
WIENER.
WIENER AYE.
THAT BILL IS NOW OUT.
FOR ONE AND THEN SB SEVEN OH ONE
SENATOR JONES YOU PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS THE
CURRENT VOTE IS [inaudible]
FIVE I'M [inaudible] ZERO WIENER.
US SEVEN SB SEVEN ONE IS OUT.
SIX ZERO I BELIEVE THAT IS ALL.
YEAH WE CAN WHICH THEN YOU'RE
NOT ON WE WILL CHECK AGAIN YEAH
THERE ARE A LOT OF TIME AND
THERE WERE A NUMBER POLL.
WHAT THE OTHER JOHN?
YES THE OTHER JONES WAS BOLD.
YEAH THE ONE THAT WASN'T ON I
THINK THAT.
RIGHT I JUST I'M GONNA LET THEM
KNOW WHAT YOU ALL HAVE JUST MAKE
SURE YOU HAVE YOUR WORK AT CAROL
WE'RE GOOD ALL RIGHT.
SO.
EARTH ON OF TODAY'S PUBLIC
SAFETY COMMITTEE.
IS NOW CONCLUDED.
THANK YOU ALL MADE UP OF